Yes.
Barely. And then you just stop all together. M. We barely spoke
before we had That's not true. That's not true. That's not true.
If you look at the If you look at the conversation that we had
Okay. Well, until she
Kelly, shut the up. Thank you, D. Thank you. You put your hand
between my legs and I slapped it away. No, I did not. Yes, you
did. I want to know. Don't lie. You put your hands between my
legs and I slapped your hand away. That's what
Psychologically you are. I haven't like done anything any huge
regrets in my life like you have. I've been I have kids. I had
a career. I have one career. I'm still doing other stuff. You
are like a famous lol cow racist calling yourself a calling everyone
a racist everything else. And yet you feel the need to comment
as if you are any bit whatsoever have any bit of knowledge to
add to anything. So I can tell that you're the only person you
can talk to is Boogie. You can give Boogie some advice. That's
Boogie is someone that needs you because they're like I haven't
heard about them. I don't know who these internet people are.
I live in real life. Maybe you don't live in real life.
successful. You are nothing. I you act you act constantly whenever
it's like my Daniel
billionaire millionaire guy it's I'm so successful in a breath
the real the reality of it is you're not successful I need you
to take a
breath a first and foremost and that's all we have going for
you nothing else you I Dan everyone has been making fun of you
for weeks I'd cool it on the l cow but you had a magazine publication
making fun of you. What I will say is that I have learned I have
learned I have learned to not measure my success anymore in the
ways that I thought I was successful. Yeah. Yeah. I don't like
measuring my ways of success in the ways of the public like
If you know anything about me, if you know anything about me,
yes. What is what? know that I was actually a very successful
songwriter and indie singer and then became an only fans for
hour right after that.
Yes, I I quit music. I did not want because of your massive success
in music.
That's kind of crazy. Destiny is being very active right now,
but I don't hear him voice right now. I don't hear you very had
very little to do I'm speaking.
My success had very little to do with my uh I made three I had
three or my success with Only Fans. I made $300,000 a year on
Only Fans. Impossible
numbers to pass up when you're 18 and you've been poor your whole
life. Would I go back and pro? Honestly, I probably wouldn't
go back. I probably have no regrets. Honestly, I'm very happy
with where I'm at right now. Weren't you Wait, no. Didn't you
cry constantly about how Only Fans was a mistreatment and blah
blah blah women's rights? Yeah. I think when I was emotional
in it, when I was still doing it and I hated it and I was emotional
about it, I I had a lot of shame. I think entering like spaces
with like males who were um like consistently shaming me for
it at the beginning was like very jarring cuz I had been in only
like female spaces who like were like, "Go queen, do your thing."
So, it was like obviously very like vexing to me to be around
that. Um, and do I have like public failures? Absolutely. I I
don't think that that is any measure of like who I am as a person.
Yeah, that's crazy that you're calling him out when you
when your public failures are so much worse. You're excusing.
I don't think I don't I don't care about my public failures.
I I think I I've connected with like my work this this year.
That is telling me not to abuse aiments. It is philanthropic.
I I have I'm doing very well in school. I'm very driven.
Um, I have like uh I have things that I'm proud of myself for
and that I and that I love to do genuinely. And so, do I do I
count my marriage as a failure?
Like, maybe I like I think that we loved each other really hard
for 5 years and then some relationships just don't work out.
Like, wait, the marriage was for 5 years? The way that it is.
I'll get myself. The relationship was for 5 years. Most people
date for a while before they get married, you know. Yeah. Um,
but I we were we had a very successful loving relationship until
we just realized that we like really really wanted different
things and that's how it is. I don't know. You think he broke
up with you cuz you uh you rejected the drugs I gave you and
then got a prescription for the same medication. Eugene, he didn't.
He didn't. I I think that I'm not going to uh I'm not going to
your your narrative of of the situation is is going to um try
to do whatever you're trying to do. I I don't Wait, Kelly, we're
getting some allegations about you real quick. Can you confirm
or deny that you're 40 plus? Yeah, sure. I'm 47. You're 47? Yeah,
definitely. Feel 47 or 53, depending on who you believe. You
look very mily for you know what you are. Oh, thank you. I think
you you've had a successful life.
Stop the chat like a I think I think I do have I have I have
incredible
I Skype blogs myself, right? So even though my relationship,
we are still friends.
I have very few enemies in real life. I love my job. I love my
I love what I'm going through. You're just a [__]
on the internet. Of course I'm a on the internet. Okay. All of
us are retards on the internet. Nero, if you act how you do online
IRL, holy,
it might be over for you. I think we all have personas, right?
He does, by the way. Yeah, that's not good. That's not good at
all. I was just joking. He doesn't I think that's true actually.
At least in the group chat that we're all in. I don't think people
think very fondly of you. Oh, Ellie, while you were uh while
you were talking to Destiny in that chat, you should have asked
why he banned you. Should have been like, Destiny, why did you
ban me? Tell me why you banned me. Maybe he would have told you.
Now, now we'll never know. We'll we'll literally never know now.
Kelly, you had to argue over your age.
Up and amphetamines. The my discord just died. Bobby just tipped
$5. Life is so wooden. She gives splinters when Jeez. Are you
40 or like 41 though? She uh I guess we'll never know. Her discord
or something. I should probably get ready to move. She ran. Oops.
That was me joining that channel there. Now we moved it. Okay,
there we go. Yeah, it's okay. Kelly, are you 40 or 41? Why are
you laughing? I don't Because none of this stuff's true. Obviously,
I'm into you can tell me. I believe Kelly is a a 300year-old
vampire. True. But also like why would I say my actual age? Also,
why does it matter? Nero, you're like you're like a gay little
ugly like your cell. Oh my god, I disavow that. This person has
their own channel. It's a
femoid. Okay.
Dan was like, I'm not keep my face on that. This woman's hit
the wall. Like you will never have a woman in your life.
Me. I was drinking and you say that cuz I'm been drinking. completely
disavow that language. That's really I'm just curious if I look
up if I look up lav do you think the videos of you yourself look
will pop up first or your divorce? Who cares?
Who literally who cares? Do you think this hurts me? Just saying
this this would be her kick channel if you were looking to do
enforcement. Okay, not on my channel but on this channel. Okay,
this channel right here. This is this is the channel that she
operates on. All right. Also, now that all of DG is watching,
Andrew Wilson made $270,000 in super chats this year. Okay, that
guy is making insane money. All right, guy is making ludicrously
high money. All right, just so you know. That was really offensive
to a lot of people, by the way. You know, not just to me. I don't
think that I wouldn't use that word for many people. I think
it is apt for you. Wow. You think your music you yourself or
your divorce will pop up? I I just want to get an answer to that
question. I I think probably my snark Reddit will show up first.
Wait, hold on. Were you one of those girls that turned 18 and
immediately turned to Only Fans because they couldn't do anything
else in life? Yeah, because I had felony charges on my record.
Very healthy life. I I you know, I [__] with it.
I was actually a preschool teacher. I loved my job. Is this like
Merk's Max story you're using? I'm confused.
No, it is interesting that she also did that though. I remember
hearing that and I thought that that was Well, she doesn't have
an Only Fans, does she? I don't know. Yeah, I don't think so.
But no, I had felony charges on my record that were pending.
Just it was like weird. I didn't actually do anything, but it
was uh it was for domestic battery. Interesting. That's crazy.
Yeah, but I took a plea of obeyance, so it was expuned from my
record. All right. Yeah. Ellie admitted that she's drinking tonight.
Really? I don't think she did that. Said it wasn't alcohol. You
stupid. I think it's like when you try to when you try to do
the like your naked bodies on the internet thing, I think that
like I think that makes some people really upset who like don't
have anything in their life. I am I am jubilant. It has never
affected my work, my school, never affected my ability to find
a partner. I've I've had to suffer. It probably affected it probably
affected your ability to keep a partner considering your person.
That is shocking and racist and I I disavow it too. Actually,
Nero would never say something like that. I definitely told other
people to call Nero that and other VCs at other times. That's
why he's now being indignant.
That's in VCs that are on stream. Nero, stop. I didn't even call
you out by your name, but you decided to expose yourself. Thank
you. I'm just saying
that didn't make any sense. Okay. Okay. Are you really saying
that right now? Nero is the most racist person I know.
I've heard him say the a multitude of times. Okay. Wow. What's
the next uh what's the next step for you laughing? Like uh the
only kind of things that don't work out. Maybe like becoming
a hooker.
Yeah, that's the next I'm talking. I'm quitting school. I'm going
back to the streets. This is what you Nero. She said she already
did that. She came back. What? you're trying to do isn't working.
My life is better than you. I've made every mistake and my life
is still better than yours. What is Oh, we know. We watch that
live every time. What is your excuse for what? Can you c up for
me? Uh, if you take your top off, I'll come up. That was really
funny. Everyone laughed. I wasn't I'm being fully serious. If
you take your top off right now, I will cam up. Yeah, everyone's
laughing. You I'm not I think you're just not brave. I think
you want me to pay $5. Girl, girl, girl is being mean and mogging
me. I'm going to her as a power play. Kill yourself in a game.
It's what you're doing isn't working. You sound pathetic right
now. You were a weak male. Okay. Yeah. Take it. Take it. You
little fairy boy. We end up taking Something wrong with you,
man. I just I There has to be If it's the Tumblr that you've
that you've been I just Were you one of those Tumblr and Rex
girls? Yeah, but you like those girls. I do. Yeah. is. But this
is why I had to like lay off for a bit. Okay. They were getting
like they were getting too crazy like this. It's a reason you
always ask women their BMI. It's crazy that your age hasn't slowed
you down and just being able to butt in. Dude,
Nero, you are literally like a you are like a mud person. When
was the last time you had sex with a woman? What? Like how is
it possible that you feel as powerful as you do speaking to women
this way? If I was in person, if we had if this was was an IRL
conversation, you wouldn't be able to make eye contact with me.
You'd be shaking. Yeah, I don't really like Latinos. They scare
me. Another great joke, Nero. Thanks. Yeah. And I spelled mint
pies all over the floor.
Nero, do you have anything substance to say that isn't like on
women for your I don't know what you want. I'm playing I'm playing
rust. I don't know what you want. I don't know if I've ever heard
you say anything else. Try to try to make a retort to me or Kelly
without being uh like doing your like edgy womanhating bit. Try
I want to see how Hold on. If he he has to do that, but you have
to do it without being racist. Back to him. Okay. You just called
me
like five times. Why are you saying that I'm the one that's being
edgy? Well, no. I I just I just I feel like I have a higher um
like capability in in in arguing with you. I think you have one
thing. Okay.
Strongest weapons away and your only fans. I have two. Sorry.
Oh, my floor is sticky. Can you not bend down to clean it, Kelly?
Because of your age. Shut up. Sorry. God, this guy's funny. Thank
you. Brady's just sitting here with his mic muted. Brady's getting
moved out unless he talks. Hello. I'm speaking. What do you want?
Engage in the conversation, loser. Say things. Be entertaining.
Don't just sit here listening. Be fans. Okay. I know. What did
he say? Can't we all just be friends? Hello. I was speaking.
Brady, where did you and uh where did you and Nero go on your
first date? You flew to Dubai to meet him? No. Weird.
Actually, I didn't ask about this fact. I as about where you
guys went, which is funny cuz I keep getting calls when I TC
Brady all the time. I
went another What restaurant did you guys go to? I'm just I'm
asking I'm trying to change the subject. Do you remember where
we enter? I'm I'm telling him. I'm telling him we had He doesn't
believe us. I can tell you exactly diameter of his butthole.
Don't do that. Do you think I cured you by getting you so worked
up when you're this sick? Do you
Nero?
When am I When am I not this worked up? When am I not this worked
up? I don't know. Maybe I can blow up. This is sort of my This
is sort of my thing. I come, I yell, I log off. Why can't we
just be friends? Is that too much to ask? Because you are made
of mud and soot. Well, actually in the Quran, God says we're
all made out of mud. So, you're made out of mud. Making suspicion
that the shape of your body is
and it disgusts me to a level or I will never respect you. So,
we can't be friends. No. Sorry, buddy. Kind of sucks. Cleaner
so I can clean my sticky floor. Anyway, just hates ugly people.
That is what that one I do genuinely. Like you should have been
an abortion. So mean. It is what it is. So incredibly uncalled
for. How long do you think this uh relationship that you're in
will last? Well, we're at least going to be tied to each other
forever because I'm having his baby. Feel like it's ugly. How
could you say that? Well, I mean, have you look at Have you looked
at his mom? I am scared. I am scared that it's going to uh he's
like very big and broad. I'm scared that we're going to have
a girl and it's going to be a big boned girl. I just know that
life is a hard life. I'll love her, but I just know that life
is a hard life. I mean, you're you're a pretty good role model
to your baby. Anonymous just tipped five. I think I am. I think
I think in real life that that could definitely be said about
me, Nero. Thanks for the five, Anonymous. When she looks up your
your name, what do you think she'll see? Probably your music,
right? By that point, um, definitely not any nude photos if that's
what you're going to say. Oh, well I was going to see your music
cuz you know it's very good. Well, yeah. If she looks up, she
will see my music. Yeah. I have an NME publication, Paper magazine.
I have millions and millions of plays on Spotify. I have a Good
Morning America shout out. I've written for others.
Why don't Why don't you go back to music lab? I never
You never stop music now. Was that I've been I've been a like
a a songwriter part of the writer's guild for years and years
and years. I never stopped. I just didn't want to do a solo project
anymore. Well, sorry, but that's what I'm asking. Why did you
stop that? Wait. Okay, hold on. Hold on. I need to get something
straight. I need to get something straight. I This has confused
me eternally. You quit Only Fans and then you returned to it,
but instead of marketing it as Only Fans, you marketed it as
like woman help on how to make them right. This was No, this
was something that I toyed with while I was still doing it or
after I had originally quit 3 years ago. I was like, maybe there's
a way I could still do
content in a way that is like geared towards women. I was having
I was I was I was having ideas. It was never something that I
did. It was a passing thought that I'd had that people had picked
up on. And then uh So, you didn't make a video with dildos and
stuff like that. Was ridiculous. So that So you didn't make any
videos with dildos and stuff going inside you and stuff? No.
Have I Have I made a video with it before? Yes. No. Like after
you quit Only Fans and then saying that it's really really bad.
You went right back to it. No. Uh have No, I didn't go right
back to it. I I have an archive up right now on my Only Fans.
I never got rid of my Only Fans, but I haven't posted new content
for quite a long time. Quite quite quite a long time. Don't believe
you, but okay. You can try to look up leaks like there's no
all the leaks. I did. I did, but they there's not I bet you do.
Yeah, good. I'm sorry. I just Yeah, there's they're six years
old. Are you better now? Am I Am I better?
Well, I I don't know. I'm just If you were to get I don't know.
For someone you're better now. For someone like you, probably
not. I think you probably prefer a barely legal type of body
type. Why do you think he really does? He really does. Because
there's there's a Reddit cadence in your voice that that leads
me to believe that you are a Oh, okay. It's got very awkward
very fast. No, it's not awkward. Why you It's only awkward when
you say it's awkward. It is. Kelly, you asked to talk to Lav
like a 100 times. What What did you want to say to Lav? No, I
wanted her to come in the New Year's stream because Nina was
there and I just wanted a stream with hot girls on it. I don't
I don't I just like hot girls. Real. You think Lav is hot? Yeah,
obviously. I have eyes. Are Are you Are you getting dementia
right now? Or You think You think Lav is hot? I'm a 300B mud
person, and I would never touch her. I have adult acne. Lav is
so ugly. I've said many things about Lav, but her being ugly
would never be one of them. Real Kelly, we should kiss. True.
Yeah. One thing, one thing that I've never understood is how
uh Destiny keeps saying that I the only thing I had to brag about
was my husband when I have bragged about that much less than
how cute I am. Much much less. That's always been my number one
thing. And for now, I haven't hit the wall, I don't think. So,
I'm I'm I'm doing pretty good. I think I have about probably
15 more years to be exceedingly um cute. Usually, usually women
that are really cute do like modeling or other stuff that doesn't
include going on Discords and posting their nudes, but you know.
Yeah. Well, I've been in magazines and I think I had a successful
career due to uh uh the way that I went viral consistently for
taking selfies. So, I don't think that um I don't think that
I'm too far beyond that. Do you think you could be a model? Do
I think I could be a model? No, I don't have that look. Do I
think I could be a popular person online because I'm attractive?
Yes. Like there are there are plenty of people who being a model
has like a very particular look. You have to be tall and thin
and and whatever. I think one of like the hottest girls in the
world is like goth Charlotte. She could never be like a model,
but she's like obviously like notably very beautiful. Like a
lot of cosplayers like they could not be models but they're like
very beautiful and and get popular online through that. Yeah.
There's like different kinds of looks. Yeah. Yeah. Um, you have
to be tall really to be like a proper model. Yeah. 5'2 kind of.
Yeah. Kind of.
Yeah. I'm I'm a little bit. You're 52.
Two. 52. 52.
And you get the 52a.
Let's get the chat up. Okay. Let's get the morale of the chat
up. And you're Are you ever going to post a selfie? You will
not. Would I? Yeah. I think that's I think that's telling. I
think you're going to make fun of me and that's like really mean
rage moments. A little bit of them. Yeah. Yeah. I think I would
be mean cuz I could tell that you're ugly. Yeah. Why would I
post them? Yeah, that makes sense. I just wanted you to confirm
it. TC Brady could never TC Brady is a very handsome strapping
young man and he has posted selfies before. Thank you. How handsome
are you, Brady? From 1 to 10. Well, you I'm like a fav. Don't
sell yourself short, King. I'm a little fav. Okay,
that's okay. You can always lose weight. You have good bones.
Thank you. You weren't born fat. We got the um what do we got
here? We got a manifesto from the Vegas guy. The guy who set
the cybert truck off in Vegas.
Manifesto is up. We'll read that in just a little bit once these
people are done hling uh racial and
epithets at each other. All right, we'll give that another five
minutes at least and then we can go on to this. Go on to this.
Stay in DG.
Uh oh. No, I'm laugh shaming. Um are actually like good at their
job. I'm proud of never being good at being a then. Yeah. Your
only fans are trash. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't want to do it. It's
Isn't it incredible that I could make $300,000 off of such loweffort
by being a Well, I'm not I wasn't good at it. So just loweffort
whoring, I guess. And you just So you were or actively are. What
do we classify? Do you think Do you think I'm scared of this
word? Okay. I'm I'm glad that you are proud of being I don't
think I'm I'm not scared of it when you call me yet. Why would
it scare you? I'm I'm just Well, you're obviously using it. You're
okay. You're You're fumble. I'm peeing. Can you hear it? I think
you're delirious from your fever. Can you hear my pee? Why? Just
a class act. Just a class act. I just wanted you to know that
I wasn't frying chicken. Why?
Why?
Why? For free. Well,
all right. how to get Ellie to Ellie, I have a question. Okay.
Better empathize with everybody who heard that. I'm going to
read this this thread from this guy who shot himself in the head
and then detonated. Wait, before you do that, can I just ask
Vegas? Can I just ask Kelly question? Whatever you want. It's
It's about your past. Okay, I'll be right back then. 2 minutes.
It's about your past. Okay. I mean, do you think this is a good
idea, Nero? What is it about? So, maybe message me first cuz
I don't remember going in on you today, Nero. So, if you Sure,
sure. I I'll I was just curious about what dinosaurs would have
looked like. Oh, is that Oh, very funny. That was way too much
leadup for that joke. Where is Wes? Actually, let's get Wes in
here. Wow. Destiny accused Lab of not writing her own songs.
Crazy. Wait, is that true? You didn't write your own songs? I
wrote all of my songs. Okay, that's why they're bad. Yeah, that
is why they're bad. If they are bad, it is my fault. For the
stuff he's been writing is just making up random today. Yeah,
he'll just when Destiny gets Wait,
why are you talking about Destiny? He's not He's not here with
us. Wait, are you aware that Destiny's not here with us? I've
been I've been calling you a wolf for the past 20 minutes. Huh?
You just You just said that. That's what he said. Are you brain
damage? I'm not back yet, but I've also never lied. Sounds like
you sound It sounds like you sound You had the brain damage.
I didn't even say that. Yes, you did. I I was quiet. I was playing.
What are you talking about? You're confusing me and Lamb speaking
probably. Do you think do you think the pregnancy is leaking
hormones into your brain that's making you irrational right now?
No, I think it's making me clairvoyant. My tongue hurts. It's
bad. Kelly, how was your day? Yeah, Kelly's opinion on lab's
alleged miscarriage. Kelly, how was your day? Kelly, would you
make my fetus into soup? Sorry, Kelly. Ignore the seeking attention.
How was your day? I feel like it would be more of a stew than
a soup.
Soup. Kelly, can you please ignore the trying to get attention?
I just Are we going to watch that Murk interview after this?
I'm confused. The what? I woke up at like Merk went on another
stream did like an interview about all of the tweets. Interview
about what tweets
what? Uh the fairy queen. Fairy Queen had a whole tweet thread
today. Did you not see that, Kelly? Oh, no. Not properly. Okay.
Can you link me so I can look at it? Cuz I I tried to put in
her name and then it said she had zero tweets and then someone
linked me something else and then I didn't look at it. You had
like a weird skitso thread. Okay. What does this have to do with
work? Uh because it was about Murk. Remember when Murk was all
like uh what did she say? Oh yeah, that she thought like Destiny
had uh invited over to sleep with her. Destiny leaked those DMs
today and it did not seem like that at all. Maybe Merk's got
other DMs to leak there. I have no idea. Okay. Did you link me
or are you throwing on stream? Uh no, I'm just going to link
it to you cuz we covered it already. You weren't around. So Okay.
Yeah, my bad. There it is. There it is. There it is.
We're glide. Well, I mean, there could be more context there,
but it seems from the context like it's pretty clearly not a
hookup. I don't know. I don't think Yeah, I don't I think Destiny
just mostly ignores everyone unless he needs to respond to them.
But I can see that feeling that way. If like, for example, he's
giving you a lot of attention because he is flirting with you
and then he stops that attention. Maybe it feels that way. Then
you're just going from a girl he was flirting with to just the
same as everybody else. Yeah, I am. He said he wanted to be friends.
He made a pass. She said no. He unfriended. The end. Well, but
hold on. He said he didn't make a pass. And that it seemed like
from the DMs that got leaked. Okay. Like Murk might have been
upset with him that he didn't make a pass basically. Fixing his
mic, dude. He was fixing his mic. Who's fixing for 6 hours? I
don't even know how you fix audio issues for 6 hours. I don't
know how that's possible. Yeah. Interesting. For sure. You just
take a You just take an aux cable, you plug it in on the other
end, and then you're good. That's it. Took like 300 hours of
work to make sure that that election stream was unlistenable,
too. You know, I I think it was amazing. I It made me It made
me feel like a true schizophrenic with all the voices in the
back of my head just rambling while we talked. There has to be
better content coming up. There just has to be there. I I I This
can't keep going. Yeah. Didn't you see he's going to interview
senators and stuff? A former governor tomorrow.
Oh, wow. He's going to talk with a former governor. That's going
to be such a good conversation. Oh, they're going to talk about
taxes drama starter of 2024 and I've been banned so good luck.
You're going to be back. I I believe in you. I don't really I
can't be bothered. They're running for Ali's running for DNC
chair. Maybe old tax reform.
Why is she getting her backtory about going to a small Catholic
school? Like why what is this tweet chain? Uh yeah, she does
a lot of a lot of like yapping in the background. Think fifth
570. Thank you to the five gifted. Big five gifted. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. Do I have to read all
of this? What is the important bit here? Can someone give me
a I you Okay, read silently, Kelly. We've already covered it.
Okay. Or go watch the vlog. Yeah, that's why I'm asking for TLDDR.
She basically just made some up. It's like basically all made
up. It's basically just all made up. She took like a random DM
she got from somebody else or sorry, a random text she got from
somebody and was like, I think this is Destiny. And then she
basically said someone else confirmed to me that it was Destiny.
And there's and then she didn't show the screenshot confirming
that. She just showed a screenshot that was a screenshot of previous
screenshots.
It's like it's bizarre. And I by the way I didn't want to like
call her out on any I was like trying to be so kind reading this
thread. I was like no nobody called her insane. Nobody called
her like any names. Chill the out. And you know it was just a
blatant skits post. It was just it's what it was. You're literally
camping outpost dude. Okay whatever. God, you got the whole VC
laughing. Why? Why? Okay.
Email manifesto sent to Samosaur
Sam Shoemate. Uh by the I believe this is the Vegas guy. Excuse
me.
Okay, it just is. You want more? Laura Gunnar moved out of Cute's
house back to Chicago. I assume Lav is over there, too. Yeah,
I think so. Did you hear Lav is pregnant? Oh, well. Yep. Apparently.
Wow. That's unfortunate. Yep. Yep. Yep. Wait, what did you what
did you cover today? Queen, you covered the fairy queen stuff,
right? Yeah, I covered the fairy queen stuff uh that I free booted
when me, you, and Kelly were on stream the other night. I just
my stream and carried the viewers. Uh and then what else did
I do? It's so cool. It's so cool watching that. I'm glad that
you know, bunch of people like their face pressed against the
window looking sad. Yeah, it's the it's the Squidward. Uh Squidward
watching Spongebob and Patrick. Yeah, it's this one. It's just
me. It's me. This is Queman. This is the YouTube viewership.
And then this is me in the window just being like, why? Why?
Why? What else I do? I cover the extra Emily stuff. Extra Emory.
Anyhow, oh, there's some um these lefty
commentary YouTubers are trying to kill each other right now
over being friends with I'm Alex. Oh, cool. Were you shocked
at how hard fairy queen fumbled completely? like that she basically
just made some up entirely. Was I shocked? Not particularly.
Oh no. Was it like intentionally? Do you think she thought the
stuff that she was saying was true and then she just tweeted
by accident? Is that
Cuz it was kind of annoying. It's I So I didn't realize how she
was and I was like telling everybody I'm like stop calling her
crazy. She's not crazy. She's not like anything. But like this
one where she's like, "This guy confirmed to me that it's Desty's
phone number." And she posts a screenshot of nothing related
to what she says it is. What I'm learning is all of these people
would be great like uh targets for like catfishing scams cuz
everyone's very stupid. So actually I'm starting to understand
how catfishing scams and similar scams work. Like people are
just very dumb. You can make money off of idiots very easily.
She also just started getting these random numbers or these random
texts from like a Indian scammer and was like, "You know what?
Yeah, I did an Indian voice to read these texts. I also did.
Yes. Good. Good stuff. This is like my next career I'm going
to go into. It's just like I'm scamming people like this. This
is a money maker. Did you also imitate I heard you do the Asian
accent. Did you also imitate Extra Emily's parents with an Asian
accent? Cuz that was dynamite for me. I did not imitate Extra
Emirates's parents with an Asian accent. No. I just I played
one of my an old clip from my stream. I played more my own clips
because I thought it was this the girl that was saying like she
didn't want to pay her like parents back the money for her college
stuff like that. Yeah. Is that really that you can make that
into a whole content segment? Yeah. Oh, cuz XQC spoke about it
for like 12 minutes as well. I see. Fair enough. Want to debate
you about the sweeping allegations. I don't care. I don't care.
Wait, that's the H3 podcast. Just lean into it just to
bring him on. What? Ethan wants to talk to you. The Jan Eore
of this community. You wouldn't let Ethan Klein on your show.
Are you anti-Semitic? It is I. Of course you don't. You would
never say anything bad about him. Okay. Is that Pepsi? It could
be. Would that Pepsi guy come on? Yeah. Is he as he sounds most
of the time? No. He's trolling usually. I That's what I figure.
Unfortunate. Unlucky. Unlucky. All right. Where are we going
next? I'm not sure. I I'm kind of thinking that I will cover
the I don't know if you saw this squeezement. Well, you wouldn't
know if you would you don't care. The Genomous Cavage posted
person posted another video. It's worse than I thought. Radio
2X. Oh, Mal Merc. Yeah, we need to watch Mau MC. That's true.
I assume there's no way that's still going on. So, all right,
that finished ago.
M live.
I find it funny that loads of people call him like MRO so they
don't have to make cat noises. Sorry, it's very mean. Uh, I used
to call him emer fine. See, he gets merked to come on.
Looks like he's started watching Cher's not so irritate movie
video. Yeah, he has ba his mind is how how did that come to be?
How did Okay, you have like I'll back up to when he starts talking
to MC. Some people bully MC is how I assume people feel when
they're bullying me. So, it feels like worse than bullying me
actually. Wait, what do you I don't know what you mean at all.
I'm saying she's even more than me and it feels bad. Oh, well,
I'm great. How are you? I'm all right, I guess. Nice. Hold on.
Let me figure out how to do this. Yeah, I like be saber. That
is not what I look like. Hold on. All right, let me give me a
second to set this up properly. Oh, wrong one.
Okay, there we go. So, let me do that. Why doesn't Moral play
good Warhammer games? I think Moral is like me. Doesn't he just
watch footage of Warhammer? People playing Warhammer? Yeah, those
are usually just recordings
other people playing. I think it's funny when people are asking
like, "Oh, why is Kelly on the stream when she got banned?" As
if Lav just wasn't here for like two hours. Is this Is this a
Destiny.gg
stream? Does the bands carry over? They do not. Although it was
uh Dan was here for a while and then Lav dropped a hard R and
Tan disconnected immediately. So, I have a couple questions based
on Lav. I feel like we need to get the holy trinity here at one
point like Mr. go laugh at me.
Okay. Yeah, you need to chill the out. You don't get to jump
yourself in that. Yeah, that's that's up.
Yeah, which I woke up today and I saw a bunch of like responses
and I just didn't respond cuz it's like what the Yeah. So, really
briefly, I'm just going to pull up the tweet and then we'll I'll
ask you questions about it. I believe so you responded to a sick
tweet. Uh the sick tweet reads, "Hold on, I'm going to Oh, yeah.
You might want to skip that bit." Yep. Consented to Destiny,
sharing her tape. Okay, hold on. I'm I'm probably skipping through
a decent amount of this, unfortunately. Frantic. He's
Majority of like the the interactions I want to have and the
ones I value are off stream, which is why like I wasn't it wasn't
ever a situation where it was supposed to be like content. I
was like, "Hey, do you want to go to the beach?" Or, "Hey, do
you just want to like hang out? Like, do you want to do something?"
cuz like I was in Miami, he was there and like I was lonely and
stuff and I was so I asked him and it like so we we hung out
but in my mind like I never like I had made a joke about getting
married for health insurance but to that's as far as sick is
absolutely nuts. Yeah. I I feel like um N
Yeah. Listen, it was it was fun. I only got a little bit of it
but the night story about how he tried to rap his sister like
twice like Wait, who is this? Who get the somebody get the picture?
Who are you talking about? Sick unchained. Sick unch. I feel
like I recognize his name. There's just a there's a picture that
describes him. Okay, it's got a slur in it which I disavow, but
this picture is just it seems to perfectly describe so many people
on the internet and it's like why why is it so accurate? This
is just every every single time. It's like stop telling us your
private stories, okay? Stop telling us your private stories that
you find very embarrassing. Stop. That's a I get it. I get that
it's like feels cathartic. Okay, but stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Thank you. I also disavow
the language on that shirt. As it ever went, like I guess romantic
wise, like I had never shown interest in him other than a friend.
Like platonically, like I never He's not I'm not attracted to
him. Did Mau know about the the DM leaks from Destiny's side
in this? No, I don't. Did he bring those up? I don't find him
attractive. Like he's he's not my Your head is covered at the
bottom of the VOD. Oh, I was covering the It's just Please don't
bully me with it. Hold on. I'm confused. Why is BB poison saying
Kelly so much? Did I miss something? Is
saying you are this you are this image? Yeah, but I What embarrassing
information
about me? Like I'm not the one that overshares
absolutely nothing about health or medical records or anything
like that. Yeah, but like is that it? That's not like personal
really. It's just like I'm sick a lot. Who cares? Okay. Some
people would say there's nothing more personal than those things.
But you know what? I've got no idea way of saying that. I thought
like personal stuff like how you feel about and like you know
like interpersonal stuff. I thought that's like the stuff when
people are say don't overshare that stuff like your relationships
and like when you're people and like that stuff. You're you're
talking a lot. This chap in my in my VC right now. He talks about
people being willing to pull the trigger. I feel like I don't
hear anybody simp for women more than this guy. This guy couldn't
pull the trigger. He couldn't do it. I I'm I'm very feminist.
He couldn't pull the trigger. Did I do Should I message Mark?
Should we get Mark on? Let's go. Yeah, you could get Mark on.
Yeah, message Mark. Actually, get her to come on right now. We'll
pull up the uh the DMs from Destiny, the DM leaks, and she'll
explain she'll explain how this works. Cuz listen, it doesn't
doesn't look good for her narrative. You get his side of it.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. And it so it was never supposed to be anything
platonic, but we hung out and like, you know, I helped him set
up for his podcast and I played some games and stuff. Dad mocking
JTO. Wait, why would you think that that's what I'm saying? Is
that not the point of the DMs? No. Well, I mean, one of the DMs
makes it seem like if there was interest, it was from her side,
but it's more that like the clear implication is she's she's
asking like, "Hey, can I just wear like comfy clothes? That's
cool, right? We're just hanging out." And he was like, "Yeah,
we're just hanging out." Ry, what are you on about? I don't That's
totally not Cherry is totally welcome to come back and talk with
me. Close chat. Just close shot chat. Just close shot chat. Like
that. But then like
I had just stayed the night and I was like, "Yeah, we can cuddle."
And and stuff like that. Oh, apparently she stayed the night.
But then like it would like I had just stayed the night and I
was like, "Yeah, we can cuddle." And in my mind like I I
didn't get that. I didn't get that part of the allegations. The
cuddling allegation. Oh, no. Cuddling.
Cuddling. Apparently there there was cuddling that occurred.
I need to back it up now because Kelly was napping over this
person. And so it was never interested in him other than a friend
like platonically. Like I never he's not I'm not attracted to
him. Uh I don't find him attractive. Like he's he's not my type
and it so it was never supposed to be anything platonic but we
hung out and like you know I helped him set up for his podcast
and I played some games and stuff like that but then like it
would like I had just stayed the night and I was like yeah we
can cuddle. And in my mind, like I I understand that some people
see cuddling as like a thing, but mine it wasn't. It's more of
just like the like the
true. I've heard some people will even shower platonically with
their friends. Wow.
Contact with a human. And I I did that once when I was covered
in red bloody paint after cosplay. Yeah, that's true. X. I had
been going through like some like troubling things as far as
like being alone all the time and and just wanting to be around
and around around the person and I had I had explicitly explained
that to him like in on Discord. So like he there was no like
room to think that I wanted to sleep with him. He's and so we
cuddled whatever and then like he had made a move to which I
turned him down. And then after the fact like it wasn't so much
that he made a move that bothered me. What bothered me is that
he led me to believe that we would be platonic friends. And it
was just ironic that after I had turned him down, suddenly there
was no more contact. Suddenly, he wasn't, you know, checking
on me and asking how I was doing. Suddenly, it wasn't like us
being friends. It just completely
he just completely stopped contact, which is fine. Like, cuz
around that time, he was also going to the Middle East and like
we had talked about that a little bit. So, I understood that
he was busy. So, I wasn't like bombarding him with messages or
anything, but like eventually it got to a point was like this
is I I talked to Murk about this and I was like, "Hey, do you
keep trying to check in?" And she was like, "No." after like
I messaged him and he didn't message me back. I just stopped
messaging him. I don't know, dude. I don't know if you have platonic
friends, but that happens. If you just stop messaging your platonic
friends, that happens. This sus. Didn't she say this on your
stream before? Uh, she said some of these things. I don't think
she said the thing about spending the night, but like I didn't
you and now you don't want to talk to me. Like, okay, whatever.
Weird. And what makes it even I don't know. This would feel less
weird to me if she didn't come on my stream and I was like, "Hey,
did you like keep messaging him?" And she was like, "No." I was
like, "Oh, well, that could happen with somebody who's busy.
You just like fall out of contact." He's like, "I know." And
then now it's like back with new twists.
Always a little concerning when it's back with new twists after
they've had some time to think about it. More ironic is he I
don't think that's concerning at all. That's actually like that's
actually like what just happens like that. Like when you're and
I'm not saying that this is abuse, but like victims of abuse
are like known for recanting or like coming back 5 years later
and being like, "Oh yeah, this actually was abuse." Like after
you have time to think about something and and uh you're like
more informed by the relationship, it's actually completely normal
to see it in a different light. Sure. But there is no additional
information here that I'm aware of. But could be true. I just
don't I I feel like it's not Yeah, it's not new information.
Yeah. I don't I don't think I don't think it's like a proof,
but just to what you said, it's like when people just literally
to what you said, but uh there's nothing abuse here, right, though?
I mean, I agree with you in general. That's just I don't think
so. That's fine. Yeah. Also, isn't it normal if she didn't want
to be more than friends and he just he ghosted? Isn't that what
you want the guy to do? Uh, sure. But I like I don't know. We'd
have to see all of the DMs to like judge, right? Cuz she's saying
like he committed to being a platonic friendship. I have no idea
what the that means. The does that mean? I don't know what that
means. Cuz I saw from logs I guess from his like his his chat
or whatever and like I think Cherry had showed me and stuff like
that like where he was kind of making it like I didn't want to
be friends with him or I didn't want to talk to him anymore or
I removed him from my life. he was like setting up the whole
time or like we weren't really like cuz that I had to go back
cuz he was basically painting the picture cuz I saw from logs
I guess from his like his his chat or whatever and like I think
Cherry had showed me and stuff like that like where he was kind
of making it like I didn't want to be friends with him or I didn't
want to talk to him anymore or I removed him from my life was
like setting up the whole time or like we weren't really like
cuz that and that's not even what happened like I was completely
fine with the interaction we had him setting up his stuff and
me
donated $5.
Weird. I smell sulfur. We listen to music and just talk. Like
that's what I wanted. Like so for him to like completely flip
the script and make it seem like I was the one who had a problem
with how it went down and how I didn't want to be friends with
him when I was consistently like reaching out and like tried
to say that.
Yeah. Yeah. That was one of the things he said. He said, "Oh,
is this like on stream or is this on It's like his me like no
it no it was they brought it up to me. It was messages where
he said oh Merc is mad at me because she sat there the whole
time. And then he's I've also heard that it's because of my BPD
that I'm angry. Like I've seen so many things he said that has
contradict contradicted each of his you know things that he said
was the reason why I wasn't wanting to be friends with him which
none of them are true and they all contradict each. Kelly, what
did you spill this time? First it was the mint pies and now it's
something else. Oh,
my
matcha latte. I'm so sad.
Okay. each other. So, it's just it's just ironic to me that like
nobody can see through the Yeah, I didn't hear it either. Like
he tried to me. I didn't want to him and suddenly he just dropped
me. And it's like that's fine. Like like whatever, but like don't
paint it like we're going to be friends because that's how I
viewed it. I viewed it as a friendship. And it wasn't even a
content friendship because I never after the fact I had I during
the whole situation and after the one few times I was on his
stream, I never asked to be on his stream. I didn't want to be
on his stream because for me I valued an offstream friendship.
That's what I wanted. I wanted to hang out. I wanted to play
games. Like it didn't have to be content to me. So it's just
it's ironic how he's painting the story different and in multiple
different Show the logs.
Okay. Uh hold on. [__] Were these logs? One second.
I'll pull them up. I'll let her keep for a second. Okay. Do you
do you I understand if you don't but do you happen to have any
of those messages that I could pull up to like prove what you're
saying is real like him talking to other people. If you don't
like
Yeah. I don't I don't think I have the screenshot. I think Cherry
has it. It's like it said that Oh, I think this is what it could
explicitly. Mark is mad because she spent she spent like 6 hours
downstairs or something like that. Uh I can't remember who has
the screenshot. It's either Cherry cuz it was we talked about
it on JTOK stream so I don't I don't have the screenshot but
like like I have all of our messages and it's not like he it's
not like it's just what upsets me is he's trying to make it seem
like I chose not to be friends anymore and he's constantly giving
like false examples or like Okay, so the DM here is uh hold on
is there anything else from Destiny here? There isn't. But I
think Merc super doesn't like me because she came over one night
like two months ago or something and basically sat downstairs
for 6 hours while was organizing cables in the studio. little
W. So, oh, he's so cool. That's that's the message that he's
talking about. And then it's good/ ready for me to swing by.
Yeah, comfy clothes. Okay, right. We're just chilling. Yeah.
Also, if you got a vape or something, it's okay if it's water
vapor, but my apartment is super ultra crazy strict about smoking.
He says, "How do we feel about like 35-year-old men saying things
like LOL W?" What's our thoughts on that? Public
I mean, it's an emote in a chat. It's just like the way people
speak. I think I think your uh hyper anal your overanalyzation
of it is strange to me. I'm the autistic one. I mean you are,
but that wasn't the allegation I was making. Anyway, and then
there's this one which was you missed a call on November 30th.
So, I sat downstairs for 6 hours while you fixed your cables.
You're a liar and you know it. Oh, actually, hold on. This message
I know what this message means. Uh MC was taking this to mean
what he was saying was like, "I didn't hang out with you. You
sat you just sat in like the lobby and she didn't realize when
he says downstairs he means his office, right? He just he means
his office. Sorry, not 6 months later. How long later? Uh, no,
6 months later. It is 6 months later. But this is this is like
when Destiny talked about it. This is her response to the Russell
logs we just set up. Oh, not this is her response to this, right?
Which again, uh, 11:29. This is the next day. This So, she thinks
that he's saying that she sat in his lobby, right? But that's
not what that's not what happened. they like hung out in the
same room. Now, I don't I don't She didn't mention the like I
I don't recall her mentioning the staying overnight. So, that's
strange. Lies as to why that is. And that's what I'm going to
back this up like all her messages. And it's not like he It's
not like It's just what upsets me is he's trying to make it seem
like I chose not so for 6 months she had the wrong impression.
Nothing wrong there. No, no, no. It wasn't that she had the wrong
impression. I think she got annoyed about it after they didn't
hang out anymore and then she like started talking about it a
little bit and then she kind of misunderstood what he was saying
there and we talked about it and then she was like good and now
she's not good again. She said she stayed the night before he
went to Israel. That was a long time ago. Okay. Not to be friends
anymore and he's constantly giving like false examples or like
lies as to why that is. And that's what bothers me. And it like
for him to paint the picture like we were going to be friends
and then him make a move and because I turned down his advances
now we're not friends anymore. Like that just goes to show like
he wanted to me. And if you if you were attracted to me I would
respect you more if you would just say that outright like hey
the only reason I want to hang out with you is because I want
to then I would have never even hung out with him. You know what
I'm saying? Like it to me it was just two friends hanging out
and it was a completely different situation.
Did you try to reach out to him at all and he just Yes. Okay.
I listen I would appreciate if the woman would just say if you
try to me I'm going to me to you. That would be nice. Okay. Well,
I'm a post about it. You try to me I'm I'm post about it. Maybe
don't like hang out with like a like a addict den best and expect
him like not to worry. You say all of those things about M. That's
up. Did you chill? Yeah. Sorry.
Yeah, I did. I did multiple times. And like I told you that near
the end of our relation or our friendship, it was he was in the
Middle East and like we were keeping in contact about that. Like
I was asking him how his trip was going like you know take pictures
I want to see like stuff like that. And then like I knew for
a fact he had gotten back cuz he was streaming at a setup and
I had messaged him didn't get a response. Gave it a few days
messaged him again and then I just completely stopped cuz why
should I if someone clearly doesn't want to be friends with me
I'm not going to continue trying. So I just stopped talking to
him and then some information got misconstrued. Like I thought
he said that I was in the lobby and I never even met him and
that upset me because then it was another lie that he was per
perpetuating. So I had messaged him and I went off on him and
he didn't answer and then I just blocked him and like I just
want to be completely removed from it. It's it just it's it's
ironic to me that people can't see through the like the only
is the way you become completely removed from this stuff by going
and doing going and doing yeah well tweeting that but then going
and doing like interviews and just all over the place. Reason
people are going to think that I'm lying or like that's not how
it went is simply because Destiny's community is way larger than
mine. Uh he has a better reputation with his community because
his community are just like him. They're all weirdos. they, you
know, they they think a certain way, which is shouldn't be, you
know, the public consensus, but it is. And it's like they're
finding ways to okay his behavior. And from what I've seen, like
this isn't the first time something like this has happened. So,
it's just ironic that multiple girls have said something has
happened, but nobody wants to listen to them. Nobody wants to
hold him accountable for how he behaves or his actions. It's
always the other girl. It's because she has BPD or she's a liar
or she's this. And it's it's not the case whatsoever. Okay. What
did you what did you know about Destiny before like trying to
hang out with him or meet him or anything like that? I mean,
when I first started streaming, like I would go into people's
Discords, like I didn't know who he was. I knew he was a streamer,
but I would get people in my chat saying, "Yo, go in this Discord
and like troll or whatever or go get on this person's Discord."
And so I would I didn't know who he was until after the fact
after I was on a stream. I didn't know that he was like a debate
bro or that he did all this stuff. Like I didn't know exactly
what I was getting into. So, I met him, did the streams, and
after that I was like, "Oh, like, you know, we we're still in
contact. Let's just like let's like be friends or whatever."
And I was moving to Miami, too. So, it's like I didn't know ultimately
who he was. I didn't cuz wait, what is people supposed to see
through? What are we supposed to get from this interview? Destiny
is a tries to people. We know. Yeah. Uh well, it's the fact that
he treats them differently after is what she's saying, which
is Yeah. that I mean part of literally like Max's, you know,
Destiny report had proof that like right after I told Stephen
I wasn't going to have sex with me like immediately started like
talking about me differently on stream like immediately like
then like the week the same week when I wouldn't meet up with
him at TwitchCon and that's when everything like went haywire.
Like it's I totally I totally believe Mark. She has no reason
to lie about this. She's come out about like people before and
she knows that like all you get is people like harassing you
and telling you like to keep yourself like there's no like she
gains nothing from being dishonest about this. Okay. I mean so
I have a completely different outlook on this cuz I don't live
my life the way Destiny does. But like I guess if you're more
like liberal about
what does he owe you to like be friends with you beyond?
No, he doesn't realize he doesn't owe you anything, but you would
you would hope that after you turn someone down and you guys
are like friends. So, this is the problem with having like casual
with your friends is like you would hope that the friendship
still holds it together enough for them to like not trash talk
you and change the narrative on you completely after denying
them uh like having sex with you. Like that's what you would
hope to happen. Okay. So, as someone that didn't have to destiny,
I feel like I need to like slightly defend him. I think the issue
here is not the or any of this stuff. It's that he can't really
like continue to maintain communication with people that ask
a lot from him. And if you're going from someone that's flirting
with him a lot and communicating with him a lot and then you
get upset that he's like communicating less because you guys
aren't flirting anymore,
uh, that's going to feel like you're being discarded, but it
probably isn't. You're just getting the same treatment now as
everybody else. Yeah, I think that's different than what like
I think has been the case with like someone like Anna uh or like
me or like it's not about like not I mean I guess with Anna she
was upset that he just wasn't talking to her. Yeah, I would Okay,
she would like loop and spiral and whilst I totally understand
why she did that and like it's everyone else started to understand
why like you know we learned a bit about OCD and what have you
at the time I can understand why there was a lot of like conflict.
But it's it's the OCD. You you say OCD, but it's also just like
someone like it's this person who is like complete control of
your narrative to thousands of people. It's like it's actually
not even like a pathological behavior to want to like clear the
record. I mean, yeah, I agree. So when people say reputation
rehab to me, it's irritating. About to step in and talk about
how lab did nothing
right? Cuz you guys haven't had direct experience with this.
So shut up. But let us finish speaking first. Sorry. actually
about
runner up DG of the year. Queen is about to defend Destiny. Go
ahead until after we finish. Absolutely [__] Anyway,
but yeah, I get that. Um, and I also get like I don't know like
at what point him and Anna resolved things and then they went
back to whatever like
I mean it's their question. Well, I don't care because whatever.
I do think that Destiny is completely capable of having like
platonic relationships with women. I just think that the situations
that led to these like I guess kind of relationships.
It's just they have additional problems, right? Queenman, shut
the up and let Kelly finish. Yeah, she's saying so much right
now. So Anna actually asked Destiny at one point to help rehab
her image. And Destiny's response was, "We can think about that
later, but for now, I just want to keep rubbing your legs and
feet until you finish your essays." Why do you remember this
thing? Because I I I read the Mr. Girl,
my Bible. So, I mean, I think gross. I think that's a crazy thing
to say to someone with like OCD around ruminating
on a public perception. I mean, that situation was very weird
in general. I will give you that one. I mean, it's it's clear
that he like even like he definitely does favor and talk highly
of of the women that he's currently having a relationship with,
but immediately after it's cut off or if she doesn't want to
go do something further or whatever, it's like he has sort of
like an established pattern of like completely changing the narrative
um in a way that he has full control over with his audience.
Uh I Lauren, same thing with Lauren. you attach so much of this
to like intentionality that I just Okay, I want to say something
about Lauren. Okay, he was defending Lauren up until the point
that she turned on him, which was after him and Molina had broken
up. And as I predicted correctly, Lauren was like, "Oh, you and
Molina aren't together anymore, want to get in a relationship."
Obviously, Destiny wasn't interested. Okay, I predicted this
like way before it happened. And I knew that she would go nuts.
So, now the thing is like Lauren's reasoning for why like uh
she hates Destiny. Now, she knew all of those things prior to
that point. So, that's why I don't really like Poff stuck in
what she says, right? Like all of this Lauren knowing that Destiny
had apparently quotations recorded people. She knew that before
she suggested that she was interested in like dating him. Sure.
But I think even before she talked about Steven, there had been
behind the scenes of of like their relationship going sour even
before she went public. And then before her going public,
I don't know if that's true. And then before going public with
what she said, uh, he had been bad mouthing her. I mean, you
if you've read the Mr. Girl report, it's like literally like
shown in full messages like every Mr. Report wasn't about like
stuff though, right? This is more recent. Okay. my personal experience,
what is like literally recorded through like hundreds of messages
is the second I said no, I'm not going to come to TwitchCon.
I'm not going to have sex with you, he started calling me like
a uh he he started talking extremely negative about me um online
like the next day. So, and that's it like there's Wait, what
can we see what behavior followed or preceded that? I would just
like to see like what what video
Yeah. What did you do appearance? Yeah, there was Hold on. Is
that not a valid question? No, I didn't do I didn't do anything.
It's like appearance. Was there nothing between these things?
What justifies a BSJ
up? You know exactly what I'm saying. And if you could pull the
trigger, you'd ask this question. But you are the s that I've
labeled
up. I I honestly I mean you could see I like Max literally lays
out like the whole like week that it happened um in the report.
I like I just don't think that anything happened. It was like
literally like a a night and day shift. Okay. I mean, I don't
recall reading this stuff, but I feel like if that were true,
probably wouldn't have been such a huge flop. I would just have
to say that's not No, it was a flop because nobody read it. Like,
it wasn't a flop because I do not believe that Chud Logic had
a favorable opinion of it and he read the entire thing. I know
because it's documented. Yeah. And he knows he swept deep down.
Yeah. I don't know. I'm lost. I think this was Chud's last moment
on the plantation when he started contemplating escape is where
he started figuring out his escape plan right there as he read
the Mr. Girl report. Okay. He keeps up at night. He loses sleep.
Trust me. Okay. He's actually said several times that I'm his
official spokesperson on this stream. So, you know. Uhhuh. My
words as good as his. That's what I That's what I said. that
he's an
I don't
I sort of I trust women to like to be able to parse when a person
is treating them wrong. Like I think it's very like differently
after like saying I don't want to have sex with you. Like I think
I it's a very like clear as day behavior if you've ever been
a woman like and told one of your friends like I'm not interested.
It's not going to happen. Like you you know what Well, they wanted
a romantic relationship. They I mean the best thing to do when
you want a romantic relationship with somebody and you have a
platonic one currently is to end the platonic relationship cuz
you're just going to keep obsessing. That's what everybody wants
unless you just want somebody who's obsessed with you in a s.
As soon as they move to like something beyond the platonic uh
the relationship either goes beyond that or it's over. There
is no it's only coping who think it goes back to being like oh
we're just going to be someone said someone said a there's a
comment in chat that says how is Tiny's behavior different from
any other guy who wants from you which I think is a really interesting
thing to talk about because I don't think that it's like that
bad of a like I think it's it's not that bad if your friend IRL
is like you know if your male friend wants to have sex with you
and then you're like no and then he sort of badmouths you to
other friends it's like kind of no harm no foul it's just like
Understandable
when that boy now has
like an audience of thousands of thousands of people who are
mobilized to harass anyone that he has beef with. It becomes
something very different. It's if they start smearing you that
would be bad. But I don't I need to see like the evidence of
that happening. And I don't think that evidence really like convinced
anybody. Have you have you read the Mr. Girl report or have you
read the the Destiny report after
control.
I would have watched most of I would have watched most of Chud's
coverage of it. Okay. I think that you need to read it in hindsight
now and I think that you will have a different opinion.
Sit down with it, JTO. Take a weekend. No, we should pull it
up on stream though and you should just control F to whatever
the point's talking about is. That'd be interesting. Could be.
Yeah. I mean, he has video like, you know, he has timestamps
of days, dates of like when everything happened, what was going
beyond like what we were messing me messaging each other and
what he was saying about me online. Uh, somebody if somebody
wants to link me like a hyperlink to where we're going, we can
cover that, but I like I don't see why I would need to read
I think it's normal to be bitter. I just I think that when you
I would just like to know Hold on. Also, can you just give me
where new information has come out that makes it more likely
that Destiny smears people after they don't have with him? He
didn't talk about Merc. There's no information that supports
that being a pattern. Well, one, I think it's um pretty damning
that like Molina is like not allowed to talk and has been like
threatened into silence. Like, yeah, I think that's pretty damning.
I think that the things that Simon has said about situation is
also damning. I think that like it's just I don't think she wants
to. I mean, she's just doing it. Well, yes, because it's it is
an implicit threat that if she talks that she will be harassed
and he literally literally said on a stream like if she says
anything, I have like mountains of of that I could throw at her.
Like I I don't like like do you think that that's like that's
not healthy to do? I mean, as a I also threaten people so I really
I don't know how much I can criticize people. No. And I honestly
to some degree this is a normal behavior. He also do that to
some degree. This is like a normal me. I'm like immediately,
yeah, I'll release everything. But someone with a platform has
a different responsibility than you
Overt dummy. Thank you for the 12. Sorry, the two gifted. The
two gifted. I have not been tracking.
We are over the time for over the amount for another hour. She's
in a nice position cuz like Destiny's banned on Twitch, right?
So her one platform she can speak on. She's not really a huge
like what's the word? Danger, I guess. I don't know. My mic is
trash. Oh, it might be because I dropped my drink everywhere
and with the settings. My bad. Yep. Let me see. Whoops. My bad.
Lav has incentive to lie and profit socially.
Like, what incentive? You guys are so brainwashed. It It's like
actually [__] Yeah, I've got it pulled up as well.
Yeah, it's like what am I gaining? What am I gaining by telling
the truth? Okay. And then hold on. I need to go reset these [__]
subs really quickly. Give me two seconds. Laugh implicitly begging
people to go harass Anna and Mela's peak radant behavior. Yeah,
you guys are deranged. Like actually just brain dead losers.
Okay, we got it up there now. All right. Uh December 29th, Destiny
asked Lab to meet the following week during TwitchCon for another
encounter. She expressed non-committal interest after Destiny
reiterate. Do we have screenshots of this? Uh after Destiny reiterated
the proposition, Lab complained that their latest stream together
was posted with the title. Destiny actually convinces her to
concede a trans debate. Lav suggested the alternate alternate
title girl gets negged by Steven for 56 minutes straight. The
top YouTube comment comments include included my vote is to replace
Lav with the cool Ukrainian girl. The So where's the flip within
the week here? You need to keep reading. Sorry, you said meticulously
documented flip within a week. Yeah. So there's like multiple
paragraphs in you. Okay. So we've got we've got no behavior from
Destiny. That is different. We've got Destiny's editor putting
a title on
one paragraph. Oh, we'll keep going. During the stream, hold
on. During the stream, this is uh this October 5th. During the
stream, Lav announced that she had posted a nude to Twitter and
would be returning to Only Fans after all. So after you had basically
the reason you'd come into the community, you'd flipped on that
entirely. You entirely 180ed on that. Okay. A post on Destiny
subreate praised me for predicting Lab's return to work. It received
768 up votes. One of them was mine. By this point, a narrative
about Lav had taken root in Destiny's fear. She's slippery, annoying,
and needed to be held accountable for her contradictions. She
showed promise and some flickering signs of intelligence, but
is imperative that she learned to take feedback improve and improve
as an interlocutor. For example, Chloic posted a 75minute video
in November 2022 titled Lavloon confronted and exposed her for
absurd cloud sharking and flip-flopping in which seven men bered
Lav about rudeness of her the rudess of her decision to abruptly
leave a small streaming panel for a large one. Yeah, it's better.
Of course, Destiny himself is prone to lying and avoiding accountability.
So, we've gone to now November and a Chud video. Still seen no
Destiny behavior.
Are we going to see the meticulously documented Destiny?
Yes. I you this how many pages is this Chad? Like I don't know.
I I don't recall reading it. I It's I think it's over 200 pages.
Like I And it's October streams where she took notes on Lab's
past public appearances and hunted for inconsistencies. On October
8th, 2022 from San Diego, Destiny DM'd Lab at task if she was
coming down to see him. I'm having like a mental health moment.
So though, so I don't know what's going on. Cherry's doing note
takingaking on all my convos. And I tuned in because I was surprised
and I thought the unhinged was a bit and it's uh it's fully not.
Uh oh yeah. Well, damn. Don't uh take anything she says personally.
Lol. She's being super personal. It's very weird. Waiting for
the tweet longer about me next. dot dot dot. I was in a weird
place already, but tuning into that stream edit like 10 times
worse. Dot dot dot. I nuked my YouTube and I'm deciding if I
still want to stream. I'm going to hide. Jesse suggested she
write down the names of people she cares about and try to remember
that no one else's opinion matters. Hours later, he asked if
she was coming down to San Diego. I'm in a blanket watching movies.
Have fun with your nerd friends. Are you awake? Cuz Cherry is.
Lol. Yeah. October 13th. So this is another week later. Uh cuz
Sherry is. Lol. Is she on? Yeah, she is. She's ready to go. I'm
coming. What does this have to do with Cherry? Sorry, I missed.
Oh my god. Go back and watch, Kelly. No, you missed it. You've
missed. Coincidentally,
I DM'd him at the same time. Oh, I can't hear Jessica. I [__]
End yourself. what it is. Aster. Okay. Uh, so we're on to two
weeks later and there's no shift in behavior from Destiny. He's
just saying, "Are you coming to
Okay. That's make it clear. The the original the original claim
was a complete flip-flop in behavior within like a day." Okay.
Okay. Keep reading, Chad. I'm sorry. So, what does this happen?
So, we we can say that that didn't happen. That didn't happen.
After after 24 hours. No, keep reading. I'm just going to write
it in chat. Okay. Not within a week. Sure. And within that week,
within within whatever a week of this, you flipped your initial
primary position that you came to the community defending that
work was wrong. It was morally wrong and people were basically
being raped for doing sex work, right? And you flipped that.
You said you were going back to Only Fans. I first of all, I
didn't I think that that's mischaracterized. I didn't flip it.
I I I have maintained the same thoughts about work since the
beginning. going back to be. Okay, I got you. And people don't
know. I said that had a lot to do with whether or not you're
doing it because you need the money. At the time, I did not need
the money. I did not think that consent was money. My argument
is very salient. Just because people didn't like what I was saying
doesn't mean that I flip-flopped. Oh, apparently Destiny also
praised your Chud logic panel that you did the 1v however many.
Apparently, what is this? It's a Chud video. Lavaloon confronted
and exposed for abruptly leaving. So Stephen up until the point
where I said that I wasn't coming to TwitchCon was extremely
complimentary to me on stream. His Reddit was like completely
lit up with like saying that he wore kid gloves with me and this
is in November apparently. He said you did really well on this
that I wasn't that smart. Yes, but it's the way that you need
to watch the video. I'm pretty sure that they're linked somewhere
or I think that there's a separate document with links
uh where like the way that he says it he'll say like yeah she's
extremely manipulative like he's starting to to change the
like very like I like there's no way that I could say this that
like you guys are so brainwashed that like you can't even you
your only response will be like yeah but you are I'm listening
and learning personally. Huh? I'm listening to nothing personally.
Jesus Christ. Oh, I didn't hit play on this. I'm taking five
minutes off of it. I think there's way more than five minutes
that was not included, but I hit play on that earlier. Okay.
Do you need me to keep reading? Is there going to be more here
about how he's changed completely?
I mean, yeah. I if you keep reading, yes, you get to see how
he is. He changes over time after I decide to not sleep with
him. Okay. This October 13th. Coincidentally, I DM'd him at that
same time to ask if he was available to talk the next night because
I thought things seemed tense between us. We'd been arguing about
Nick Fentes for a week and he'd taken to banning community members
who took my side in the argument. He told me he was free to talk
right then. Again, I didn't understand the nature of excuse me,
the nature of Desi's content at that point, and he had no idea
or I had no idea that he would agree to a conversation about
a relationship while simultaneously setting up a cage match between
Lav and Cherry, all to cause maximum chaos. However, I ended
up being quiet for most of the stream because I didn't understand
why I was there. Lav and I joined the stream around the same
time. She angrily confronted Cherry for mockingly telling her
to call a hotline. You did a video in your announcement to returning
to work that you privated your videos and you blamed it on me.
You said I'm doing these streams. I'm so mean and you got banned
from my chat because you couldn't help but keep watching and
it was like self harm to you. So when I do have somebody who
I think is not well who is historian
history suicidality
and cherry related you can you can blow past this. Okay. Well
I mean I it seems like Max is including it like it's a big part
of this like
happened was a thing. Sure. Me and Cherry were fighting at that
point and then he had like this is when he was like oh these
like I'm like I'm going to make content now of them fighting.
Okay. Cherry and Lab continue to fight about Lab's stances on
work with Destiny half moderating and half leading to exchanges
like this. Okay, so you're not going to post any nude photographs
of yourself just meant to be enjoyed. It's going to all be educational
stuff. Well, people can jack off to those like people are going
to jack off to those. That's not what I asked. I don't know what
you're talking about. What I'm asking is, are you going to post
any random nudes or naked stuff? You're only going to post educational
stuff? No, I will post naked stuff also. Well, okay. Well, that's
After the stream, he DM' Lav. Good combo. Sorry everyone jumps
in to gang up on you. Uh, Lav just brings everyone to the yard,
I guess. Christ. Smiley face. I'm myself. That means Cherry wins,
though. Lauo, dude, cherries. I hate you now, Smiley. Do you
think I'm dumb? Not at all. I think you're pretty smart, to be
honest. Just confused about organizing
some concepts in your head, and it's ultra hard to sort that
out in literal combat arenas online. You really are trying to
figure this stuff out on ultra hard mode. Try not to let random
losers discourage you online. Trying cringing late in the night.
What? Aren't you cringing so hard? Uh-huh. Al combat arenas online.
Bro, that's some danger with this [__] That is rough.
In the arena of ideas. We're in the arena of ideas. You can't
make fun of it after participating.
I actually
since I'veated and my brain has Trying hard. Trying hard. You
can't send that back and then go, "Oh, this is cringe." In retrospect,
this guy trying to cheer me up. Cringe. Actually cringe. Wait,
no, I don't think him trying to cheer me up is cringe. I think
being in a debate in a debate sphere like online is cringe. Oh,
no, you can say that. Yeah. Anyway,
uh late in the night sharing startup publicly accused me of flashing
them had a herniated disc. We know all this. I don't want to
go into this too much cuz uh I feel like it was just listen people
got gassed up. Okay. Think it's up. No, he's not. What are you
talking about? Wait, hold on. I think it's up because Max she
is Max's friend. We already know that Max has this wound.
$5 Lav lied about Hassan doing a Did she? I I don't know that
and I'm not going to ask her any questions about it because I'm
going to keep asking if it happened or not and I want that that
plausible deniability. So,
uh, we already know that Max is his wound. He's very public about
it where he's very cautious of himself around women. No, he's
not. What are you talking about? Yes, he is. No, he's made so
many women cry or feel uncomfortable on stream. What do you mean
he's careful? No, no, no, no. He's married to another woman.
There's no relationship between him and other women. Wait, is
he married to Shayen? No. I mean, maybe colloally he's saying
married like monogous. I think I think he just doesn't care.
I think he just didn't care about their relationship, so he like
just inferred. Wait, so these are preceding some of these
uh DMs. So, we already read the I'm coming. Christ, I'm myself.
So, above this, my wife dropped for the best. Steven some light
teasing. I'd never spill. No, we keep each other's secrets. We
have a beautiful symbiosis. I keep your secrets. You eat my heart
bury. Oh god, I'm actually talking to myself. I actually don't
want to go through this anymore. We're about to Is she on? I'm
coming. Actually got to go. Actually got to go. The dates.
Well, no. I put together the dates cuz we read these DMs. This
is like earlier in the day. Okay. I Yeah. I just The idea that
like there's no element here. um like after you guys didn't meet
up. I think that's just incorrect. Show the meme. Also, this
this this part up here is not included in the report, which is
feels a little disingenuous to tell you the truth to cut this
part out of the report. I'm sorry, but that feels quite disingenuous.
Quean, what do you think about cutting this log out of the report
when it's from a few hours earlier? What was the part they should
have been included around?
Uh this entire part of the log right here where like clearly
the What was being said? What what claims this relevant to? relevant
to the claim that Destiny had 180ed on Lav that he that after
the refusal to be uh to be to go to TwitchCon that Destiny had
totally 180 on her and that their relationship changed like he
he just did. I I don't even care. I He just did and I don't
My most embarrassing moment of my life is is ever have like ever
I didn't want to talk about any of this. Why did we get I know.
I forgot. I forgot how embarrassing it was. I forgot how embarrassing
it was. Sorry. I don't want to talk about anymore. You're right.
I lied. I lied. He never did anything wrong to me. And I'm not
even saying that. I just I didn't want to cover any of this.
And I get forced
claims that I've been Yeah. I don't I for I forgot the rabbit
hole we were going into. I I lied. It doesn't matter. I actually
never genuinely I lied about ever meeting up with him. We never
met. We never met up. So yeah. Wait. So did Matt Where does Max
say uh Destiny 318? Well, I don't know who you're talking about
with uh Yeah. I don't know. I don't know who this I don't know
who this person I think that was the general narrative that like
Destiny had changed when um when lab I think I just I just don't
know you said it was disingenuous to cut out the report but I
was wondering what which claim which point it was meant to be
included at what was this okay what were you fighting with Cherry
at the time about cuz I'm a bit lost on this one was it about
what was what about were you fighting with Cherry about cuz this
was 2022 I don't I forget I I think she inconsistency on our
She had made Okay. Is that it? Oh, I remember that. We did like
a bunch of feminism panels. I didn't bl No. No. She had she had
did a deep dive on me and she had like told me to like call this
hotline or something and I thought that that was just like crazy
rude. I had like never been uh treated like that in the space
at that point. I just think it's funny coming from her specifically
telling other people to call us. Well, yeah. I mean, in hindsight,
yeah, of course that's funny, but it is what it is. Very strange.
Okay. Uh, where are we going? More merc DMs got released apparently
for these ones. Miscarriage eat a freak. True. What? Yummy, yummy.
Okay, can we not? I can't believe I got seven nominations and
I didn't win anything. You guys for what?
DG awards. Oh yeah, congratulations.
DJ of the year. That's awesome, man. You should put on your CV.
You should tell us a joint nomination for both of us. You know,
you you as my primary male co-host was joint nomination for both.
Thank you for all your efforts. I appreciate it. Uh shaking my
head. Okay, whatever you say. In like a week and a half, my apartment
will be empty. I won't have someone over at that point. Lol.
Have fun in Austin. Oh, perfect. Your boyfriend is leaving. Smiley
face. I need one. I want a friends with benefits, actually. Oh,
yeah. I find like finding some Who just left? Laugh. Okay. Uh
I find like finding someone off Tinder would be super easy for
you. What the? Nah, I tried it. Tinder Grow. Snow cute, man.
I'd rather just yearn for for it than actually get it. I've been
busy with Overwatch anyway. I actually really like it. It's addicting.
Been helping with my depression. Oh well, that's good if it's
keeping you occupied at least. I'm still bored. Well, how do
you feel about plastic surgery? Um, I mean, I could maybe understand
some people are going to say, "Well, this is her hinting at something."
I don't know that that's necessarily true. I mean, you guys
just the crazy kind of autistic woman
Oh, well, I'm I'm friends with this guy, so I'm going to tell
him that the stuff I tell the woman I'm friends with, it's not
going to be taken any different way. Yeah, I think that's what's
happening here, bro. This is her
uh wanting to is a FWB, bro. Pisco molding. Okay, what's Pisco
Malding about? Ken just joined the channel, by the way, as is
always true for all of these times where somebody is like annoying.
Yeah, Pisco join. Uh,
hold on. Listen, Pisco, if you want to come in and and make this
point that Merc is like thirsting for Destiny's, you're welcome
to join. Okay, go ahead.
No way. Pisco was coming. Okay, that would be funny. Well, I'm
just saying that like if you want to make that point, that's
fine. That would be awesome. What did you say? Let me read this.
Yeah, please go. Come on. J such bad. What the are you guys actually
kissless? Why can't I just chat in peace? No way I join. Okay.
Well, I'm just saying if you want to do that, you can go ahead
and do that. I'll let other people listen. I read the logs as
they're saying. I'm saying this isn't necessarily that and I
don't know if that I would necessarily say this like Yeah, I
don't know that I would necessarily imply when she says I want
the FWB that that means she's asking. You need to get the yes
or no in there if you want to imitate Pisco.
Does this mean this? Yes or no? Yes or no? Okay, we read this.
We back to the more of this interview. Like I I've already said
I think Murk misrepresented this. I I feel like she misrepresented
but whenever I
listen intentionally misrepresent intentional misrepresent. Yeah.
Do you think it I don't I mean that's trying to that's trying
to split hairs between like well is she like mentally ill in
some way that makes her like feel like this is reality? I'm not
totally I don't think she's mentally I think she's just a bit
I don't know if I'm mentally ill. Okay. Listening to the allegations.
I'm not listening to what people say. Like
we only care. I'm very oblivious when it comes to stuff like
that. I don't do my own research on people and I don't really
care to because what what matters to me is how the person treats
me which we see how he treated me. So, you know, but like I wasn't
I'm not into this person's lore. I'm very self-absorbed in that
sense. Like I wasn't worried about all that. I wasn't doing the
research. I don't care. like it's just people that I come across
or people I come, you know, I have a connection with and that's
that's literally all it is. So, as far as like what I know about,
I didn't know anything. It's just like me meeting someone, me
talking to someone for the first time, getting to know someone.
So, okay. Um, you say he he made a move on you while you were
cuddling. Is this the first instance that you could remember
of him like trying to initiate something like that? Well, that's
the only time. That's the only time. He wasn't like flirting
with you or nothing before that? No, I wouldn't say it was flirtatious.
I didn't see anything that was like, "Oh, he's flirting with
me." Also, I'm extremely nice. Rean Ruben donated $3. Merc put
in the UI in autism. Jesus Christ. When it comes to like friendships
and the opposite, so maybe he could have said something, but
I it doesn't register to me like that. I don't think he was predatory.
I don't think that he was doing necessarily anything wrong. And
him making a move. I mean, you have a girl laying in your bed.
Like, I get that. and he respected, you know, when he made the
move, what he did what he did. You know, I slapped his hand away
and that was the end of it. It's just upsetting to me that he
portrayed it like we would just be friends. And so, it's just
ironic that whenever I turn him down, suddenly he stops talking
to me. That's what I have a problem with. And I mean, you know,
but I also I also never led him to believe that I was interested
in him. Like, if I'm interested in someone, they're going to
know because I don't I don't hold my cards close to my chest.
I I lay it all out there like, "Oh, I'm into you. Like, I like
you. I I have a crush on you. Like it's it's very obvious when
I'm into someone. And I never did any of that with him. I never
had said that I was interested in him. I never I never did any
of that. So I don't I think he took me cuddling with him as like
that, you know, in which is fair, but also if I'm explicitly
saying I don't want that or like I'm showing you that I want
to be friends, I think it's it's it's a difficult situation.
Okay. What is the uh
what would you say the general like atmosphere or vibe as as
gay as that sounds was when you were talking to him off stream
like either in person through text or on calls or anything? I
think I well in person platonic cuddling. Well, there have been
former community members, okay, there have been former community
members who have suggested that you can platonically shower with
your friends. So, it's not the most thing I've ever heard. Okay,
there are other degrees here. And he was veryospitable. Like
we But here's the thing, like when I hang out with people, I
don't have to be doing anything. Like I just like spending time
with someone. I like being around someone. So you could be over
there doing your own thing. I'm over here doing my own thing.
We're having a conversation. We played music. Like it was very
it was negative. Like he was never creepy. He was never like
he was a he was a normal person. There was nothing like oh like
he said this or he was like it was it was very normal. We've
had he's very kind in conversations. But it's funny that something
I have noticed. I think the only way you could really identify
what was going on here, like uh if for example, if Merc suggested,
hey, like I don't necessarily want to go home, like could I sleep,
you know, in your apartment tonight or something? If that was
what was suggested, like I'd be like that's a signal in one direction
where like making a move might not be wrong like or incorrect,
right? It might be like, oh, this person's like actually into
something. Maybe we try something. Right. I don't think she was
saying that making a move was necessarily wrong, right? She even
said like you Yeah, she didn't say that. really. Well, she's
saying she's saying that after he made a move and got like slapped
away that not being like like super into her and DM like not
being all over her DMs at that point while he was right about
to travel. I think what she's I think what she's trying to say
is that it seemed like he was willing to be her friend initially,
but then once he realized that there was actually no chance of
a relationship,
um he backed off. Now, I don't know if that's true, but that
seems to be I think what she's saying right now. I mean, it could
it literally could also be it was Max Striker Films Queen's best
money. But um Max, we love you here. Okay, Max, if you want to
come, your money is always good here, Max. Okay. Yeah, you're
so desperate. Yeah, stay winning. Stay winning. I'm sure he hates
me. Um what were you saying? Oh, yeah. It could also just be
that like, hey, I feel like this is like I don't it's like any
signal I'm trying to interpret is like wrong and I don't I don't
think I should like this is really like a good situation for
me, right? Like I'm interpreting this as like an interest signal,
but it's not. Now you're turning me down. I'm confused. I don't
want to be confused. I don't have time to be confused. Bye. Well,
I mean, yeah. I mean, that seems reasonable. I don't I don't
know that she ascribed like intentionality to it. It's kind of
implied, but the intentionality is in like because you because
I wouldn't you right away, you just stop talking to me. Oh, right.
Yeah. Okay. That the intentionality that's implied here. And
I'm like, well, no, it seems like there could be some very mixed
signals happening here that are getting confused, getting crossed
about him. People are getting publicly he'll play one way and
then like in private like he's completely the opposite. Like
for example, like about my whole I'm not going to get too much
into it because I don't want to, but like the whole twit longer
situation. He was very vocal about how he said I was in an energy
vampire and how I was lying basically and all these negative
things, but yet in private like we had normal conversations.
It was it was kind. It was a kind energy. And then like hanging
out like he he we had conversations about music. Was the twit
longer was it the twit longer on Parseek or was it the twit longer
on did she twit longer Destiny? I actually don't even know which
one she's talking about. Like it was it's just how he portrays
himself in private and how he responds to people in private is
completely and opposite of how he is on stream which is unfair
too. Okay. Um so like there was really only one boundary that
you had to after that he What's that? You think Destiny's avoidant
in person then we'll blow people up on stream when he's talking
to I mean he is avoidant. I just don't know if he is in this
situation. Um, I like I have a hard time even if everything Murk
is saying is accurate, I have a hard time of being like who cares?
It's like I I don't know that even if she is being entirely accurate,
would that necessarily mean Destiny did something wrong? I don't
don't know. Like uh it seems like Destiny disagreeing that they
stopped talking. I just pull the logs here. I mean, maybe if
he like blocked her and was like off, that would be kind of nasty.
But like I don't think he did that. So I don't maybe I tried
to make a move on Mark in my sleep and I don't remember it. But
she had to fight me off when I was trying to sleep. I think that's
uh supposed to be facitious. Going to sleep over. We did nothing.
I made no moves. There have been people I've been interested
in that haven't reciprocated. It happens. Just not with her.
I even drove her home the next morning. We were both chilling
fine. Never had anyone slap me away before. We kept talking afterwards
though. So isn't that what happened to CC? Wasn't he? Didn't
he do that stuff? Sleep? Well, I think more sleep assault because
he has night terrors, but didn't really push anything. Nothing
like that. Like he wasn't Oh, wait. No, no, no. Adept did try
to imply that he sleeps assaulted somebody or something. Yeah,
never mind. Adept did try to say that. I don't think anybody
ever corroborated that. What? Whatsoever though. It was just
Destiny IRL. Hi. We can hang out if you're free, please. I mean,
Destiny, you told me to myself IRL, so I mean you're not okay.
No, maybe you are entirely different to other women to me. And
do you know you you said earlier I think at the beginning of
this conversation you don't know anything about the recent leaks
like at all. Well I know about the guy.
I don't want to I don't I haven't watched this so I don't trust
either of these people to be responsible about any of this. Awesome.
Very cool morale. Very cool. Don't trust these people at all.
yeah we swall awake. Uh yes that's true. That's true. I've watched
I've watched him play Marvel Rivals. Okay. He does some insanely
weird. Makes me blush. And that's like when playing games I do
just talk about a lot. There's just like a lot of talking about
I'm game.
That
That's understandable. Okay. That's just understandable. That's
believable. Hello. This now welcome to the stream. Dad stream.
Welcome back. Boom. Mr. Quman. How's it going? Pretty good. Thought
I'd uh official meeting of the Julinati here. What the [__]
is going on? I heard you had to leave after Lav was dropping
offensive words against black people. Yeah. I mean, you know,
it's actually true though. It's actually so real. It's actually
This one made as well. This is very interesting.
Not as funny, but a little interesting. You know what's the annoying
thing is? It was proven that Lav did in fact not lie about something,
but I can't talk about why, but it's something I got dragged
into, and technically I owe her an apology. So, uh, I have to
in fact not lie about something at one point. Is it about her
son allegedly? Uh, no, not that. Obviously, I can't say why.
We got to be vague here. Or Kelly will get screamed at. Oh. Oh,
was that the delayed reaction? What's for me? Merk's in the waiting
room, though. Based her
What's up, how's it going? Welcome. Hello. Hello.
What's up? Let's get this party started. Let's get this started.
Jesus. Wait, so what's going on? I think Good question. Destiny's
a little frustrated with uh some of your allegations. What allegations?
Feels like he stopped talking to you at all. He did. I literally
showed It's like 6 months ago. Yeah.
That's literally That's literally after we hung out. Okay. And
he stopped answering. Like I can show all the DMs right now cuz
he It's funny how he screenshots one section. Wait, I thought
you I thought you hung out in November of 2023. M. No, wait,
wait, wait. No, no, no. It was in May of 2023, wasn't it? Hold
on. Let me pull up the DMs. That says 24, doesn't it? Party.
I don't even think I have I have him block. Yeah. Um, so the
last time he responded to me was 6824.
And then I said, "I'm fine. Get any cool pictures? Anything?"
Didn't respond. I asked a question. When did when did you guys
hang out? We hung out Let me find the exact date. One second.
We hung out. We hung out like I I can find it. It's leaked somewhere.
Give me a second. It was We hung out uh on or around the 9th
of the of What's 5? June, July, June, May. Yeah. And then he
like a month later he's still messaging you about stuff. The
last time he messaged me was the
month later. 65. Yeah, but it was like it was starting to taper
off and then he just completely like stopped responding and stopped
answering. And like I
would message him and like I'd give it some time and then he
wouldn't answer and I'd message again and then it was like over
the course of like like we talked about this. Go ahead. The last
time was 71624 where I kind of just like gave up because I said
I hope you're okay. I've seen a lot and from the last time he
answered was 618. like he just stopped answering. And that was
20. That was last year. Yeah. 24. It must be last year. Okay.
And these messages, the one you're showing that we hung out after
that. But uh didn't you block him for No, we No, I never blocked
him. I didn't block him until just recently whenever I thought
he was saying that I hung out in the lobby the entire night cuz
I got on stream. I was like, "Just so you know, that's not what
happened." And then Cherry's like, "No, he just calls like his
other apartment downstairs or something like that." Yeah. And
I had this. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And I messaged him about that.
Didn't get a response. And then I was like, you know, I'm not
even going to get into it. And I just blocked him. All right.
So, you hung out after this? So, the the first hangout was in
May and you hung out a second. No, no, no, no. We only hung out
one time. Okay. Yeah. So, but for like a month after that, you
guys were messaging and it tapered off, you said. Yeah, it started
to taper off. Like we had a few like he responded like a few
times after the fact we hung out but then like it just he just
completely stopped like you can tell when there's like a difference
in like the messaging. I mean you are basing that on only two
messages though. I mean this guy when you go
see you don't see like the frequency of our conversations before
that screenshot. Like we went from like talking to like every
single day to barely talking at all. Okay. But that does happen
in normal friendships too. Like I've had that issue with that.
A lot of my friends. I I get that, but it's like it's a little
ironic. It happens after I turn him down and then we go from
like talking cuz even when he was busy, he took the time to message.
And I'm not saying like I'm not saying that he like owes me a
friendship, but that was what I believed we were going to have.
And when you go from like talking all the time to barely talking
after an incident happens, it's a little
I just uh I don't know. The thing is good one.
I just have a hard time. Okay, so say he was interested in you
and now he's not interested in you anymore. Like that's normal,
which I have nobody.
But I've never said I've never said I've never said that. That's
what I'm upset about. What I'm upset about is we I was hanging
out on the premise that we were going to be friends and to stop
wanting to be friends or having communication simply because
I turned you down when that was what it was from the very beginning.
He can make his own decisions. I've never said he's done anything
like predatory or anything wrong, but I just think it's a little
for him to like stop talking to me after I wouldn't sleep with
you. That's the problem. He can do that. I of course he has every
right to choose to do that. But for him to do it,
yes, but it tapered off and it tapered off and I've never said
that it like I've never presented it to be something that it's
not. I've said the same thing from the very beginning. I just
think it's I said I've never said he'd done anything like inherently
wrong or predatory. It's just the fact that I looked at him as
a friend and then ironically after I wouldn't sleep with him,
suddenly the responses start to slow or he all outright stops
talking to me. Didn't you say Mark's story had changed earlier?
The story never changed. I've said the same thing from the very
beginning. Oh, I hadn't heard about the like sleepover, the cuddling,
and then the the turndown. Yeah, I had not heard that when we
talked before. I didn't hear any of that stuff. You know what
this timeline does line up with? Yeah. Okay. So, I know this
this is a crackhead theory. Uh I think Destiny was getting very
fed up of drama at this point cuz this is when he started to
be mad at me, right? Possible that he stopped talking to you
because No, with me, right? So, it might have colored his like
opinions with other people because you'd probably be seen as
a person. I think it might just
it was never it was never like
a public interaction until I had talked about it because of what
happened. It was never public. Like all of our like back and
forth and our conversations and us hang was private. Like it
wasn't it wasn't like I was coming on a stream and talking about
it or like I wasn't I mean this is a crackhead theory, right?
It just might have meant that he was distancing himself from
a lot of people that are like us, right? Which might have been
a good thing. I've never like even hanging out like he's like
he saw what kind of person I was like it it wasn't like I was
doing anything like like in an evil way or like being drama cuz
like our conversations never revolved I mean nobody thinks you're
okay nobody thinks you're evil Mark but you are a dramatic person
otherwise you would be but it wasn't drama
friendship wasn't our friendship wasn't drama our conversation
weren't drama how we hung out wasn't drama that's what I'm saying
it was like chill it was very regular it was like, "No, it's
not." So, it's it's just confusing to me that if you gave him
a bad taste in his mouth, why he couldn't take our interactions
and see that it wasn't the same. Again, it's just a theory. Okay.
It's the fiction hour. What's up, guys? How are we doing? We're
good, buddy. Yo, what's up, bro? Good times. Mark, how many how
many conversations have we had in the totality of our friendship?
None. How many times have I hit on you or made a pass at you
in the totality of our friendship? Um, once. So, none. Except
for the one time at night that I never said there's no possibility
and you I'm just curious after that hangout did you reference
point you said that apparently despite the fact that we've never
had a conversation ever never talked about it ever and you said
coming over that it was just a hangout supposedly in the middle
of the night I decided that that was my attempt to make a pass
you put your hands between my legs did you not I did not
want you don't lie you put your hands between my legs and I slapped
your hand away that's It happened. Yeah. This never happened.
For no other reason because of the fact that you're literally
2 feet taller than me and you would kill me. Like even if I wanted
to, you would literally now like an absor
when I you were literally spooning me. You put your hand between
my legs and I slapped it away. No. So I'm making
you making [__] up. Yes. You were making [__]
up. Okay. Wait. No. No. I'm curious. I'm curious. I'm curious.
Why is it that you would say Why is it that you would say that
we were cool and you wanted to keep being friends and chat to
you in your sleep? I never said you I never said I never said
you tried to rape me. I said I would understand
autistic. Sliding your hand between somebody's leg is not making
a pass. That's like the most aggressive way you can try to do
like if a woman I have but that's the thing. I never said it
was a bad thing. We were laying there. You made a pass and I
denied it. There's nothing wrong with that. You making a pass
isn't wrong. I understand you keep repeating the same thing.
I didn't make any pets at you. And if I was going to, it would
be sliding in between your legs. You literally You did though.
You did though. Why would I lie about that? What do you mean?
Why would you lie about it? Do you know? Hold on. Do you know
why I stopped talking to you? Oh, let's hear it. Cuz I've heard
multiple reasons why. And I stopped talking to you because somebody
linked me on your stream that you randomly said that I was trying
to [__] you and I was like, "Nah, this is like a
month or two afterwards. Tell me, this isn't you were crashing
out on some random on stream. This never happened. There's no
evidence. There's no logs. You never talked to me about this.
You never brought it up ever. And you seem to act totally like
this never happened in all of our follow-up conversations because
I did talk to you after Why would I bring up you making a pass
at me if I didn't want it to happen and I didn't want to talk
about it? So, you're saying I had to acknowledge you making a
pass at me for it to be valid? That doesn't make any sense.
No, I feel like that we would probably clarify that given the
fact that you clarified before coming over that we were just
hanging out and nothing was going to happen. Okay, but why if
if I turn you down, that's the end of the conversation. Like,
there doesn't need to be a conversation about you making a pass.
You made a pass. I was cuddling in your bed. I get it. I don't
have a problem with that. But I have a problem. But post Vance,
I would never make a pass at you. You're insane. There's a reason
why you are apparently insane that you made. Yeah. You can appeal
to that all the girls all you want. But I have not had that conversation
with you. You can ask anybody that I have had a relationship
I didn't. Thank you. Yes. Thank you. At least you admit it. Thank
you. That doesn't make sense. That doesn't make sense. I didn't
ever say that you one tried to me. I said I acknowledge that
the past happened and there's nothing wrong with it because you
had a girl in your bed. I don't have a problem with that. The
problem I have is that it's ironic that the communication lessened
and alt-right ended after I said no.
Yeah, that's not what irony means. But also, we still talked
after we hung out. Yes.
Barely and then you just stopped all together. MC, we barely
spoke before we had That's not true. That's not true. That's
not true.
If you look at the If you look at the conversation that we had.
Okay. Well, until she Kelly, shut the up. Thank you, D. Thank
you. Literally, if you go to the frequency of our messages beforehand,
you can see that there's a difference. I never claimed that there
was anything wrong with you making a pass. I get it. But bring
up you're bringing up the same rant overaining.
No, no, you're not. But you barely stopped. You stopped. That's
the problem. Like over months later after you began to say on
it tapered out. It tapered out and then once I realized, oh,
maybe this is the reason because I said no that now you don't
want to have anything to do with me. Why would that be the reason
when there's literally no indication of that? There is no other
reason because I didn't do anything wrong. There was to wait.
Why didn't you say you do something wrong for us? You just like
talk less to completely not talk at all when we went from talking
almost every single day when there was a higher frequency. Wait,
when are we talking every single day? What? Give me a date range.
Every single day. I mean, if you want to if you want to just
show go through all the messages you can do. When are we talking?
Give me a date range. We're talking every single day. Um, okay.
Um, just for example, let's see. May 5th to first the May or
what's five? June June. June 1st message there, message there.
Uh message on the 2nd, you messaged on the 2nd. Um then you messaged
on the 6th, you me you messaged on the 7th. It's it's daily.
You already skipped four days there and this is now from the
from the 6th to the 7th to the 8th. Are you serious?
Bro, okay, let me just share my screen then. If that if that'll
[__] help, I'll share every single [__]
message to to show I think that would help. Like if it has to
be like this. I never had a problem with you ma like making a
move. Like that's fine. But to sit here and say that I'm lying
about it. That's I knew that this was going to happen if you
ever got involved that you would say it didn't happen. It's at
the end of the day it's my word against yours. But your word
has more value than mine because of what people attribute me
to. Like it's not fair. I have no problem with you making it
pass. What I have a problem with is you completely stopped talking
to me when I thought you were my friend. That's you're such a
full and you're so disgusting. Okay. You're literally a disgusting
person. Okay. There's literally no evidence in any part of this
that I stopped talking to you because of that. Yes, she did that
whatever that was it would have been ironic that I'm going to
need
the word the communication stops.
Okay, let me let me unblock you so it shows the messages. I'll
start from the very beginning so you can see here. Look at look
at the amount of conversation we had. Look at the amount of the
conversation we had compared compared to down here after we met
after we hung out when suddenly there's less conversation. And
I understood you were on a trip. I understood that. That's fine.
I got that. But when you get back and then suddenly we stopped
talking. You didn't answer here. You didn't answer here. And
honestly, it's it's suspicious to me because we went from talking
like this, like this to that, which led me to believe it was
after we hung out. What's the only reason? Because suddenly what?
There was no reason. There was no benefit, which is fine. That's
fine. No, it was because somebody go through the log. Somebody
go through the logs and find the first time that you randomly
said on stream out of nowhere that I made a passage and you shot
me down. That's when I start responding to you on
this is just the mystery. This was the mystery night pass. I
guess that could never be resolved. Then I guess it's not about
resolving. But if I feel upset and I see something someone else
say something about it, then suddenly the puzzle pieces are starting
to fit. I have no problem with you besides the fact that I thought
you were my friend and it was a very and you know it's my fault
for you know expecting other people to owe me something. Maybe
that's what I can apologize for. I'm sorry that I expected you
to be my friend but it's upsetting when you stop being my friend
and there and the only thing that I can grasp at or get like
a reason why is because you made a pass and I turned you down.
There's no problem with that. I don't I don't have any ill feelings
towards you other than the fact you stopped being my friend because
I needed somebody. I wanted to have a friend and I have no ill
feelings.
The fact that I made a passage at you on stream that just like
Yeah. The fact you wanted to just like lie and make that up is
just like really weird. Yeah. I like because you know I just
kind of weird. Yeah. Yeah. Why would I? But like what what what
would I benefit from lying about you making What do you mean
from attention? You do this all the time. You've had these same
types of runins with people.
No. No. There comes a time when suddenly the attention thing
it's there's there's like Are you serious? Are you serious? We
cuddled. You put your hands on me. You spooned me like what do
you I put my hands between your legs and you did. You
very slid your legs. Okay, bro. It didn't happen. I don't Can
you describe the poses and like what the action was? He literally
he was he was spooning me. He slid his hand between my legs and
then I just I put like I pushed his hand back like I slapped
it away and then we just continued like cuddling. That's it.
Were your legs like together or like separated? We were spooning.
I was in a fetal position. No.
Was it Was it like he slipped it between or was it just like
he put He just slid his hand between my leg. Like what do you
mean? Yeah. This never happened. This is the dumbest thing of
my entire life. It never happened. Okay. Okay then. It never
happened. Like I I
There's no point. Like I'm not going to argue about it. Like
why would I make it up? I have no reason to make it up. There's
nothing wrong with
You keep saying there's nothing wrong when you're making me sound
like I never No, that's you. That's you being worried because
I never used the word. I never even said there was anything wrong
with it. There was nothing wrong with the interaction. I don't
care. I don't. The point is you stopped being my friend. That's
the what I have a problem with. I never I never I never said
that you you tried to rap like don't make it something when it's
not. All I said no how is how bro you are using those words.
I never once used the word salt ever. You need to mute me not
block me genius. So that's your problem. All I said was, "You
made a pass. I turned you down." And it's a little ironic that
you stopped talking to me. That's it. That's all I And I I didn't
stop talking to you immediately. I just had fewer conversations
that tapered off and then you made a weird conversation stream
and then I stopped talking to you. I will say I don't think she's
claiming salt. It's good to get the clearance cuz putting your
hand between my legs that sounds like it could be, but I don't
think that was her intention. Okay. I think she was trying to
say
I don't care. But that's literally what it sounds like. No, it's
good to clear it up. But I'm just saying that I don't think that
was
somebody came over. It would be a really weird thing if somebody
came over clarifying we were just hanging out as friends and
that's what we were doing the entire time and I would have like
shot slide between your legs over in bed. That would be a really
weird thing to do. Sure, bro. Whatever, dude. No, I think I'd
be like normal to be honest. That's what I'm saying. That's why
that's why I never had an issue with it. Like I'm already
you guys are autistic, but I'm not autistic. We literally clarified
before she came over that we were just autistic. I think that's
super I think that's I think that's super autistic to try to
somebody when they're in bed and you've already clarified that
you're just hanging out. Personally, I think that's a little
weird, but you know, a lot of people just hang out a lot of the
time, right? Oh my god. Whatever. Like this is so Yeah. And I
never I never ever claimed that it was assault or or anything
like that. I said I acknowledge that cuddling with someone even
platonically like I get it right. Like I Why do you keep repeating
the same? Stop saying I get it. I want because I want to drive
the point, bro. Okay, whatever, dude. Okay, whatever. January
4th cuddle gate. What cuddles were their friends? What the was
happening? Odd. Oh. Oh boy. So, uh, Destiny, you want to clarify
why I got banned then? Going to assume he has figured out how
to mute me? Someone else want to ask? All right, we're just Kelly
muted. Yes, she's asking why she got banned.
Morset hater
because you're an attention, Kelly. That is very non-specific.
I'm going to need more info than this. I don't know about that
tension part. True. I I personally like the part where they were
having a heated argument and you just started singing a song.
Kelly, definitely not indicative. Do you know why? It was Alanis
Moriceet. Ironic, right? But all of the examples aren't ironic.
Okay. So, never mind. Mer doesn't know what I really means. Yeah,
of course. And here come here come back in. This Okay. Did this
really have to be blown up over like a Twitter thread and have
like a whole confrontation about it? Why couldn't this been kept
private? What do you mean? Oh, because Burke was not making it
private. Burke was publicly talking about it all over the place.
No, I I made one tweet. I made one tweet and I talked about it
on my stream one time when I get You just went on stream. That's
what
I watch you talk about it on moral stream. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
You didn't let me finish.
You talked about it on my stream. Yeah, I did. Cuz it got to
a point where it's like I see other women talking about it and
then I want to give my take, but it never it was never presented
in like a in a like predatorial way. I never claimed that he
did something shady as far as like salt or like doing something
wrong. All I said was, "I think it's unfair that I thought we
were going to be friends and then I turned him down and then
suddenly we're not friends anymore." That's what I'm upset about.
Wait, doesn't that happen all the time? Like, aren't you sometimes
like, "Don't men become friends with you and they're like, "Hey,
do you want to?" And then they're like, it does happen all the
time. And it is probably what you want to have happen when a
platonic relationship when one person tries to make that relationship
romantic and it fails.
suddenly not be have that conversation like if you just that
would be autistic like like if you just like say like look this
is what I thought it was which I never gave it like he said himself
he he confirmed that we never had any conversations right so
if suddenly he was viewing the friendship in a sexual light communicate
that to me and I'm like fine I won't okay then if we can't be
friends because you want to have sex with me that's fine like
I get that right like it sucks but like also just to be clear
it was To be clear, he's also saying he didn't even make that
move to begin with. But he but he but he did. Like I don't like
if I was like to me it would make more sense like to say like
oh well he he [__] me. Like and if I'm a liar about
all these things and I like to lie about salt, why wouldn't I
just say oh he tried to like actually [__] me or
like he like it doesn't make any sense. We were cuddling. He
slipped his hands between my thighs. I I pushed his hand away.
Slapped his hand away and like we continued laying in bed. Like
there's nothing wrong with that. making a move on a woman who
is like cuddling in your bed. Like it's like it's there's nothing
wrong with that. I don't I don't have a problem with that. My
problem arose after the fact and I never presented him in a in
a like predatorial way. It wasn't predatory. I didn't feel predated
on. I just felt like I got kind of treated because I thought
our relationship was a friendship and it mattered. That's it.
And I've always said that. That's what I've said from the moment
I talked about it. Continuing to call Merk an Amazonian like
goddess is just making me want to be in bed with Murk at this
point. You're not my type. Sorry. Damn.
Or it's rough out here. Oh boy. You heard the 40-year allegation
and you lost interest. Oh, that's rude. Okay. Uh, wait, wait,
wait, wait. I had a point to make. Oh, does it matter then? Cuz
you don't think he did anything wrong with the with the push.
But like if he if you guys were just friends, you'd still feel
just as bad, wouldn't you? Like that he'd stop talking to you.
Is that really what it all comes down to is that he stopped talking
to you. That's right. You're like that's what you're upset about.
But like does it matter if he tried? So he says he didn't try
to push it. You say he did. But even if he didn't, you still
have a problem, right? No, because I guarantee you that's what
made like I I I don't think that I feel like that was the reason
he stopped talking to me, which I guess confirms that he was
only talking with to me to sleep with me. That would be the problem.
That would be like the ultimate thing, right? I think that if
he didn't make a move, I feel like none of this would happen.
But I don't even know if he would have hung out with me if he
didn't want to sleep with me. Make sense? Like that's how it
that's how it that's how it makes sense to me in my mind now.
You know, all I'm saying is I wanted a genuine friendship. That's
why like all of our stuff was like us talking, us hanging out
was like off stream. Like I didn't want anything else from him
but a platonic friendship. And I told him that in the messages
because like I was I had just moved to Miami. I was lonely. I
was I just wanted someone to hang out with and like music-wise
like we do have a lot in common and like we talked about like
his saxophone and like you know music and and stuff like that
and I I did like him as a person like not like like like but
like he minus all the political and like all the streaming like
I I do like I did enjoy him as a person and that's that's it.
like it's there was nothing ever else. But it just like it upsets
me because of how it ended. And that's what I've said from the
very beginning. That's all I have a problem with. I don't think
he's predatory towards me in my case. I don't think he was predatory.
I don't think and I even said like he was he was veryospitable,
very very kind. Like we had good conversation and it's just it
it sucks how it ended. And I felt like once I realized Hold on,
hold on, hold on. How is it not predatory if I'm only being friends
with you just to you and I'm misleading you there and then when
you don't move in the middle of the night? That is different
from assault. That is not the same thing. No, no, no. We didn't
say I said you said predatory. Didn't you say you wanted to add
your voice to all of the other women? Are they also just claiming
that I just talked to them and stopped talking to them when they
for my case? I'm saying you want No, you said you wanted to join
all the other women, but you said you wanted to join the conversation.
I never called you predatory. So, you just wanted to join the
conversation to give that supposedly
I say it does it does give a lot towards your character of what
they're saying if you stop talking to me because I wouldn't sleep
with you. Do you think that I might have stopped talking to you
because you also like DM me like 50 million times in the night
and then delete all of them and you did this over and over and
over and over and over again. No, because you would still respond
and I do that because I would put like Hold on, hold on, stop.
I would put like an eyeballs thing and I'd have no idea what
the you were saying or what was happening. But you but you said
that you stopped talking to me because I was talking about it
publicly. So either you stopped talking to me
that's when I stopped. Hold on. Stop. No. I said I stopped responding
to you after I heard you say something publicly. But our like
substantive conversations probably decreased because now cuz
I went back and I read our logs and I see you doing the little
eyeball thing to your call and then I just remembered, oh yeah,
I used to wake up with 52 notifications for MK cuz she would
spam me and then when I wake up all of them would be deleted.
Oh wait, really? That didn't happen over and over. It was not.
No, no, no. It wasn't 52 messages. Oh, I'm sorry. How many messages
was it? You think? Maybe like once.
Once it was 52 messages or 52 times it was one message. It wasn't
52 time. There was no 52 times. You're making it seem like I
bombarded you with messages. Was just You did. It was literally
unhinged. Yeah. No, it wasn't. And see, now you're trying to
paint me as unhinged to have a reason for why to invalidate what
I'm saying.
I don't care. Like, you're not going to do that to me. You can
sit here and say all that, but I'm I refuse to be painted as
unhinged, which is not the case. You got to stop doing that.
You do that to a lot of people where you say, "Oh, would you
please stop generalizing? Please stop generalizing. Please stop
generalizingly denying behavior. You're just kind of lying. You're
just I'm not lying. I'm tell you about how when we were there,
how you uh you got a rope and you threw it on my neck. You tried
to throw me off my balcony to me." Oh, but I don't have any logs
of that. I have no proof of that, by the way. But it definitely
happened. You tried to throw me off my balcony and then hang
me. Remember that? My my claims aren't wild like that one. Like
come on. That I would really put a rope around your neck and
hang you out the balcony versus you making a move when we're
cuddling. Like what's more really you keep saying please stop
assuming that I want your level of social like awkwardness or
unawareness. Am I going to make a random move on? I can rec
and I agree. I agree. But you still put your hands between my
legs. Okay. Yeah. I don't think that ever happened. And you definitely
kind of push me off my balcony with a rope tied around my head.
Okay. Well, then yeah, it did. Oh, yeah. Refer to some other
random unrelated story. Sit here and say if I have to sit here
and say that I tried to push you off your balcony for you to
admit that you put your hand between my legs, which there's nothing
wrong with because we're cuddling.
Like, then fine. I tried to push you off your balcony. I held
a gun to your head. I push tried to push you off your balcony.
Um I you know, I forced you down on your hands and knees and
made you How many times if we were to go back through our DMs?
Who's trying? How many times are you asking me to hang out versus
me? Like a lot. A lot. A lot. Like like 10 plus times, right?
If I'm so desperate trying,
if I'm so desperately trying to like hook up with you, why are
you the one that's messaging me all the time to hang out? I'm
like, not I didn't say you were desperate to hook up, but when
the opportunity arose, you're definitely going to make a move.
Oh my god. No, I'm not. Because that sounds autistic. But okay.
Okay. So, yeah, let's use autism as a reason to invalidate what
I'm saying and say I'm a liar. Gotcha. Okay. All I'm saying is
battle like it doesn't make any sense. Like I don't like is this
cuddlegate or is it autism gate? It's kind of it's hard to tell.
Agree with color as in many such cases. Going to be a resolution
to this. Burka's not been learning from it's literally just a
he said she said they both they both keep saying that's the thing
like
and I knew that if this if he if this happened like this is exactly
how it would go. But that I don't I've never like it's not like
there's a problem with it. I just don't know why. Like wait what?
Can you stop doing Can you stop doing the Kelly tier like abusive
be like there's no problem to like touch me in the middle of
the night and I wanted to add my story line with all these other
girls that were you wrong with it please oh my god please off
okay dude whatever it happened I'm not lying don't you ever send
him a message like hey is there a reason why we're talking less
well I I I tend to like that's not going to be a message I send
immediately I'm going to try and get a conversation going and
then be like, you know, then continue on. That's not something
that I'm just going to send out, right? You know. What do you
mean? There was like one there was like one message that I didn't
respond to. What? There were multiple. What? When it goes I literally
showed the frequency of us talking before and after. There's
there's a stark difference. Ninja
I asked you Hold on. I asked you I asked you how you were doing.
You took the day or No, I'm sorry. You took six hours to respond.
I said, "How are you doing?" You said, "I'm fine. Got equal pictures."
I asked a question. And then a month later you said, "I hope
you're okay. I've seen a lot." Those are the only things I haven't
responded to. That's it. Yeah. And if you take that and compare
it to our original frequency of messages, it's starkly different.
Which means which made it to where I was. So those two messages
So those two me you thought I was such a close friend to you,
but those two me.
Yes, we were. I literally just showed it. I literally just showed
it. We literally went from talking every day. Every day. Like
I that I don't like I'm not going to argue about that. I I literally
all I'm saying is all I'm saying is how I feel. How I was be
how I was made to feel. I never said you're not saying how you
feel. Shut the [__] up my Yes, I did. I said I feel
like it's that you abuse 101
statement.
You're literally abusing actions and it is just not true. Sorry.
It's not. You're just lying. All right. I'm lying then. Whatever,
dude. Okay. What? Now we need to psycho analyze why Destiny thinks
autistic people are abusive inherently. Like
I have nothing to like there's nothing even like to lie about.
Like there's a reason why I didn't want M to be bullied. Okay.
Like there's literally nothing to even lie about. Like like if
I looked up autism in the dictionary, it's just a picture of
M's face. If I had like a friend and I and he just started talking
to me out of random, I would just message him and be like, "Hey,
are we okay? Like you have you've kind of been distant." which
which I tried like I wanted to do but at that point it was like
not even worth it because I saw that he wasn't responding. And
I was like, "You know what? I'm just going to be done with it."
Like, I don't Okay, then it's not a big deal, right? Because
of the one because of the one message I didn't answer. You I
already explained that. I already refuted that. I said it was
the frequency of messages before and after. Wait, so it wasn't
a big deal. It It was a big deal, but it got to a point where
it's like, "Okay, I've said my piece. It's over now." But if
people still ask me that whole tweet thing, I didn't even know.
It was like I didn't All I saw was something about like Destiny
like trying to every girl he comes in contact with. I'm just
curious. Wait, I'm curious actually now. I want to know. Where
did my head come from? Was I like trying to sneak in from behind
or was I like coming all the way over the top and then like going
down? Did I have to scoop down the bed to like compensate for
the distance or what? I think we can go figure out. I think we
could figure out. You probably slid your hand like sort of like
did I get up or get on my knees horizontally in between the legs?
You realize we're the same height laying down, right? That's
First of all, that's not how that works. That is how it works.
You're saying you're saying huddling works. You literally said
You literally said that you had to stand. Did I have to stand
up? Did I have to stand up? Did I have to crawl towards the end
of the bed? Like, are you Is he saying it was the little spoon?
His He was He was spooning me and he he put his hand like I don't
like Oh my god. He's trying to say it never happened by like
bringing like my height into play when in reality I've cuddle
I've cuddled with shorter men. I've cuddled with shorter men
and have done way more than we did with shorter men. height has
nothing to do with it because if you want it to happen it's gonna
happen. Okay. Like are you serious? Like and it's not even something
crazy to like so you like bro like are you serious? Like I don't
just be clear that you don't get shorter if you lay down. What?
I
was a little I He was the He was behind me. I was in front of
him. Destiny was a backpack. True. Yes. It was a backpacking
situation. This is
Oh, sure. Jetacking. Yeah, jetpacking. Sure. Sure. Go to bed,
Brady. What are you doing? You said you were going to bed like
two hours ago. Fighting it right back. I for my life right now.
You're not fighting for like Why? Oh my god. Dan, I need to know
your thoughts on all of this. Okay. You've been hanging out.
What are your thoughts on all this? I'm sorry. I just Dude, I
just got a 5V square wave to go and I didn't even have to use
Oh my god. He's not even paying attention to the drama. That's
crazy. I heard my what? End of life crisis. Not even a midlife
crisis. Wait, you guys, at least I know how to do with my hands.
Uh-huh. Oh, are you working on your car again? Also, Kelly, he
cannot hear you. Like, the allegation is Destiny knows how to
do a few too many things. I was talking to you, Dan. I said,
are you working on your car again? No, I'm working at my uh on
my workshop here. And I tell him to be to unmute me cuz he's
being a Dan. The important question is Okay, I have one question
for you, Dan. Do you get shorter when you lay down? Uh, I think
don't you when you sleep, aren't you taller by like an inch or
something when you first wake up or something? I'm always taller
by an inch when I wake up. Something like that. Uh, horizontally.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. N, what are you up to right now, brother? Just
stroking it, bro. Me, too. Brilliant. This chat's like nearly
half broke bongers.
They're a menace. They're all a menace. Why don't you just Why
can't you guys be cool after this? Okay. Who you talking to?
Destiny and Merc. No, because I've seen like so many reasons
as to why he stopped talking to me. Cherry showed me that one
screenshot from his chatbot thingy. What he said? Like I just
It's Yeah, he said he said that I was mad because I stayed downstairs
for like hours and didn't really do nothing. That was a reason
why he stopped talking to me. Um, like I've just heard so many
things and you made a public post talking about how he like public
said that. Yeah. Yeah. Pretty crazy how that works, huh? But
it's like there was there's there's so many reasons and then
I I hear so many reasons as to why people stopped and I just
it's it's not I just said what I said to talk about it. There
was nothing like inherently evil that was said. It's not Maybe
you Maybe you keep saying that it'll be true. Just keep saying
that same. But it is true. I've I've not said you. I will say
Cherry tried to show you this, Mur. I'm just I'm just telling
you. Cherry tried to show you this cuz she was saying she he
wasn't talking cuz you heard that he was talking. She just wanted
to explain downstairs. I'm just telling you that he meant downstairs.
That was before. Yeah, about that. But I'm talking about how
there was the screenshot of him saying, "Oh, I think Merc doesn't
like me because she was downstairs for hours." Or something like
that. And And he was making Wait, wait, wait. When was that screenshot?
When was that screenshot? I don't know. She just showed it to
me. Either she showed it to her show
November 29th. Uh, November 29th, November 30th, one of those
two dates, which that was like the first somewhat semblance of
an answer I got, but it's like it was constantly changing. You
tried to make it seem like I didn't like you for that. If I said
No, if I said that in chat, the reason why I said that was because
you'd already lied on stream about me trying to pass it to you.
I didn't in that case. Wow. Well, crazy. And how and how would
that wouldn't even make sense if I was still trying to keep in
contact with you after we hung out. If I hate you, you weren't
trying to keep in contact with me. You had messaged me in months.
What are you talking about? Oh, but yet if I did, you would sit
there and say, "Oh, you sent me 52 messages and like you were
bombarding me." Sorry. What was that? Oh, that was a real clever
little tactic. Your last messages to me was were on July 17th.
How are you trying to keep in contact with me? You're lying.
Can you just Can you just admit that you just lied? You got caught
in a in a huge lie. I literally kept trying to talk to you and
it never was a case of me not liking you and you know that because
I I kept trying to keep in contact with you. You're like trying
to turn it around on me when it wasn't even that. You chose not
to be friends with any which is fine but I still have a right
to be upset about it cuz it hurt my feelings. Wmp and that's
fine. People don't have to regard my feelings but they can't
like if I feel upset about something I can I have that right
to be upset about something.
And like to say that I was upset about like you fixing that wasn't
that wasn't even the case cuz one I helped you and I and I had
fun like hanging out. He's gone. He's gone.
It doesn't even matter. He is bad. He's muted. So Mark, how'
the uh interview go earlier? He just asked me some questions
and I didn't I didn't even know it was it like tied in with other
cuz like I said I don't I didn't really pay attention. I didn't
even read the whole thread of what I responded to. All I said
was oh wait before you continue don't say any names. Don't mention
people. Just Okay. Just be cool. Yeah. Go ahead. Uh like I said,
I just responded to a tweet and I just sent it and I wasn't really
thinking of it. I just said, "Oh, yeah, that seems similar to
what happened to me, but like not in like the I don't even know
the allegations. I know some about the allegations now tonight."
That's the first time I knew about it. But all I said was what
I said and that's it. And I didn't see anything wrong with it.
I just thought it was it was interesting. I mean, how did you
come away feeling after the morale interview? What did you think
of it all? No, I just I mean I just talked to him because he
wanted to talk. I said fine. It wasn't It's not like Do you like
Moral? I mean we talk private. I mean he's funny. Yeah. So he's
your new destiny?
No. I don't really I don't really talk to many people anymore.
I've kind of just been doing my own thing. Wait, can someone
catch me up on what's going on like very quickly? Uh did you
delete your tweet? Because I'm looking at [__] off.
I didn't see anything. No, I didn't. What was the tweet that
you're referencing? Oh, it's it's on my page. Hold on, let me
find it.
Is it like an older one or something? No, it's like I don't know
when it is, but it's not like old old. It's December 20 December
2nd, 2024. He tried to sleep with me as well and completely ditched
me as a friend when I would win. Orbiter or not, I think it's
extremely problematic to want to every single female you come
in contact with. Platonic friendships can just be just as valuable
as intimate ones. And I said that in I think response to one
of Lab's I don't know that whole story, but I think it was to
Lab or something like that. And I saw that I was like if it was
uh old cuz obviously that's like a month old now. So that's fine
cuz I assume that's cuz fairy queen like quoted it and that's
why this brought up again or whatever. Yeah. Wait, hold on. I
just want to point out for both of you guys, you understand you
could both like this could be your your actual conception of
what happened, right? Like he wasn't making any pass at all.
Uh maybe his hand like touch you somewhere like slightly. I I'm
just Okay. Well, you know, this always happens with people. I'm
telling you that he thinks nothing happened that he wasn't going
to make. He knew in his head he was not going to. No, he's lying.
Okay. There's no if ands or buts about it. He's lying. Okay.
N I tried to I tried to help. So you weren't there. Okay. Shut
the tried to explain. Okay. Yourself.
Uh I just think you should listen to victim stories. Have we
not listened?
We we've listened a lot. Uh,
is that Darius in your profile picture?
Is that cat that slowly knocks things off the counter? That is
the most accurate description of me I've ever read. Really? It's
very true. I just stare you in the eyes while I like slowly push
the object closer to the edge. Uhhuh.
You're so hot. Turn Kelly's volume down. I don't need to do that.
It's fine. So Jason, who just like he's like somebody else is
fighting with him like Hassan's like on him and he's like gh
Kelly. You remember when Kelly Jean was a total
no the chat was responding to you using as your example of like
no Destiny said this about me with the fourth the Kelly Gene
rule in the fourth eye discussion. I want you to think historically,
okay, for a culture that you think of is traditionally masculine
and then I want you to name it. Okay, top your head as quick
as you can. Go traditionally go
books please. Historically a people a civilization a people a
civilization historically masculine. You think of masculine people
masculine? What does this mean? I don't know how to think of
a civilization as masculine. There's women and men in all civilizations,
isn't there? Okay. Awesome. Oh, that's an answer. That's an answer.
All right. That's what she's got to do. She's got to leave live
her truth in the world. Do you think that she's going to become
friends with Casey Tron? Uh, no. I don't think so. I don't think
she'd like specifically go to be friends with other people. Um,
no. How would I down? No, I don't think so. I don't think so.
Osmosis. It's a scientific function. When you are around, sorry.
When you are um when you're pushed out and the only people left
is red paint, guess what? You're going to become you're going
to get red paint on you. Boom. Point proven. Uh maybe. See, this
is what I mean about the sleeping pills coming in and me starting
to be less effective as a debater. Yeah. Yeah.
Something way better 20 minutes ago. I just think with this one
like it's difficult for people to go and just like like you can't,
you know, it's also bad optics to get this like Kelly saying
this stuff and then to immediately like cut off contact with
it, right? Like it's pretty bad. You you probably should think
about some things. You know, all the Trump bots mad at Amy Comey
Barrett for not being 100% Trump loyalist. No. What did What
did Amy Comey Barrett do that was not Trump
I don't know. Oh, people are also really bad at um at like uh
saying Kelly Jean's bad. Although I guess they don't have my
experience. Somebody's like saying you should never be in one-on-one
Discord calls with kids. I think Kelly's like, "Good, that didn't
happen."
Good that didn't happen. What? Yeah, she Well, it's like that's
fine. The person's like, "Oh, you were in a Discord call with
Nathan oneonone." And it's like, "No, that was a group call."
I don't know if it's better if it's all kids, but probably at
least a little better witnesses and such. Then she tries to throw
vegan gangs on
the gangs. The gangs of Europe that they've been talking about
that's happening on Discord. Oh, yeah. Exactly. Yes, the grooming
gangs on Discord. True. That is a specifically white person problem.
Okay. Discord grooming gangs. That is a white person problem.
And I was about Hold on. I was about to say, wait, maybe not
because of Darius, but also Darius is white, so hard to say.
It seems to be a predominantly white problem. Okay. Discord grooming.
What is going on with Kelly Jean? Uh she's posting on LSF. Um
getting mad at Destiny. Okay. I'm pretty sure. Wait, is there
context? Uh there would be context. Hold on. It's going to be
somebody saying that like why did you get banned or something?
Isn't it explain the problem with Kelly Gene? I'm clueless parent.
You know Kelly Gene is bad news if even Destiny cut her out.
Uhoh. Uh do you like the song Bad Boy or Life by Diddy? No, I
don't know that song. You don't like that song? I don't know
what song you're talk I can't think of the song. Wait, what song
are you talking about? Bad Boy for Life. Oh, I might know the
song, but I don't I can't think of what it sounds like off the
top of my head. I don't know. I don't know music by like song
names ever. It It's one of those Oh, yeah. No, no. I 100% know
that song. Never mind. I 100% know that song. It's uh It's one
of these things. I think it's still jam worthy even though, you
know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We Yeah, I know. I know the song. Hold
on. I was trying to get the context on this Kelly Jean comment.
Uh, so this is the top level comment. It's about Emirou. It says
she's told this story before. She talks about it on her server
before just to avoid getting dinged for rule four. I assume this
is uh Emiru. I uh hold on. Is it top or bottom? I I can't tell
if I'm reading top to bottom or bottom to top right now. I met
a streamer that wasn't chill as IRL except for Train X TV. That
guy, lol. I met Trainrex at Blizzcon and I was with Kelly Jean,
hot blonde league streamer, and he tried to hit on us and Kelly
played along cuz she's amiable, but I can't do it. My face was
too obviously annoyed and he popped the off of me and he was
like, "One day I'm going to be the biggest streamer on Twitch.
You're going to think back to the moment you rejected me and
regret it." I was like, "Okay, lol. Okay, buddy." Train wrecks
is in the wow section. Oof.
And then that's a shame she had to deal with Train and also hang
out with Kelly is I guess where this starts. So people talking
[__] about Kelly, I guess. You know Kelly Gene is
bad news if even Destiny cut her out. Mau explain the problem
with Kelly Gene. I'm clueless. And then Kelly responds with this.
Woof. Sorry, there's the context for you. There it is. There's
all the context. They said her name. How did she even see that
comment? I don't know. She was looking at the thread earlier.
I saw her looking at the thread cuz she said, "Oh, I was here
for this when this happened." I wouldn't be shocked if somebody
in my Discord linked her this thread and said, "Hey, Kelly Gene,
are you going to let people talk you like this?" Seems like something
that could happen. See, Emir mentions Kelly. They seem to be
talking about it right now. I'm trying to see if maybe they can
say why this happened. Oh, really? Yeah. Really? Really? Trying
to see. They're talking about it in general chat a little bit.
I can't see general chat. Where's that? My Discord.
Oh, where the
dude? Look at that. Someone's got You see that thing of me that
someone did right there? That's funny. That's a good one. Wait,
in my in my Discord. Yeah, in your general chat, someone did
a face thing of me. Look how funny that is. Oh, yeah. They do
this. They be doing It's looking It's looking down at a comment,
too. It's like, huh? You got to reverse it. So, it's looking
up at the previous comment and it's like, what the eyebrow all
eyebrows? Hold on. Let's Let's Let's listen to this. Party later.
You should come. This popular streamer and this popular streamer
are coming. But it was really awkward because those popular streamers
were Kelly's friends and we knew that they weren't going to this
party, but she she was being really nice. She was like, "Oh,
yeah, like maybe we'll stop by. Like, yeah, seems nice. We'll
let you know." She's really she's really really nice to people.
But then me Oh my god. Who's the are Okay, this is a different
Kelly Jean. There's a different Kelly Jean that exists somewhere
out there. Okay, there's a different Kelly Jean somewhere. This
one is like a Okay, Kelly was cloned and replaced. Okay, Kelly
was cloned and replaced. Oh, you guys know me. I can't really
like act. And so I was obviously my face was just like annoyed
like just like no reaction. I was just like, "Yeah, like I don't
really want to talk to this guy. He's I don't know. What a bitch."
Okay. What a This guy's like pouring his heart out to you. What
a [__] Okay, she couldn't even pretend to be nice.
What a I'm just kidding. And then he turns to me and he's like,
"That's a joke. You know what? Someday I'm going to be the biggest
streamer on Twitch and you're going to regret not giving me a
chance." And I was like, "Okay."
And to this day, he is not the biggest streamer on Twitch. So,
well, l I guess. Uh, but yeah, this was in like 2000's.
She kept going, Dan. She Kelly kept going. Really? I think it's
weirder to tell a teenager in detail about having an underage
babysitter fetish.
Why is she like this? Why can't she be chill? Give me the link,
Dan. Why does she have no chill? Give me the link. I got to send
it out. The link? Uh, I don't have a link. I got a picture of
a comment here. You want me to You want me to go find it? I know
how to do that. Hold on. Kelly
Jean.
Let's see here. This one, this person was calling her a and she
uh she went harder on someone else in response. Good times. Good,
good, good time. Actual broken system kind of. Kelly's in the
waiting room. Oh, Kelly's there. Let's go. But also now I need
to be right back in 2 seconds. So Oh my god, this guy. The I'm
pulling her down. We'll see. Kelly is here. Hello. I brushed
my teeth, but now you made me come downstairs. I ate shortbread
again. That's just very annoying. Okay. Well, I'm bl I'm blaming
you for this. I'm going to need to brush my teeth again. Kelly,
what do you have to say for yourself? What do you have to say
for yourself?
That's pretty good. What is What is your with your comments on
LSF right now? Trashing Destiny. That's so crazy. Trashing. Yeah.
Yeah, it kind of is. Those There's other people like talking
about you and you were like
probably the one where you babysitter thing for no reason. That
was pretty crazy. Was it no reason or is it because I'm getting
criticism of like weird and so because those people are definitely
not the kind to respond. Hold on for Okay, that's totally fine.
But just first qu cuz I don't necessarily criticize all the posts.
Okay, but first question I was just say, have you given up on
being friends with Destiny? Are you like we're not friends anymore?
He banned me and unfriended me. Like and as you've told me yourself,
he clearly hasn't liked me for a year. So what is Yeah, but you
coped about this for a long time. If you're like off of that
page, we're not friends anymore. Then I'm cool. Then I'm like
there's nothing. It wasn't cope. It's what I believed at the
time. Yeah. Completely unfounded illogical beliefs are cope by
definition. Okay. Do you think I was doing it intentionally?
No. But that the whole point of cope is Well, then that's all
people care about. They only people only care about coping intentionally.
And yes, you can. No, that's not true. Yes, you can. I will just
be your pay. Genga ninja donated. I should have played the Wy
song. A little Whly Wayne song. W. But I mean, I don't hate him.
Mostly I just want him to actually do the thing and like fix
the right. I like that stuff. I just I just mean like random
people are fighting with you and you're like completely throwing
death under the bus. Uh how many times has he done that to me?
Oh, that's my donation alert, Pisco. It's my donation alert.
I say that the donation alert. How many times has He's done that
many times. Uh I don't know. Has he done that to you a lot? Yeah.
Just like he's like somebody else is fighting with him like Hassan's
like on him and he's like
you remember when Kelly Jean was a total [__] I mean
it's not in that scenario. It's more like saying Kelly Jean is
such a subhuman that it's fine that forthought is absolutely
deranged to her. Yeah, he said any treatment is justified, right?
Any treatment that's not on his platform.
So why the after that point would I then have to care about his
feelings if he didn't give a [__] about mine? Why?
You don't have to. You don't have to. I just I it was mostly
like a one-sided thing where like you were I I felt like you
were like we're friends and I'm like well if you're friends you
shouldn't do but if you're not friends anymore it's fine. Why
are people saying fourth on one? He's literally had a mental
breakdown and left.
Uh, I don't know. Like, hello. He's on holiday. When has he ever
done that and like taken his mod away in that how many years
he's been around? I I I just I'm just telling you I don't know
that. Do you think that? Do I think I think probably he didn't
like the way the community was acting or maybe he just didn't
like the way things were being received and he realized that
uh he puts effort into his real life, it rewards him way more
than being a good like Reddit janitor. So, he probably was like,
I'll just go do that for a while. I don't know if I call that.
Seems like a moment of clarity, but right. Surely that seems
like cope. And no, definitely the last time he spoke about me
when he came on briefly on the stream that was like he was on
the verge of crying. Really, Kelly? Crying? Yes. You want to
watch it again? Certainly not my commentary, but uh yeah. I don't
know. I don't know. What do you want me to say? You're going
to pretend like you didn't hate Full Thought more than me right
now. Uh yeah, I didn't. I'm not sitting here like celebrating
his downfall out of nowhere. Um, I'm not doing that either. You're
being weirdly manipulative in this conversation. I simply mentioned
him because other people in the chat were saying 4.1, but he's
literally not here. So, what did he win? No, you brought it up
first. Hold on. You You just made that up. You brought it up
first. Okay. You brought it up first. No, I was I was responding.
Hey, I said I gave you the random example. No, no, the chat was
responding to you using as your example of like, "No, Destiny
said this about me with the fourth the Kelly Gene rule in the
fourth eye discussion." What are you talking about? is saying
I was responding to the chatter saying fourth one that's not
related to anything I was talking about
that's like an unrelated comment
we literally literally contact message that is true social the
only relation but I'm not saying I'm telling you that the causal
the the reason okay the cause for that was her saying the thing
about forethought both because you asked me to give examples
you asked me to give so I gave you one so why are you speaking
you brought it up what was the purpose Look at this. I thought
them were being You choose. Everybody else will bring it up.
You brought it up. You lost. You lost. Hot air balloon right
now. You just zip into space. She brought it up. Yes, cuz you
asked me to give you a go. That was one dumb ass. Appreciate
it.
Okay. All right. We're on the same side.
Or sorry, we're not on the same side necessarily, but I I don't
really have a lot of criticism. I was like, "Oh, Kelly is one
example. I just
That's crazy. You said you always How did you get me out of bed
to not give me much criticism? Really? Really? Kelly, get out
of bed and just I thought you were coke that you and Destiny
were friends. I thought you were still in the coke that like
he was just getting mad and he was but eventually you'd just
be friends again. I thought you guys were just on the same I
thought you were on that coke, but you're not anymore. You're
off. Well, I I still don't know what its problem is. So, like
I'm still confused. Okay. Because it started like what? You wouldn't
be confused now though, would you, Kelly? because you've done
it. You've No, no, no. I don't mean I don't mean confus. Well,
you could say it for both, but when I say confused, I mean of
the what? Why? Not so much that um why it started, but like if
he doesn't if he doesn't with you going on if he doesn't with
you from now obviously like this is probably it's probably the
end, right? Yeah. I mean, sure. Uh I don't know about that. Hold
on. I don't know about that either. I don't really care that
much. And that's why I already made my opinions well known like
a month ago when this stuff happened. Uh it's why I haven't bothered
to like um message him to be like I got to get unbanned. I'm
just like okay whatever. I think you should just make a smurf
account called Wellyween and rejoin and then ask for they unbanned
Kelly Beans so there might as well be a smurf of me in there
now. I don't know why I do. I can't remember why they got banned.
Wait, what's the Kelly Beans account? What is that? It's not
me.
army. They got banned for impersonation before. So, oh that's
why, which is funny, but whatever. Okay. Ask her if someone from
Discord pipped her off on the LSF thread. Oh, how did you find
out? Were you reading this thread? How did you see this? Pro
linked me the uh video. He didn't link me the thread, so I don't
think he was. He just linked me a bit because Emory mentioned
me. Yeah, she brought up the train wreck stuff and directly mentions
me in the clip. But of course, as soon as Kelly Dean is mentioned
anywhere for any reason, completely out of context, there's a
bunch of freaks in there being
mean like level of stupid. So, you know, um I'm not above fighting.
That is what they're like. That's what those Redditors are like.
That was an accurate impression, Kelly. Thank you for that. Okay,
I appreciate that. Well, you're fighting me on a even playing
field on LSF. All right, so uh I did think it was a little weird
that Emir was like, Kelly's like the nicest person in the world.
I was like, oh, wow. You can tell they haven't hung out in a
while. Damn. It's almost like No, I have I saw her in 2023 at
the very end of 2023. She was at Canute's wedding. Okay. It's
almost like the majority of people that hang out with me aren't
like uh bra just died. Aren't sending absolutely insane comments
in my direction first. Uh could be. Yeah, could be. Ask her how
long she was around Emirou. How long were you around Emiru for?
Um most of that evening. Did you guys catch up? I sat I sat next
to her at the wedding. I sat next to her near dinner and then
we went to the casino for a bit and I invited Destiny to that
and he did not come presumably because that was after the cherry
mental breakdown. Okay. But did come which was nice. Uh-huh.
Why doesn't Kelly do cosplay with Emmy these days? Um I mean
she says herself in that video. I've been ill and I haven't seen
anyone. I haven't done like a proper cosplay collaboration with
anyone in ages. I haven't even like cosplayed myself properly
in ages. Wasn't Emiru underage then? I mean, she was on her Discord
or whatever. Like the You see the Discord post is here. There
was there was somebody who posted like logs of her in her discord.
When I met her the first time when she came to England, she was
18, so I think she would have been 19 here. Okay. I don't definitely
not underage. Kelly, somebody's saying you should cosplay somebody
from Rivals, Marvel Rivals. Uh yeah, a bunch of people said that.
My housemate is also she's just doing like a psy cosplay. I haven't
even looked into who the characters in Marvel Rivals are other
than the ones that I've seen on the page. I'm just like mentally
checked out. Yeah, I thought I thought we'd just get you looping
on the whole Destiny is my friend actually thing, but apparently
not. So, is that that's what you're Do you think that I would
still continue that loop after those comments? Does that make
much sense? No, but it didn't make sense before that either.
So, I mean, I've been critical of him and I think that he does
not like that. And I mean, Dan has said it as well. Like, being
critical of him is like, you're walking a tight rope of like,
you like I feel like Dan I feel like Dan's anti-fan behavior
is starting to really concern me. I agree. He has been He's made
me be like, "What?" Not what I was saying. Whoa, Dan. We're just
trying to join the Discord as well. No, Dan is gone. Listen,
we were hanging out with Dan when Dan took his sleeping pills.
He was gone when he left here. Um, he takes the same ones as
me, which I also have taken as well. So, yeah, I won't be uh
taking super long. Okay. All right. Stream ends. Be serious.
Perfect. Are you serious, Kelly? Be serious. It's so I don't
know why people are saying bridgeburned when he banned me and
removed me a week ago and he's been weirdly hostile to me like
increasingly
hostile. I don't know, at least the last 6 months. I mean, I
think that's probably fair that the bridge was burned before
this. I mean, he was madder at me around the time around the
forethought stuff than anything else, but I barely did anything
in that situation. I don't know if it's just cuz he was really
mad at like the idea of losing a forethought. What? I don't He
was really mad at Dan for weaponizing you against forethought.
I had to guess. Okay. Um, but why was it? And he didn't think
he didn't think Dan really cared about how you treated, Kelly
Jean. I think I don't think he thought Dan was concerned about
how you were treated at all. Okay. I think he was like, "Oh,
this would be really really easy to like dunk on Forthought with
these Kelly these Kelly logs." But Forthought also doesn't care
about Anna as he'd like to call her Ana. He didn't know anything
about her. Couldn't pronounce her name and she hadn't been around
in a year. So like, okay, even if Dan did do that. Yo, Benny,
join the Denny. Like, I give permission to use the weapon.
I'm pretty sure it's Benny. Oh boy.
doesn't have to join the waiting room. Benny has notable. Let's
go. Benny can just jump in whenever he wants. How do you feel?
How do you feel, Vinnie? You want to take a victory lap or what?
What's going on? It's just It's just I don't know, man. It's
just so crazy. It's just so crazy. He was just so right the entire
time, every single time. And it's just like, you know, it's it's
not enough. It's not enough that he was correct and people are
starting to see the light. I feel like I feel like there need
to be some retractions. I feel like there need to be some apologies,
Wait, do you feel like uh you feel like it should start with
Chud Logic? Who was right? I'm lost. Start with it. It probably
should start with Chud Logic, but I'm not holding out whole
uh Mr. Girl. This is one of Mr. Girl's bigger fans. Yeah. Would
you agree with that? That it needs to start with Chud and his
one-sided sweeping of that situation. Yeah. But the thing is
it really this guy this guy was the head house brother. Okay.
And then he had the nerve to call other people out who do the
behavior he used to once engage in. Okay. It's reallyed up on
his part. I'll just say it. Okay. 10,000 lashes. That's all I'll
say. Yeah. But I don't I I I feel like I don't really see Chad
as like a uh like a truthsayer. I feel like um he's kind of like
a rat opportunist. So, you know, he took the opportunity to That's
what I'm Me too. And I'm like, bro, could I get some solidarity
here? And I can't get any solidarity. Oh, you want solidarity
with Chud Chud? That's a rat opportunity. Yes. Thank you.
Yeah, but I don't you're not you're not quite there yet. You're
not you're not at his level. You still try. That's true. You
see, that's that the stench of destiny. You still have the stench
of destiny on you where you're like, "Oh, I have smart opinions
and I'm going to be rational and logical." Doesn't do that. He's
just talking and making money. And I don't necessarily have a
problem. He's just like an entertainer, you know? Like you're
like, "Oh, we're going to be covering this today." But, you know,
it's like it's like you're trying to be a it's like you're trying
to be a a guy with good opinions. And I Like again, I don't have
a problem with it, but you know, I just hold you to a higher
standard. Just my opinions. Just my opinions. Yeah, but like
if somebody disagrees with you, you're like, "Get in the Discord.
Otherwise, I'm going to ban you." No, I only do that when people
are misrepresenting what I'm saying or they're not understanding
being. Somebody tells me what my opinion is and they don't understand
it, I will say, "Get in the Discord, loser. I'm lost." If people
want to just argue that I'm wrong, I'll be like, "Talk about
it. Let's go." They're saying, "This is what you just said and
it's not correct." Yeah, you you're out of here unless you come
and defend yourself right now. Is he ranking you on like a sweeping
level? Is that what's happening? I'm a bit confused.
Uh I'm so happy that Kelly's adopted this word. It means it's
not long for this word world anymore. It's going to be gone.
I feel like I I feel like Kelly was one of them. I'm not going to
lie. I feel like Kelly was one of soon so it doesn't matter.
Who was That's unfortunate. I'll be praying for you. I feel like
Kelly was one of the people who was um you know like oh Mr. Girl's
crazy. What's wrong with him? He lost his mind. Uh yeah, I'm
not going to suddenly just agree with Mr. Gold because like Destiny's
being a [__] It's like what am I is that what you
expected me to do? Well, it sounds like it sounds like you you
agree that he did some weird stuff and you agree that he doesn't
take any criticism and you agree that his community I agree with
the second part. Yeah. I don't this stuff it's it's not that
it's weird. Um obviously it's that it's hurt other people. I
mean does that sound that different from what Mr. Girl said?
Yeah. I don't remember everything that Mr. said if Mr. Girl came
out, by the way, just so you know, if Mr. Girl came out was like
Destiny's a real [__] and he doesn't seem to consider
other people's feelings, uh, literally nobody would have disagree.
It wouldn't have even been a thing. I didn't know that Destiny
would have been he had some very specific allegations. Okay.
So, you think that all these people that are now beefing with
uh Destiny, they're just saying, "Oh, he's a real and he doesn't
consider other people's feelings, that's all they're saying?"
Hold on. Fairy Queen, Kelly Jean. Okay. Did Fairy Queen Fairy
Queen really Oh, hold on. Did you read Fairy Queen's post? I
didn't make allegations either. I just want him to fix the situation.
It's like a bit different. All right. I didn't say that these
people were correct. I said that all these people hated on Mr.
Girl and now they agree with him. Mr. Girl could be wrong, too.
Hate on Mr. Girl. Yeah. Fairy Queen tried to jump him in in like
a stream. It was God. Okay. I didn't like Mr. Girl because he
sent me not not once but twice messages asking me for the platonicness
of my relationship and asking me if I Destiny. That's why I don't
like him. That was weird. He's a journalist. You had to get the
scoop. Weird behavior. You had to get the scoop. He is very strange.
I just
Benny, I'm Benny, I'm a journalist. I need your body count right
now. A
Oh, boy. The voice crack is not a good open for that.
Oh boy. Well, you know what? Now I hate you, too. Now I think
you're weird. Yeah. No, it seems fine. Uh, that's actually a
banger of a comment. Destiny literally say, "You can talk to
the women I've been with. I hadn't done anything weird." But
then when someone actually does it, he kills them. Bro, I almost
lost my mind. I was like, "What happened during the Lefty arc
when everybody was saying, "Oh, Destiny might be a You can talk
to anybody I've had a relationship with. They won't tell you.
You can talk to as many of them as you want." And then Mr. Girl
does it and now all of a sudden he's a crazy person and they
shot him in the street. Isn't that insane? Isn't that crazy?
I mean, the issue was he was trying to get dirt by talking to
people that had clearly not been with him like me. So that made
me that undermined what he was trying to do. What do you mean
clearly not being with him? How is it clear? I had stated that
I hadn't. I'm like, do you think I would change my status just
because like Mr. Girl messaged me? Also, yes, it's obvious to
me because I know I haven't. Okay. Well, if you send it publicly,
why do you think you have problem with
there real quick? I think it's really disturbing and bizarre
that you guys are so focused on the details of Destiny's life.
I think that's bizarre. unhinged crazy weird weird to tell you
the truth. Yeah. All right, man. This isn't talking about his
life. This is me saying I did not have sex with anyone. That's
the opposite. That's an life. It's also me talking about why
I find Mr. Girl weird.
And I think him doing that undermined what he was trying to do.
You can think that he's weird things. But I think it's about
time that you look inward and you recognize that he was always
right along. That Jewel was right all along. I'll never admit
that. No, just criticized one thing already. I don't know how
much I care to go over a Mr. Girl manifesto to see what's wrong
with all of it. I mean, I never even finished reading it, so
I'm not asking for that. I would say that hold on. You you have
to admit 100%, Benny, that he came up with a thesis for that
manifesto, was given essentially zero feedback from the additional
people. So he had like an additional thesis from talking to two
people, sought additional evidence to publish a manifesto.
Zero additional evidence and published the manifesto anyway with
the allegations that he originally sought more information and
more evidence of. Right. Um
what do you think his original thesis was? Uh that his originals.
Do any of us even remember? Well, Cream definitely would, but
um Scream reads that a lot every other day. Really? I read it
before bed every night. Oh, I had times people in the Discord.
Um, it was something like uh what was it? Destiny derives pleasure
from making women fight each other. Is this not a Was this a
Max allegation or a lab allegation? I forget to be honest with
you. No, I think that was Max. Okay. He he went up with that
one a little bit. I'm not going to lie to you. Who did he did?
That one was a little uh that was a little out there. I won't
say it was imposs it's impossible, but uh I wouldn't have gone
with that. I would have just been like uh he's a weird freak
taking uh taking advantage of his position to everybody. Yeah,
but weird freak doesn't mean anything. Weird freak is you could
say weird freak, but then eventually like you're going to have
to actually say the things you think are wrong, right? And that
was the issue is that that basically was what Max was doing and
then he had to really get like specific about it. He didn't have
info. I mean, there's reasons you could say that like that what
Mac did Max did wasn't wrong, but like I think the way people
argue it typically is they just say he was right and they don't
actually engage with the fact that the manifesto was not compelling
whatsoever. Yeah. I I always say that I thought the manifesto
was bad obviously as a
not compelling.
Uh so like the person in the chat just wrote Destiny did go the
blonde chick into fighting left though. So like the Zoe stuff.
Um I Okay. So when I brought this up uh this is what led to like
the
argument as I like to call it cuz uh he ever doubt your ability
to take the current conversation and relate it back to something
you and yourself and what you want to talk about. Shut the [__]
up and listen. So, shut up. Just like immediately. Immediately
like why ask me to be here if you don't want me to. What you
just said reminds me of a thing that happened to me and I need
to talk about me right now. No, it's directly the same topic
that he just mentioned. Like destiny pitting girls. That's like
the only way you can. You really couldn't sit down and listen
cuz you you can't sit down. I have to laugh about it every time
it happens cuz it's very funny to me. Okay. I'll be sure to get
out a notebook and write down every time you're self involved
now. Okay. Just
you need more pens. Go ahead. So, like that's the first time
he got really mad at me, right? And he started like screaming
at it was like an hours long conversation where he was just molding
the entire time and then pointed out, "Oh, I'm in spicy chat.
Therefore, I know all of this stuff about him even though I didn't
even speak about him in there." It was really like really weird
behavior. But he did get really um he was really sensitive to
that as a topic because otherwise he wouldn't have spurred a
bunch of insults at me when all I was telling him is, "Hey, if
you play up to the memes in the chat about you pitting girls
against each other, they're going to start thinking that it's
real." Which is true cuz that's what was happening in that point
in time. And then he absolutely lost his mind cuz he thought
I was saying something else. I think he probably thought you
were trying to, you know, give that narrative legs. Yeah. He
said I he said I thought he thought uh he was giving like the
actual Mr. Girl narrative. Yeah. Well, I mean you probably have
to confront the fact that you are doing that a little bit, right?
If if somebody's like if somebody's been accused of being a and
you're like, "Uh,
excuse me." Um maybe you should take when I say no as no, or
else everybody's going to think that that guy who called you
a is correct. I just feel like you are kind of leaning into it
in a way that's uncomfortable. Okay, that doesn't mean you're
incorrect. That's not the situation. It's not something that's
not the situation how it went at all. This was okay. It was off
stream and he was currently typing in the general chat stuff
that was going to aggravate that as a topic. Yeah. So, we was
intentionally playing into it and I was like, why? I mean, if
you don't want people to like perpetuate this rumor, why are
you playing into it? How does that how is that the same as Mr.
Girl just stating it is a fact? It's not the
Uh, well, giving a piece of advice. Just because you like watching
people fight or you does not mean you like you get pleasure out
of it. Those are different things. So if you're saying oh well
like if I said get pleasure out of I just said he was not so
if I said that do do does he now have to like not not so air
anymore? Is that not something he can do anymore? I said he was
playing into the part which is pitting women against each other.
No it's getting pleasure from pitting women against each other.
Okay. Well, how the [__] am I supposed to prove that?
It's not like I could hear him fapping in the background, is
it? Obviously, that's the only part I would about. So, you had
proved like I said in the Queenman analogy that he's making fun
of not soite and you're going, "Oh, well, that guy who said you
get pleasure out of this sure was didn't use that analogy again,
actually. Thank you." I think that the analogy that you use to
very solid metaphor, I think it's a pretty good analogy, too.
Quite frankly, wouldn't be surprised if it's true. I'm not saying
it is true, but Hello. Hey, I'm on your team. What the? Well,
I'm just, you know, I'm just trying to be an honest guy. You
don't even know if what is true. Let's get this one out, Kelly.
It would help if you would like state we're actually talking
about. Don't worry about it. What happened to Cherry? Where's
Where's Cherry been? You got up at the juggling joke. No, it
was uh because you said I'm funny. No, no, it really do that.
Yeah. Yeah.
That you don't know what you're talking about. It's a position
you're very comfortable in. So, continue. Replay it then. What
do you mean replay it? I have conversations with this person
that you're unaware of. Okay. Well, everyone else saw the video,
not whatever the you're saying. Yeah. Do you think she was mad
at what you were saying or you think she was mad at what? He
was mad. I never said it was like the defining thing of why she
You're such a You're so Raya donated $5.
I'm sorry. Did she not look when you said that I was funny or
that made the juggling joke? Was she not? Was she happy then?
Or was she quite clearly? Uh, I think she was That's a answer.
But wait, I literally started talking. It was kind of you as
well. Me and for not saying, "Hey, Nero, what the bro doing?"
It was kind of cringe and was being an [__] No, it
was all that. You idiot. So, it was that and it's just because
you didn't defend her. It's the narrow comment. You stupid.
I don't know either. I said, "Are you deaf?" I said the tucking
comment. Yes, I did. Okay, that was the first thing I said. You
know you're referring to the joke. You know you're referring
to the joke. You would have said the comment. The joke. What
do you mean the juggling thing was a joke that Nero said? It
was a joke I said for We're watching the DJ Awards show. Why
are you trying to tell me what happened? Yes, but I I said the
juggling joke first and then you said no and then I said this
thing then and now you're like no, it was the juggling thing.
I'm like felt like I'm losing my mind talking about Nero's comment
at at best here you are incredibly ambiguous because the entire
thing is precipitated by the DG award the video with the juggling
joke. Yes, that was the last thing. Yes. And that's the first
thing I said. Okay. I'm saying verbatim you're quoting me in
that in that clip and not the Nero thing. The Nero thing is different
and came after after like a long argument. Um well now I'm just
confused. Oh, just state it very clearly then if you think I've
said something inaccurate. I don't Kelly is one of the only people
I've ever been exposed to who's obviously met their full potential.
That's very kind of you. I am tired and I've taken my medications
that helps me sleep. Okay. So, yeah, I'm not functioning on 100%
currently. Okay. So, if people aren't very clear about what the
they're talking about and state like names and what places or
whatever, yeah, I'm going to get confused. Okay.
mad all the time as she argues over a point where she didn't
say names or or anything and it led to confusion. Well, I'm not
going to confuse myself and I did say names and things. I said
juggling. I was specific
specifying something quite specific. There's actually something
wrong with you, J. You got a problem. Okay. Wait, so did we did
we sidestep the the cherry thing or did Kelly Jean just
cherry
didn't stick? I'll actually say what happened. There's a weird
thing weird ways that I deal with conflict that don't work with
way Cherry deals with conflict is probably going to lead to the
overall partnership on stream not working out in the long term.
Yep. Is that it? Is that all you're giving? Uh that's all you
need. That's literally what the problem is. Cherry and I have
had an argument like the one we had on stream or like the that
moment like a thousand times and still stream together. Part
of a larger conversation. Sure. But why did it come to a head
then there then? Yeah. Damn you co-host. Did it Okay. Why did
it come to a head there then if like that conversation was literally
irrelevant? Oh, cuz it was obviously I had a lot of other stuff
going on the background, right, and a family member and intensive
care at that exact moment in time like Okay. So, I was I was
obviously on a You think you were more said multiple times to
people in the stream? No. Uh I think I think specifically I was
more frustrated in general. I know.
I didn't even notice you get mad at her, but maybe you did. I
don't know. Yeah, that's why I just said you are not privy to
the actual conversations that happened. Well, yeah. I'm saying
how it looks from an observer. I'm not pretending to know any
personal details, am I? You are. But now you're pulling back.
No, I'm not. Ow. Where did I do that? Mhm. Mhm. It's not a answer.
It was the juggling thing. I know it was the juggling thing.
You're saying it was the juggling thing. Okay, that's the first
thing I said yes because you you then said Nero was the re I'm
so confused. First I said, "Oh, it's the juggling thing." And
you're like, "No." And then I went, "Okay, it's because you found
me funny." And you're like, "No, it's the Nero thing." And I'm
like confused because the Nero thing is the first thing I mentioned.
And now you're saying it's not the Nero thing. It's just all
of it's completely irrelevant. I said that was what started the
fight. But I said before any of that, there are conversations
behind the scenes that you're not privy to. Yes, but nobody cares
about get any further into unless you're going to actually talk
about it. I talked about it. All you need in therapy, we have
a phrase called uh it's never about the orange. Okay.
The [__] That'sed up. Don't don't don't do the orange
thing. Why an orange? Well, at some point did you go to therapy?
It's No, I mean like
not like I'm in therapy. Listen, Kelly, I want you Kelly, I have
an important question for you. Okay. An important question for
you. I want you to think historically, okay, for a culture that
you think of is traditionally masculine and then I want you to
name it. Okay? Top your head as quick as you can. Go traditionally
go naming. Holy [__] No, please. Historically, a
people, a civilization, a people, a civilization. Historically
masculine. You think of masculine people. Masculine. What does
this mean? I don't know how to think of a civilization as masculine.
There's women and men in all civilizations, isn't there? Okay.
Awesome. Oh, that's an answer. That's an answer. Yeah, but I
don't know what that means. It's people kind. Uh, it is people
kind like from a certain era. Yeah, like could be from an a bygon
era. This people you like think of that and it's like, oh, it's
masculine manly dudes. Okay. That they like represent that that
ideal. I don't know. I don't know. Like any any time period in
the past where a king was in charge probably was worse, but that
I don't know. No, I mean it doesn't necessarily have to be worse.
It's just, you know, masculine. Um, yeah. I don't
All right. What? What? Okay. What was the purpose of this question?
Uh, it's it was just for a hypothetical. Yeah. It's I already
said I'm taking my meds. Okay. I'm just about functioning to
think. Please don't ask me random questions as if this is going
to be Look, Kelly can't [__] do a hypothetical.
Start. Did you just Yes, it was intentional. Okay. You do start.
That is a good impression of you. Do I When do I do that? Yeah,
pretty often. Do I really? Yeah. Oh, I might I do make sounds
that uh Yeah, you're It's not sorting. It would be obvious, I
think, if you'd see me. But like I do like the like holding in
a through your nose, holding in a laugh. I do that. True. Why'
you snort? What the [__] you doing, bro? Say he can't
tell the difference. Snorting is inhaling. The exhale is not
snorting, bro.
Okay. Okay.
I'm just I'm just struggling. Okay. Somebody break the silence
cuz I feel like the next question I'm going to ask is going to
be about breakfast and it's not going to go well for anyone.
Was anyone like watching?
What? I didn't hear what you said about extra. What did you just
say about extra Emily? Nothing, man. Nothing. I was joking. Oh,
Emmy. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. No. Didn't
he say extra Emily? I did say he thinks they're the same person.
Well, sorry. He thinks they're the same audience. What is this
awkward silence?
I'm just I'm just smiling. Kelly, what are you talking about?
Is that awkward? I'm having a good time. Feels pretty awesome.
Okay. Okay. Well, let's find a topic then. Hold on. What's going
on recently? Wildfires. There's wildfires. What else is there?
Wildfires. There's Pisco fighting with this guy. I'm not super
interested in that one right now for this.
Back stream. Focused on the no bully stream. Well, hold on. Kelly's
talking about What about Kelly? Why are Americans focused on
this thing? Because Elon Musk said it. Well, the grooming. Oh,
the grooming gangs. The gangs. Uh, yeah. Everyone's focused on
it cuz Elon Musk was talking about it. They usually give him
this much attention when he says something. Uh, yeah. I mean,
he controls Twitter, like the biggest social platform in the
world, and he astroturfs all his tweets. Of course, remember
anyone caring this much about something he said before in like
this avenue at all? Uh well he I mean he was literally like we
should he's basically Trump's biggest adviser and he's like actually
we should go and invade right now. We should go and invade the
UK and and liberate them from their tyrannical government because
they let the Browns okay there have been a bunch of convictions.
So what exactly is it that people are mad at that are the more
people they want convicted? Like there's I think the dude who
organized the quadruple penetration of a 12-year-old got like
3 to 5 years or something. Most people are like, I think organizing
and facilitating the quadruple penetrative of a 12-year-old is
worth more than three to five years in prison. I think those
people are probably upset. You're going to find those cases in
your country and every other country as well. Trying to prosecute
for any length of time is difficult. I mean, there's that guy
that was in the Olympics, right? That's what I said, Kelly. That
probably if you had like dead to rights evidence from like multiple
people, probably would have gotten more time. What do you mean
was prosecuted? I'm saying like if you had ded evidence of like
this like let's say there was like a videape or like multiple
witnesses like in these cases where there's multiple witnesses
potentially that like you could very easily see the sentences
go up but I'm not sure the sentences would go up in this case
because I feel like there's probably not a lot of evidence. The
the this the sentence is determined by times that are like given.
So the max sentence is x y or z. It's not going to get a lengthier
sentence just because there are more witnesses. That's a strange
thing to say. Uh, I would say there should be more sentencing
because it's a 12-year-old and it's also trafficking of a 12-year-old
and probably like if they but if they had pro these are all allegations,
right? I don't know what they prove out proved out in court about
this person. Then then you're advocating for the laws to change,
which I wouldn't be against because I do think that laws in some
instances are kind of weak. But 3 to 5 years is about right for
that crime. I know it sounds horrible, but that is about right.
in every other country.
No, I'm saying that's about right for the UK. That that crime
and that 12-year-old that sentence. Yes, that's about right.
I'm not saying that I wouldn't personally advocate for it to
be more. If you're going to ask me, Kelly Jean, would I advocate
in like increasing the length of sentences? Yeah, of course I
would. But I'm telling you what are currently there. And what
is currently there is what is there. And I don't think judges
are allowed to just randomly determine a much longer length of
sentence. Like I don't think they can. Isn't that against the
law to just be like, "Oh, the max sentence for this is 5 years,
but I've decided to give them 20." I don't think they're allowed
to do that. I feel like for a child, it's usually there's usually
escalations there versus just regular Yeah. If you're saying
3 to five is good for child, it's like is like adult things have
determined laws. These are also laws that are there. I don't
know what you mean. So you're you want to advocate for new laws?
No, but you're saying like, you know, that's that's the standard.
You a kid, you get, you know, 3 years by by the time by the time
you come out, you could still them again and they still be underage.
I would advocate for them being [__] laugh if I could.
But yeah, but what I'm saying what I'm saying is do that. If
you raped an adult, would you get like community service? I'm
going to be incredibly
uh or does the fact that they're a kid not make a difference
right now? I'm going to be very dystopian. If people that committed
crimes got the length of sentence that I think that they deserve,
our prison population would not be able to sustain it. And that
is sad and that shouldn't be why people get the length of sentences
that they do. Um and I would certainly advocate for you know
like I don't know chemically castrate the I don't know like cut
the guy's off. I don't know. Drew is still resisting. Drew is
still resisting, guys. Wait, wait, wait. Just one second. Uh,
category one assault, which is the worst assault, is category
range says 3 to seven years with the sentencing. Yeah. What is
category one? All right, then. So, you guys just don't have like
escalations for children or anything? Uh, I'm not sure. I can't
It doesn't say children. I mean if no if the um if the person's
underage it is different from an adult but that doesn't mean
that the child sentences are just magically 10 times longer just
to heal. Also it's kind of saying twice as long but a woman or
any adult and a child you know they're still very bad like trying
to be like oh well the child should therefore get 10 times longer
is just like a bit strange really. I don't think it's strange
at all actually. I think that the sentences overall should just
be longer. Otherwise, you're saying that's what we're saying.
Yeah. The same laws are fine if the sentences were a little longer.
But, uh, also I think there's also there's like prostitution
here. There's like human trafficking, prostitution here that
like these things also and what you're feel is if you can be
proven to Yeah, that's what I'm saying is like that's why it's
so bad because if the things that are alleged are true and proven,
then 3 years in prison, 5 years in prison is way too little time.
Technically the allegations are like I've got the child ones.
I've got the child ones. So it's it's category 1, two, and three
again. Cate every one. Obviously the worst ones the range is
4 to 9 years. Um
what are what is the worst for those ones? Oh actually just link
it. It's 4 to 9 years for a which I guess is significant degree
of planning offender acts with others uh to commit the offense
use of alcohol/ drugs on victim facility. So this is like, you
know, modifiers. If it has any of those, it's 4 to 9 years. If
it doesn't, it's 3 to 7 years. That's category one. I feel okay.
I feel like this is one of those things where they maybe didn't
predict or think about the fact that there could just be all
of those at the same time. They're like, "Yeah, there's an element
of this, it escalates once." You know what I mean? But these
guys were like, "No, we can." Have you looked at Have you looked
at your own country's laws and how they compare, or are we just
picking apart the UK here? I'm including multiple different crimes.
So, I'm not including just this
not just the assault crime or just not the um the rape crime.
I'm just saying cuz most countries the crimes they're very similar
laws. It's like yeah, we can sit here and criticize the UK, but
you're probably sitting in a country that just has very similar
laws. Oh, hold on. Federal sentencing guidelines. Wait, somebody
linked me this. This is federal sentencing guidelines fence level.
But it doesn't say what what this is, right? you just sent me
like a blank document that doesn't actually I would be surprised
if America has much longer sentences but America does in policy
just do longer sentences and uh maybe in America you can still
marry your children from the age of zero in some states
crimes it's not about whether they
I mean there are marriages from the age of zero uh recently I
don't know they just give statistics of whether underage kids
have been like married or technically You're allowed to like
duel and kill somebody in some places in the world based on the
laws in the books. Do you think that you could get away with
murder by by threatening to by dueling somebody? Do you think
that it's bad that maybe these laws have not been ratified considering
uh America's No, because honestly for all of these laws, there
are discretionary things where where those laws can be changed
on the fly. It's not just like, oh, I found this old law on the
books and actually I can totally get away with murder. Every
other UN member has that except for the America. Okay. So yeah,
I think that's pretty. Every other what? UN member state has
what? No child marriage. Uh the same. Yeah. No child marriage.
And the US is like now we're good. We like child marriage. Yeah.
It's ratifying the convention of the rights of the child. They
just haven't done that. Okay. Why hasn't the US ratified the
UN convention rights to the child? Uh concern about sovereignty,
parental rights, or the impact on federalism. So the United States
on a on a constitutional basis probably feels like they can't
do this. Like this would be overreaching. So probably they're
like, "Oh well, it's up to the states to individually subscribe
to this." So why are there still multiple states where you can
get married at the age of zero? Is there a problem in that? Yeah.
Yeah, it is up to those states. And that's very weird. Uh
which states child marriage legal? Cuz here's why. I don't really
care cuz nobody's getting married to states that a ban child
marriages of 2023 most of the good ones. Can I get this map this
map right here but with an overlay of demographic data please?
Just curious. Sorry. Irrelevant question. Uh child marriage in
the US in uh marriageable age counting for exceptions.
There are four states. Is this Louisiana or Bama? I think this
is Bama, right? Alabama. This is Louisiana, isn't it? No, it's
not. Louisiana has to be attached to Florida. I didn't do very
well on this quiz. Wyoming, that's Mississippi, that is Oklahoma.
Okay, that would be New Mexico and California. So, California,
strangely the most liberal state, does not allow or does not
cons get concerned about marriage from the age of zero. Crazy.
Yeah, kind of weird. What sort of people are the most powerful
in California?
Not a good argument cuz I can go over to New York and not a good
argument. Yeah. And Florida. But like that's basically the US
goes, "Okay, well, we don't really have the right to do that
because that's not how our country works." So you can't just
say the US is like that. There are four states in the US that
are like that. I can criticize a lack of laws in place to protect
children. Sure. America. But I could just as easily say, wait,
the UK, okay, the UK allows like some like because Scotland determined
that they didn't want to put a specific law on the books. Okay.
What is What do you mean? Does that mean that your country allows
or What does didn't want to put specific flaw in the books mean?
I don't know. I'm giving you a hypothetical. Never mind. Kelly,
what did you How would you feel if you didn't have breakfast
this morning, Kelly? Why you being rude, J? I assumed you were
talking about this person is the worst. You didn't tell me it
was a hypothetical. I assumed that that was a literal statement
on the case that we've been discussing. It's not. It's a hypothetical.
Okay, then just say it's a hypothetical and repeat it again.
How would I feel if Scotland said people are telling you that
your country didn't have a problem with because Scotland which
is a part of the UK didn't want a law in the books that the UK
did? Yes, that would be bad because they can't do that. Okay.
So, I would feel like concerned deeply obviously. Okay. Now,
look up the rates of child marriage. You found that at least
10 states with the highest rate of child marriage per capita
between 2020 18 were Nevada, Idaho, Arkansas. I think this is
below 18, right?
In Florida, 16,400 children, some as young as 13, were married
in 2000 to 2017, which is the second highest incidence of child
marriage after Texas. 40,000 children were married. God damn.
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. Can I get child marriage in the Middle
East?
I mean, obviously things are going to be worse in the Middle
East. I'm just pointing out But yeah, but how much worse are
they? Maybe, maybe we're criticizing these people. Okay. Every
year 700,000 versus for like 20 years in the States. Those are
the numbers. Uh, never mind. This is significantly higher. It's
like significantly significantly significantly high. I mean,
also the Middle East. No way. Percentage of women who are married
before 18 in Iraq is 24%. That's nuts.
North Africa, by the way, that is an absolutely massive land
area. Why? Why do you think so many people do that, Kelly? Why
do you think so many of them do that? Why do you think they're
all like that? Why do I think? What? Like what? Sorry. Everyone
that they're inclined to marry kids off. Yeah. Oh, hold on. Here's
some important information just real quick. Oh, wait. No, answer
his question first. I'll I'll save this. Um, I don't know the
cultures involved with these enough, but I know obviously women's
rights are terrible in a lot of these countries. Yes. If there
are no rights, there is no ability to complain. There's no law
to like I guess to appeal to. I know not all countries in the
Middle East are exactly the same and some have more rights than
others, but they're pretty similar. largely no I do think there
is some difference like for example some countries do allow others
do not at all why haven't they changed the laws governments
the way that the societyy's structured to be very uh not it's
not just not against women is it it's like against anyone that
is poor and has like no influence you're just a bit as a addendum
Kelly do you think it would be concerning to do a lot of immigration
from places where like things like child marriage or Very very
good question. That's a very good question. I do wonder about
the immigration in these cases. Like what were the jobs and what
were the things these people were doing? That would be interesting.
So for there to be an actual profile because why really would
they need to be here? Cuz like I don't know was was there a large
amount of people fleeing Pakistan for like refugee status? I
don't know. Buying corner shops. I don't think so. Yeah. I don't
that's why it's strange. Yeah, really makes you think. Okay,
now I need to do the bit that this guy he linked liked. Okay,
to answer Kelly's question about laws in the US, every single
state in the union and the federal laws have harsher punishments
than the UK for rap children. Decent portion are life without
parole or death as well. Wow. Because kind of just a culture
shock. It's like, you know, a kid is kind of like your knee in
the UK. In the US, they think it's like a really bad thing.
This is why we need them, right? This is why we need multiculturalism,
guys. Can you link me to this? Which state offers the death penalty
for a child? Uh, I don't know. Um, I didn't click it, but I will
link it to Which state offers like I don't know it plus 20 years
or something. They almost definitely loads of them do Kelly.
I don't know why you're even the US. That's why I'm asking
penalty is available in some country some states. I don't know
anything about it. The reality is that just a lot of the time
sentences aren't that good and people need to stop crying. something
so emotional about it. But well, stop stop getting emotional
about getting child rap. Okay, this basically is just saying
there's no maximum sentence. That's a unique perspective, but
you know, but wait, but that's what you would want, right? No
maximum sentence. So, in the really bad cases, you would go like,
oh, you quadruple penetrated a 12-year-old and then threatened
to kill her parents if she told them. Uh, yeah. I'm not saying
it's a bad thing. I'm saying I highly doubt it that most of these
people are getting these type of sentences even when they are
that bad. Uh, wait. Why would you say that? Because I've seen
the whole point of the discussion. I've seen some of the sentences
for in America. It's not that for child like incredibly traumatic
abusive like like specifically again the hypothetical here, not
hypothetical, the thing that happened in the UK, the quadruple
penetration of a 12-year-old. I feel like that gets you whatever
the maximum sentences sentences. Okay. I would like to hear the
term quadruple penetration of a I don't want to hear the thing.
Jesus, why do you keep saying it? I didn't want to I didn't want
to read it. But you know what? Those those Pakistani gentlemen
are imaginative. Okay. I didn't want to have to read that that
happened. Gross. That would be real. True. Control F. 96 instances
in this article. Why what are we doing here? I mean, our sentences
look quite similar to California. So, by the looks of it, I'm
just doing the thing so you guys understand like why people might
be upset. Like when you when you go and you call somebody racist,
I just want you to understand the thing that you are saying they're
racist for being upset about. Okay? Yeah, call anyone racist.
It's the same for white people, yet they're crying when Muslims
got the exact same sentence as white people do. That's why it's
racist. Uh, okay. Show me, show me the Just show me any of these
people who will go, "Wait, wait, hold on. That quadruple penetration
of the 12-year-old, those perpetrators were white. Actually,
let them off with 3 years. Ignore it. Show me that example. uh
the UK. I'm I'm sure in the UK, but because I've heard the race
discussion be had, but the reality is that those are the sentences
that being handed out to white people every day and they just
only care. This specific crime I'm I keep having to say over
and over again that's happening by white people every day in
the UK. I think you guys might have a different issue. At some
point, a white person has quadruple. The majority of child is
committed by white
UK obviously because there's white people in the UK. At some
point, four white people have quadruple penetrated a 12-year-old
and they have received a sentence that is within the sentencing
guidelines. That is probably bad. And those people should get
way way harsher punishments. Yes. Okay. Why should they get way?
Do you think because the punishments are bad? Okay. I don't believe
in just like punishing people. You need to tell me why it would
be like good or beneficial to have these people.
Kelly was trying to explain why Japan's not racist. That's not
what I said.
Well, somehow Royal Kitten House's videos are still there. So,
yeah, because he does other stuff. His channel is not purely
dedicated to my content, right? 90%
your content. Kelly, you got it. You ass thumbnail he's using
of you. God damn. The world if Kelly Jean ran things, guys. The
world if Kelly Jean ran things. Okay. Yeah. You'd still have
a house. Wow. Wow. for pretty much everybody else. I don't think
it's like that bad. Like he he kind of like maligns people equally.
Oh, he also hates Britney Simon.
That'sed up. That's some up editing. Jesus, that's mean. Why
do you guys not get on the left? There I ask.
We didn't get I mean, if she doesn't like me, she doesn't like
me. But I I love her. Okay. Wow. I'm just kidding. People are
starting to think I'm actually racist. Maybe I am. Maybe I am.
I like that I argue against racist stuff most of the time and
everybody thinks I'm racist and for laugh because she's a woman
on the internet people are like no she's not really racist even
though she's saying the most racist all the time the crazy scale
we have to fight against Indians then but I'm also I lived in
Salt Lake City where like Mormons are known for being like very
beautiful and gorgeous and Aryan and in Los Angeles everyone
gets surgery to look beautiful so I've just been like around
very attractive people my whole life and so being here is like
genuinely insane. I went to go see a hockey game and how people
treated you like publicly like 5 years ago. What do you mean?
Nothing. You know what I mean? No, I actually don't know what
you mean. It was a joke about hitting the wall. Shut up. You
know exactly what I mean. Why are you pretending you don't know?
I got it. I got it. I got it. You got it. You got it. Can you
hear me? I can hear you. Okay, now I figured it out. So, it's
been womenless here. Why is that there? JS. Uh, well, cuz Kelly's
really annoying sometimes, so I'm not giving her a role to join
the channel. And then, uh, Cher's not coming on stream anymore.
Was those the only two women that were like uh regular here?
Like super regular? Yeah. And then beyond that, sometimes uh
Nu would come on. I think N's been playing video games in my
Discord instead of joining the stream, which is it is what it
is. And then I think you would come on probably. You're probably
like third or fourth most. Excuses. Excuses. I listen people.
It's still we're getting past the It is what it is. It is what
it is. That's what you said for Nu. Well, yeah. She's playing
video games. If she wants to play video games if people want
to play video games instead of coming on stream like that their
that's their option. Okay, they can do that. I can't just like
shut that down, tell them don't play video games, come on stream.
So what what do you have to do to I hate coming here? I don't
I don't see anything that would make me as a woman not uh come
here on your stream. However, what do you think? Let's do some
inter or selfreflection.
What do you think you have to do? Introsction. What do I have
to do? I just have to reach out to women more. I could easily
just reach out to women more if I wanted more women on the stream.
Or I could just move Kelly into the channel. Like Kelly has to
come on earlier and I was like, I don't think it's Kelly time
today. So Oh, Kelly's literally in general chat like complaining
right now. Bring her on. I I She would have to join the thing.
Can you tell if anybody's listening to me right now, can you
tell Kelly to join the thing? I saw that uh you her and the uh
was that Nu who was with her? was or I think so. Yeah, Nu was
on here the other night. The love of God, give me some goddamn
perms.
Kelly, Kelly, Kelly, Kelly, Kelly. Damn, it's been a while. How
are you doing? How the are you doing? I'm good. Also, I realized
I don't have you added as a friend, so I can't send you a message,
which is weird. Did you change your settings? No, no, no. I haven't
changed my That happened with me with with Hold, I'mma add you
now. That happened with me with with Cherry and uh there I think
I added you. You should be able to add me back. I got you. Okay.
Oh, there is that. I was going to
I we you and I cuz you sent me It was no problem with you sending
me DMs. I don't know what changed because I remember uh you and
I uh sent uh I'm not going to discuss the DMs, but we had a a
DM conversation. Yeah. Yeah. We spoke a few times. I don't know.
Settings change somewhere. I'm not sure. So, I don't I don't
know what happened with people who I was talking to all of a
sudden I can't talk to anymore. Oh, you might have changed like
your personal settings to like Yeah. So, you have to have friends
that non-friend could send you messages at some point. Did you
change that maybe? But Oh, you know what? You're right. You're
right. I always forget to have people as friends because I just
have Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Thank you. Yeah, that's the
problem. Okay, I'll fix that when I'll get around to it. Or just
remember to add people. Well, depends how many people there is.
I don't really add people. It's just that I I allow like if I've
DM'd you, I I can like me and JS. I don't think me and JS are
friends and we can communicate to each other on DMs, I think.
Oh, hold on. Is that true? Yeah. Remember how long just takes
me to add friends list
and immediately as soon as that happens, he starts the blocking
tirade. That was funny. That was months before everything else
happened as well. You're such a baby. God, it's so strange that
I messaged somebody like 12 times in a row. Have her back. Messaged
somebody 12 times in a row and then they blocked me. Wow. It's
almost like there's a connection. What happened? The first time
it happened, you were being a You didn't like that I brought
up Darius on your stream, so you blocked me. I didn't even know.
Is that true, JS? You didn't like her brain? I literally you
know that's true cuz you actually laughed at how we had that
fight tree. So why you don't know that? Okay. The the other times
maybe you weren't being a for the first time. You definitely
were. The first the the concept is if somebody else is live who
like I stream with and I have like overlap with and you come
to my chat and you're like they're live right now. They're covering
this. You're just going to get banned automatically. Okay. Well,
I'm not saying you don't have a point. I'm saying you're also
being a you think you're banned. Well, I I say off, Kelly, and
then I block you cuz you will you'll literally mess. You didn't
even tell me you blocked me. I didn't even notice. You had to
tell me like the next day. Oh my god. He blocked you with a DM.
He didn't even have the balls to tell you he blocked you. That's
a little bit of power. Somebody's being super annoying. I just
blocked them. Dream. Like, literally, I just block anybody who's
being super annoying. It's very easy, very trivial concept. Why
can't you deal with confrontation? I also I also think that's
completely made up that I let you know that I blocked you. There's
no way that happened. You did. I didn't. You would have been
asking me about something. You would have been asking me about
something. I didn't notice.
You told me. That's just how it happened. I didn't notice because
I didn't try to speak to you. So, I had I think that's obviously
not true, but you know what? I don't I would have to send a message
to notice, right? So, I was live on stream with you when you
did it and then I came back the next day and I hadn't noticed.
I think in 2025 we should get to a point where we use our words
to express what we really feeling and how we're feeling. Only
with people who are capable of introspection and change which
precludes Kelly. I've apologized to you. I've apologized to everyone.
You miserable pretens. What do you mean? Okay, we're going to
gaslight Kelly now, are we? Uh, in in any case, it's not so perceptible.
Also, now it's too slow. There's a time limit on it. Yeah, after
you've been like a certain amount annoying. Yeah, sure. Obviously
true. Wrong. Okay. I mean, you're literally asking me about my
interpersonal communication style. You can't tell me I'm wrong.
It sucks. I'm just going to do things the way I do. You don't
Yeah. How well has that worked out for you until now? Uh, incredibly
well. Built an entire stream off of it. I don't know why you
accuse me of not doing it well. What do you mean? That's not
your inner personal. That's like screaming on stream. Those are
like the opposite. Okay. Interpersonal is what you do privately
with people. No, it has a lot to do with what you say publicly.
People do too. Why would you act like interpersonal was only
private conversations? One-on-one private conversations
louder. Pardon me. That was really That was a really burp. Hold
on. Pardon me. And you go way louder than that. I get way worse
than that. I'm not going to uh subject people to that. But no,
like that what you do in private. That's how you communicate
in private is like made. Uh, no it's not. It's literally meational
why things are bad in in personal as well. Call the [__]
I totally am. I don't know what you're talking about. No, blocking
someone is not. I was being a [__] Blocking somebody
is saying you are whining about something that we've already
discussed to death and I can't take more of these DMs back. I
wasn't whining at all. I hadn't even noticed you blocked me.
You were mad at me because I brought up barriers. You whined
a lot in the whole the whole thing with you leaving stream. You
were constantly sending me like eight or nine unresponded to
messages and I was just like this is too much. I'm blocking.
I can't handle this. Okay. At no point would that be possible
because I wouldn't have been able to send those messages if you
had blocked me. So when the long
the blocks just came whenever you were mad or you couldn't be
bothered to speak about something. Ashley is probably more accurate.
Exactly. Yeah. But then there weren't messages before it. You
just doesn't ever really engage with a conversation. Eventually,
somebody's like, "You know what? I'm done pretending that you're
gonna actually engage or care about anything. I'm done." When
you're in a mood, I'll just block. I'll move on. You just are.
Yeah. And there's the made. Did you want Did you just walk away
from your computer? I'm bullying his own street. I'm not wearing
socks and I don't like not wearing socks. So, why are you not
wearing socks in January? Jesus. Cuz I have heating. I don't
know. They're What was I saying? Oh, I don't know. I I've like
explained plenty in in DMs like what my issues are. Uh, and then
once it gets annoying, I just block the person. I'm just like,
"Hey, you're not listening." Yeah. And I'm telling you what your
issues are because I also do that a lot for the sake of stream
because I hate getting what everybody does when they're mad at
me is they message me. They wait until I'm streaming and then
they message me a 100 times during my stream. And so I block
people who do that. That is another thing. They like they like
forget I exist until I'm streaming. And then they're like, "Now
I'm going to try to get his attention." And guess what? You got
my attention. And that's not good for my stream. That's why.
And now I throw it in a blog. You blocked me. But
I mean, you might have done that probably. Pretty much how I
block everybody. I mean, I don't Now I remember that. I think
like Destiny's perma van. That's also Kelly going like, "Ha,
loser. I won." By the way, she's like, "Yeah, I won. I won."
I don't think that at all. I just don't care. Okay. I kind of
like it. I reached my own opinion on something like a like I
don't know like a month before that happened. And uh I knew that
if I gave the mildest criticism, there was a good chance that
would happen. So whatever. And I also think he's a Soon as Kelly
was from DJ, she rejoined my Discord and started trying to come
on stream, by the way. Just saying. No, I came on your Discord
before I got banned. Are you lying? He's telling lies now. Canadian
telling lies. Yes, I came on New Year's Eve. I wasn't. How am
I lying on? I don't remember. You were lying. If you lie, I feel
like you started coming on stream way more when this happened,
though. Why the you lying? Well, yeah, because also there's someone
else not here. Anyway, awkward.
Why does Kelly try to bottom out at the end of a monotone grally
raspiness? That is a really specific question. I don't know.
Because I felt like it probably. So, JS, you guys uh think a
lot. Do you have any New Year's resolutions for 2025? Uh yeah.
What are they? I can't talk about them or I won't be motivated
to you know how like talking about stuff sort of drains your
motivation to actually do them. No. In other words, I think you
don't want to talk about them because you don't want to be held
accountable to keeping them. Okay. I'll be back on YouTube this
year. Okay. That's not in your control. I'm talking about something
within your I said, "Okay, normally New Year's resolutions are
things that you can do yourself that you have control over. I
can control that."
love.
Cuz they don't know what I look like. Tree. They don't know what
I look like. Okay. I can't say anything more than that. Just
let it go. Oh. Oh. Is that your only Is that your only resolution?
That's my only resolution. Yeah, my last my last uh what do you
call it? My last appeal, they gave me back an automated no within
3 minutes. So, damn. Yeah, we But realistically, I think you
speak to a person. I just think what's actually happening there
is like the account's too small for them to care about and I
think that will on the other side it should translate to like,
well, the account's too small for us to care about, so they just
won't care. I think I think so. We'll see. I told you I missed
that you're on not on YouTube because your streams are so long
and I don't get a chance to watch all of them and it's like there's
some only content that I'm only interested in and certain drama
that you talk about that I'm only interested in and I wish they
were just like clipped into like VODs and I think that happens
but I think the issue is nobody really wants to do a channel
that's purely that because if there's a channel that's purely
that then it could be removed. Like there's the RA channel that
I show sometimes. Who does that? It does like a bunch of my You
could just have somebody else could make in their name just to
call Clip's channel and you wouldn't be able to report it. It
would just as long as it wasn't made in your name. Do you have
like a sibling or like somebody like Mr. Girl Mr. Girl channels
get taken down all the time. I'm just saying there's no like
financial incentive cuz eventually once these get big enough
they do tend to get reported and it's like oh this is this is
content from a creator who's banned from YouTube. Well somehow
Royal Kitten House's videos are still there. So I because he
does other stuff. His channel is not purely dedicated to my content,
right? 90%
your content. Kelly, you got it. You [__] ass thumbnail
he's using of you. God damn. That one's not that bad. All the
other really bad. He also made like one of them. Like why? It's
so weird. The fat thumbnail pretty funny. God, I'm never putting
on terrifying. I'll say it. I'll say the fat thumbnail is pretty
funny. I look like female Wiz with makeup. Can you zoom in on
the RIP
or are we just bias on the Wait, what did you say? Can Can you
zoom in on the first thumbnail? RIP DG2.
Sure. Yeah, there you go. Thank you. I don't think he hideously
edited this one as much as the others. Oh, that one's not so
bad. Oh, yeah. Okay, I'll subscribe to him. I didn't even know
this channel exists, though. Yeah, does support lots of royal
is absolute trash related things.
I don't know. He doesn't like you. I will say he hates you for
pretty much everybody else. I don't think it's like that bad.
Like he he kind of like malign people equally. Oh, he also hates
Britney Simon.
Good. That'sed up. That's some up slot editing. Jesus. That's
mean.
Hunchback of Notraam. Yeah, but there's like a whole thing tree.
Okay. There will always be some motivation for people to post
this stuff because I I I wrote them down. I'm going to subscribe.
I didn't know this video exists. I didn't know exist. If you
if you post this content or reacts to this content, it's like
good for views. Like lots of people get lots and lots of views
off of these. So yeah. So yeah, people post like reactions, they
get a lot of money. Okay. Every time I speak for more than like
30 seconds just tell there's a fight between this guy and Queman
for who can post who can repost the content faster and Queman's
getting absolutely right now. Cleman is getting like absolutely
obliterated by this guy and he doesn't like it. Okay. I feel
like Queman's like 2 seconds away from asking doesn't do anything.
He just reuploads what's already there. Yeah. Quan actually has
commentary. That's true. No, that's not true. That's not entirely
true. Quayman has absolutely taken to a little bit just replaying
my VODs and being like very little commentary which I don't I
don't mind. I've given him permission to do that. I gave him
permission to do that. Okay, cuz I like my content being on YouTube.
I like people seeing that I'm still creating content and then
they'll go, "Wait, where is this getting done?" So I full permission,
okay? Full permission to my friends to do that kind of thing.
It's funny. I I was recommended his his uh live stream out of
the blue and I don't know why I'm but I went to look at it. It's
just got a lot of overlap with Destiny content basically. No,
like these are good for me guys. Like I don't I don't hate anybody
who posts my content on YouTube because like obviously I want
my content to exist on YouTube and like realistically the money
from YouTube would be really nice. Like I'm sure I'm sure like
a 20,000 view video I'm sure that's going to make like 50 to$100
or something. Like the money would be nice from it but or maybe
maybe $30 to $70 or something but like why did you get banned
from YouTube? cuz I watched a Darius VOD and then I got like
some happened. Basically, there's like a guy saying like give
yourself fs slur in this vaude. I was Darius and then it didn't
get censored correctly and it's whatever. He should give you
a cut. Uh Riyle's offered me a cut from this channel. I it it
hasn't been monetized for a long time. It might be monetized
now. 20,000 views makes you $50. On a video that's 2 hours long,
it could. Yeah. On a video that's 2 hours long, uh 20,000 24,000
views cuz that's a lot of watch hours, right? Advertising is
usually like commensurate. It's usually related to watch hours,
not number of views on the video. Yeah, that's true. I truly
wish he would stop putting my tag, name, and picture in his
videos. Y piece of [__] Are you going to stream on
YouTube or just run a clips channel? Uh, I don't know. I don't
know. The thing about streaming on YouTube is like, oh, go ahead.
He doesn't want to talk about it because it's not going to come
true. It's a New Year's resolution, right there, JS. Yes, exactly.
But also like the money you get from streaming on YouTube is
good in that it like you can monetize your audience more on YouTube.
Like more people will pay for stuff. They'll pay for super chats
and way more people will pay for super chats on YouTube, right?
You get way more donations off of YouTube. When I ran super chats
and Streamlabs at the same time, 90% of the money came from super
chats, 10% through Streamlabs. And then I thought when I switch
over like the Streamlabs would increase to like the full amount.
No, the Streamlabs went to like 20% of what it was before, right?
So what like it was like basically instead of being 10% of the
revenue it was like 20% of what because it's more convenient
because people have their
Yeah. Exactly.
And it's like on the it's literally you do it through the same
thing you're chatting through like the thing you're interacting
through. You just hit a button there and you just donate. It's
so convenient. Everybody super chats. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. I'm
here because of that channel. Base. What's up Stanley 67? Somebody
give Stanley 67 a sub right now. Do it. Somebody gift him a sub.
This Stanley 67 guy, he's he's just back here. Give him a sub.
Well, what are you saying? I should perms. I should just make
it so I can move in the channel and type in the chat. Why don't
you want Why don't you want to give her perms, JS? Cuz I'm so
annoyed that you my Oh, okay. You said multiple times directly
after that you would give back to me and now I'm not even asking
for that. I'm just asking for some like poverty. I also made
it very explicit that those were timed
Y, thank you for the gifted sub to Stanley 67 and Stinkfist 570.
Thank you for the five gifted
stinkfish. He got a free sub in my chat not too long ago.
Today the stinkfish five seven7 guy I think. Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
thank fist. Yeah, he he got a he got a sub in my chat cuz I just
finished streaming uh 30 minutes ago. This guy is so lucky. He's
getting free subs everywhere. What the hell? Two people gifted
to Stanley 67. But yes, Stinkfist is getting Stinkfist is all
over the place. Okay, all of my people are all over the place,
but thank you. No, Spectre as well for the gifted sub to the
reason I know his name. The reason I know his name is because
I when I said, "Oh, Joe just gifted a sub to Stinkfist
577." And I was like, "Oh, your name is terrible. Change your
name." And that's one reason why I remember that name. So when
you said it, I was like, "Yo, he just got a gift to sub in my
chat, too, earlier today." Damn. Oh, Zena's got the DG cat in
it. I guess some people have the Zena thing. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Yeah, I know those are timed offers, Kelly. I would have given
you moderator back if you joined back then. But instead for me
Discord and try to split my community. I'm not even asking for
that. I don't want powers because then I have to do things. I
just want to be able to type and like join the chat. Well, you
can type all Wait, I had to turn that back on, right? I think
I turned it back on like before I Yeah, but you'll turn it off
again.
I only turn it off when we're doing like the intro. That's it.
Make me some poverty poor. It's a new new compromise. Turn it
off while we're doing the opening. No. Dad, speaking of the opening,
Kelly, if you want to speak, okay, if you want to speak, you
can do what everybody else does and go to
The $5 tier will buy you permission to speak when that
How long did I give you free content for? Why the I pay you.
You tried to take that free content away. No, I didn't. That
would be impossible. You did.
Overt dummy. Thank you for the two. How? by trying to leak my
DMs out of Destiny to him. Trying to get you banned by trying
to obviously a lot of my viewership was stemming from Destiny's
community. If I had a completely antagonistic relationship with
Destiny, it would be hard for me to stream. Then you'd just be
queen type two. It wouldn't have made your stream disappear.
Uh, it would have absolutely my revenue massively. Why are you
pretending? You don't know. You could be even bigger than you
are now. You know how I know? You know how I know, Kelly? cuz
one of my donators, okay, literally doesn't type in my chat and
he just likes being the number one donator in every Destiny Orbiter
stream. So, he goes around and he donates until he's number one
on the leaderboard. And that guy, if I if Destiny hated me or
I hated Destiny, I don't know if that guy would be here. As of
as of now, 556 gifted subs from this guy. Okay, you are a streamer.
Wow.
$2,500.
You an eagle. You, Kelly, you tried to take that away. I know
you were an eagirl. Sorry, I was unaware of whatever pay situation
you had going on here. Yes. I Do you think that this isn't a
money-making enterprise? This is a money-making enterprise. And
why are you saying you're unaware, Kelly? One of the things you
said explicitly multiple times. I think it's weird that this
guy makes money off of you and doesn't like you and hates you.
That's what you said. You said that explicitly. No. No. I said
I think it's weird that they you're
No. Oh, why would you say I was just telling you what I actually
said? I actually said you're saying the same thing. I said no,
that's not the same thing. They are the same thing. You can choose
to still give money to you when they know. Then they know that's
whatever. That doesn't that's not the same as destroying your
stream. Okay, that's some uh I didn't say destroying my stream.
I said my monetization, which you tried to do explicitly. Um,
no. Okay, that doesn't No, that's not my motivation. Some fluff
still on my microphone.
JS, I am a hater of your uh intro. I miss JST.
Wait, was it now? T. It's the JSTL case is for me. It is. That
is a good intro, but I like the new one more. And And we'll always
move forward. Okay. Can't just sit in the past forever. I want
to I wanted Wolf Gang to make me a new like intro animation,
too. But Wolf Gang is like Wolf Gang went away. I was like, I
want to tell Wolf Gang to make like an an opening intro, like
a new opening intro for the stream, but he's just like dead.
So, what do you mean dead? He's uh Well, he's he's hanging out
with his girlfriend. He's been hanging out in another country
for a long time. Oh, are we jealous? About to go home. No, I
want work done, but he's not working right now. He's like away
from all of this. So, yeah, he's working, but he's working, you
know. Yeah, exactly. He's working something. Just not his He's
my art slave. Go back. Get back to the tablet. Back to the tablet.
Okay. The eagle bouncing up and down on the yoga ball. Yeah,
exactly. Damn. Some freaky going on behind here. I wasn't aware
of it. Pays the bills. Why are you Why are you talking, Kelly?
Why? This is insane. Kelly is literally like explaining. This
is like a coal miner being like, "Look at this weird loser mining
coal. Oh my god. Oh my god." Can you imagine? Personal experience.
Yeah. Don't you feel good though? Like like seriously, instead
of you being here by yourself, you have us here with you. I'm
happy you're here, Tree. And if you want Kelly here, then you
know, I'm willing to be okay with that. But cheer up, loser.
Uh, let's see. Just added, get back to the work to work tablet
slave. And she posted a whip. That's [__] up. Jesus.
No, he's working at WC on his He's not white. He's like Brazilian
or something. You can just use actually for him. He's not black.
Uh, I said he's Brazilian. Okay, but there Well, if you use the
exact same nationality. No, Brazilian is a nationality, not a
race. No, it's not. Brazilian's basically an ethnicity. The No,
it's not. Okay, I must be confused. I thought Brazilian meant
the women have huge asses, but you know what? Maybe it doesn't.
I feel like we all know this, but you know what? Trees disagreeing.
As ethnicities, then I want to be a separate race from the French.
Okay, we get to do this. Oh, French. Hey, speaking of that, are
you happy to soon be an American? AS
I but I I am 100% like, yeah, I'm down with a trade war. Make
everybody's life one cuz I get paid by in American dollars from
an American company. But uh two, yeah, just do a trade war. Just
do a trade war. Okay, trade war. W trade war. Let's go. But it
doesn't seem like the soontobe prime minister of Canada is going
to uh is going to cuck to to Trump. Nobody's going to Trump.
No. All they had to do, by the way, you could absolutely get
Canada to join the US. If we had like conservative government
and if if the US was like trying to woo Canada, that could absolutely
work. People People like the States. People like this like joint
North American culture we have. Everybody likes it. We could
just be like, "Yeah, we could be one country." But when you go
the route of like, "Yeah, you we're going to take you over."
Everybody here is like, "Yeah, no, actually kill yourselves.
you just so just so you you know where I totally understand why
the Ukrainians burned down all their bridges uh tree I understand
I understand completely now I don't want Canada to be part of
us because you guys are too like lip tarty and stuff like that
you too woke I don't want I don't want you guys part of us okay
I mean it with love though you know what I'm saying cuz listen
you don't you don't want to go to Canada and get a bunch of free
cheap meds or No, I'm not on any medication, but I like their
maple syrup. I don't eat like meat. I am a pescatarian, so
their their Canadian bacon doesn't interest me. Bacon is ham.
It's just ham. It's just sliced ham. It's just meat, which is
hype one carcinogenic. True. Actually, that is actually true.
There's a studies on that. JS, what does your country offer that's
appealing? And besides the second or third largest oil reserves
in the world probably I'd guess probably the largest unexloited
mining resources on the planet too I would imagine. Okay. Uh
what's being mined what's be everything like what the Canadian
shield is like literally the largest unexplored unexloited area
in the entire world. There's just going to be a of stuff up there.
Almost certainly uranium. If you wanted to start like a nuclear
power revolution it would go through Canada 100%. Well how that
doesn't happen. That sounds good. So if I was to come to Canada
and I said, "I want to bring back something to America, all that
you two have to offer me is maple syrup, oil, and uranium radiation."
Resources. Yeah. Resources. Yeah. It's like obviously a like
a frontier country. There's not that many people here. It's uh
cancer or cancer. Those are your choices. Oh, sure. Fresh water,
too. Actually, the largest freshwater reserves in the world,
too. Okay, now we're talking. Where is that? Do you guys have
any springs? Hot springs? Uh there are hot springs. Yeah, all
over the Rockies for sure. But uh beyond hot springs? No. Like
freshwater reserves? Like just massive reserves of fresh water.
Tons of lakes. Tons and tons of lakes. And uh also we control
basically all the water to California if uh if it got really
bad. But I think this would be this would be like a declaration
of war thing. So we can't do it. But technically we could like
dam up like some of the water flowing into California from British
Columbia and Californians would be very upset. But I feel like
that's that would literally be like a declaration. People would
be like, "Yeah, no you we're actually taking over." So we won't
we won't probably ever do that. But technically that could be
a possibility minus some very nice people I know in California.
I don't give a [__] about California. Really? So
Callie's your fault? No, no, no. The water is there already.
I'm saying we could divert the water, but I don't think that
uh I think that would be like a literal declaration of war thing.
I'm pretty sure you're atheist, aren't you? How the does an entire
like state not have water? I just How are they? Cuz there's a
million people there and it was probably a desert at some point
like a lot of the areas they farm in. How did they not see it
coming? They did see it coming. People have been complaining
about all the things that are happening now. Uh no, they did
what was required. Listen, to actually intervene, you'd need
people to want interventions. But when I go to somebody who lives
in the Hollywood Hills and I'm like, "Hey, we need to build we
need to erect structures here that uh that are going to make
this landscape look worse, but they're going to help us prevent
forest fires." They're like, "No, no, no. Kill yourself." I literally
that's what my property value is from. It's from the view of
these hills. Why the would I let you put a bunch of structures
here that make it look gay? They said that the reason why a lot
of stuff is happening in California is because it's all of the
bad ju guu from the Mexicans for American taking it. I there
are other countries, okay, that know the process of dealing with
like forest fires. Like you can just take the information from
them then. It doesn't require like destroying
things necessarily, but like if you have a bunch of like vegetation
that is like going to set fire, like you don't just keep it around
until it gets set on fire. You don't need the All that vegetation
is what makes it look cool. And everybody who lives there is
like, "No, no, don't get
that doesn't set on fire." Is there a lot of vegetation that
doesn't light on fire? Who does it? Yes. Some of it is literally
worse than others. Yes. Some of the stuff they have specifically
is pretty. Just to be clear for people, I realize the water reserves
were all full. I'm talking more about the broad drought that
led to everything like realistically you water you could just
like shoot water at all those trees. You could keep that from
being drought conditions at all from being like tinder. But that's
that's like a different argument. Apparently, we need a lot of
the what trees don't catch fire, Kelly, in a wild in a wildfire.
You link me the trees catch fire. I don't know about trees specifically.
I know there's like a bunch of like plants and stuff like fire
resistant. I don't know about trees, but I know that some trees
are trees. Some trees are a lot worse. Yeah, but you know the
trees on the mountain side is like literally what makes it look
good, right? Well, replace them with other trees. I don't know.
Find a tree expert and fix it. They're going to have to fix it
now, aren't they? Cuz it's just a pile of ash. No, you don't
have to fix it. Literally, you just like just leave the ash.
Okay. Great. You know, but you understand that trees grow really
fast from forest fires, right? Like so just trees that were there.
No, you probably do something, but you just seed out. Invasive
Tasmanian blue gem eucalyptus is super flammable. Is that what
was in all of those hills though? Was it Was it the invasive
Tasmanian blue gem [__] eucalyptus? Is that was in
all those hills? I don't think cactuses set on fire, do they?
Yeah, but I'm That's what I'm telling you. Nobody wants cactuses
out there because the whole point of like their all of their
property values is that there's these massive mountains that
are right next to LA that everybody wants to go hike in, right?
Are you saying cactuses don't look cool? I mean, that's just
objectively false. I don't know. Okay. Cactuses are cool. All
right. You You have plants, don't you, JS? I realize the eucalyptus
is Yeah, I do have plants. I realize the eucalyptus is a problem.
I just don't know that that's the LA like the Hollywood Hills
or the Palisades. I don't know that the eucalyptus is the problem
specifically there and that you can go and replant some you don't
have the eucalyptus there anymore. If it is, then yeah, you should
probably make sure new eucalyptuses aren't growing there. That
would be good. That would be very good. They didn't sweep the
forest like Trump suggested. Probably true. I don't know if they
groomed some [__] You should be moving through those
and like picking up dead wood and stuff. Yeah, Trump was right
about something. Maybe he says a lot of things, so some of them
are bound to be correct. You know, do you see all the I I know
you're on you're not on the right, but holy [__]
that goddamn Benny Johnson is catching hell right now from the
right for what? So glorious. I never like for platforming uh
Andrew Tate and trying to goddamn whitewash him as somebody who's
being censored and and basically uh painted as a bad person.
And it's like you don't even Oh, I hate it's like you can tell
that these are being paid off. Benny Johnson is the worst. We
watched a Benny Johnson video the other day. That guy is a Oh,
I hate God. Hate his ass. I can't stand him. We hadn't drained
too long. No idea who that is. Dude, we still have water. No,
no, no, no, no. American person. Nobody ran out of water. Antonio
the Great. Nobody ran out of water. It wasn't a water reserve
issue. That's not been the thing anywhere here. It's not a water
reserve issue. He pretends to be straight. Oh my god. He pretends.
And by the way, if your argument is you could have used Tar Lake
to drain and like deal with uh drought, then what do you think
draining the lake is? Do you think they drained that lake into
the ocean? I'm almost positive they would have diverted that
lake to like feed other things there to like prevent drought
conditions in most of those places, right? Like, do you think
they just diverted fresh water into the ocean? Or do you think
probably they diverted into like farmland and turning stuff green
and not leaving like broken drought like deadened plants all
over the place? To Larry, not to Lara. Well, I said to Lara,
but to Larry. Okay. To Larry Lake. Maybe I'll just stop making
your houses out of wood. Americans
Jesus. My brows my browser crashed. You guys can't hear me? We
can still hear you. I can hear you. Okay. It crashed and I had
to rejoin. So many people have like reasons that they thought
this wouldn't have happened. It's like dude I I'm almost positive
that like everybody's the people the government organizations
in California have had these exact arguments and like there's
trade-offs. There's a list of trade-offs and these are the the
decisions they made that are like hey there's some trade-offs
here. We made the best decision we could the resources we have
cuz that's what humans do broadly. Why she talks Tree wanted
that. Tree asked for this the exact uh the exact thing she's
got here. No, I didn't. They did this to me cuz I'm black. They're
trying to say I'm an angry black woman. Now she's going to say
this. Yeah, now she's going to say this. This up this I did not
want this. I was like, how could you guys do this? I'm like I'm
basically How could we do this? I feel like this is a modern
day lynching. Okay. I'm basically Who is the other person? Somebody
said this the other day. Oh, Lionus Tech Tips. Yeah, I'm like
Linus Tech Tips. I'm basically like a modern day. I'm being framed
right now.
Have you ever considered not speaking on subjects you're clueless
on most everything? Sorry, but like wood burns the fastest. It's
not that other materials might not eventually burn as well, but
when their speed is burning fast, then more houses burn and then
more areas burn. You stupid [__] If all the houses
were concrete, not nearly as many would have gone down, would
they? Jesus. Didn't you learn anything from like the three wolves
or what? No. Three little pigs. Three pigs. Wolf comes alongs
and blows down your stupid house, dumbass. Puff and puff and
puff. The world if Kelly Jean ran things, guys. The world if
Kelly Jean ran things. Okay. Yeah. You'd still have a house.
Wow. Wow. Just wow. Oh my god. Wow. True. No, that's too much.
I was just asking for more fires, isn't that? Oh, is glass very
far. Stupid. No, it directs. It makes fires. Oh, do you think
when they build green houses they actually light fires like burning
an ant with a magnifying glass? they can do and they have done.
So they've had to like change buildings because they were built
so poorly. They were setting the cars on next on fire. So yes,
glass gets hot green houses or like the randomly concave buildings
that somebody made cuz they thought they were a cool architect.
You're naming like one in New York, but that was just one that
was extreme which was funny. Sure. I was making like death lasers.
But yes, no glass is whatever. That's it. is still like uh not
the best thing if you want to avoid fires. Whatever. Archimedes
reincarnated. Let's go.
Okay.
California have plenty of earthquakes. Yeah, you can still build
houses to code. Keeping in mind with earthquakes without it all
being wood. Wow. How, Kelly? Tell me. Are you okay? You know
I'm not a civil engineer. You want me to sit here and like discuss
how you It can be done. Very interesting. Nice. Look at Japan.
And are all of their houses made of wood? No. They have highrises
everywhere. In Tokyo, they do. In everywhere else in Japan that's
not Tokyo, what do you think? They Wait, Kelly is unaware of
World War II. Kelly's literally unaware of World War II. And
that's amazing. That's That's amazing. Everywhere else. Everywhere
else in Tokyo
like change. Old wood houses. Yes. Because that's what you think.
They mostly most of the houses in Tokyo are still made of wood.
I'm sure they are. I don't know. No. Well, I've been there and
know they're not. There are a lot of traditional houses that
are made of wood, but it's not the majority. And like Japan has
a long-standing tradition of building uh like cheaper houses
because they have hurricanes and they have earthquakes and they
they've got like every natural disaster. So, they don't build
like super like solid structures outside of like Tokyo basically
outside of like their major metropolitan
scenarios. They can and they have houses that can be just Tokyo.
There's plenty in Osaka and Kyoto as well. I said they're major
metropolitan areas. Yeah, where they need high density housing.
Yes, of course. Why the would they have it in the nowhere? They've
still got the house. You can't build. By the way, just so you
know, that's because you can't make extremely high density housing
out of wood or nobody does. So, people are leaving those areas.
There's no need to like make anything new in those areas because
those houses are all worth like £1. Like, they're selling them
off for nothing in Japan. Not quite. That's true. Yes, they're
selling those houses off for nothing in a lot of areas. Wow,
I should buy some real estate in Japan. You have to be Japanese,
I think. But I mean, it might change. Ellie's been to Japan at
least two times, guys. She knows Japan very well. Okay. Three
times for several weeks each. We said at least three times.
I was correct. Wow. It's more than you, isn't it? Yeah, it is.
You have you you understand Japan, Kelly, and I couldn't possibly.
I couldn't possibly. But you understand Japan from singing karaoke
there. Excellencio. Kelly's been to a car from having traveled.
She understands civil engineering for sure since I've traveled
throughout a huge amount of it and not all of the houses are
shanty sheds. Yeah, I would say that Japan's capable of building
high-rise buildings that are capable of By area. Do you think
more of Japan's housing is built out of concrete and steel? I
knew it. I'm I'm just asking you a question. By area, do you
think more of Japan's housing is built from steel and concrete
or wood and paper? It's irrelevant
because it doesn't matter. not irrelevant. Not irrelevant at
all. Doing it. It is irrelevant. The point is they've been capable
of doing it. And I in Tokyo a lot of it is more majority not
houses. You understand that the reason they did it was it was
driven by economic concerns and in LA in their downtown area.
Do you think they have little single family houses built out
of wood or do you think they have houses built out of steel and
concrete, massive high-rise buildings? I am aware that there
are more of those and there's going to be a lot more now, but
there aren't nearly as many. No, there aren't because none of
those none of those actual fires happened in the like internal
downtown area of LA. So, yeah, there's only 150,000 people displaced.
9.7 million people right near the hills where everything's going
to set on fire. They aren't houses. They're like state-of-the-art
mansions. Some of them are ones. I'm talking about all of the
other areas that burn. Yeah, but those places burn down. on.
Yes, I am aware. Okay. But all it does it slows it slows down
the rate at which those houses burn so that the emergency services
can get in and stop you. You can't stop all fires. Obviously,
what you can do is reduce the amount of fires. And if everything's
made out of wood, you're just, aren't you? Yeah. I think like
if we go look at Joe Rogan apparently like 30 years ago he got
told by somebody like yeah if a fire hits the right way the wind's
going the right direction we're just it's been a known issue
that like if they get the right forest fire there they're
just haven't dealt with it cuz they're like well whatever we're
rolling the dice you can talk you yeah why just agree that what
are you doing is this a nervous twitch what a tick oh no I just
do this all the time I do this while I'm commenting by myself
too oh it might be like a twitch like a yeah like a twitch or
something. But I just I just do it. It's what I do with my hand
while I'm uh watching something. While I'm talking, it's like
it's a natural thing while I'm talking. I just do this. I'm not
even looking at the screen that's doing it either. That's the
funny thing. I just do like roughly this pattern. Yeah. It's
like every time you start talking or yelling, the little sensors
start going around and around. I've been watching it for the
last couple of minutes. I'm like, "Yeah, I do that. I do that.
People can tell you I do that all the time. I literally do it
all the time. It's goofy." Do I have autism or or Yeah, I do.
Probably some some kind of autism or Tourette's or something.
I'm sure. It's probably why I say the nword so much. Yeah. Win.
Nice try. What? What do you mean nice try? That's literally what
I'm known for. It's literally what I'm known for. Why are we
pretending that's what I'm known for? Thank you. Jesus. Now,
Kelly sing. Oh, Cherry's not here. Cherry should be here to sing
it. Should be here to sing it. I'm sure she's thinking it if
that makes you thinking it in my direction. Kelly, you're not
allowed to talk about Cherry. Shut up. Keep that name out of
your mouth. Okay, keep that name out of your mouth. Okay, thank
you. Imagine if she'd done that to start with. I miss I miss
Cherry, too.
Well, apparently you're all hurting your feelings by me being
here. So, we're not I won't I'm here. I will just be your pay.
Rean Rubin donated $3. Harry Truman, Doris Day, Red
Winell, Joe Deio, Joe McCarthy, Richard Nixon, Stud Baker, television,
North Korea, South Korea, Marilyn Monroe. Uh, thank you for the
$3. Ruben, Ruben, I do not understand, but thank you very much.
Appreciate it. Tree, what were you saying? I want to talk again.
So, listen. I think on a special occasions you should play that
intro song that I like so much. Once in a while. Sure. Okay.
I got little victories. Oh, I should send you like a retro jersey
thing. Football or hockey. Okay. Just throw the retro jersey
on once in a while. Well, what's a retro jersey? It's where you
wear like the old jersey you wore from the 70s cuz you're like,
"Oh, look. Look how cool this was once." and the whole team wears
the old jersey and they play a game and then they go back to
their regular jerseys. Their regular modern jerseys. Oh, okay.
Is that a Canadian thing? Uh, nope. That's a I I said both. It
happens in the NFL sometimes. Happens in hockey. Happens in like
every sport, I think. I'm sure in basketball they do it sometimes,
too. Just don't watch Just don't watch basketball very much.
Why? Cuz you're Canadian. No, cuz I'm white. Sports. Gross. Are
you? No, I'm not. You got race checked by Kelly. No, I just thought
it was funny when Jessica was talking about what was it like
was it Indian people coming to Canada or was it somebody else
and then it was the conversation of like your grandparents are
going to be sad because they won't necessarily get to have babies
that look like them or something and I'm just thinking you are
a how much percentage native Canadian like not enough to visibly
Yeah, my native grandparents are probably really upset and you
were totally fine that you're just white now. Well, what do you
I don't have a choice. What do you mean I'm totally fine? That's
like saying you're totally fine with being it's like you have
to deal with it. Are your grandparents you can't change your
grandparents crying until
breakfast every day? Oh my god, my grandson is white and not
like whatever the I don't know. I'm just thinking if your grandparents
can deal with you being you, won't all the other grandparents
just deal with it too? I don't know. I never be great grandparents
assuming
like that would even happen anyway. I think white people great
grandparents died before I was like conscious of the world. So
I don't know how they're really upset. But white people killed
them. No, they were old. That's not very dramatic. How my my
my great grandma was like 92 when I was born or something. What
the [__] How I would assume people would have kids
even into their 40s for a while. Get like two sets of parents
that are like 40 when their kids are born. Then yeah, that that
happens. That's that's even that's only 80. So they're like nearing
the 50. You're 40. You have your kids. Your kids are roughly
40. They have their kids. You're 80 when they have their kids.
Those kids still have to grow up, right? You said they died when
you were like just born. So then my then my dad was like 20 or
something or 25. I don't know. My dad was some great grand
great grandparents. Yes. Not my grandparents. My grandparents
were not 90 when I was born. That would be insane. Yeah, that's
what I thought. I was like, so uh no crying great grandparents.
No. What did you get? Maybe I mean it's not such a big deal then.
I don't know. I'm sure I'm sure they did cry cuz my Did you guys
kind of just like got wiped out? My dad was like blonde hair,
blue eyes. My dad looks arroant as Okay, I don't have those traits.
But yeah, that's the person. No, my Yeah, basically my my Oh,
I'm probably doxing myself super hard. My grandmother was like
actually significantly like Native American or indigenous in
in Canada is what she'd say. And then my great my grandfather
was like Norwegian or something. and all of their kids had blonde
hair and blue eyes. But then the funny thing is like when my
parents got married, I remember sorry my parents tell the story
of like when my parents got married and like the priest came
over to my parents were like, "Do you want us to kick these like
native guys out of here? Like they're kind of this is kind of
weird." No. Jesus. My dad was like, "No, that's my grandma or
that's my grandpa or that's my like my dad or something." just
like can you not can you can you can you off like so so uh white
people did to you exactly what you're concerned about other people
doing to white people it didn't happen to me it's not something
you perceive I mean it did it happened to your parent goes in
the opposite direction it's saying I think there could be a thing
where parents or grandparents are like oh it's kind of weird
like I would want them to like look like me carry on like a line
or something I don't think that's weird I don't think it's racist
I think that's fine to feel that way a lot of people feel that
way but the kids themselves aren't going to feel that way or
if they You're a bad parent. Yes. Wait, who do you think I'm
arguing is like annoyed? Kelly, are you so You're so dumb. Listen,
you do you listen to the words? God, this is why, by the way,
this is why you get blocked because we have discussions and you're
incapable of like processing information and changing your opinion.
You think white people are at risk as like I don't know, as much
of a minority as Canadian. What did you say? Yes. I think any
minority population is at risk of being like having prejudice
work against them 100%. But it's a much larger population. So
yes, it could still be a minority. But if the population is so
large, they're not going to disappear anytime soon, are they?
No, I'm not worried about white people disappearing. I'm not
worried about any of that. That's not a significant concern of
mine. I also don't super care. It doesn't bother me. I just am
open-minded enough that I can go, "Oh, other people feel that
way. I understand that. I respect that. I don't think that makes
them evil. If my grandparents something I care about, I literally
don't care. This baby is not white enough." I would be like,
"The
weird." Okay, I just want you to admit that then basically every
non-white race is significantly more racist than white people
and that matters significantly more to them than anybody else.
Um, we are more racist, sorry, or they're more racist. They are
far more racist. Every Asian family is still like that. Every
black family is still like that. There are tons of families that
are way more racist than white people from other races. That's
obviously true. White people are objectively the master race
at being anti-racist.
Okay, that's just objectively true. If you reject that, you are
that's just objectively true. Other countries are a lot more
homogeneous just because like you know hasn't changed. Yeah,
obviously that more homogeneous. You're not Why hasn't changed
in those other countries? Not as many people immigrated there
or white people didn't steal it and kill a bunch of people. Depends.
This is the progressive brain rot. Just admit that white people
are the master race of being anti-racist. Kelly, just admit it.
Nobody's as good at being not racist as white people. Nobody's
even close. I mean, it's not close.
Can I get Being anti-racist is basically like the NBA for white
people. Okay. Like, yeah, there are some black people who aren't
really racist, but but it is like a white person league. Okay.
So, I mean, you want to engage with this topic probably or you
just want to meme cuz I won't bother if you just want to meme.
I'm I'm meing and dominating this topic at the same time, which
is the best case scenario. That's why I'm asking before I give
me an example of another country that is not majority white that
is anti-racist in a way a white majority country is. How am I
supposed to [__] do you want me to give another country?
I don't know how a single country that's not racist against minorities
or or has anywhere near the integration and uh like acceptance
of minorities that any like white majority country has. So, I
need to think of a non-white country that is Yeah, I realize
you don't spend a lot of time thinking about or considering non-white
countries, Kelly, but do it for a second. That is okay. That
is less racist than where Britain or America or Yes. Britain
or America or Canada? Yep. Okay. What are those? What are the
options? I don't know. I feel like I whatever I respond with
is going to be I don't know what Brazil's like. Also, isn't um
Brazilians white? I don't know. The black folks down in Brazil.
Uh what is the majority ethnicity? I don't Oh, yeah. What do
you think the crime is? I'm going to have to Google it. I don't
know. Also, why do they keep talking about Brazil? Ethnicity
in Brazil. Race ethnicity in Brazil. Math of the world's most
ethnic least ethnically diverse countries. Oh, this is gay. This
is made by somebody who hates America. This is somebody who's
like, "Oh, Africa is the most ethnically diverse country because
um actually there's like a thousand ethnic groups and we like
delineate like between these tiny tiny variations." That's so
gross. Why would you do that? Why would you pretend that all
of the white people who who mixed in the US aren't like the same
kind of ethnic diversity? That's crazy. Sorry, I'm looking at
something else, but it's also a good example because Brazil is
apparently white. Half of them are mixed race and oh well a bit
less than half I suppose. It's like four million whites, four
million mixed race, four million black or two million blacks.
Like how the am I supposed to determine like you said pick a
homogeneous country. That's is this is not a homogeneous country.
Oh, cool. Sure. Like I need somewhere that is like 90% at least
that. I'm just saying I need I need another country that is not
run by white people that has like racial segregation laws. Like
you can't you can't be racially segregated. Just give me one
of those that like discrimination on the basis of race is not
allowed. Segregated. Oh, so you want like racism law both socially
both socially and and legally discouraged. There isn't any though
which parts of Asia.
True. Counting Jews for white. Counting Jews is white for this
case. Okay. Nope. Japan has always been fine when I went there,
but they also have a history of
just said Japan. This just said Japan. Are you kidding me, Kelly?
a lot of Chinese people and they're similar ethnicity or the
same really though I don't you literally just picked you literally
just picked the most racist country that's ever existed Kelly
I just want you to know that okay
racist objectively Japan is more racist than than like Hitler's
Germany was Japan is like the most racist Jesus okay
Japan obviously it was bad but I'm not talking about Japan in
the 19 enough. I'm just tell I'm not talking about Japan in World
War II. Hitler didn't know Japan. Yeah, sure. Okay. I'm I'm saying
considered them honorary.
Yes, he did. Do you think Do you think uh So, yes, Hitler did
consider them honorary Aryans. Do you think Do you think [__]
Japanese people considered Germans honorary Japanese? Why are
we talking about 90 years ago? Nope. Nope. I'm just telling you.
We're talking about now. Yes. They they like have a lot of different
laws now. They Okay. Do they have a lot of immigration? Do they
integrate a lot of non-Japanese people into their culture? I
know it's more now in certain sectors. Yes, it is more now because
that's because for for like decades it was zero. It's also falling
and a variety of other reasons. By the way, why we import people
too in these countries we're like look at look at how long Japan
waited and now they're kind of themselves. We don't want to be
that. Yeah. I don't also think Japan is the best example. or
it's just the one I've been to. I think Taiwan is better. One
of my friends talks about X, Y, and as like as like a Hot Only
Fans model, I went to Japan and people were nice to me. That
means they're not racist. That's actually that's Kelly's worldview.
I I just realized
misogyny is helping you has enlightened me to understand how
you have this opinion. I got it. I got it. I I understood. I
understand. You're a [__] I know the issues with
Japan as well, but there are issues everywhere. We're talking
about laws and like things that are held up systemically.
Yes. Not just like Can I say something? I am so I am I am so
happy right now. Are you happy? Holy.
You know in America psycho he has a headphone. Yeah, I know.
I know. I know. This is me right now.
Yeah. Okay. Continue. Also, Korea. I'm not sure. I think Korea
is good. I mean, they had a whole issue with their own people
splitting in half, but I don't not really heard as much about
foreigner hate from Korea, but it's also not as touristy, so
I don't I've had friends I've had a bunch of friends that have
stayed there for months. I don't lived in Japan for almost a
decade socially. Very difficult to be a foreigner unless you
got thicker skin. Bro, I would love to go to Japan just to be
like the victim of racism for a while. I'd love to I feel like
I'd go there and I'd be like, you know what? It's based that
you guys hate foreigners. I You guys are based. Foreigners do
suck. The girls like give you a massage by stepping on your back.
Would you like that too? They're pretty tiny, too. Do they do
that in Japan? Is that a Japanese thing? I would have thought
that was like a Southeast Asian thing. Not like Japan specifically.
More like an Indonesia or Thailand or something like that. No.
I I seen the women with the komodo kimodos. Am I pronouncing
that correctly? Kimos. Kimono. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've seen
them with their socks and they have this little shoe on that
goes in between their toe. They do it with their socks on. Doesn't
that defeat the purpose for the people who are into that? No,
no, no. I'm telling you the process, right? And so they take
the shoe off with that strain that that splits their toe between
the the middle toe and then they they take off these thick socks
and then they and then they like have the oil on the purse the
guy's back and he's like on this um bamboo mat and then they
just step on them and they have their little It looks so cute
when they're doing it. Okay. Or they're stepping on. I can sit
here and be critical of Asian countries, but we were looking
for I'm talking about laws and like things that are held up systemically,
etc. Like I don't know otherwise, yeah, there's going to be racism
everywhere. There's like race there's like xenophobia, extreme
xenophobia just between countries in Europe. I don't The amount
of hate the Greeks have for the Turks and vice versa is just
like yikes at certain points. But like every country's people
hates a bunch of other people. I don't and everyone hates Britain.
I just think I just think JS is trying to discredit you, Kelly.
Don't let him get away with that. You're doing really good standing.
Yeah, I'm never worried about that. That would require me caring.
Exactly. Yeah, for real. Oh, no. Don't get me wrong. The Greeks
have a good reason. Okay. There's a lot of genocides there. Just
like the Chinese have a good reason to be a bit wary of the Japanese.
Okay. Sorry. Let me clarify again. That's just my whole entire
point that like western white people, okay, western I'm saying
real western west of Europe, okay, American white culture is
just the master race of anti-racism, okay? Like these people
are the least racist people on the planet. They they literally
no other country could give me a country other than Canada that's
going to mass import people from a different culture and actually
have a significant portion people significant portion of people
say you guys are racist if you don't like this. There is nowhere
else. There's nowhere else where you could even end up in this
situation where you could find out that oh some people are still
kind of racist. Okay, maybe Argentina, but I don't know if that
was necessarily like don't cry for me.
Uh I mean I don't know some beautiful people in Argentina and
white Canada's number one. True. But I don't know if did Argentina
make that decision consciously or was that just like we snuck
some Nazis in here. Shut up. Stop talking about it. I think certain
countries have like a Well, can Canada has this it's it's like
a politeness thing. Some countries are more polite. Racism is
less of that doesn't necessarily mean they're less racist.
I don't know. Sure. But Japan Japan's racism is overt in it policies
in a way. Is it still now?
I would actually say if I was when it comes to I don't know about
Japan specifically, but definitely I actually still believe Japan
like LGBT stuff. It's a bit weirder than the racism part. like
they be like it took ages for them to just like have gay couples
and like Kdramas and stuff and J dramas like that was taboo.
Yeah, I'd have to look like into specific laws but I'm like fairly
sure a lot of things have changed. This stuff is also a bit of
a problem places
JS should feel at home then over there. Yeah, I mean yeah it
depends on where you're looking and what you're looking at I
suppose if you like Google what are the problems of this country
a little list I imagine. Yeah. Do you have any black friends
in real life in Canada? One that I would consider like a friend,
but I don't talk to him very often that I went to university
with. Black. He's the only black guy in my graduating class at
university. Well, there's one other No, I'd say he's the only
black guy in my graduating class at university. The only uh That's
not true. That's Wait, that's not true. But like I He's the only
person who hung out in the groups I did. The only guy I like
graduated with who was like around a lot. So I will say Okay,
so people are saying Japanese only. Japanese only. That's not
okay. So if they think that you can't speak Japanese and their
menus are all in katakana and whatever, you're not going to be
able to read them. So there's no point in you going in there.
They won't know what you're saying and you won't know what they're
saying. But it like I've been into several of those places then
with a friend who does speak the language and then they're like
fine with me being in there. It's not that they hate white people,
it's just they don't speak English. Convenient racism. Well,
how are you going to serve someone if you can't speak to them?
True. Absolutely true. Wait, I'm not even listening. I just said
true. What were you saying? Whatever. Okay. I mean, should they
come up with a Supreme's around, but he's not joining the Discord.
What's going on? Probably. But in the places where this happens
tends to be sort of either more rural places or like not in the
center of places. I have to I'm going be here for another 10
minutes. I have to start getting ready for tomorrow. But I haven't
been here all year. So, and I'm so happy right now. That's a
wonderful moment right now. Yes. Don't you enjoy this? Don't
you miss it? I enjoy it a little bit. Yeah. Awesome. What do
you call it? Just multiple people coming on. Yeah. I don't I've
been inviting people on as much. I just I like sticking to the
content that I'm doing when I'm doing it. You know, like if I
if I'm doing content, I would like to stick to that content most.
I was watching what you were looking at, Asmin Gold, and I was
like, "Oh, this is where he pulls off. I used to be at one of
my subs. he going to so like on 2017
or yeah 2017 he pulls out because he's he wants me to get back
in boxing and I told him I'm like dude I'm um actually took a
sabbatical I would expose you as a dominatrix and not knowing
that I bragged about that and then I was like okay now you understand
I keep my client list quiet if you if you say this I'm going
to reveal that you one of my I'm you know it the dag on quiet
list is the off records if you were exposed you know which he's
not exposing me he thought he was exposing me but I was like
pretending that you know nobody knew I was a prod or I was a
retired pro dom and he was like well I want you to get back in
boxing I want you to take me back as a class like dude I don't
do it anymore I'm sorry who are you talking about specifically
I missed this what's his name the alt writer uh that was going
to pull off Timoo's hat go back oh wait was that that was the
guy who pulled off his Yeah. I don't know if I can go back to
that. I don't know. It's not in this video. It was like earlier.
No, you just you just you just showed it. You showed it where
the guy was about to What is his name? Ah, he's on my website,
though. If I I have to let me go to my website. So, I did I No,
I did just have it up. So, it's whoever what this guy is. This
guy, I don't know his name from this. Let me go to my website.
Hold on a second. He looks like an ugly rat face. Rude. Old rat.
Very rude. Is it incredibly rude? In fact, Millennial Matt. Millennial
Matt wants to be. He went for went for tree.
He was my customer. He was he was a he was a loyal sub of mine.
I had a lot of I had a lot of alt writers. I had a lot of sons
of uh grand wizards and and uh and then they just turned on you.
No, no, no, no. They they he he he he enjoyed our sessions and
I took a sbatical and he was mad and was wanting me to still
take on take on uh take him as a client like take him on as a
sub a paid sub and I was like no dude I'm like I'm just I'm out
for a minute. Give me a if I come back in I'll let you know.
And uh cuz I was the only black dominina at the time that offered
boxing, wrestling,
and uh physical domination uh sessions cuz my other friend, she
had passed away. She she was a bodybuilder, so she was offering
that too, but she passed away. So I was the only one left. And
then um and then I took a sabatical. So they were like they prefer
to be physically dominated by black dominance. Like especially
my friend Jasmine, she was like uh 6 foot and I'm 6'3 so it was
like and she was very muscular like she took steroids so and
she wasn't ashamed about it. It was like, you know, she loved
being very, very muscular. And so it was like, you didn't have
that many of us in that industry. And so a lot of these guys
try to top us from the bottom by saying, "Oh, well, if you don't
do what I want, then I'mma do this and that and the other or
I'm going to go here and this that blah blah blah." But I've
never been ashamed of being a former pro dom. And I love it and
I'm back in it part-time. So it's like I love this is something
I've always was upfront because you can't hide like that. You
know what I'm saying? like my pictures are like all over the
place. I put them there. And so he tried to blackmail me. I'll
put it on my website. Like if anybody go to my website, you'll
see where it says. So I I linked the post where he uh revealed
like one of my videos and a lot of my my regular sub subscribers
were like, "Yeah, we know about this. Tree always told us about
this." And then other people like, "What?" And I was like, "Are
y'all really surprised? Like tree of logic is a dominatrix. Are
are you really clutching your pearls?" And I thought about it
like, "No, we ain't clutching our pearls, but we clutching our
pearls over here." And then I was like, "No, you understand that
the that uh cuz when we get a lot of people, we keep their identity
secret. We don't snitch. We don't reveal anything. If we had
to go to court, we don't say anything. But when you reveal it
as a way of blackmailing, then all bets are off." And so that's
when I was like, "Okay, so you're going to say I'm going to tell
everybody what you went into." And I did. And he hasn't been
back on to it. I show I said ple too can play at this game. Unlucky
for that guy. All right. This is why I don't talk to women though.
I will say. Okay. Women can't use your against you if you just
don't talk to them. Okay. He did it to me first though. You know
what I'm saying? It's like I'm I'm the vict
he drew first blood. I There's a lot of people I that are important
people. I would never mention their name. I would never say,
"Oh yeah, you I got proof of you seeing me for this, blah, blah."
I would never say that. But it's like when you try to blackmail
me to get back into the business just to see you and you only
that ain't going to fly with me and the my best customers are
racist white boys. All right. I mean I could see that. Actually,
you know what? I could definitely see that. Unlucky for him.
Should have kept that to himself. Yeah. He should have just left
me out like, "Dude, just just go find somebody else, dude." I
don't understand like and I This is my thing with men like this.
It's like, why don't you find a woman that's black, that's st
tall, that's strong, and then you train her, you pay her to train,
and then you have your own little dominatrix in the box right
there that you can deal with. But then again, I do understand
their complaint cuz when I have mentioned that so much, they'll
say it is not in a woman's nature to be that much of a it's not
in that woman's nature to hurt men and not feel sorry for it.
So, it's like it is, you know, a lot of women are nice and loving
and nurturing because we are the ones that give birth to children
and we're the nurturers and we make good nurses and blah blah
blah. So, it's kind of like to be a cruel
woman uh on consensual things. It's not the norm and it's it's
it's an extreme minority. So therefore, you a lot of these guys
try to get women who don't have it in them to be that type of
a [__] to be a and they don't want to do it cuz they're
acting out of their character. Did that make sense? Yeah. Yeah.
Ding in chat says, "Oh, what? Women are very cruel." Like plenty
of very cruel women out there. And I think that's like very different.
The way women normally hurt you is not is not like the overt
hurting different emotionally. Yeah. Yeah. when you hurt them
emotionally, that's when they're cruel. But if somebody if like
you got to ask like your the average woman like, "Hey, if a guy
paid you $20 to slap them in the face as hard as you can, would
you do it?" And most women were like, "No, no, I wouldn't do
it." So, a lot of women are cruel because they felt emotionally
jaded or wrong. Well, and they won't even say why that is. They're
like, what they actually think is like, "No, that that disgusts
me. That person disgusted me." But they won't say that. All they'd
have to do is be able to say that and then they could do the
dumb thing, I think. Right. They'd have to say like why they
don't want to do it. I feel like some people would be okay with
that. But I think they just
I think No, no, no. Cuz cuz Okay, real quick. Cuz you know how
I got into this, right? Right. Nope. No. Okay, real quick story.
This is Everybody knows this story, right? I used to be when
I left the policing, I became a personal bodyguard of exotic
dancers where people to call strippers. And one of the girls
that I was bodyguarding now, and I bodyguard because women fight
each other behind the locker rooms to steal their tips and all.
It's a bunch of [__] that goes in the in the changing
room versus outside. So, I'm not protecting from other men. I'm
protecting them from other women. Anyway, so one of the girls
that I was I was my client, she came down and she says, "I need
your help. This man keeps coming to the champagne room. He wants
me to kick him in the balls and slap him in the face, but I just
can't do it. I'm I'm so I He just And he says he wants me to
order someone to do it and he'll pay $100. And she said, "I'll
give you half of it if you do it. If you go up." I said, "You
just to slap him?" She's like, "Yeah, that's it. You You can't
slap"? She's like, "No, I don't want to hurt him and I can't
slap him hard enough." I said, "Sh, come on. Let's go." So, we
went up there when we went to the champagne room and there he
was, you know, butt naked on his knees. He looked up at me and
I looked at her. I said, "This is the you want me to slap?" And
I and I and he's and she said, "Yes, I I" So I, you know, looked
down at him. I said, "Do I have permission to slap you?" He's
like, "Yes, please." And I said, "Okay, on the count of three."
One. No. I didn't even get to three. I didn't even get to two.
Soon as I said one, I slapped the [__] out of him.
And like his went and I And then she I was like, "Is anything
else?" And then she's like, "No, that's it." And I said and I
looked at him. I said, "You're welcome." And I walked out. Somebody
Hold on. Hold on. Somebody make the intro right now. Somebody
What? that I've never heard a more a more appropriate intro than
that one right there. Sorry, I don't think you're aware. Like
that's the Destiny Dan podcast called Anything Else and a lot
of people when somebody says anything else, they'll do like the
smash cut to the intro for that show and you could just do that
whole thing and you're like and went and I was like Anything
else? That's Yeah, it's a perfect smash cut open for their show.
Okay, make the meme right now. She didn't even She didn't even
give me half of it. She gave me the entire $100 bill. So
nice. crazy. She was so impressed. So, oh, sorry. So, the reason
why I mentioned that the reason why I mentioned that story is
because that situation right there, a lot of women are constantly
asking I mean a lot of these men that are in the stripper rooms
are constantly asking for certain type of BDSM services. And
a lot of those girls can't do it. Some of those will, but most
of them won't. Why is that so like badly photoshopped in? It's
like uh cuz it's supposed to cover the whole soy jaw thing at
the bottom. But then I have three hands. Uh yeah, this is a part
of the picture. Don't worry about it. It works. It delivers the
message. Don't worry about it. I actually didn't even notice
the other hand till you said something. I finally I finally started
getting racist memes served to me and I really appreciate it.
Okay, hold on a second. Hold on a second. Liberals when they
see a starving child. Dominicans when they see a starving Haitian
child. Oh, sorry. It's both when they see a starving Haitian
child. I feel like this is not going to be good. Get that ugly
disabled freak away from me. I don't want to look at his up face.
His smooshed in garbled baby disabled face. I don't want to look
at it. Dominicans are racist. This is just true. We know this.
We figured this out. All right. Wow. Oh, yeah. I need to message
more people to come on. I feel like there's a bunch of people
in the Discord. Like I I should message Malik to come on sometime.
Malik's like around. I just I've never messaged her to come on.
Also, she streams all the time. I don't know if this Discord
is like her pace necessarily. Very specific person to bring up
just to go has a crush on Malik. I just meant somebody who can
participate in like racist conversations, not feel totally lost
cuz she is literally racist or at least somewhat racist. A good
context. Why are we calling She survived Kicker Keep but came
back a couple times. Why? Where was the racist? Where did what
what did she say that was racist? Are we pretending that Kicker
Keep couldn't get racist a lot of the time? Yes, but that doesn't
mean she was racist. Mal.
Okay, I'm lost. What does she mean? Was just one of the people.
Who else is there? There's other people in the Discord. I thought
she was just on Kicker K. Also, I'm like trying to think of people
like Trey just came in and said I was like maidenless. He was
like she was like, "Why the [__] are no women coming
on here? Are you misogynist?" I was like, "Oh, no. I just don't
really invite people on." So, out of the women who are in the
Discord, that was one of the people you could invite on. I think
just to go on thinking about Malik. That's what I think. Oh,
Lab's here. I forgot Lab was here. Lab's been on a couple times.
Tree. I think you know that though. I'm I'm good. No, thank you.
Yeah, I think you know that. Think you know that? Yeah. Amaranth
is here. I've never inv I was like gonna invite Amaranth on,
but there's never like a I think she wants to prepare before
she comes on. I don't think she just wants to come on spur of
the moment. She doesn't like the She's been preparing for the
last year. No, I mean like she I think she wanted to know like
oh if there's going to be a panel. She thought it was going to
be like a wick situation and I'm like no I don't do getting my
hair done for the last 9 months. Yeah, I get it. You hate Kelly
hates Amaranth like a lot. A lot. Oh, I just think the reason
was bizarre. Kelly hates Amarant because Amarant I think would
go and like had a reply bot on Twitter that would like leech
engagement from Kelly's tweets. Think she just hates that like
plays the game better. No, I don't hate her for that. That one's
just funny. I don't want to say why. I dislike her because it
involves my other friends that she let down shitty way. Kelly
does hate Amrath. She just can't tell us why. Never mind. No,
not hate. Don't like. Don't hate. Wow, dude. I'm serious. If
I was a guy, I would have so many hot women. I have good taste
in women. You understand that's not the purpose of the stream,
right? For like my personal goon sessions. That's like That would
be very weird if that were like my personal motivation.
Yeah, Dad. I never stopped a lot of Why the are you people laughing?
Why did you just start laughing?
I feel I feel like I've never had a sister before to bully my
brother with. This is what this feels like. That's nice. Why?
Why? Why did you two just laugh? Go ahead. Explain why you just
laugh. Don't worry about it. Explain why you just No. Explain
why you just laughed. No, cuz I got to go. No. No.
You're about to end up in Kelly land right now if you don't explain
yourself before you leave. Explain why. Explain why that was.
Explain why that was laughed at.
Why are we persecuting black people? For real? With your racist
ass. Oh, it's kind of weird just because I'm racist. Obviously,
you guys are going to end up in Reand down. You're going to have
to go and play video games, okay? In random Discord channels.
is really he's literally there right now in a Discord channel
hanging out playing video games. Why doesn't he come here? Cuz
he hates you, Kelly. No, he's sat in like those calls with me.
But he won't come here. Hates Kelly. True. He's literally sat
in those multiple of those calls, including like earlier today.
That's not That's not like on stream. What's the difference?
Also, I was on his stream. Shut up. You're on his Well, I think
he would take that. I think he would dig that. That's probably
true.
If he doesn't hate you, he'll join right away. I think we'll
see.
Can Kelly Cany convince him to join or does Rally hate her? We'll
see. We'll see which one is true. Sit me up. He's there in the
Discord right now. There's nothing that would prevent him from
joining. Surely Kelly can convince him to come join the stream.
Under the debate group therapy voice chat. Hi. Really? I think
he said his price for BG through lab and Kelly is $50,000. Well,
I thought it was 500. Wow. Or did adding lav suddenly inflict
both. Drag him in and ask him. I'm not going to I'm not going
to discip
him into this channel. Join if he wants. Also, he could deal
with that cuz his teeth's broken and he needs to get a root canal.
Is that true? Yeah, you said it on stream earlier. He said my
that is why his price is so low. He is desperate for help dentally
and that's why he's going to subject himself to Kelly. True.
Jesus. I didn't mean it that way. That was a great thing to do.
It was the point that Kelly just said extreme goal for she didn't
even realize what she said. It's so funny. She actually didn't
realize what she said. You are twisting everything I say. It'll
be the worst possible way. You are I That's a natural interpretation
of what you just said. That's a very natural interpretation with
his teeth fix. He did. Wick's got good teeth now. Damn. Wow.
Is that true? Damn. What did you do? Get veneers. Uh, he had
like a I don't know what he got put in. His teeth are all fixed
up though. Somebody Oh my god. Zanakali, you have issues. You
have like actual mental issues asking that question. I don't
even want to read it out. Kelly can read it. Okay. Yeah. You
don't even want one. But I will tell you something un Well, Aerodite
mentioned her issues yesterday, right? The acidic tears comment.
So, I spoke to her and asked her what her symptoms are and then
I found something. Well, I already knew of it because I mentioned
it on the stream, which is like Shogun syndrome. Linked it to
her and she's like, "Damn, this is all of my symptoms." And my
doctor said they didn't know what it was. And I'm like, "Yeah,
you don't have something new that you have to wait another 10
years to get a diagnosis for." Wow. Although it was a very tedious
thing to get a diagnosis for, so good luck. Is there a is there
a like conclusive test for it that exists? There are tests for
it. If your anti-ucular antibodies, if they're positive, you're
more likely to get a diagnosis for it. You can get biopsies on
saliva glands. You can get saliva tests to like show how much
saliva you're producing, whether it's like provoked or unprovoked.
You can have someone look at like your tears if you're having
like dry eyes and see how much like tears you're producing. If
Kelly diagnosed Aerodite before Destiny did, Destiny has to stop
watching House Clips on stream. That's just objectively true.
Rude. You should check Kelly's people make fun of me. I'm sure
is even worse. I don't want Let me see here. Okay. Why? What
did I say that was pseudocience? The disease I mentioned is an
autoimmune disease. It exists. It's not pseudocience. Okay. Shut
up. I don't even know. Wait, what? What? Hold on. Is that what
she's mad about? The pseudocience role? I've only got two roles
and it's British and complete. Those are the only two roles I
see. while I No, I was talking to somebody in the chat that called
my comment pseudocience. I I don't know why. One of these days
I'm going to look at the chat, but I have to have my other monitor
open it up. And also, one day I'm just going to come in there
so somebody can give me a gifted sub, but I can't do it right
now. Anyway, I'm about to bounce. JS, as always, it was a lovely
time coming up in here. I've had a great opportunity to sit here
and enjoy you with my girl Kelly. Miss you, Tree. Wonderful January.
Yeah, girl. Should do this more often. Yeah. Thanks for coming
on, Tree. Talk to you later. All right. Thank you. Bye. Bye.
Can't believe I missed her at the very last second. Very last
second. Why do you guys not get on the left? There I
No, we get I mean if she doesn't like me, she doesn't like me,
but I I love her. Okay, based. Wow. Hold on. Give me a second.
I'm just going to disconnect and reconnect my headphones. Useless.
How is he an idiot? I'm getting like breakups in Discord a little
bit. I can't tell if it's phones or what. Reconnected. We're
all good. One of you should talk so I can see if this is actually
What are you What are you guys doing? What's the vibe? I know.
It stopped. Oh, we're just
Kelly was trying to explain why Japan's not racist. That's not
what I said. I think Japan is racist. Japan's been racist. Yes,
there's there's racism. Like I don't know how to quantify it.
I haven't studied the racism of each. See, Lav will agree with
me on this automatically. White western white American people
from North America, okay, are the master race of being anti-racist.
Like they're the most anti-racist. They're the least racist people
on Earth. It's just true. It's literally just broadly true. What?
Western is confusing. What are you What are you confused about?
Western whites are the least racist. American whites. American
whites are the least racist. Yes. Yeah. Probably all of them
as a people. As a people level. Yes. On an aggregate level. Aggregate.
Yeah. Aggregate level. Yeah. But I bring up I bring up those
averages bad. So, you know, I do know. Yeah. Guys, I'm just kidding.
People are starting to think I'm actually racist. Maybe I am.
Maybe I am. I like that I argue against racist stuff most of
the time and everybody thinks I'm racist. And for Lav, because
she's a woman on the internet, people are like, "No, she's not
really racist." Even though she's saying the most racist all
the time. It's a crazy scale I have to fight against. Indians
then I feel about Indians asking for a lab. When have I ever
been racist against Indians? What? I don't know. Why is my Why
is my webcam always get stuck? Why is Lav's audio so trash? Uh,
I don't know. I'm guessing she's not I'm so far away from my
thing. Is it It should be working now. Apparently, it's working
now. Wait, what? The mic is working now. You're closer. I think
so. It should be better now. Oh, also you open up your camera.
Hold on. Defaults audio box. Let's see. Is this Hello. Is that
okay? Hello. That's way better. Yeah, that's way better. Yeah.
Okay. Wow. Left. That's a nice nice place wherever you are. Nice.
This is not a nice place. I'm This is Is it not? No. I mean,
angles. No, it's it's nice. It's just not I would not I would
never decorate like this. Okay. This is not a permanent home.
I move into a my permanent home next week. Funky Boss says, "Chem
up, Kelly." Kelly won't cam up. I did my job this month. Okay,
I'm in like pajamas. That's not relevant. Kelly would have to
go do her makeup for like at least 40 minutes to cam up. This
is just the case. Obviously, that's not even true. You The gift
that gets spammed all the time has barely any makeup on it at
all. Okay. Heavy makeup for New Year's Eve was like a rare mostly
cuz I'm lazy and I can't believe that's not a Kelly specific
meme. That's an all women meme. That's not that's not target
at you directly. Okay, don't worry about it. You can do makeup
in like especially for stream that's good enough for stream in
like 10 minutes. That doesn't mean I'm going to bother to do
it now. True. Lab is brave. Lab is one of the few brave ones
who will cam up without like a significant amount of makeup on
regularly.
Just say Kelly on the makeup every time. Brilliant. And then
people but then people screenshot and then um bully me. So maybe
never do that actually. Kelly never ever do that. That is true.
That is true. If Kelly did that, she would get bullied relentlessly.
That'd be up. People do do that. Yeah, they Yeah, they do. They
just bully me over those stuff instead. Tony wants me to pull
this meme up of like the standard trad conservative right now.
He says
as a tracad
conservative. I'm just saying like a trad conservative right
now. This is like where they are like NFL dark manga last these
dark manga. It's literally just manga but called like a gay larer.
There's a there's a gay larper. Yeah, basically dark mega [__]
ball enjoyer. Literally fat. Yeah, that makes sense. There's
a lot of those in Illinois. It's been like actually the craziest
culture shock moving to the Midwest. It's like I like the ugliest
people you've ever seen live here. Like the ugliest people you've
ever seen in your life. Morbidly obese. Like disfigured levels
of disgenic. It is actually crazy. But I'm also I lived in Salt
Lake City where like Mormons are known for being like very beautiful
and gorgeous and Aryan and in Los Angeles everyone gets surgery
to look beautiful. So I've just been like around very attractive
people my whole life and so being here is like genuinely insane.
I went to go see a hockey game and how people treated you like
publicly like 5 years ago. What do you mean? Nothing. You know
what I mean? No, I actually don't know what you mean. It was
a joke about hitting the wall. Shut up. You know exactly what
I mean. Why are you pretending you don't understand? It was a
meme. Hit the wall when she was 20. I don't understand. No, it's
not funny. I feel like I've gotten steadily hotter, so I don't
even understand that. Wow. Power printing. We don't understand
jokes. Okay, that's fine. I didn't I didn't really understand
where you were going with that. Sorry. It didn't really Uh-huh.
She understood completely. But no, it is it is genuinely strange.
It is genuinely strange to be around um just like normal looking
people when people say it's actually crazy like online
like what people are saying is mid when like most of the world
is just genuinely ugly. Like most of the world is just genuinely
like below mid. This is why I say lab isn't racist. She just
hates ugly people. That's a that's actually genuinely true. That's
actually genuinely true. If you let lab talk about ugly people,
you see the real physioamy is real. Physio is real. Wait, is
that the actual word for it? Physio.
Yeah, like skull shape. Skull shape.
I just I'm enjoying Kelly being here and having to walk through
this. Good times. Walk through what? I just didn't know what
that word meant. Skull shape dictates attractiveness. Correct
or false, Kelly? I mean, it can do. It depends on the period
of time. We found certain things more attractive than others.
But I mean, if you have a massive dent in your head, it's not
going to look good. My boyfriend has a dent into the back of
his head that supposedly means that he's a criminal. Why would
you tell people this? Jesus. Cuz I think it's really funny. Wait,
I have a really quick question. Okay, Kelly, is is Zindaya attractive?
Do you know who Zinda is? Is India attractive? Kelly, laugh,
don't answer. I'm going to I didn't even hear she's the She's
the girl that
Spider-Man. She's like taller than him, which I find quite adorable.
Yeah, she is the girl who's dating. Yeah, I think so. I'm going
to have to go. Lav isn't attractive. I think so. Okay. I think
she looks like the like the like she looks like people of the
future. Like just like ethnically
like super ambiguous like like that is what the future had to
throw. By the way, let me translate into racist for you for somebody
with that skin tone. Yeah, she looks really attractive actually.
No, that's that's not even I think people with her skin tone
are the most attractive people genuinely. I I don't know. Like
I'm a huge proponent of race mixing unironically. Okay. I've
heard this
the most beautiful people say this before. Yeah. Yes. The most
never made fun of anybody for race mixing before. You never imply.
Oh, no. Of course I've done that. But I just sometimes I say
things. All right. But we're all of those people ugly. Listen,
things can go very right with race mixing and things can go very
wrong. I'm just trying to determine that cuz I think it's funny
to prove my theory, but I mean I don't put much stock in it.
I could be wrong. Some of the best race mixing is when it's a
black woman, white man. that some of the best kind of different
than the other way around. I think so. I think some of your uh
lowest divorce rates are are
black women, white man. Pretty sure. Wow. Pretty sure. Well,
Tony asks uh a person being pro- race mixing. Never heard of
that before. Or he says that thoughts. I'm not even guys. I'm
not I'm not even That's a old dead meme. 23 and me right now.
Where is it? I know you've done it. Just give me the results.
I can look. Okay. Is it sub or is it above or below 10%? 10%
Ashkenazi%
Ashkenazi from Bellarus. Yeah. Okay. 3% broadly European. They
would they would take you to Israel with those with those numbers.
I'm pretty sure 23.1%
indigenous American, 2.6%
North African. The is your family? How did you become the anti-ra
mixing person with objectively like you literally don't have
because because you're more multicultural than Canada is. Okay,
that's You have no idea. That's only h that's like literally
only half of it. Like gets crazy. I'm like 20% Moroccan. Like
is all over the place. Yeah. 19% Irish, 5% Scandinavian,
12% broadly northwestern European, which I think is like like
Hungary. So I think right let's look northwest European it would
be where your grand great grandparents were just like all over
the place. Northwestern
Europe is where? Oh Belgium. That's got to be Belgium because
my great grandma is actually from Belgium. And then it's 16%
southern European which would be south which would be I mean
it could be Croatia, Serbia, Albania,
Greece, Italy, Spain, Portugal and then yeah 15% 15% Portuguese
from Madiraa Portugal. How the do we get how do I get all of
these opinions at the same time? feel like so I get called like
the biggest Destiny sweeper and then also I get people in DGG
who say things like this feel like Jto is some kind of dirt on
Destiny. I'm so conspiracy pill. This dude is the biggest anti
fan I've seen and it's chummy with two of his biggest anti fans
laughing Kelly. Like why
can I be both at the same time? How can I be like the biggest
Destiny and cover up all of his crimes and also be the biggest
Destiny antifan and I hang out with all of his biggest anti fans?
How? How can I be all of these things at the same time? That's
incredible. You know what? It's like me now. Just brilliant.
That's amazing. I just think it's amazing that I can somehow
be all of these things at the same time. Oh, yes. I'm such a
So, what have I said exactly? That makes me an anti- fan. Okay.
Is it me just pointing out that I got banned? Hold on. You You
guys have to understand. I'm not changing anything. I just think
it's like incredible that I I need these two sides to talk to
each other. I need them to come together and figure something
out. Do something. Which one? Which one? Which one? Yourself,
Kelly. Which one am I? You did a big yourself. Which one am I?
Hands together. Am I an anti fan or am I a fan? I need these
two sides to have an argument over it. Okay. Wash your hands.
I need these two sides to come together. I don't even know who
you guys are talking about. Uh me. I'm talking about me. Oh,
also presentation if you want to see what we're actually always
make it about me. I don't care what you're We know. We know.
Kelly, what is it?
Lab has some upside. Okay. Lav doesn't do that. Lav can like
see the conversation and she can like contribute as if she doesn't
exist in a way that Kelly is like totally incapable.
Like Kelly literally only becomes aware of the conversation when
something is referenced like that maps onto her experience or
that she's like been thinking about recently. Otherwise, she
like is not in the conversation at all. I quite literally said
purpose. It's good times. Am I Am I here? Am I experiencing psychosis
if I just say I do it intentionally there? Like what's your point?
Well, that that was intentionally, but you absolutely do it non-intentionally
all the time and it's very funny. No, you just think it's not
intentional. I don't know why you would think me talking about
myself would be unintentional. As I say that, Lav is adjusting
her hair in her camera at this exact moment in time. Wow. What's
wrong with that? Nothing. I was I was literally arguing that
Lav is not selfobsessed and then she started like meing into
the camera. So, I don't know. There's no winning. There's only
losing.
Sorry, I just discovered that I am on camera and that I look
like this. Sorry. Wow, she had no idea. What is this? I just
got linked. Hassan and Carolyn Quan are talking to the incarcerated
firefighters while they are on their downtime. Prisoners who
are risking their lives battling the fires for pennies on the
dollar, sleeping on forest floors at night. Twitter hates outside
links and posts, but he is currently live. Here is a short thread
of clips.
This is so awesome. millionaires going and being like, "Guys,
it's so up that you guys are out here fighting fires." By the
way, it's all on a voluntary basis. They can't force these people
to fight fires. I got my nails done to go do it. That was crazy.
Oh, pretty. Oh, cool. Wow. Wow. You can Wow. They're actually
like my favorite nails I've ever gotten done. Sorry. You literally
just talked about how I like actually muted about me. Like you
I feel like that was [__] with me, but now you're
laughing as if you weren't [__] with me, so I'm not
sure. No, I that was actually complete self unawareness. My bad.
My bad. I mean, what are we going to do? Make it about gisticle.
Who or what the is a gistle? True. Like it's just so boring.
Literally, you make it about the topic that is on the screen,
which has always been the purpose of the stream. And then Kelly's
like, why won't you let me into the stream? Why won't you give
me rolls to join automatically? It's like, yeah, you don't understand
purpose the stream. You literally don't get it.
They should force to fight fires with a color on. Okay. Okay.
All right. Like possibly like squad. Exactly. Like squad. Uh,
by the way, Rey didn't join. Just proving my point. Kelly, just
proving my point. Okay, don't care. Kelly lost. Just to make
that clear for everybody. Kelly lost. What did I lose? I don't
know who this is. Kelly is down. Kelly has been defeated. It's
over. What have I lost? Uh, everything. Everything. That's unfortunate.
If Lav is going to slug on Cam, get Darius in here. Wait, is
Lav like putting Vaseline on or something? I think slugging is
like when you put moisturizer on. Like I I I think it's Vaseline,
but kind of get your skin moist. Okay.
Well, she's not doing that, guys. What do you want me to do?
I don't know what Darius is doing right now. We need Darius to
white tea. Darius is weird. He scares me. Yeah. He has like really
heinous vibes. Vibe terrorist. I disagree. I disagree. I think
Darius has got good vibes. What are those good vibes? Just totally
not vibes. I think if I had to classify them in Yep. Yep. Snagna
says, "Kelly reminds me a lot of LTG. The way he says he's mentally
untouchable, Kelly to show her hairline immediately." What's
an LTG? A low tier god. LTG tried to hit on me. Shocking. Should
I read his DMs? Bad thing. I don't know. Yeah, you should read
his DMs right now. Let's Let's hear. Well, what is his name?
Duan.
Dylan. Yeah, Dylon Sparrow. Yeah. Here, I'll I'll spell it for
you. Where's your
Oh, this is really funny. Uh, does he have good RZ? I don't rate
eight out of 10. It's like this. Our last conversation is it's
this in regards to full bush pubic hair. It's this way a vagina
can be displayed. I like the authenticity you display. I said,
"Thank you." He said, "Of course. Keep being you." Based based.
Yeah. Shocker. We see private communications from LTG and he's
just based. Okay. Who's shocked? Who's shocked? No, I mean he
wasn't like that cringe. It's just like funny that he was like
DMing me. Actually, he was being a little cringe earlier in the
DMs, but they're like not loading for some reason. Oh, well,
destroyed. Dang. He saw the cooch. Well, I'm guessing he saw
pictures on the internet. Or maybe Liv's just sent him full pictures.
Who knows? No pictures. No, no, no, no, no, no. I had a I There
was a There was a picture on my um Instagram that showed like
my No, on my Instagram that showed my lower um tummy in the very
very very top of my bush. There was no like It was like barely
LWD honestly. it like it was not very it was it's on Instagram
so it can't be that LWD. It was just sort of like a feminist
like it was a feminist like Yeah, it was like a feminist like
hair post. You know what I mean? Yeah, for some reason it's not
loading. Sad. Oh, I might actually have screenshots of it. God,
I need to learn how to spell his name. Dao.
I I put it in your DMs. Should we watch the Tom video? We watched
the Tom video, but I
I feel like it's not a good I I feel like wasn't I don't know.
Well, video wasn't a huge one. He did a video on low tier god.
Okay, where is it? Here. Is it an old one? Wait, did he call
it Did he say LTG or LTG? Okay, hold on. What do you mean his
name is not that difficult? John John Silverstein 3 days ago.
Loar god, the most toxic villain of competitive gaming. Oh, I
watched that video months ago. The biggest crybaby on the internet.
Damn. Wait, are we watching the old one or we watching the new
one? Cuz 3 days ago we posted an hourong video. It's not a 20-minute
video. I watched a live video on the fire. We watched it already
earlier in the stream. How do you go from crybaby to most toxic?
You haven't seen LTG's response? You have to. It's so funny.
I saw a little bit of LTG's response. Yeah, we watch it. We can
check it out. We made videos on him. Does Tom have a beef with
this guy? Uh, wait. This is an old response. This is an old roast.
Wait, they they did a they had a whole back and forth. They're
literally just Are they just recycling their back and forth from
before? Our recyclers literally a year ago. Low tier god roasted
me. My response when is there a new response? Is that what's
going on? New children. Turkey Tom or low tier god? Low tier
god. There's like rumors that he does but he doesn't acknowledge
them on the internet which is like whatever. He does like if
he has kids I don't need him to like talk about it loaded. It
loaded
listen is two days ago. Yeah. We can watch we can watch uh what
do you call it? Oh, you're going to do more DM dumps. Okay. Yeah.
This is this is this is funny. He liked my story. Well, I had
saw I had saw that he had made a comment about me on stream.
This was like during all of the like the he who should not be
named stuff that happened two years ago and then he made a comment
about me on stream. Made a video about me and then whatever.
It had like I think 20,000 views or something and then he replied
to my story after I had seen it and I said, "Boo, what do you
want?" Like obviously like you know I saw the whatever and he
said, "Lol, I was just liking a story. Why do you say that?"
I said, "I watched your video." He said, "Lol, I thought I was
unbiased with a comedic twist. You are very smart. didn't like.
I said it wasn't unbiased. It was just your bias. You got me
wrong. And then he said, "School me then. I'm confidential."
LTG made a video on you. Yeah. Oh, okay. Then he said he said,
"School me then. I'm confidential. I find you extremely interesting
in your different personalities you seem to have." I said, "Lol,
I'm just multiaceted." I don't know why I said this. He must
have deleted something, but I said the whole quote, "She pretends
to be a good girl thing. Do you think it's possible many things
can be true at once?" I'm not a category or genre of woman. Oh
god, my cringe. My cringe. He said, "I won't lie, I'm intrigued.
I guess I categorize my personality slightly different. I feel
like I can't be multiple people. Depends on the day." And I of
course I think you could be multifaceted. I think that's what
makes you unique. You do realize that you possess the power to
pull as many identities as you like. Right. I think you're a
I just think you're a master at your craft. I said absolutely.
I said, "What is my craft?" Let's go. Yeah, I know. I said, "What
is my craft?" He said, "The ability to effortlessly wear a different
mask at will." not something everyone can do and be comfortable
doing. I said, "I'm adaptable to my surroundings. It's not a
mask. I'm just emotionally receptive." Queen
Queen stuff. I'm not pretending to be different people. And he
said, "You definitely aren't pretending. I wouldn't say that.
I just thought I could relate because I operate on many different
versions of myself. I initially thought you did something kind
of similar." I said, "Do you think you wear different masks?"
Um, he said, "Yes, I wear plenty of different masks. I can't
be the same person in every interaction. It's not possible for
me." Do we all Do we all act to some extent? He said. I said,
"I suppose, but you should integrate all of them. It's all you."
He said, "Off aderall, maybe." And then he asked me my story.
He's like, "So, what's your story?" And then I was like, "Get
off a bad for you." And then he said, "I only use it for anxiety
every blue blue moon." I said, "Meditate instead." That was like
basically our whole conversation. But yeah, he's like, "There's
like a skitso riz that a lot of guys will do where they're like,
let me let me tell you about yourself and you're like deeper
purpose." That's actually some of my some of my favorite RZ is
that RZ. High tier RZ. low tier god, high tier r. Wow. Wow. Wow.
I mean, it's better than just like show me your I guess it is
better. And then he sent me a picture and then after that whole
conversation he had sent me a photo of like Adam and Eve and
he had said Eve always had a hairy box. I said interesting. He
said absolutely. And then he said it's a way vagina can be displayed.
I like the authenticity display. Thank you. And then he said,
"Of course being uh TB and Gio." Wow. Guys, if you want more
incredible epic content like that, I suggest you follow me on
this on this platform or join the Discord. discord.gg/jsd.
Okay. If you really like the content, okay, you consider throwing
a couple bucks my way. All right. You could TTS. You could donate
through Kickbot or through Streamlabs. Both links exclamation
point. Donate in the chat. Okay. If you want to sub, you can
sub on kick individually or give subs on kick. Every dollar you
contribute adds to more time on the stream. Wow. We currently
have, I believe, eight subs,
eight, seven to eight subs to hit the next hour mark on the stream.
Okay. Uh, if you really, really, really like the content, go
ahead and join the Patreon.
Thank you very much. We need to check out apparently Turkey Tom
getting roasted by low tier god two days ago. This looks like
it cuts in a little bit late though. So, which video is it? Cuz
this one is this one going to have his Instagram picture after
this. Does he only stream now because his YouTube is banned?
I think going by Google. I can't find like his I don't think
he posted on YouTube. He streams on Twitch. I see. Okay. Wait,
which one though? Is this old or is this new? Which is which?
Sorry. Is this cutting in halfway or do I need to go like deeper?
Which video do I watch for his response? You know the LTG Cloak
said it? I do. Paul Stalin slot. Thank you for gifting a sub
to Soapbox. I know it's the same stream, but one of them clearly
starts. We'll just go with this one. It guy's a squeegee, man.
Keep dropping. donate or sub get out of like whiten
please. Unbaby from Kit Kat. You're what? You don't kick? Yeah,
I've been banned for like a year. What's your What's your name?
The white women oppressed. All right. I feel very depressed right
now. Thank you. Someone asked if I had a new song, so I'm responding.
Okay, I'm hitting uh I'm hitting play here. Wait, or am I? LTG
bitterly rants about Turkey Tom and wants to fight him. Why didn't
you link me this later on? Is it not relevant? What's going on
before this happening? Why do you guys cut it in 3 minutes later?
Why is that? Why is that where you start the time stamp? That's
silly. Okay, we're continuing. Watch this. Turkey Tom did another
video on LTG after he's done many videos on LTG in the past.
Okay, another new LTG video. Okay, Low Tier God, the most toxic
villain of competitive gaming. 3 days ago, 555,000 views. Main
channel video. Okay, we're watching Low Tier God reacting to
a couple of like new faceless weirdos that keep at me on Twitter
that have YouTube pages and I don't know some faceless Oh, hey
Dan. All right, talking about I found out about a new LOL counted
and I'm like, bro, who the We're uh we're checking out Low Tier
God reacting to Turkey Tom's video. Did a hit piece on him. Okay,
Turkey Tom did a hit piece on low tier God apparently. Explain
that to a Victorian child. Explain that sentence to a Victorian
child. Turkey Tom decided to throw down with low tier god. Okay.
Clout battle.
Holy. Explain that to a normal person. We don't have to explain.
Why would I explain it to a normal person when I have my audience?
It's just funny. It's a funny sentence. Relax. Holy, you're autistic.
Okay, keep going. Literally about to say I don't have normal
people here. It was another joke. Hold on. Over to the E desk,
actually. All right, we're done. Okay. What would be the Victorian
alternative to a rap battle? Oh, I love this. Is it like a people
speaking poems to each other? Uh, probably. Yeah. Lav would be
Lav would be like the Eminem of the 1700s. Okay. Real. I'm a
poet. I'm a melancholic mad man. A creature with a bubble of
hot poison in her loins. I feel like that. Nobody can dispute
that. Yeah, it's just objectively true. Okay, Dan, you're on
your desk now. Okay. All right. Like kick in kick games. Yo,
shout out about 8 months. Like clicked on the page. Give me three
roll less than three. Some were like 69,000 followers. some worthless.
Another one of these punk ass YouTubers that hide behind the
camera just doing documentaries and fake [__] on
people like those those ass you know the type of people that
just basically make the most slanderous content possible about
people that are way more popular than them. So [__]
oh my god, my ears are burning. That's crazy. I can hear myself
coming through Dan again. Get the cancellation on Dan or maybe
push talk's good now. No, it's not push and talk. It just the
echo cancellation just kicked in. Okay. Kicked in like the VTEC.
You know VTEC when a VTEC kicks in? Yeah. Wow. Just like that.
Hold on. Okay. Hold on. You stop replying and I'm going to talk
to myself real quick and we'll see if it comes through. It is
not coming through at all. It's good. Well done. Well played,
sir. Like that. I just, you know, I just I caught myself replying
and I just blocked the dude. Like don't at me on Twitter, bro.
And don't mislabel me. I'm not one of these fat
balding, feeling sorry for themselves,
crying on stream. I'm not I'm not no lol cow. Whatever the it's
called. What is he talking about? You know, take a look at the
He's not a law cow, guys. He's no LOL cow. All right. He's no
LOL cow. He's not.
Okay. I don't think he dye my hair a different color so I don't
me anymore. He's not. He's not. But that's because he's so cool.
He if literally if he didn't look so cool, he would be a LCO.
His personality is that of a low, but he's ascended because he's
just so cool. Okay.
True. You actually can't be a local if you're super hot. Yeah.
There's some place beyond loc that he rests. It's not even just
that he's hot. He's cool. His demeanor is also cool. Okay. Honestly,
true. Comparative to you, just say cool. I mean, it's not hot,
is it? Comparative to what about me? My personality, how I look.
Which one are you? Which one are you, Kelly? Obviously the cool
part. Okay, thank you. Thank you. Will follow. You think academics
will follow a lol cow? You
academics shimmying through that turn style at the at the subway.
Definitely not a law cow in his own right in any way. Sure. Think
you think people would be inviting me to to guest star on certain
sh on certain platforms if I was a LOL cow? No. The some low
tier god. There's it's completely different than a who does this
or does that. I'm not some some squeegee. I'm not no basic from
a authentic has ingrained himself in multiple and I mean different
levels of this. Yeah, of course. I mean, come on. Of course,
it was everything about me is is fake slander. So, what else
is new? I don't even know what the LOL L cow is. Yeah, I just
I just look at it as just Why does he keep saying it that way?
Brought that term up on his own. I feel like he's got a good
idea of what an LOL cow is. Okay. Why does he keep saying LOL?
Why not just say lol? Who does that? That's so annoying. He's
better at lying than you, Kelly. If he says it incorrectly, then
he doesn't know what it is. Obviously. Obviously. Free free promo
for me. It's more syllable.
Anything that makes you have to do more work speaking is annoying.
Like I said, the end of the day
microphone. There's nothing. What's wrong with it? We hear each
other through it. I hear myself through it. Wow. I could see
how that would be. Yeah, that's how we feel every day, Kelly,
when we have to hear. Well, I'll keep doing it more just to bother
everyone else until you fix it. Oh, let me see if I can get Nvidia.
Nvidia, you're supposed to be tech people and you're absolutely
useless. Wow. Listen, you single person in this call has like
an extreme asberers cadence.
It's like it's like almost hard to listen to. Uh-huh.
You could be anybody. So, I don't know. Well, Dan obviously I'd
take an example. He talks and then Kelly talks like how she talks.
That's true. I do talk how I talk. That is an accurate statement.
Yeah. Every like if if there was like if this was like a group
call where like we were talking about like Asperger syndrome
or like um multiple personalities. I think that like we could
take any chat from like anywhere in the world and they'd be like,
"Oh yeah, these people are like clearly autistic." Okay. Uh yes,
true. Just like Spider-Man meme of everyone pointing at each
other. Just had an just had an observation. Can you give me like
an example? Honestly, realistically, can you speak in autistic
cadence for me, Lav? Just tell me what it means. Well, that's
what I I was actually about to ask question. I was actually just
about to ask that question. I don't I can't perceive my own voice
very well. Do you Does the chat think that I have Asberers or
autism, Cadence? I don't think it's Do an impression of it, Lav.
Do an impression of what somebody sounds like impression. Just
Just try it. Try your best. Try your best. Try your best. No,
say no. I would lean downs. You were just valley girl cadence.
Okay, that's kind of hot. She's a beautiful perfect voice. Thank
you, slapmonger. Vocal fry. Do I have vocal fry? You definitely,
you know, I just realized something. You know the reason that
this type of doesn't happen on Destiny stream more often? It
it just clicked to me. The reason why it's because whenever anyone
goes on Destiny's stream right now impromptu, he seems super
annoyed and then he's like and then like nobody wants to say.
It's like if you if you pop in, he's like, "Hey, what's up? What
do you want? You know, instead of like the more chill vibe that
used to be back in the day, I just He's always been like that
somewhat. I just ignored it. Really just realized that, Dan,
that that's what was going on through it. That's been the case.
That's been like objectively the case for a long time. Yeah.
That he's like, "I don't want to talk to you. Get the out of
here." For a while, forever. At least since uh October 7th, but
maybe even longer. I'm not totally sure. A long long long time.
Kelly Kelly complained about it all the time. That's why Kelly
came on this stream cuz she's like every time I call my desk
last the longest. I'll get rid of me. Well, until you b me then
I guess you can literally boo. Literally the mentality. Well,
go to uh echo cancellation. Hold on. But I am a bummer. I guess
does this work? Say something. Talk over. Yeah. Talk over me.
Is it working? Talking over Dan. Dan, what are you doing right
now? What's going on with Dan in this in this Can is it [__]
You have your Well, you have your mic open. So, obviously, if
I'm talking, I need to talk for a little bit. It's not opening
on its own. Not totally sure. We're probably if you don't have
headphones, we're just always going to hear you a little bit
though. Even with echo cancellation on, but it's whatever. Doesn't
bother me. All right. Well, let's see how it goes. Or you could
go get some headphones
you useless
your [__] feet. Go walk and get some. Don't want
to wear headphones. It's the reason why I'll keep shouting until
you do. Wow. Brilliant. Wow. I don't feel like you're allowed
to say brilliant. I feel like that's a way more posh thing for
you. Well, actually, I don't know how. I don't know. I feel like
people who say brilliant are people on science channels and [__]
I don't understand Americans, Canadians, whatever. Kelly is not
David Atenburgh coded. Negative. Ghost rider. To sit here and
talk about animals. Press play already. Now I have to wait five
seconds to press play because the chatter said it and I can't
take a chatter's advice ever. Five, four, three. I'll get on
me who's doing better than me at life. I promise you that. I
don't give a how many subs you got. You're not doing better than
me. That is a fact. It's free. You're talking about money. Turkey
Tom is definitely doing a lot better than LTG is in life. Yeah,
but Turkey Tom is uglier and gayer. I don't know. Jesus. Maybe
Turkey Tom's young. I feel like there are a lot of racist women.
Turkey. I feel like he could be 18 or 35. He's one of those faces
like David Dori. Like just like permanently 13. Wow. But what
what an incredibly rare What an incredibly rare talking point.
He would look like the and the victim at the same time, bro.
Zerka won. Okay. Zera just did it way better. Zirka just did
it way better. Okay. Promo. I sorry that I'm I was like having
while you were like uh watching streams religiously so I didn't
know that that was on the uh the docket.
What did you get out of that? What did you get out of having
all those times? What did you what did you earn from that lab?
A fun time. What do you earn from having what a weird question?
Wow. Is it like you you like level up on and then you get an
achievement at the end? Brilliant. Brilliant mate.
That was Australian. I don't give a [__] about a
faceless ass online weirdo dropping a video and I'm taking it
personal. It's just like another squeegee. Bro, people been dropping
videos about me since 2015. What else is new? Every year it's
a brand new that claims they never heard of me and starts dropping
videos doing fake ass docks on me and like that. Bro, you never
had a conversation. How the would you know info you know nothing
about me? Wait, who has an Instagram? They post their pics. Which
person are we talking about? Cuz I would love to see your Instagram.
Who the is the turkey dude? Who's that? There was some squeegee
to drop something. Oh, that dude. Yeah. Let me see this dude's
Instagram. That's his name now. Let's see. Dude, squeegee. Damn.
Is that like calling him homeless? Is that Squeegee? It's like
a homeless person. He's not faceless at all. Well, I think LTG
is saying that uh he doesn't know who he is, right? I don't know
who the he is. What the squeegee looks like. I know. I seen I
didn't click on it, but I like seen it. I'm like, okay. But then
I clicked on all I clicked on every video. Not every video, but
I clicked on the videos that he drops on his channel, and I didn't
take it personal. I'm like, that's just what this guy does for
money. I I mean, I kind of looked at it as as an honor. I mean,
you're still a and a faceless weirdo, but to me, I just look
at it when people when people that have big platforms drop videos
on me. I'm not I just look at it as an honor, bro. He's like,
damn, who's this little guy slander or not, bro? It's honor to
me. I mean, these guys Is he a mouse? Is he a slammer? You might
have that in common. You know, I only did that for two months
when I was off. There's something about pretending not to be
40 on the internet that just turns you into a mouse slammer.
It's crazy. What was that comment for? How do I How do I go into
my keychain?
Oh my god. Half of my two terabytes is taken up by photos. That's
crazy. How do I find my keychain, my passwords? How do I How
do I look at my password for an app? I don't even remember on
on iPhone how to do it. You have a MacBook tell you how to do
it. Go to keychain access. Is there keychain access on an iPhone?
Oh, found it. Okay. I literally just had to I literally just
had to look it up. Unmute Dan. I can't unmute Dan. Dan is muted
himself. That's why the cat ears are on. He can't hear over the
cat ears. Okay, we're going. We're going. These guys, you're
never going to see them in person. They're never going to pop
out. They're they would be squeamish and andless per, you know,
in person so on and so forth. You know, you drop a video on me,
cool. Engagement for me. I was about to be annoyed, but then
I remember just fat. I'm probably bouncing. This is the dropping
videos. Do not be bothered by faceless fat ugly men on the internet.
Ugly as clearly showing this by saying in the discord and talking
about how not bothered you are. Let's go. I was bothered. That's
what I just said. I was bothered to not look at this geek for
this very reason. Bro, you know, is this a white guy with no
beard? Bro, look at this guy. Bro, how the is this guy dropping
videos on people looking like this? Literally a NPC to society.
Just a complete squeegee. Your haircut's ugly as too. This guy's
a squeegee. You got to laugh at people like this. Come on, bro.
Now I'm laughing. It's just not the best. It's kind of awkward.
That's a That's a great photo. Okay, that is a great photo. What
an awesome picture. Matching outfits of it. What an awesome picture.
Wow. Like a person like this, I don't even see you IRL. Like
I'm so high up here, bro. People like this, I don't even see
them IRL. I swear I don't. Bro, who doesn't know who Vegan Gains
is? If you've been on the internet for like 10 years, you know
who Vegan Gains is. I'm not gonna be like, "Who? Who? I don't
even know who the Vegan Gains is, bro." Like, who the Come on,
bro. Of course I know who Vegan Gains is. He used to put in major
work in like the mid like 2010. So boring. Is there a point to
this thing? It's crazy that his straw man voice is just like
a hood black voice. That's weird. Is there a point? Uh Lord your
God's talking turkey and it's funny. Okay, can we get to it?
We're literally watching him out loud. I love you, love. This
is like me when I could do this without No, we're literally watching
him tricky talk right now. We're in the process of watching
so weak. This is like one of his weakest low tier gods like he's
done so much better. Yeah, I don't know if you know this low
tier god ramps up. Lav, he ramps up. He's not mad yet. He needs
to make himself mad. Okay, this is this is a version. Okay. Now,
I'm not princess, so I wouldn't call him a gorilla. But if he
were a gorilla, he needs to pound his chest before he goes ape
before he goes
what are why would you say that about needs to my friend's thumping
his chest right now. He's thumping his chest. Okay, he's getting
ready to go. He's amping himself up. Apparently, I said it cuz
Tom is here. Tom goes gorilla mode all the time. So,
very weird. Listen, low tier god's ramping up, okay? Stop him
out. Stop his ramp up. Okay, let's play major work on YouTube.
He used to a lot of people up. Yeah, this guy's a squeegee, man.
Keep dropping these J. Somebody just realized he up. Uh, yeah,
you must be new here. There's significantly worse racism on this
stream basically 90% of the time. So, I didn't realize if that
was literally just the joke as I meant it to be. Yeah, videos,
bro. Look at you. Swagless
ugly. What kind of logic is that? people here being more racist.
Looks like a thumb with hair is going to be racist. Just ugly.
You know, he's one of those type of guys that basically he knows
he's ugly and a NPC. So, he wants to make his Instagram comedic
to try to hide the fact that he's ugly, swagless, and a nobody.
So, basically, it's one of those guys, you know, like one of
those ugly guys that try to turn their they try to like turn
into humor because they know they're ugliest. Yeah. Basically,
one of those guys. You said he got by his girlfriend and carved
her name in his chest. Simple
is just sounding like me. So it's uncomfortable. It's just it's
just like me. Like I need him to stop cuz Tom is not ugly. This
feels weird. Oh no. Oh no. Should I need to be safe for actually
ugly people? Tom's not ugly, but Tom's like not as attractive
logo. Lo God's like anybody below an eight is ugly. That's where
he's coming from. He's got to get in his mindset. Okay. I guess
I'm just not that harsh. So it feels kind of awkward. Buy an
individual and have chat GPT write the whole thing for you, then
hire someone on Fiverr to edit it. Yeah, I'm not worth like Okay,
this ugly, worthless squeegee dropped the video on me. This guy's
a NPC. There's a literally nothing but Chud Logic viewers in
this guy's uh donation. The squeegee. I'm going to have to Google
what a squeegee means. Is like right. They brought up the lyrics
thing. Now they said Turkey just chat GPT's scripts and pay somebody
else to edit them. He's They're hitting on every point. That's
crazy. That was got to be true. That's got to be true. It's like
a It's like a Chud Community Rose session right now. It's like
the guys that clean. Thank you for the free promo. Yes. You're
trying to be comedic cuz we know and you know that you're ugly
as like you're like this is how NPCs and ugly guys combat the
fact that they're ugly as they turn to a comedic approach. I
can see right through an NPC just like this. Let's make it like
this. You guys can see his face in full. Never heard of this
guy before today. That's literally not true. He's like responded
two videos in the past year to Turkey Tom directly. This is the
worst negative canthle tilt I've ever seen in my life. Like like
eyes. Like eyes. Listen, if if Tom's watching, he joined the
Discord and like me right now and disprove this. But I don't
think he's watching. Okay. I don't think he's watching. I don't
think he sees anything that we're doing right now. Literally
a NPC holding up a girl Lego set. Bro, hot. The comedic approach
is basically it's what it's doing is you're trying to harbor
into the comedic approach because you're an insecure ugly. Basically,
you're not fooling anybody. There's not a
mouse hiding under there. Aggressive mouse thumping like likely
got interrupted before. What evil hairline is he hiding under
that haircut? How do you have that haircut as an adult man for
like several years? He like has short hair now, doesn't he? Or
he had short hair for a while. I don't think his hairline's bad.
Just realized that it's a soup made of money. Wow. Right. I don't
think his hairline's bad. Okay. Okay. The only aggressive What
are you doing? Sorry. The only time I was this aggressive with
my
mouse was when I was off my meds that suppressed my testosterone.
So, I was like high high testosterone. I was out angry. It's
just like constant mouse slamming. Is that what the Baldersgate
campaign, Kelly? You couldn't your your testosterone levels were
off the charts? It's almost like It's almost like when you stop
all of your medication that control your hormones. Yeah. It does
affect your behavior and mood. Yeah. Ellie was literally experiencing
road rage. That's what that's what explained all the things.
I was. So you understand how powerful a hormone testosterone
is. Uh yeah, I have a lot of it. Too much. Yeah. So you acknowledge
that um you know bodies with like b like when you're born into
a body with like high testosterone, you're going to be different
than than someone who wasn't. Yeah. I'm incredibly angry with
all my meds. Yeah, it's not great. So, if someone was like if
someone had like testosterone courarssing through their veins
for likely
she's already a turf. Do you really have to do this lab? Is this
required? Is she a turf? I didn't know that Kelly was a turf.
I'm not a turf. She's a woman. But presumably trans women take
the medications I do to suppress the testosterone, right? Or
they But imagine Well, yes, but imagine
you're socialized that angry. Do you think it sticks with you?
I think it does. I mean, I've just said that it wasn't due to
socialization. It was just my medication. Well, I know, but if
you can imag if you can imagine feeling like that, but like 10
times that and then you grow up with that. You can imagine that
some of that is
I am I refuse to comment. I feel this is not going to end well
for me. Oh, you figured it out eventually. Crazy. Maybe she is
learning percent of attractive features on you. Eyes ugly, eyebrows
ugly, facial hair ugly, head shape ugly, hair cut ugly, zero
gains at all, no gym, you're a grown man. Okay. I I feel like,
how do I not sound gay? Tom goes to the gym. Tom has got like
the sleeper build. Okay. Are you scared about to be scared about
looking gay? Like you're actually gay for the comment first.
I make the comment first. It's like a joke. It's a whole part
of the whole thing. Soon as you make me pause and explain it,
it stops being funny. I don't know why you have to like It wasn't
funny to begin with. Okay. Well, need to work on that. It's possible
I know my audience in this room over time. You're right. You're
right. I might know anything. Wow. Make a wish. 111. Why do I
still have a Why do I still have a Halloween background? What
Halloween background? Are you asking? Oh, I don't know. She's
talking. No gym at all. Forearm skinny. Arm skinny. Damn near
one one.
Wait. Pause. Pause. Pause. Pause. Pause. Tom is weak as he doesn't
ever benchmark an abomination. 111. Actually, guys, it was 111
1111 for just for 1 minute straight. I'm not sure what to respond
with. Nobody gives a crazy actually. Crazy. Bill. Oh, yeah. Sure.
If you guys want to stream and keep going. I think we're seven
subs away right now. Or a Well, actually, you can't do a $2 donation.
So, like one more $3 donation and then seven subs.
Yeah. So, we're we're pretty close. But if you guys want to donate,
okay, you can do that. Otherwise, uh we will go to the Oiler
channel after this. Okay. If we end before, let's say 11 Eastern,
I'll probably do that. All right. Wait, no, not 11 Eastern. Midnight
Eastern. Midnight roughly around midnight, we'll do that. Continue.
Dropping videos on people who are way more popular than you.
A white guy with no beard is crazy. Like, I'm black. So, if I
happen to not have a beard, all right, cool. A lot of blacks,
some of us don't get that. But if I was a white guy with no beard,
bro, I would feel like generations cheated me. You know, before
you drop these videos on people who are better than you in life,
you should probably contact him. You squeegee. Don't tell me
this guy. The other thing about this is like just for Tom's sake,
Tom's explicitly like doing this look like for a purpose. Like
this is a part of the branding, right? Like Tom Tom knows that
the facial hair looks kind of like Scraggly. He knows that this
like the brand. It's the brand. Okay. It's the brand. He's leaning
into it. Evil. Yes. Okay. You can go. We understand this is not
this is not an organic. True. Thank you. Actually, Lav's right.
Okay, Kger selling us. Thank you for the gifted subs, guys. We
appreciate it. Okay, we appreciate you. This is him leaning into
the brand obviously, right? We can see
I'm just correcting the things that are obviously incorrect as
I always do. Okay, if you don't you want non-aututistic content,
go somewhere else. Okay, nonautistic. I'm just telling you that's
what it is. That's what he's doing. Okay. Okay. The bald patches
are on purpose. Link me the bald patches right now. Link me the
bald patches right now. Link bald. Tom leans into it because
he knows he's ugly. Okay, I don't think that's quite where he's
going, but that is something he said. So, and now it's And now
it's 112 1212.
That's crazy. Generations cheated me. You know, before you drop
these videos on people who are better than you in life, you should
probably contact him. You squeegee. Don't tell me this guy's
white and Asian. Please don't tell me he's Hispanic of some sort.
It would be even worse. It's even worse if you're Hispanic with
no beard. You also don't give a about your health, [__]
You got a cigarette in your mouth. You're a lame. Look at you.
That's actually a dirty ass small ass desk. Just a complete squeegee.
Dirty ass shoes. Don't care about your appearance. Probably a
uses toilet paper. A tap out shirt and Chuck Taylor's. Yeah,
bro. You blend into society perfectly. You're a NPC. You quirky
still smoking cancer sticks in 2025.
Like, go get this bait off my screen. Appreciate the free promo,
you ugly. There's nothing to do because there's no real doc.
There's no real actual information about me on the internet.
So, I should have sent his DM. I do enjoy this cope at the end.
The whole no information about me is true. Do quickly fell for
LTG. I mean, I guess so. Thomas switched his ends. He has.
What's his Instagram again? I forgot him already. Going back.
Okay, good one. How about I see if he wants to fade? Hold on.
Let me see. What's his Instagram? I forgot it already, bro. Let
me just offer the fade via DM. I'm send him a DM. Like, let's
meet IRL. That's all I said. Wait, he still does this? He still
does this whole thing after the whole Viscante thing. After he
got mogged by the palest, skinniest, whitest dude on the planet.
He still does the whole come meet up with me IRL. Like this guy
literally him to his face IRL. He didn't do anything. I How in
the world is he still actually doing this the same bit? That's
nuts. Yeah, black. You know, you know the the real black thing
would just be able to just offer the offer to fade off the rip.
Let's meet IRL. Oh no, this I'mma guess what? 25.
23 looking like this. How are you? 23 and you don't even got
a baby face. Looking like full stressed out cubicle workers at
23 making videos about
Okay, stressed out cubicle worker is funny. Okay, that's funny
as actually. I don't I don't necessarily like Listen, if you
show me this picture, I would never make that criticism, but
now that he says it, the shadows come in like bags under his
eyes and I can see it. Okay, this guy paints a picture. All right,
that's not my fault. Hope you make a nice $200 off the video,
bro. Maybe 300 bucks. I'm not mad at anything else. I guess that's
We are going to eat some insulting him the entire time. I don't
think so. Literally, the video name is LTG bitterly rants about
Turkey Tom and wants to fight him. So, what is the video that
Turkey made about? I don't think LTG would necessarily win. We'd
have to see. Tom Tom might be there's a chance just because Tom
like did YouTube from like a very young age. There is a chance
that he's like Hassan coded with like no mechanical uh like me
no muscle memory in his body from like anything athletic, right?
So like he's like kind of strong but he's got nothing like do
you know what I mean? We all know what I mean with the Hassan
kicks, right? We saw Tom fight at UFC. I don't know. I'm just
saying that there's a chance Tom is like the um what do you call
it? Like Hassan coded in that way. Tom got that rage. Remember
that fight? The fight? No, I don't. Play the video. Hold on.
Do I have it in my I do. Well, I've got one of them. This is
just like a a risky run as like a YouTuber. If you've always
done content, if you've never been like into athletics in any
way, this is a risky run. Okay. That like this is this is your
version of like being in shape with like no no like mind muscle
connection anywhere in your body. Bro, you're in shine around
here. Oh. Oh my god. What happened? You died. That's [__]
Watch out, dude. This is a joke. Uh, wait. Is this really a joke?
I don't think it's a joke. One when he's in the gym. The one
when he's in the gym is I'm aware of both. I'm aware of both.
I like this one cuz it includes the Sam Hide bit. And every once
in a while, I like showing the Sam Hide kicks. I'm just going
to record a little bit
Terrifying.
Actually, actually spooky. Hold on. Hassan K. Hassan kick. There
we go. Zesty kicks with agent. Yep. These are all my history.
I only have to type it in and it pops up. It's so good. It's
so good.
You miss it. You miss it. If you're not watching, you miss it.
Power. Power. Power. All right, we got an hour of triceps and
we're out of here. Yeah. All right, let's keep going. Hell yeah.
All right, now we're going to do the Wi-Fi. Can't wait.
Boom. Boom. Boom. Asana has zero lower body mobility. Well, it's
not just mobility. It's like your muscles work in like chains
for certain activities and you can learn them when you're young,
but it seems like it's quite difficult for like somebody when
they're 30 to be like I want to be athletic now and you didn't
learn any of those like you don't have those that mind I guess
is it mind body connection that that muscle connection mind muscle
connection right you don't like have that so your bodies connect
together it just doesn't work right so it's very hard to develop
when you're older somehow oh this
I forgot about this leave me alone this Tomurkey
just as This isn't actually Tom, though. Kind of funny, but not
Tom. All right. Where's the Where's the LTG video? We'll see
if there's any account really quick. This is not the right one.
That's not the right That's the right one. Right. Let's see.
Yeah, I'm safe about it. Yeah, we're good here for now. There
are no actual real facts about me on the internet whatso I don't
give a what in post about me. There's zero real facts about me
on the internet. Nobody knows where I live, my income, what cars
or car I drive, what ex what what what multiple sources of it.
Like nobody knows a thing about me, bro. Like you have to really
know me in person to know anything about me. Just like there's
just like there's out there that really like got thinking that
I got Deontay Wilder legs. What did we say about ferret people
yesterday, Dan? I forgot. Oh, he's muted. Not good. They're not
good people. Not good people. Oh boy. Lav's only got the one
though. Not good people. Lav's only got the one.
I have three. Oh, wait. When did you get three? How do you have
three? Okay. I got so Oswald really needed a friend and um so
I obviously I went with my boyfriend to the pet shop and we wanted
to get him a girlfriend or a wife and we she came like with she
was like she when we went to the pet shop she was there cuddled
up with like her sister and the one that we originally were going
to get and then as we were leaving like with
Brun Hilda her name is Brun Hildy as we're leaving with with
Hildy the um Gunter was like looking directly at us and then
we like couldn't He couldn't leave without her, so we had to
get her also. So, now we have three. But I hate Gunter. Gunter
is the worst. She bites. She's bad. We should have We should
have only gotten Hildy. Um, okay. Thank you for Thank you. And
come up to me in person be like, "Oh, bro, that's crazy. Like,
your legs aren't small, bro. Like, I don't even know what they
saying on the internet. I got strangers coming up to me and telling
me this." And on top of that, there's d like dumb ass trying
to stifle my height. Guys, he totally has strangers coming up
to him on the stream being like, "Whoa, bro. Your legs are not
as small as they said on the internet." Whoa. What? Wow. Your
legs are like normalsized.
Oh my god. That totally happened. 100%. That definitely happened.
Real. Very real. Very real. Because they're mad they're not 6'5.
I already told you. I don't care about being 6'5. It's just the
genetics that I have. So they'll try to like stifle my my height
and say I'm 6'2. Then when pull up on me, they be like, "Oh,
damn, bro. I didn't think you' Because you're believing the internet."
That's all speculation. Don't no on the internet that never met
me, never have a conversation with me know a goddamn thing about
me. There are no real facts about low tier guy. Period. I don't
give a what bum
from my past said, "Don't none of these know me. If you're speaking
negative on me in the first place, you're envying in the first
place." It's just literally that simple. Wow. It's nothing but
envy. Why would you say why would you even be saying something
negative about somebody that has nothing to do with you that
literally triumph you in all in all ways of life? So off tops
when people see me in person they automatically got a chip on
my shoulder because I don't know if you a troll or not. So I
got to stay ready. So when you see me in person my face is going
to be blank. I'm going to be like all right. Okay for sure. Like
off the rip there ain't no smiles or any of that type of [__]
because I'm I got to be ready at all times. So, no, I don't look
like a nice guy in person cuz I'm not. I'm on guard at all times.
Of course, they find me attractive. Why else would they be jacked
off to me 24/7? If I was some ugly, crunchy, fat black, what
would be the obsession? Anyways, though, like the thing is I
I don't even really like I feel like there's so much more in
life you could be mad about. B, shout out for the sub. There's
so much more in life you could be mad about than me. Wow. I guess
that's listen that's every time somebody gets in controversy
on the internet it's because everybody else is obsessed with
them and wants to them. Okay. Apparently that is all controversy
on the internet according to low tier god. Okay. I apparently
that's a paradigm we're comfortable operating in. Do you not
think that I mean I think that you're strumming what he's saying.
I mean, he's already I mean, he's giving sort of a like a halfbaked
thought, but I think that there are plenty of people online who
get like really pissed off if someone is attractive and then
if they're doing something dumb, it like makes it like much more
fun for them to like harass them because it feels like you're
like you're making things right in a way or it feels like you're
it feels like you're making life more fair. Like that's just
true. Okay. And with someone like low tier god where like a lot
of like fighting game people or like just gamers in general are
like genuinely like decrepit fat disgusting like freaks with
like neck beards and adult acne. You see someone like low tier
god you're like you're fuming. You're fuming. Wow. Okay. I think
most really really good fighting game players don't look like
that at all. I think pretty much anybody who's like number one
at something usually has enough This is Gun like can at least
prevent their executive dysfunction enough to like train up at
a game or something and then they they're usually pretty. This
is Gunter. Gunter's evil with the LTG singing video. Uh I don't
know what he's singing. What is this? I don't know what this
is. What did you just link me? What did you just link me? [__]
is this? I put this in here. What is this? Oh my god. Bite laugh.
True. Gunter bite now. Do it. Dude, Gunter's Gunter is actually
evil. Gunter is actually evil. I should not have gotten Gunter.
She's the worst decision I've ever made. And now Gunter is about
to poop in a corner. Gunter, hold on. I need to go put Gunter
on the pad. I need to put Gunter on the pad. That room must Oh
my god. Three ferrets,
dude. Ferrets are the worst for that. God, just imagine. You
see the David Doick transformation lab brought it up earlier.
No, I don't really think about that. Hitting me. It's spinach
just link. What? What? Why did I just get like this? What the
happening here? Get off me. You're going to see things that no
human being should be shown. Jesus Christ. I used to browse daily.
Bring it on. Bo Black makes
no wait. No, there can't. That can't be real. I refuse to believe
that's real. That has to be fake. This is Brun Hilda. Really
got three ferrets. That's This is Brun Hildy. She's the cutest
and the sweetest baby. That's nuts. That's Is it that wild to
assume that it might be considering you've been spamming [__]
in the Discord? Spin V. I think it's wild at all. No, no, no,
no. This is photoshopped. No, no, no, no,
no,
no, no. Who are you saying no to? No, no,
It's a Bolex. No,
Bob. No,
no. Yeah, that's not what I thought you were talking about. I
thought you were talking about Roblox. No, no, no, no. Thought
you just really hated ferrets. No, no. There's not night. There's
not not safe for work. No, wait. Hold on. This is on There's
no way Queeman's offline. If this is true, there he has to still
be streaming and he never streams this late. There's no way Queman's
sitting offline and not commenting. Is he not Is he not reviewing
this right now? He's talking about something else. How How is
he talking about something else? There's no way. There's no way
he could be unaware. Maybe this is just old. Get him on the show,
bro. Where's he at? Bro, what the Jewish representation? What
is happening? Sorry, I have to keep clicking through these. I'm
I'm being linked threads in real time of Black. You little Is
there a reason for this? I'm uh Is there a reason for what? Does
he do this like normally? I don't I don't know what this is.
What are we looking at? I People are saying it's Bolex, but I
don't know if it is. But it like the facial hair and hair matches.
So perfectly. Does he have like a loot account or something?
Is that apparently? Yes. He's This is the fansly he made apparently.
Why are you spending so much time looking at his concerning?
Anyway, because it is humiliating for another person. Sorry.
I don't think they think it's humiliating, do they? They put
it online. No way, dude. There's no way. There's no way. Yeah,
I saw this one.
This is the just happened. Did Lav just get attacked? It is.
Literally Gunar's
psycho abuse question mark. Did Queenman really just end stream
dude? There's no way. Hold on. Did Gunar's up to evil? There's
no way. This can't be real. Hold on. I need some people discussing
this that I can rely upon. No, it is. Hey, sweet girl. Don't
bite your pants. Holy.
I can't I don't think I can show the other image. The other image
is just Dude, no. No. Who is this person? No. Bo Blacks. Do you
know who Blocks is?
Maybe. I'd have to see a photo. This image is Will you get rid
of some of your pets when your kid is born? No. I have two dogs,
three ferrets. Relax. That's not even a lot of animals. This
is him. This is Boax. Bro, I'm not going to lie to you. The uh
it lines up too perfectly, unfortunately. That's like a perfect
That's like a You want You want to hear You want to hear lore?
That's like a one to one. Uh yes. Anything other than Jessica
saying no, no, no, no, no, no over and over again. Yeah. So,
my ex-husband abandoned my cat in Los Angeles. Like, just left
it like at our Airbnb. Hold on, hold on. Full caps just been
sent to me in DMs. Full has been released. Warning, be careful
on Twitter. Okay, I I can no longer free school Twitter because
this ised up. This is really, really Who cares about this? Who
cares how he dresses? Just so we're uh It's embarrassing as Yeah.
How How is this embarrassing? Who cares? Okay, it does feel very
you guys are just boy wearing clothing. Who gives a [__]
Anyway, oh my god, all my frets are fighting. They're going to
Everybody cares about that. Absolutely. You know what? Everybody
cares about what you guys are saying. Anyway, uh so my husband
abandoned my cat and I couldn't get over there because it was
in Los Angeles and I didn't know where she was and he didn't
know where she was. Nobody knew where she was. And so my boyfriend
asked his old roommates to like find the cat. And Palm Bi, who's
the sweetest, most beautiful girl ever, found my cat and adopted
her because my boyfriend is allergic to cats and we can't keep
her. True. Get Palm Bi on the stream. Lav right now. Let's do
it. She would never stoop this low. She would never stoop this
low. And so now my beautiful cat Buu is with Palm B. Wow. What
is she? What are you saying about right now, Lav? That'sed up.
What? Anyway, she like she went she went to go No, no, no, no.
You're on. Everybody enjoy the stream. She rescued She's
trying to run. She rescued my cat and then adopted her, which
is like the sweetest thing ever. And my cat had like fleas and
stuff because she was abandoned for like a month and he didn't
tell me. And yeah, she like took care of like the fleas and everything.
Like very very sweet lady. Very very sweet lady. That Ridge Wall
guy really sucks. Godamn. No, he just like he obviously didn't
want like the pets, but yeah, shitty thing to do, but whatever.
He was just busy. Well, I don't understand if it was in that
house. How did he not know where she was then? She got out where
the house was. Oh, okay. I see. She got out and he like didn't
look for her. Lol. But whatever. He's not a cat. He's not a cat
person. So, Black tweets, I'm officially woke now 3 days ago
with his his gender, his driving license, driver's license, services
card. Never mind. It's just an identification card of BC and
his is X. Wow. You're doing Oswalt. Is Bo Black like a Tom? I
don't get it. Yeah, they were good friends. Oh, so they they're
both the same person to you. I guess they're the same version,
I guess. They like do the same videos. They're like really good
friends. What do you mean? Is Bo Black's like Tom? How do you
mean like Tom? As in you hate him. I love Tom. What are you talking
about? I went out of my way to be like Tom's not ugly. Why are
you calling Tom ugly? Also, Tom's like probably better than Jim
than you are. I meant like Tom Tent Tom. Oh. Oh, Tom Fery. No,
I don't even hate Tom Fery. I also But this guy is like Tom Fery
to like Nicholas Deorio. Yeah, sure. That's probably true.
I love you. No, I understand. Nicholas. So,
is that what you think, Kelly? That Nicholas is only on Boax
cuz he's scared he wouldn't look as good as in a dress as Bo
does. I'm not saying this guy's good-looking either. I'm just
saying Nicholas Dioro is hideous. Wow. Very rude. Very rude.
Does Destiny No, Destiny Turkey. You just sent spent like 15
minutes going with this guy.
If you have a full beard and you wear a dress, okay, not good.
In any case, not good. If you're hot enough, you can pull it
off. That's what like Scott wears, mate. Thank you. No, you're
just wrong. You're just wrong in every single way. You're literally
just wrong in every single way. You're like You're trying to
come up with some sort of some sort of exception to this. Nope.
Nope. If you're hot enough, you can get away with anything. Yeah,
but the the thing is is the full beard the beard the patchy beard
like that precludes people from being that hot automatically.
I mean, yeah, I'm not saying this guy is hot. I'm saying it's
dependent on being hot. Sure. So, give me give me the picture
of the person who's got a full beard who's hot. Kelly, give me
three and then I'll admit you have a point. Otherwise, I think
you're being a right now. A full beard is hot. What do you mean
of anybody? I don't like a full beard. No, a full beard is not
attractive on a woman. Lav Kelly is arguing that a full beard
is attractive on a woman. Please tell her. How did I say that?
The [__] I said I said if you're wearing a dress,
if you're wearing like a full dress, like a sundress, you have
a full beard. That's not cool. That's just obvious.
Is this person Is this person a trans woman? I don't know what
you're saying. They're gender fluid. Yes. They like are the whole
thing is they have a beard and they wear dresses. Yes. That's
like all of the branding. That's all of everything. And Bo has
talked about that, too. Never mind. I can't even bother to argue
this autistic. This is like This is like the sketch. This is
like sketch all over again. It's crazy, Mr. Peny. Cuz Mr. Girl
was taken. Oh boy. Oh, Mr. Girl just needs to remind us over
and over again how homophobic he is. Okay, we get it. What do
you mean I'm homophobic? Men in dresses. How am I How is that
homophobic? The gays make you uncomfortable. I They don't. I'm
literally is icky. Is icky. That's you right now. You're trying
to defend this cuz you're trying to not get cancelled right now.
I think it's funny as can you have this? This is just like this
is just like the sketch thing all over again. I'm saying you
find it icky and you've let us know. I'm the ultimate female.
Why settle for being hot as a girl or a guy when you can do both?
Down to do anything or anyone?
Sweaty face. If you find it so icky, why do you spend so much
time looking at it? Did I say icky or say funny? I thought I
said funny repeatedly. This is very funny. Where is it funny?
You kept saying no. No, no, no. No, no. More time on this than
like a dick sucking video. Like, how have you spent more time
on this? I don't understand how you Hold on. Hold on. No, the
those videos that you're talking about, I've spent at least 10
hours on. What are you talking about? Why are you saying something
when you don't watch my stream? Yeah. Shut the up. I just I just
feel like it just doesn't come up. It just doesn't come up. It
does all the time. Cuz you're allowed here is one of the reasons
it comes up all the time. I haven't I haven't I don't think I've
ever Have I brought that up? I don't think so. Uh, you almost
certainly have. Yes, you just did now. Well, I just did now for
sure, but I don't think And I also have been referencing the
sketch and saying this is the same thing and that's why it's
funny. And I also cover the out of the sketch. You're a random
dude who's an influencer and then we discover that you actually
have a transgender account where you go on Tik Tok or for where
you where you go on only fans, not Tik Tok, and like actually
make and it's like weird and degenerate. That's just funny. That's
really funny. It's always funny. It's always going to be funny.
It's always funny. It's always It's always sunny. I don't care
about what this guy does. Why do you care? Who cares about what
anyone does? Love is like my innermost thought. Yeah. I You guys
literally will go. It could be like the end of the world. Okay.
Donald Trump could order the like nukes to fly everywhere and
you're like, "This is boring. Can I talk about my ferrets? This
is so boring. Can I talk about this email I got? Can I talk about
my my medical test results? This is so boring. Why are you guys
talking about the world ending? Can I tell what is there to say
besides this is cringe? What is there to say besides this is
what is there to say really likes looking at trans
don't post the pictures. No
that's that's that's your cover. You really actually like it.
Stop. No. You don't want to be around the frets? Go on the bed.
You want to be around the ferrets? Go on the bed.
Why? I can't I can't stop. I can't stop looking. I must look
more. I haven't been looking. I'm I'm making fun of you now.
You guys have successfully changed my focus, my target. You've
completely changed my target to you guys being Yes, Zanj. Thank
you for the three gifted. I super appreciate it, buddy. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Oh, that gets us to eight and three.
We're basically there. Let me go ahead and I'll I'll save we'll
save us the $2 and we'll keep going. Okay. 21 37. Another hour
on the stream. Let's go. Thank you very much, Sage, for the three.
Topping it up, dude. Gunther is crazy. Yeah. Well, is Gunther
wearing a dress? Wait, she's a woman. Gun is a lady. Bad response.
Oh my god. K just wants to use rating reaction stream. Uh yeah,
100 subs for that. Okay. 100 subs. Technically, Gunar is not
a woman because she's a child. She's a child ferret female. She's
not an adult human female. Okay. All right. We have to 100 subs.
How many [__] are you going to review? Just one.
Just one. Jesus. So with Sketch, I think it was a [__]
review to be fair. Which by the way, Sketch is like basically
no criticisms. Okay, that guy went crazy. [__] Dan
still hasn't fixed his Oh my god. I just I want if only Lav was
around at that time. Lav could have reviewed it. I feel like
Lav's review would have been so funny. Of what? Of the sketch
[__] videos. Oh my god. I ate to it. I thought it
was great. Look at sketch. I I was just like, "Bro, that guy's
got like Listen, I didn't realize that technique transcended
like Okay. Jesus Christ." Yeah. And she just t You could appreciate
it. Also, just how much to kick, Lav the Queen, and Kelly the
40-year-old. Now, there there were some other leaks that felt
like I was watching gore. It It didn't feel to me at all. It
felt like I was watching gore. Okay, where are we at here? Uh
I would need Quimman here to cover this stuff. I'm not I'm not
just going to go and mock this guy for being trans if I'm if
everybody in in my Discord is against it. I can't I can't fight
him. What What leaks are we talking about? We are talking about
Boax's brand new Okay, relatively brand new Only Fans or Fanlessly
accounts that have been found. Okay. Where he has been posting
pictures of himself apparently or just the general like save
the dog. The dog's okay. Didn't we already know Bob is trans?
Yeah, but he's making Okay, he's literally posting like luds
and nudes on the internet of himself in dresses and stuff. That's
a different level. Okay, that's a different level. So, what do
you mean? So, that's funny as I think we're so I'm sorry. I am
I hate this rivals. Is there anything like is is there like are
you guys just going to keep making fun of like a a population
like trans people or like Okay, you won yourself for making this
argument right now. I just like I just don't know why. Pretend
it's Zia. Okay, go ahead. Pretend it's Zonia for two seconds.
Get your head in the game. Lav. Okay, we're laughing at somebody.
Just pretend it's Zia so you can get your transphobia on. Okay,
cuz we all know it's there. We've all witnessed it. We've all
witnessed it. Stop. Aren't you signing and being like, are you
really
protected population right now? And like
her into the war line. Brilliant. Pretend it's Brianna Woo. Pretend
it's Brianna Woo. What happened to Well, I know what Brianna
I don't know anything about Zia. I just know that when I one
time you're being super transphobic to her in my Discord and
I timed you out and said if you're going to be transphobic to
her, you can't be here. Well, I was being
I just bring her up again and get laughed to do again. Well,
Zia Zia was being rude. I was only being literally
complex concepts. Kelly has like the you could be encouraging
the
talking about
concept of like a three-year-old. It's insane. When you say can
be awful,
Kelly, how would you feel if you didn't have Everyone expects
to be their expects their gender to be off the table. Like, if
you're going to be awful to me, why would I not make fun of you
for being a like, it's it's got to be on the table. Yeah. It's
all disavow the language. By the way, when you bait things, they
happen, which is what I just said. I didn't say on Za. I said
pretend this is Zia. You're a dumb.
My whole Wait. What do you think the point of me saying that
was? Hold on. Wait, Kelly, I want you to tell me. Kelly, hold
on. Hold on. I want you to prove to me that you have better abstract
concept, permanence, and understanding than a three-year-old.
What was the point of the comparison I made or what I You were
trying to make You were trying to make a point, but the problem
with trying to make What was the point? No. What was the point?
You have to answer what the What was the point I was trying to
make that she would be that kind of transphobic to those people.
Oh my. Holy. Okay. But it's moronic the point when you know she
will as shocked as you guys are. Okay. I'm all you've done is
made it. You dumbass. She actually got it. I I lost like I was
just trying to cut off. She actually got it. It took like It
took like 90 seconds for us to get there. But she did get there.
Actually, now I'm not actually confident that she didn't just
read it from Chad. Did somebody tell us somebody about to kill
themselves? God. Jesus.
It's almost like the point was very obvious. That's why I didn't
think I had to bother like spelling it out. I don't believe you
have the ability to spell it out most of the time because you
don't operate if you have that ability.
That's why I'm assume everyone else is at least as intelligent
as me.
You assume I'm as intelligent as a spoon. Uh, we don't have anything
specific on the agenda. There's like politics stuff that we were
that I was covering, but I'm not going to cover that with Kelly
cuz I would shoot myself in the head. So, I don't know. Do you
have another topic? If we have another topic, we could go there,
but don't threaten me with a good Just covering I'm just covering
what's up. My parents are like a gang and they're beating up
the broom. Um, beating up the broom. My broom in the in my room.
They're beating up the broom. Like, they're all three of them
are attacking the broom. Okay. Crazy. Do you guys like my dog?
Let me see the dog. the sausage dog. Do you have Rivals downloaded?
Nope. I watched other people play it today. It does look fun.
I haven't tried it. It's It's better than Overwatch. I think
it's It's pretty fun. I like the aesthetics. It's cool. Why are
you guys giving me like geopolitical videos? Why would you do
that? Did you ask Dan how he's holding up? What do you mean how
he's holding up? Tree of Logic. Tree of Logic. What's Dan doing?
Is he making something? Yeah, he is. Here, I'll show you. Hold
on. I'll I'll show you. Wait, hold Dan. Saltman.
Hello. Saltman technology. There it is. one. Dan, I need you
to be watching this uh thing for a second. Okay, we've got a
video here. All right, I need Dan here for this. Okay, so quick
meme. Quick Dan meme. Saltman technology. Okay, don't don't me
have it too lightly on here. Okay, here we go. All right, this
is Saltman Techn. Wait, are you watching? Hold on. I'll restart
it. I am watching. Yes, he's watching. I don't know what I'm
watching. This is Saltman technology here. All right. So, Sean
has score. Three, two, hold on. America deserve boom. Thanks.
That hurt my ears. Premium. He laughed. He laughed. We saw him
laugh. We all saw him laugh. Okay, we all saw it. What is it
supposed to be though, actually? What is it? Oh, it's uh like
sensor. It's a thing to do his own custom audio for the sensors
in his vehicle. So, like if his door is open, it'll say like
left door open. And I think he wants to do it in Japanese. Why
the pipe sound though? Cuz it's a meme. In Japanese. Jesus Christ.
Quick meme. What is the meme? What is this? Make one thing clear.
What? Dude, the chain thing's so stupid. I don't care. I don't
care. It's not funny. Is subbed to Bob's OF. I'm sure he has.
I'm sure he has. Listen, I'll leave that. I'll leave the scrging
around on the Bo Blacks Only fans to somebody far better equipped
to to deal with that. Okay. And that's morale. Sorry. Is there
more to be done there? Don't think is there more to be done on
what? The thing you just said. more to be. Yeah, you could poke
around all of his only fans pictures, see if there's anything
funny there. For sure. Doesn't it seem like the longer that you
do that, the more gay it just makes you? Why do you think I'm
opposed to people think I'm gay? I'm just Well, if you're not,
then by all means, you're the one that says it's yucky. I've
seen you. But I just don't care. If people think I'm gay, they're
just wrong. It's Why would I Why would I care? So, you just want
to subject yourself to yiness for what reason? Yeah. Have you
not witnessed literally this Discord call? Why are you bringing
uh this clip up then? I'm not like other girls. I'm Kelly Jean.
I'm not like other girls. I'm Kelly. Are you a girl, Jessica?
I'm not like other girls. I'm Kelly Jean. I'm not like other
girls. I'm Kelly Jean. I'm not like other girls. I'm Kelly Jean.
Oh, it's like looping. I thought it was just going to replay
the same thing over and over again. I thought it was like longer.
I'm not like other girl Jean. I'm not like other girls. I'm this
video so I don't like I'm not like other girls. I'm I just started
this. Where is it? Where's the cab?
There it is. Jesus Christ. Hell. All right. The [__]
does that clips for no reason? Hold on. I don't know. Which you
admitted on stream. I wasn't trying to harm you monetarily. You've
already admitted this on another stream that you were trying
to harm the stream. No, that never happened. It never happened.
If it's the person that owns the stream, it just felt weird that
he monetizes your community when he was saying that he hates
you. Yeah. Wow. Oh, a whole [__] opinion of weird.
Wow. Is that the same as saying, "Oh, I want to [__]
him and make sure he loses money."
I don't think they're the same. They are. They literally literally
like It's very concerning to me that you're making like Are you
Are you arguing that because you didn't try to close my bank
accounts and like prevent me from ever getting employment anywhere
that you didn't try to with my money? That's like what you're
trying to do. The argument is that I said entirely different
words, the intent was not there. We can keep coping about it.
Okay. I I don't know what to tell you, Kelly. I don't know what
to tell you. I don't know what to tell you. I don't know what
to tell you. Oh, cry more. Okay. All right. Where are we? I really
don't have like additional content from this. That's not just
me reacting to like the Zuckerberg stuff or whatever. The So,
I told I told Queen you should come in here and talk about uh
what do you call it? Talk about these Boax leaks. These these
seem to be shocking. Don't forget she threatened you with defamation.
She did. That is true. That is also true. Threatened to report
my channel and my Discord. They Okay, they weren't threats. And
I said, I would have to if things were not removed. It was a
warning so you can delete stuff. You don't stop being such a
I'm going to have to hit you again. I don't want to. I will have
to. It's not a threat. Just if you don't stop being such a I'll
have to hit you. Okay. Do you want me to explain why that's because
I'm not threatening to hit you? I'm trying to protect myself
from negative things being done to me already. Okay. That's why
it's different at saying, "Oh, you've hit me, so I'm going to
hit you back." I have I have a right to my voice, Kelly. Calling
you a log cow is not hitting you. It is not. It is not. It is
not. That's not what I was complaining about at the time. Stupid.
That is absolutely why you were saying you were going to report
me to Discord or sorry, kick. No, that's not. And I'm not going
to go over why because like he's bringing up all of the demented
stuff that was on the stream. Okay. you I think that maybe you
genuinely don't remember just how hostile you were at that point
in time and just exactly the type of stuff that was being put
up and put around on Discord itself. Not on Discord. You my kick
channel. It was Discord and kick. Okay. So, it depends which
one you were talking about, but like both. I've said kick repeatedly.
Okay. Because I'm trying to narrow this down to what I did what
I said and I don't understand. Like, do you have a clip for me?
Can you show me exactly what I said about you that was somehow
defamatory or or that couldn't be on stream? There aren't clips
anymore because it's older. Royal had a video of it, but he deleted
it because I reported it and that video is gone because it was
like that bad of me doing something. Can you just describe what
it was that I did on my Tik Tok stream? No, I don't want to bring
it up. It's gone now. So, it doesn't matter. Okay. I don't think
so. I don't think that's true. I disagree.
I disagree. Oh, you can disagree.
No, I can think that something is defamatory or harassment and
you can say I don't think it is. But that doesn't mean what you
think it means or what you're trying to imply. I'm allowed to
think, hey, X, Y, or Z is causing me harassment when it is. Okay,
let me see here. If you don't think you're ever breaking any
rules, what is there to be scared about? Wait, do you think do
you think that uh well, I mean, obviously if they saw something
else they didn't like that wasn't related would be a concern.
Or that you have enough pull to get me like banned from this
place? Although I don't think that's the case, but if you had
enough pull to get me banned without it being fair, that would
also be a concern. Well, they
like, of course, the cops should be able to come into your home.
Of course the cops should be able to What do you have something
to hide? Are you committing a crime? Why shouldn't the cops just
be able to enter your house at any time? Oh, we're comparing
kick to the cops. Good job. Okay. Well, kick is not at danger
of causing you actual bodily vi.
So, oh my god. Secondly, the first part you circle arguments.
So, yes, kick is where I make my money. If I'm not on kick, how
am I making money? If I'm not If I'm not on kick, how am I making
money? It's not the same as having a gun shoved in your face,
you stupid [__] Where? Who said that? Who said that?
You just compared it to the police. That's what you were going
into your house. Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Well, say unarmed officers.
Unarmed officers entering your house. If you're not if you're
not committing any crimes, what what do you have to fear from
the cops going into your house? Yeah, I'd agree. I'd agree. Oh,
well, you would be completely
Well, no, because the cops have like knocked on my door before.
I don't what what you're Canadian. What is the problem? What
is the problem with like literally the cops could come in? They
could they could bring me to my place in your like bathroom like
again. Oh my god. Yeah. If you've got nothing to be I'm sorry.
Do you have a lot of like hiding in your house? You scared of
Kelly not have the ability to think abstractly? She does not.
It does not. Yes. I think No, I think that's what the police
are for. And often they're not like Yeah. You just said they're
unarmed policemen. No, I'm not scared of unarmed policemen coming
to my house. Okay. Why the would I? Okay. Worbling, thank you
for the anniversary announcement, by the way. I seem to have
lost it. What did you say? Wait, it went away. I've lost it.
What's this about? Entering your home after 5 months of subbing.
Thank you for the message, Warbling. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. What just enter your home either with a message that says
I appreciate bizarre comparisons because otherwise you're just
making the argument that if someone does something wrong to you,
you shouldn't do anything. If you believe that someone does something
wrong you Sorry, what did I make up? That I was deaming you,
I believe. Right. Oh, you're going to say that I wrote your I
wrote an assumption of your age on the screen. That's what it
was that upset you. Okay, that's what it was. That is just me
talking. Okay.
All right. Uh Portoeller just let me know. Vagina. Thank you,
Portoeller, for using your 12 month subscription anniversary
to save Vagina. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. What is Dan
working on today? Maybe he wants to tell us. I would guess just
the same thing he's been working on for the past couple days,
but he might want to jump in and tell. I'm not sure. Uh, his
Wait, his sound isn't coming through. Oh, no. I I see his face
turning on, but I don't hear the sound. Heckman, ladies and gentlemen,
is that the same as saying, "Oh, I want to him and make sure
he loses money."
I don't think they're the same. Whatever. We're going to use
no invidia broadcast now. Hope you're happy. Wow. Okay. GG. Well,
hold on. It shouldn't be Nvidia broadcast cuz your your thing
was coming through. Give us a number to never get Kelly back.
Uh, I don't really ban people based on numbers. I was I was asking
how old is Kelly? Cuz you're saying like how old she not saying
she doesn't want to she doesn't want to give that away. Yeah,
I've already had like a month's worth I had a month of doc threats
as you are aware. Okay, so yeah, I don't give out personal information
because that makes finding me easier and I would prefer that
not to happen if that's all right. Are you actually older than
I am? And did you not just listen to a word I just said? Sure,
I'm older than you. I'm 48.
Why not? God, the fact that people do not respect this careful.
How's that for a nuke, buddy? That sucks. Guys, honestly, I was
like, "This guy totally won and then he dropped that." What the
He's so gay. I like couldn't handle
Why? Why would you do that? You could have just said Epstein
and it's like not even creative, but it's just fine.
One second. Destiny's Destiny's crashing out again. Also, why
is he typoing so much today? That's bothering me more than anything
else. I don't know. Why is he he's not watching this stream,
is he? Is he drunk? just like rolling his face along the keyboard.
Good. Like he lays out the points fine. Why is he just such a
que? Yeah, he's just cringe. It's hard to get through. Even like
the understanding of calling someone a bad person. I wouldn't
even call Stephen like a bad person. I would call him like an
abuser and a predator, but I think person is like very elementary
or young person with the intention of assaulting them or inducing
them to commit an illegal act. Guess what, Destiny? Nowhere in
that definition does it say that grooming has to be a slow process.
It doesn't have to be a process. There isn't like there isn't
like a time limit to it. If you're just not about being a timer,
but like it's not about being a time limit. It's it's about the
fact that there has to be a process there. If you just send like
let's say someone sends an unlisted. So if the kid gives it up
too quickly, it's not grooming. That's a horrible thing to say.
It's amazing. You mean the legal definition of a thing that's
being discussed that's illegal? Of course it does. Okay. See,
right? That's just what you got to do. Thank you. Thank you.
That's how you do it quickly. You cut the head off instead of
making me listen to you yap to them for 45 minutes of call. Yeah.
If you think you were correct and that's why I said okay, that's
not you. It doesn't matter how I won. I won. See
the real analysis, but I still haven't finished my plug for the
Patreon. There's multiple tiers, guys. There's the supporter
tier if you don't like getting if you don't like getting things
put in sub mode in chat in general chat, okay? Like I'm about
to right now, actually, for the next little bit while we watch
some stuff. I'm I'm actually taking Just give me a second. I'll
go find it. Darius, don't switch that screen. Okay, we're going
to show really quickly. We got just a very important message.
Where is it, Kelly? Where'd it go? Hold on. I'll find it. I do
not know what message. I just got cut off. That's That [__]
sucks. Oh, if you if you're a brand new woman joining the DG
universe, okay, we have one important warning for you. Just get
yourself ready. Prepare yourself. There's going to be a little
There's a little God, that was a lot of buildup for like a one
and a half second meme. There's going to be a little I'm sorry.
This I I'm sorry. Welcome all new women to GG. This is what you
need to expect. Okay. Darius IRL leading the train. Oof. Just
a little. Well, this might be underelling it a little bit with
this trash content. Cozer definitely doesn't recognize this clip
at all. He doesn't know where it's from. He wouldn't know. Uh,
we also have another version. Hold on. Where's the other version?
There's another version here. Just in case you didn't like that
one. We do have one other version. There's going to be a little
What else? Hold on. Nurra made another one. Nurak made a quick
little meme. Listen, this is this is the concept of a meme. Okay,
the guy the people outside the courthouse. Okay, let him rap.
DGL
DG for life. Okay, just let let him rap. We need him. We need
him. Trump fascism's at our door. We need him. Just let him.
Uh, by the way, it's not real rape. He just He just doesn't care
about consent. Are we really winning? Um, all of those people
will go on my stream. Really was literally on this stream. Snow
thief. Snowy. Really was literally on this stream specifically
explicitly. Uh, oh yeah. So, all the tiers. So, $5 supporter
tier. Listen, if you don't like the white genocides in chat,
okay? If you're not a fan of getting silenced when we're in subscriber
only mode in the general chat, then I suggest that you look at
the $5 tier, okay? Uh also provides you soundboard options in
the voice chats. All right. Priority access to Colins as well.
You want to upgrade that. The next tier that where you get meaningful
benefits is Oiler chats. Okay. And in the Oilers tier, you get
exclusive pre-stream, postream content. depending on how we're
pretty early tonight. Uh we could possibly do like a free or
not a free, we could possibly do an oiler call tonight. I'd actually
be excited to do that. Maybe I'll think about ending around eight
hours tonight and getting off to do an oiler call. Hey, what
is this? Hold on. Hold on. Somebody just linked me a clip and
said, "You'd think Darius would be able to sympathize with other
people." Uh yeah, oiler tier. JWP tier. I'm not going to show
the Patreon anymore because I've interrupted it multiple times,
but possibly an Oiler call tonight. Possibly. So, let's go. What
is this? Now I'm getting my penis shown to other men. What the
Oh, I'm guessing somebody was sharing his nudes or something
and people are just saying, "Oh, you think Darius would, you
know, understand or respect or have empathy for the victims of
this kind of like pseudo revenge and this this sending of your
nudes without consent, right?" I think so. I think this is probably
a fair thing. Probably Zena. I have no idea. Bad clip needs to
be longer. I I also I think it's meant to be funny. It's not
meant to be sad, but it is a little sad. There's like Darius's
total lack of consideration for his former friends and people
he supported in the past. It's also part of the cope that Zena
was saying I assume that is similar for Darius's because this
stuff has happened to both of them and possibly by each other
as well in some respects. That is why they don't think it's a
big deal. And there is like two ways of dealing with something
when something bad is done to you and one of them is to pretend
it's not that bad. So this is like they're in denial. So they
don't want to have to like face the reality of how some of the
things people have done to them probably. So I think Zena went
out of her way to say like you can't groom a person. You can't
like groom an like anybody beyond like a kid and was talking
Oh, the Ryan Beard video is out too. Maybe we'll watch that.
Actually, we'll go to the Ryan Beard video next. Okay. Zena was
saying that yeah, essentially like she could and I'm like, Zena,
you converted to Islam. You hooked Sneo up with like threesomes
when you when you were like losing your mind. You gave him all
the drugs he could get. Like you you literally did everything
everything for this guy. Why are you pretending that you weren't
groomed? Oh, also you're an Only Fans model and suddenly you
tried to become like a trad wife after joining Fresh and Fit.
Why are you pretending an adult can't be groomed? You You literally
have been groomed multiple times into multiple different roles.
Why are you pretending otherwise? I don't know if I like grooming
in all respect, but I would say it was manipulative and I think
she is manipulative. Sure. Manipulated definitely. Um, what about
Collins? Depending on the Collins, we can um we can pause through
this video. I don't know how much of this video is going to have
new information, right? Join the waiting room. Somebody. But
yeah, we we would need call-ins for people to call in. You know,
we need people to call in. They want to be here. Join the Discord.
Join the waiting room. Uh yeah, if you guys want to hop in. When
are we having our Dan showdown? I don't know, Kingler. I probably
I maybe have that off stream. It's probably just not something
I want to argue. Dy, we need Diddy Jeers to call in, not Anti-Destiny.
Okay, in the chat. Somebody posted the chat. God damn it. Okay.
Also, where's my Ryan Beard video?
Meet your Destiny. Instead of focusing on the facts, this Ryan
Beard guy is not a fan of Destiny. I know that. Jesus was late
in. All right. All right. We're going to check this out. This
is his big uh his big brand new
What other chat would they be to post a Discord link in? You
stupid. So, how's nobody posted the Discord link? Is anyone People
not have the Discord link? Exclamation point Discord in the chat.
By the way, the Discord link is so easy. It's discord.gg/jstlk.
My name is literally on the screen. It's discord.gg/
and you type the name that's on the screen. How hard is that?
That can't possibly be hard. Be rude at the new people. Okay.
No need to scream. Oh, is this guy also a Yeah, I could see him
being a Oh, maybe I'm not going to like this video. I hope he
doesn't make a lot of points. Imagine if Ryan calls Destiny subhuman
in this video. That would be bases. Um, was that what he got
mad at Destiny for? was calling people subhuman. Was that what
it was? Why are you yelling? I don't know. I don't listen. I
can't read. Sad. Yell equals funny. Okay. I've watched some Kais
and yell equals funny. Okay. Yell equals. When I do it, then
it's funny. Yaps a lot. Maybe you want to 2x. Okay. All right.
Maybe, maybe, maybe. I don't wish to bring anybody any more harassment
than they've already received. But you have to understand that
at this point, I'm kind of being pushed into playing my entire
hand. There will be no vague allegations today. There will be
no mentions of nukes, only mushroom clouds. Oh wow, only mushroom
clouds. Jesus cow, thank you for the 11 months. I think you're
currently like timed out for a week or possibly. Oh no. Oh wait,
wait, wait, hold on. Jesus cow. I think the guy who just subbed
is like timed out. I need to actually check now because I'm curious.
He might be timed out or banned. Oh, five days left on his timeout.
Well, I think you deserved it. I remember it was pretty unhinged.
It was pretty unhinged, brother. Man, whatever you said. I went
with the title Keles a Oh, this is a guy who's doing it's a content
nuke on Destiny. Okay, Destiny content nuke. I would assume there'd
be a lot of Bob Seven points in here. I'm guessing case study
on internet terrorism and mass media manipulation. This is going
to be a cataloging the past year demonstration of what happens
when communities fail to hold their own members responsible and
what comes of the belief that there are no bad tactics, only
bad targets. There's going to be a careful documentation lies.
I'm not running around screen sharing people's nudes. I'm not
having secret recordings in my apartment, bro. I I don't talk
about anything all the time ever. Are we serious? Did he have
the Did he have the uh Did he have the books smarts clip of like
I really hope something of mine leaks someday so you can see
how good I am behind the scenes? Cuz that one's a banger. Okay,
you need that one. You need that one. Did he have it? I didn't
see it. Nope, he didn't have it. Let's watch it again. Manipulation.
This is going to be a cataloging of the past year demonstration
of what happens when communities fail to hold their own members
responsible and what comes of the no tactics only bad target.
about Destiny is that he is very good at choosing which people
to be his enemies. Ryan Beard is one of those people. He's Well,
so maybe he is I more than him being I think I think it was that
he was soy. He was really soy. But the problem with Destiny's
current situation is that nobody deals better with somebody who
is refusing to take accountability for a situation that they've
put themselves in that and and they're like the morally black
character there. Nobody has dealt more with that than Destiny.
And nobody has more eloquently described the the patterns of
behavior of people like that than Destiny. So to deconstruct
Destiny's current behavior, all you have to do is play Destiny
clips. It's based. Okay. Did you ever you just have to play them?
Did you ever show this image on the SC stream? Oh, what? Just
waiting waiting waiting waiting waiting for Kelly Kelly Jean.
This one we're going over his going over his tweets. Is this
the child tweet? It's just the child tweet. I'm not doing the
child tweet. Okay, he's going to do it. He's going to Sorry about
it. But show the edits. Oh, fine. I did the edits. That would
be Destiny is a woman's name. Okay. Sorry. I want to apologize
for my last tweet. You should treat every single woman you come
across like a child who's incapable of voicing an opinion about
literally anything. Ideally, you would bring her dad along to
every so he can guide her through the process. Steven Benelli
the first can fix this. Are you supposed to read the other tweet
first? Oh, if you are noticing your tapes are repeatedly leaked
and you don't do or anything, you probably shouldn't have the
emotional you probably don't have sorry the emotional maturity
to engage in. You should just grab a caretaker or something and
stick to furry sorry. Yeah. Okay. He understands his own words.
So maybe he listen to himself. Sure. This is Kelly Jean's edit
right here, I think. So, okay. Let's watch this. Let's watch
this banger from Ryan Beard one more time. Okay. This is going
to be a careful documentation of lies. I'm not running around
screen sharing people's nudes. I'm not having secret recordings
be in my apartment, bro. I I don't talk about anything all the
time ever. Are we serious? So then the question stands, did you
southern
scams? Every single person on the internet that is pushing NFTTS
is just trying to find a bigger sucker. You can basically God,
what a dumb point to add to a video. What a dumb point to add
to a video. And you can NFT that you can get. Oh, this is going
to be cringe. You know what? If you buy it, I can go right up
here and click autograph and I can whatever the the comments
the comments that is sharing nudes comments. Those will be enough
this one. Okay, it's bad but NF1 so hard. Oh, also BPF1 BPF1
Mike from PA1 Hassan one Destiny is okay Destiny is and left
in an alley now. Absolutely paused up. Okay, paused up on multiple
counts. It's over. Okay, threats. Unfortunately, we've now discovered
that that might be something he's into, but nevertheless, that's
where it is. Bullying. They've got the uh they've got like I
didn't know what it was like exactly what he said to Anna. So,
they put it on screen. I can go right up here and I can sign
whatever NFT you want me to sign. Okay. Oh, you might have missed
these. I think we had these up. Tell Anna if she leaks my I might
have some pics to share. Damn. He did. He did say that. Yeah.
Dumb it. Yeah. How old or recent is this? This video is like
It's currently premiering. This video is literally currently
premiering. Can we watch a completely different video? No, you
can not talk for about 30 minutes. Why would you ask me? Can
we watch a completely different video? We just started a video.
Co, go away. I'm sorry. Go away. I will lose it. Doxing. I literally
just doxed that girl. The one that threatened to throw egg on
me like a week or two ago. I mean, the President Sunday stuff
is more egregious from him. Far more egregious. Okay. And then
obviously, you know, you got Dan as well, which I'm starting
to consider them like a pair more and more. Doxing Hassan's editor,
doxing that random guy who said he was going to upload anything
else to Spotify. Doxing the Odashara guy who now is inexplicably
drinking the [__] of both of them. Um,
what what the [__] Well, the Odashara guys really
and basically puts things about his identity all over the internet.
So, probably a little less so on him than the other two. Yeah,
leave alone the threats of doxing that have come out of Dan.
So, uh, doxing in what way? Uh, so the so the the lamb guy, the
comrade lamb guy, his names weren't known, like his full name
wasn't known. Dan doxed that. He said it on my stream. It's reallyed
up. And then Dan called the Dan found out the guy who said he
was the guy emailed Dan taunting him. So, I'll give him that.
But then he called he found this guy's name, called his work,
and then like asked to talk to his boss, which is like Jesus
Christ. I'm just baffled that this guy cried because I said that
the girl he was with looked like she was out of a dumpster when
he does and says all this stuff. Oh, right. Also, Dan posted
pictures of his friends kissing his miners. He also did that,
which was uh pretty rough. What? He did what? Um I mean, I can
go find the screenshots. The screenshots are somewhere. I I they're
somewhere. He literally did it in my Discord. He like talked
He like talked openly about doing it in my Discord. It was kind
of wild. Shut the up, Kelly. You dumpster. I just am the dumpster.
That's true. I guess so. Jesus Christ. I I don't give a about
like doxing and an utter lack of accountability. Molina recently
confirmed that the tapes leaked by Destiny former Jesus Christ
girl were shared by Destiny without Good one. Good one. Nice.
She has no legal recourse. Can I got a I've got a whole bunch
of super chats for you. Wick ready. Okay. Over the years. Jesus
Christ, dude. Absolutely obliterated. Absolutely obliterated.
Unequivocal.
Never to be equaled. Wick W right there. Okay, that was uh that
was brutal to watch. That was brutal to watch. I've worried about
the types of tactics endorsed by progressive communities. The
uncomfortable distorting of narratives. Honestly, I'm pro genocide.
It sounds really shitty, but like I think that Israel should
just draw it about where it is now. And I don't care about Israel
Why the would you Why the would you delete a video in Destiny?
Why would you dilute? Destiny has actual crimes that he's being
held to account for and you do an Israel Palestine clip. Are
you out of your mind? That's really
Well, I mean, it's a content nuke. It's not like a documentary
he's done. Well, why not? Isn't there a bunch of other videos
going over the content specifically? Like, if he wants to do
going over all the other not There's not a lot of videos going
to make fun of everything for Destiny. Why not? It's just it's
just funny cuz it's like it's literally shifting facts. Let's
say there's a person that's like 30 years old and tries to like
randomly like 14y olds and 15y olds. That wouldn't be I don't
think that would be considered grooming. The general inability
to hold themselves. That's a bad clip, too. I don't know if I'm
going to keep watching this video. This kind of dog to a decent
standard of behavioral conduct. Okay. All right. I Sorry, that
clip is chimps. Okay. All right. You know what, Kelly? I'm going
to try to be less of a grumpy Gus. Okay. I'm just going to enjoy
Destiny, you know, saying things and then like not basically
holding to them. But I don't know. It's just I feel like some
of them are just not going to be valid. I probably have to call
that out. And I don't like I don't like watching a video where
I'm forced to defend Destiny. That that okay, then don't keep
your mouth shut, dummy. The rioting needs to stop. And if that
means like white redneck militia dudes out there mowing down
protesters that think that they could torch buildings at 10 p.m.
then at this point they have my blessing because holy [__]
This is the tale of an internet bully given far too much power.
Did you guys know that if a breaks up with you and you send your
nudes to everybody? Even that's wrong guys. On a mission to seek
fame and fortune. What's that look like revenue wise? I think
last time you said it was like 50k a month. It's probably a little
bit higher than that now. Yeah. By building a career through
vicious conflict. Actually yourself.
We've allowed ourselves to gaze into the abyss for far too long.
Destiny is the result. On January 8th, 2025, the streamer Destiny's
ex-wife Molina accused him of sharing videos of her without her
consent to a 19-year-old young woman over Discord. Something
I can't like I'm not going to go into. There's no way he used
the code cave clips. Like I cave one, I guess. Jesus Christ.
Tell anything, but there's plenty of people that's wondering
this, but I feel like this should be obvious. Nothing has happened
with consent with anyone. Not me and not anyone else. Like there's
been no consent on January 21st.
Yeah. Very clear. By the way, by the way, covered those covered
those clips on stream. I actually went and found the VOD for
that stream and watched the VOD just to make sure I knew exactly
what I was seeing. 25. One of Destiny's close friends named Pixie
accused him of also sharing videos of her without her consent.
Destiny later revealed that this 19-year-old he had sent these
videos to had allegedly been hacked, leading to these videos
being leaked on the internet. I think a friend of mine's account
from uh that I talked to like three or four years ago ended up
getting compromised and uh you know sometimes you just got to
roll with it is what I don't think it was all I think it was
like two years before this, right? So that's already like a distortion.
But it what do you want me to say? What do you want me to say?
Okay. Later on that same day of January 21st, one of Destiny's
previous close friends named Cherry not only accused Destiny
of sharing a recording of them having without her consent, but
also of recording her without her knowledge. Destiny has since
admitted to sharing these tapes of Pixie and Molina without their
consent. Cher's allegation is still just an allegation, but she
has recently filed a police report against Destiny. This is the
story of Steven. Also, Destiny has never made a statement about
his his innocence in this. He's never come out and said, "This
is wrong. They're lying about me." Right? If if there's something
misrepresented,
all he has to do is a really simple thing of, "I've never recorded
a encounter without consent." That's all he's got to do. That's
all he's got to say. That's all he has to say. Why won't he come
out and say that? Why won't he say it? What What is the harm?
How is he going to be You just make that statement on its own.
I've never recorded a encounter, audio or video, without consent.
It's so easy. It's so easy. Benel II, a man given far too much
power and the ways he has abused this power for his own personal
gain. Hi. So, this video has been a long time coming. I've been
slowly collecting evidence about this man Destiny here for about
3 years now, and I don't know about you, but I think it's finally
time to take this down. Destiny is widely hated by a variety
of communities across the internet for a variety of reasons.
But no matter how hated Destiny became, he always had a strong
army of sickopants that would defend him no matter what he did.
However, recently almost all of his orbiters have abandoned him.
Orbiters are what he calls his friends who stream with him. I
just want to point out abandoned him. Orbiters. Who's on the
Who's on the orbiter list? Okay. Who's on the orbiter list? We've
got these are Destiny's orbiters right here. These five people.
Okay. Why is love Darius consent
Conquistador. You know the word concistador, right? Why is it
Why is it there? Is that I think she was mocking him. She's mocking
him for some reason or another. I can't remember why. Yeah, it
was pretty funny. Or what he calls his friends who stream with
him. Basically, the implication is that Destiny is this massive
planet, and all of his friends are these little planets that
orbit around him. This has created an ecosystem where most of
Destiny's friends rely on Destiny's success for fame and money.
And because most of these people rely on Destiny for money, they've
done a remarkably good job at sweeping allegations against Destiny
under the rug for years. However, these recent allegations against
Destiny have been so egregious that the majority of even his
most loyal orbiters have decided to leave his orbit. Now, barely
anyone is still defending Destiny. One person who is still defending
Destiny is Uhoh. Dan,
don't show the dead clips.
Don't show the dead clips. Gain
from Fresh and Fit, who recently decided to shame Destiny's victims.
Before I go, I feel extremely violated with how so many people
saw me non-conceptually in a vulnerable position. I feel like
people are always going to use this as proof that I slept my
way to whatever achievement I garner. I feel like it's evidence
that everything would be better with me gone. So, here's the
thing about this statement. Pixie had just found out about this
stuff, right? Pixie was basically a week into processing this.
Okay. Oh, free the white names. Sure. I'll free the white names.
This is like Pixie was just like a week Oh, no. Sorry, not a
week. This would be two
probably two and a half weeks into processing this. But like
she's still like up about it, right? And trust me, I think probably
equally to her videos being out there. She doesn't want to say
it, but she probably trusted Destiny completely, right? She was
doing content with Destiny. She probably thought this person
was a really important person who cared about her. That's probably
how she viewed this person. The the betrayal has to do almost
as much damage as actually having the non-consensual videos leaked.
Like that has to you up, right? So she's going to say like, "Oh,
this stuff." But like I'm sure she's got a lot of thoughts in
her head where she hasn't totally like figured everything out
yet, right? I taking these as like legitimately like um you know
ironclad statements of fact. It's like dude off. It's so it's
so stupid. Well, I hate to be the bearer of bad news, Prixie,
but uh you did your way to the top. You know, you got to call
a spade a spade here. Even though Myin is an absolutely insane
anti-Semitic woman hater who stands for everything that Destiny
claims to be against, Destiny says that he has more respect for
Myin than for anyone else on the internet. In all of my years,
God, this feels so all my years doing cuz Myin So this is really
easy. It's because Myron will go to places where every I'm just
saying this this one this one I agree with this one. I I agree
with the sentiment here. I don't agree that Myin's like respect.
I would respect Myra more than anybody else in the internet.
Okay. I think that's wrong. But I I understand the sentence.
I'm going to Listen, Kelly, if I'm if I'm defending him, you
tell me to shut up. Okay. Can you Can you give me one of these?
Shut up. I'm not going to I'm not going to do it. I'm going to
I'm basically I'm here. You
I'm telling you to give me one of those. Okay. If I'm defending,
I don't want to defend. So, you know what? This is basically
a Kelly react segment. Okay. Right now, this is like a Kelly
react. Myin Myin is just successful Darius. like they're both
meaningless when it comes to any type of morality opinion. Thank
you. I have more respect for her than any other individual. By
the way, this statement, I don't I don't care. I should reevaluate
even this statement. Okay. Why was he saying about this about
the guy who was like this guy is basically like if Nick Fentes
is like the Kobe Bryant of anti-semitism, then Myron Gaines is
like the Shaquille O'Neal of anti-semitism. And watching them
like dunk on on that like a couple of those Rumble streams, those
guys knew more ancient world lore. They're like, "Yeah, let's
let's roll through, you know, 1400 to 1500 central Europe. Let's
talk about what the Jews were doing there." It's like, "What
what the how are you how are you like how'd you track these people?
You guys have like PhDs in anti-semitism, right?" So, it's a
little weird to come out and say you respect him because of like
how he can defend you. It's a little weird to just say you respect
him. He's an anti-semit. So, he was he was really weird to Lily
Pichu, but I guess Lily Pichu doesn't matter anymore cuz she's
also gone cuz he's a freak, I guess. And Yeah. And by the way,
he's saying that he respect that anti-semite to his podcast co-host
who's days or weeks away from launching a jihad against Twitch
for what? What was that ch uh Kelly? Kelly, what did what did
they launch the crusade against Twitch for? I forget. Yeah. Okay.
I'm trying to work with you, Kelly. We're trying to play off
of each other. Kelly, help me. What did they launch that crusade
for? You figure out whatever
for
[__] was. It was anti-semitism. Anti-semitism was
the answer. in Israel. Oh, who cares? Said they weren't even
banned. Apparently the amount was signups for like 5 minutes.
I tried to work with Kelly there. That was [__] up.
She just who cares about that?
Feel so All my years doing content, I have more respect for her
than any other individual. Apparently, the amount of respect
that Destiny has for you as a person is dependent on how willing
you are to suck up to him. He is the only person that I have
seen that will consistently go into areas where there's so much
like laughing and jokes and fun times to be had right here if
he were on me. But he doesn't. He won't do it. I have some level
of empathy for Destiny's orbiters. I suppose that does mean a
lot if you think about it, right? That he's like, you know, the
anti-semitism. I can excuse the anti-semitism, okay? So long
as you don't [__] on me with two black guys. The
anti-semitism, I ain't let that go. This guy didn't [__]
on me. Thank God. because it is difficult to be stuck in a position
where you financially rely on someone who is not a great person.
But I have basically no empathy for Destiny because I believe
that Destiny is a massive piece of and I will hopefully demonstrate
why I feel that way in this video. In this video, I will go through
nearly every harmful action that Destiny has committed over the
years and then allow you Yeah, I just uploaded it. It's the new
one. Yeah, there you go. Boom. you to come to your own conclusions
on whether or not you think this is a person who deserves anyone's
admiration or respect. Before we jump into Destiny's actions
from across the years, I think I should take a little bit of
time to dispel some possible well poisoning that Destiny or his
community DGG could try to attack me with. The first accusation
they might throw at me is that I'm obsessed with Destiny. This
is an accusation they like to throw at anyone who criticizes
Destiny. Personally, I don't think it makes me obsessed with
Destiny. Wow. I wonder I wonder who else does that. I wonder
who else might say that critics of him are obsessed
that I've been researching him for the purpose of criticizing
him. None of Destiny's fans accused me of being obsessed with
Sneo when I did a deep dive into Sneo's harmful actions because
they don't like Sneo. But they probably will accuse me of being
obsessed with Destiny because Destiny is their daddy. This is
the first video I've ever made about Destiny and it'll probably
be about an hour and a half long. Compare that to the probably
hundreds of hours that Destiny has spent on his stream criticizing
Hassan. And I have nothing against
One second. Destiny's Destiny's crashing out again. Also, why
is he typoing so much today? That's bothering me more than anything
else. I don't know. Why is he he's not watching this stream,
is he? Is he drunk? Like, why is he typoing every message? I
don't know. I mean, he's he's intense. Kelly, he's very upset.
Just like rolling his face along the keyboard. There are tons
of vulture communities invested in this whiny [__]
Okay. This guy does content nukes. It's his thing, you dumb.
Do you think you're special? No, he is watching you. I don't
know. I don't know that he's Why would I know that he's watching
me? How How would I know that? How would I know it? Is he Is
Destiny Okay, if we're obsessed with Destiny, then Destiny is
more obsessed with Destiny than anybody else. Okay, so hi Destiny.
Hey, how are you doing? It's your favorite sea hag, sea monster,
whatever. I'm getting confused with wine hag. It would just be
pretty hypocritical to accuse. Wait, who is he watching? He might
be watching Darius. Is Darius watching us? He might be watching
being obsessed with Destiny for making one hour and a half long
video about him while Destiny has talked about Hassan for hundreds
of hours. Destiny has written multiple incredibly long manifestos
criticizing creators like Vosch Keffles and Bob 7 who Destiny
believes have wronged him. I'm letting this play. I find the
label of manifesto a bit cringe. I see nothing inherently wrong
with Destiny writing manifestos to chronicle the bad behaviors
of these creators. So in the same way, I guess this will be my
manifesto against Destiny. And if you have an issue with me making
this manifesto, I hope you will stay logically consistent and
also criticize Destiny for making manifestos about Vosch Kevles
and Bob 7. If I had to predict how Destiny himself would respond
to this video, he would probably respond with something similar
to this tweet that he tweeted at me a couple years ago. You're
hopping into a bandwagon of people accusing me of being a rape
apologist because you're still upset that I bullied you off the
internet a year ago. Don't play stupid. You know exactly what
you're doing. To be honest, Destiny isn't 100% wrong here. I
am jumping onto a bandwagon of people criticizing him, but I
don't think that's an inherently bad thing to do. Destiny jumps
onto bandwagons of people criticizing Hassan all the time. When
Ethan Klein makes videos attacking Hassan, Destiny jumps onto
the bandwagon. So, when a bunch of people on the internet are
criticizing Destiny right now for sharing women's tapes without
their consent, hell yeah, I'm going to jump onto the bandwagon
and roast the [__] out of him. With the way the internet
works, criticisms against someone are more likely to stick when
that person is actively engaged in a controversy. This is just
how the internet is. So, yes, I waited to make this video until
you were in a possibly career-ending controversy because I knew
that this would make more people listen to my criticism against
you. Do you have a problem with that? You know how the internet
works, Destiny. You I was going to say he had this content nuke
ready to go. I I think he literally just gave it away that he's
like, I had this half I had this like 80% edited before this.
Get ready to get roasted.
Bandwag. I just want to point out quickly. There's people in
DGG right now saying like to go after Chud and then somebody
else here said like we should get DG to mass report these channels.
That's kind of weird
on there. I don't think I listen the position that they're in.
I just don't think that would be a wise thing to do because I
do believe given the Dr. disrespect stuff that having like a
weird like predator scandal is enough for YouTube to look at
certain people's stuff. Okay, it's like we should all back down.
Okay, I have a YouTube channel and I'm saying back down. Everybody
stand back and stand by. They're getting into the whole reporting.
Everybody shut the up. Don't talk about reporting channels. Stop.
Okay, weirdo. Controversies all the time. But now that the shoe's
on the other foot, you're mad about it. um all the other from
all the other vultures and all the other communities that are
like coming in trying to like make drama out of this that don't
give a about any victims or any people involved which is oh look
it's another guy it's another guy who failed to message the victims
that he knew who was in the hands of a leaker he didn't message
any of them oh hello who joined I just don't know how he has
the nerve to say that it's just crazy it's our favorite little
guy what's up you see your feature in this video n oh you were
you were literally featured Hold licate
content creat Oh, spoilers. Spoilers. He's watching the ABA video.
He's back to the beginning. Where does he explain this concept?
Right here. Okay. Have abandoned orbiters.
All of his friends who stream with him. Basically, the implication
is that destiny is I just I'm just glad you could be here for
us along for the ride. All of his orbiters have abandoned him.
Orbiters are what he calls. Okay, let's
Let's go. That's the goal of Ryan Beard on Noven. Something's
something's got to be done about this guy. How everybody is going
to now
this guy down. I'm coming out as non-binary video. Pull pull
that. I'm not. But listen, we're on a content nuke. He's doing
a content nuke. He basically said he's like, "I had this basically
done before any of this happened and I'm so glad it happened
so people actually listen to it now." Just straight up like,
"Yeah, you I was ready to you over the second some dropped."
which is hilarious. The majority of people don't give a [__]
about any of that. I don't care about that. Another accusation
that Destiny's fans like to throw at people who criticize him
is that they're just doing it for money. Oh, you mean like how
Destiny has made money from covering other people's controversies
for years? What a dog argument. Yes, I'm going to make money
from this video because this is my job, just like Destiny makes
money from criticizing other people because that's his job. But
this video isn't just about making money for me. I genuinely
care about raising awareness for the shitty stuff that Destiny
has done. If you're going to write a manifesto Oh, damn. Oh,
he should be like half of the money I make from this video. Put
the link in, too. That's cool.
Yeah, it's the first first one in the give and go. Hey, I got
on board. Okay, I decided we're we're breaking the conditioning.
Okay, Kelly, today we're breaking the conditioning. We're doing
video. He linked to all of the he linked to all the Twitters
to everybody as well. That's nice. I don't know why he put Lab's
Twitter in there. Uh, I don't know either. Um, but cool, cool,
cool, cool. I mean, technically, Lab has gotten a lot one victim.
Lab has gotten a lot of harassment from a lot of people online.
So, about raising awareness for the stuff that Destiny has done.
If you're going to write a manifesto about Keeles and say that
she needs to be held responsible for her actions, a demonstration
of what happens when communities fail to hold their own members
responsible. I'm going to do the same thing to you. Now, let's
focus in on this part of the tweet. You're still upset that I
bullied you off the internet a year ago. You know what, Destiny?
You are not totally wrong. Being bullied off the internet didn't
feel particularly good because people don't tend to enjoy being
Oh, wait, wait. Are you saying that this guy? What did you He
called him fat and then he posted a bunch of pictures of him
really fat. Why is Destiny criticizing people for being fat?
We've all seen the beach picture. Okay. Yeah, true, true, true.
But I'm just I'm just saying uh it's really funny that like this
guy's basically like, "Yeah, you did bully me bully me off the
internet." And Destiny's now realizing, "Oh, wait. If I'm a costic
prick to like everybody around me, eventually people are not
going to like me very much and then they're going to pray on
my downfall and they're like the whole thing." He's like, "I
can't believe people are they're vultures. They're all around
me just waiting on my down." It's like, yeah, you you are a complete
to like tons and tons and tons of people. Of course, they're
waiting on your downfall. You were a total prick. Of course.
Jeez. Jesus. bullied Destiny and his community. I'm going to
back it up so I can watch. I'm going to let I'm going to let
him deliver that line again cuz he looks really happy that he
can do that. And on this part of the tweet, you're still upset
that I bullied you off the internet a year ago. You know what,
Destiny, you are not totally wrong. Being bullied off the internet
didn't feel particularly good because people don't tend to enjoy
being bullied. Destiny and his community definitely have bullied
me over the years, but I don't really care to relitigate my personal
beef with Destiny. Destiny and his community weren't very nice
to the suitwearing fatty. Who gives a? But Destiny, you don't
get to criticize Keles for being a bully. Internet bullying.
And then turn around and take pride in the fact that you're a
bully. That is called hypocrisy. The fact that Destiny and his
community have bullied me in the past probably is a factor in
why I chose to make this video. And I would argue that the treatment
that Destiny received from creators like Vos and Keles is one
of the reasons he made manifestos against them. As much as I
might want to, I am a human being and I can't fully separate
myself from my own personal biases. And the fact that I have
been bullied by Destiny and his community in the past does probably
make me somewhat biased against them. If you feel like my personal
bias against Destiny means that I'm not the right person to make
this video, I respect that opinion and I encourage you to go
watch a different YouTube video. But in this video, I'm going
to try my absolute best to be as unbiased as possible and stick
Oh, Queen, did you see that Destiny was losing his [__]
about the Chud Logic thumbnails and titles? No. Oh, you didn't
get a Wait, did you not review any of his blogs today or have
you been mostly on other stuff? I looked at his logs, but I didn't
see the Chud ones. Yeah, he was freaking out about the thumbnails.
Apparently, Kelly was saying that DJers were saying like, "We
need to go report Chudlogic's YouTube channel." And so, yeah.
What was Well, one brought up one brought up Chud. The other
one just said, "Let's report like these channels and these channels."
Weird, baby. Uh, I think it was just Let me see here. It's the
thing. Hold on. There's like so many. Jesus Christ.
I can't find it now. Where are my quotes here? Hold on. I'm I'm
finding it. Stick to the facts as much as possible. I am gonna
try my best to not view Destiny in bad faith because I think
even if you view him in good faith, he's still a piece of I do
feel like one of Destiny's tactics from across the years is Okay,
I found it. We'll we'll back it up. We'll we'll keep on Ryan
Beard. But desperate response to his friend, Wait, hold on. Oh,
it's just white squares. Okay, I think I said this was this could
be raiding. Desperate response to raiding his friend. Okay, question
marks question mark. What? And then there's there's some other
[__] about Cha in here somewhere, I think. But, uh,
he tried to he tried to do this whole thing, everyone should
get DK thumbnails in solidarity with Chud. Not a terrible idea.
He did this whole thing about he's like, "These people are all
engaging in the argument of hypocrisy fallacy." It's like, "Bro,
nobody wants a fat personal traitor. Shut the up." Yeah. Argument
from hypocrisy is a fallacy. Someone could theoretically argue
a thing is bad while still doing the thing itself, the bad thing
itself. It doesn't impact the argument. Example, a doctor who
smokes still saying smoking is bad for you. It's like, okay,
nobody wants a fat personal trainer, bro. Ain't nobody want that.
Didn't he like ban like talking about logical fallacies a while
back because he just hated it so much when people would do it
all the time? He just gave so many people way more fuel to to
just mock him for. It's like I think he he thinks he's in like
a battle. He thinks he's like a Yagami light, right? That's what
he thinks. I'm always going to say it that way cuz everybody
flips it. All right. He thinks he's Yagami Light, but literally
everybody's just sitting here and pointing and laughing at what
what like a disgusting freak he is, right? Like everybody thought
you were this big badass debater. You're actually just a disgusting
freak who sends of his friends to other people he doesn't know
and has never talked to. You know what I'm saying? Like that's
that's it. That's what it is. A weird gay creepy freak. There
you go. Oh god.
There you go. There there it is. Gay.
Well, sometimes sometimes you got to be accurate, you know. Sometimes
you got to be a little I can't get British people to behave.
Got to always use the gay. Okay. Sometimes. Sometimes. Those
are the words of infamous Destiny Orbiter Quimman. Okay. Is to
be Destiny's friend. I know I'm better than anyone. Good friend.
You do. Well, technically technically. Okay. Incredibly mean
to anyone he has a conflict with. So when that person eventually
decides to make a video criticizing him, he can just write that
person off as obsessive and just mad because he bullied them.
As a spo, I'd appreciate if you address some of the points made
in the Britney video. She seemed to be pretty fair, especially
in her conclusions. I don't have time to address every deranged,
obsessive video that's made about me. I still haven't watched
a Britney video. Just add this tactic to the long list of tactics
that Destiny and his community use to deflect criticism from
themselves. The last criticism that Destiny and his community
might make against this video is that I'm bringing up a bunch
of old news that Destiny has already addressed. While that might
be the case for some of the things I talk about in this video,
this video is not being made for Destiny's community. I'm making
this video for the broader internet, and the majority of the
broader internet doesn't know about all of these past controversies
that you might consider old news. Look, he's talking to me. I
didn't like that. Uh I didn't like that he was going back. He
went to like Israel Palestine stuff early in the video and I'm
like I wish he'd just focus on it was an intro.
You miss it was an in. He's addressing me and saying hey this
is videos for the broader internet and then he talked about how
he's been like planning this for a year or two and I was like
you know what based let him have his dubstep intro. I said you
know what based he's been planning this for like a year or two
years. It's like that's awesome. Contrary to what you guys might
believe the entire world does not orbit around Destiny. If Destiny
is going to be interviewing potential presidential candidates
like Maryanne Williamson, then I think the broader political
community deserves to know about Destiny's past actions. Destiny
has said before that he has nothing to hide and people can't
expose him for anything that he's done in the past because he's
open about everything he's done in his life. When someone else
was trying to expose Destiny for his bad behavior, he sent these
messages to his chat. He wants to expose me, that's fine. Let
him expose. But he needs to post receipts instead of just vaguely
alluding to [__] There's literally nothing anyone
could have on me for anything because I don't do anything bad/weird.
I am the cleanest in this entire scene. The worst anyone could
ever have on me. Oh, is he reading these? He has pictures not
going to criticize. He can talk about whatever he wants, but
he should provide proof, not just baseless
All right, let's technically go bottom to top. All right, Destiny.
In this video, I will provide plenty of proof receipts to back
up everything that I It doesn't matter. He's still right. You
can read those top to bottom or bottom to top. It literally doesn't
matter at all. It's the same either way. Okay. So, I I'm being
pedantic. I don't have to be pedantic. Doesn't matter that he
read it in reverse order. It accuse you of what you said in these
messages is true, then you should have absolutely no issue with
me lying out everything that you've done over the years on the
table. Are we on the same page? Great. Honestly, I feel like
the fact that I feel the need to lay out all these preamles and
pretext and shoot down possible criticisms before they make them
should show you that Destiny's community have become masters
at deflecting criticism against them. You can call these Bert
from Mary Poppins in the way that they're masters at sweeping.
The joke here is that Let's check in on what the community accused
of being like full of fest is doing really quickly. Oh, they're
just gooning in a group gooning session. Oh, well, directed by
Darius, head fast and chief. Okay. All right. Interesting. Who
could have imagined? Who could have imagined that? That is the
Destiny community content of choice. The bird from Mary Poppins
is a chimney sweep. It's a funny joke. Okay. Off. My goal in
this video is not to push some sort of political agenda against
destiny. You can't make this up. You can't make it up. Yeah,
Darius. I think Darius is just going through his like I guess
his like spank bank on Twitter or something. Yeah, they're now
just they're doing some top 10. Let's go. Hold on. Let me check
out this top 10. Jesus.
Like you mix with laugh. I see it. Yeah. They're just They're
just straight up like Yeah. doing some ton. It's time over here,
guys. Straight black hair and eyes. It's time. Crazy eyes. I'm
moving that back over. Fast. All right. Cool. I actually think
he is a very smart dude who's one of the best debaters on the
internet and one of the best people at using logic to defend
liberal values. I debated Destiny a couple times a few years
ago and he definitely wiped the floor with me, especially in
our second debate. I have no shame in admitting that Destiny
is definitely a better debater than I am. Even if I disagree
with a lot of his opinions because I'm a leftist, I can still
recognize that he's done a great job dunking on a bunch of dumbass
conservatives. But like Destiny said in his manifesto against
Keles, I don't think we should be afraid to hold members of our
own community accountable. Demonstration of what happens when
communities fail to hold their own members responsible. And Destiny
has done a lot of up that I think he needs to be held accountable
for. Just because he's a good debater who's really good at defending
the liberal ideology, I don't think that means Killinger, you
have to jump in the Discord now. Your Discord Wait, wait, wait,
hold on. Actually, Ruben donated coming through. Spank bank.
Who is Das going to file for bankruptcy? The donation was Spank
Bank. Is Darius going to file for bankruptcy? Killinger, are
Wait, I can't tell if you're like what you're saying. Wait, what?
They are just going to full on They're just going to full on
eat to what? Prove they are eating. Oh, are you talking about
those guys? No, those guys are just gross. That's just gross
that I don't like being associated with. Don't goon. Don't Don't
be like random gooners. Find something more productive to do
with your time. Don't sit in a Discord call gooning. Sorry, what
did you say, Queenman? You're going to watch the wick panel that
happened tonight? I like I poked around a little bit. That's
the deposition. I poked around a little bit in it. There's going
to be a little Jesus. This is more compelling now that I've watched
the Darius. I poked around it a little bit. I couldn't find anything
really compelling. I'm sure Connor made absolutely arguments
again because he's on some absolutely
hilarious. He is liter He literally says, "Yeah, I will excuse
it." But it basically says he will excuse it if Destiny does
something bad, but he would attack Assam for the exact same thing.
And that's beast because that's how you win. That's what he says.
What a
It's just Vosch. The whole all these years is just Vosch like
five years. That's what I said four years ago. I've been I've
been saying that for like months now. It's literally just like
because it started with some of the stuff about lie. That's where
it's at. That is where they are at. It's just [__]
It's like just I want you all to admit that Vos was right. Just
say Vos was right. Vos absolutely actually intellectually outpaced
Destiny. If you think Destiny's correct and he's approached it
in an intelle intellectual way, Vosch outpaced him massively.
Bosch got to where Destiny is in like a couple months. Unironic.
Unironically. Hold on. Every time Destiny criticizes someone
from now on, they're going to respond like this. I don't know
if I showed this on stream. Do we show this on stream or was
this just like Destiny's community or not? I'm sure it's some
of them. But, uh, yeah, that's really the way that I feel about
it. I I think that Destiny's community should focus more about,
you know, him being on the defender list potentially, uh, instead
of me saying something that's taken out of context. That's you
guys. Every time Destiny criticizes somebody from now on, every
time there's like a DGER on Twitter, that's you. You have to
deal with this. I think you should Why don't you go focus on,
you know, recording people non-consensually, why don't you just
go focus on your your little triangle over there? Okay. Get the
[__] out of here. Get the out of here. Okay. Asmin
Gold's 100% a J talk viewer, I guess. So, I guess so. That's
been just like one of those people that's like he's like broken
clock. He's like he's right twice a day. Just ignore the other
things. I listen I don't I think it's just funny that now like
that everybody in this community thinks that's awesome. Whole
bunch of like parallel or sorry um like nearby communities will
just go yeah Destiny go focus on your go focus on your court
cases bro. Isn't it somewhat fair for Destiny to be upset about
Chub Chud's thumbnail calling him a since that isn't true and
potentially slanderous as far as I know. Not defending his other
actions but this is spreading misinformation unless I'm missing
something. I mean yeah he can be mad about it. I think it's funny
and by the way like
guy who doesn't respect consent or like the autonomy of women.
100% true. Actually, not just women. I shouldn't say women because
tech you make you could absolutely make an argument for by deception.
I don't know if I would agree with it fully, but there's actually
an argument for by deception when you record someone without
them. By deception is a thing. Yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Cuz there's
just like no way they would consent to that if if you told them.
That's why you haven't told them. At the very end of his premiere,
Ryan Beard just came into chat and said, "Jreg is highly involved
with this." I don't know why that makes me laugh, but apparently
I feel like that's I don't know what that means. I don't know
if that's serious. I think Listen, I think I'm joking. Lol. Oh.
Oh, watch the last J-Rigg video. Watch the last video. Jreg video
today rocked. Did it make any sense? It was very funny. Okay.
All right. I'll check it out. I'll check it out. We should sweep
his bad Jesus. You're autistic.
How am I autistic? that I thought I thought dude JRE does serious
business
you keep interrupting my video Stephen can really say that he
wants to be a serious political advocate if he doesn't want to
manage his personal life in any way that's serious like why should
the DNC involve you in anything that they want when your personal
life looks like a train wreck that's going to be bad PR for all
of them why should anyone want to spend time debating you on
these bigger platforms if all you're going to do is bringing
tarnishing their reputation right it's like if you're serious
about this you should make this sacrifice and If you can't, then
I don't think you really care about the political positions that
you claim to care about. My goal in this video is to simply lay
out all of his actions from across the years that I consider
harmful and allow you to come to your own conclusions. All right,
let's get into it. In this video, I hope to establish a pattern
of how Destiny over the course of his career has repeatedly taken
advantage of and harmed women and occasionally children, and
how he has advocated for a world that makes it easier for people
like him to harm women and children. We'll start by going through
Destiny's harmful behavior towards women. Then we'll take a detour
to his harmful behavior towards children. And then we'll loop
back around to his harmful behavior towards women again. Sound
good? Well,
okay. That was pretty awesome. That was pretty awesome. Delivering
it is is like he's he's so happy. I never thought I would say
it, but not only did Hassan win, not only did Mike from PA win,
not only did Caseyron win, but apparently Ryan Beard has also
won. Literally never thought I would say that in my entire life.
Okay. Never, never, ever. It easier for people like him to face
in the Discord, by the way. We'll start by going through Destiny's
harmful behavior towards women. Then we'll take a detour to his
harmful behavior towards children. And then we'll loop back around
to his harmful behavior towards women again. Sound good? Well,
it's not going to be. Around the end of 2011, Destiny assaulted
a woman on his live stream. I'm not using the word clip. We have
video of him. Wow. I can't I can't believe he was sensitive enough
to This is just uncensored all over Twitter. The Mia Rose clip,
but I can't believe he was sensitive enough to
openly.
Oh, you don't understand. They made him drink. It was his first
time being drunk. He had no idea what was going on, though. You
don't get that. He was being all He's just a baby. He's just
a baby. Oh my god. I'm just a baby and I needed to grab her.
It was assault. I would say that in my streaming career in the
past, like totally publicly like I completely and totally likely
assaulted a girl on stream before for like five minutes or whatever.
I got super drunk and was like grabbing her for the breast the
entire time. Later, Destiny has attempted to downplay his actions
here by tweeting, "I was drunk off my ass, literally for the
first time in my life." And he said that at the time he didn't
understand how bad it was, but now looking back years later,
he understands that it was reprehensible behavior. And at the
time, I figured like, oh well, you know, we're going to anyway.
Like, it doesn't matter. Like, we're she's chill or whatever.
Like, I'm drunk. It doesn't matter. Like, at the time, I'm thinking
like, you know, oh, it's not a big deal. But like looking back,
I'm like, okay, wait, this is like really, really, really reprehensible
behavior. But the funny thing is is like probably every DJ gear
agrees with that. But you guys if you want to know like when
people talk about being brainwashed and stuff. Hold on. Like
probably if if it's really Can I find the song? Oh my god. I
can't find the song. Where's the Where's the song? I think it's
just Oh, no. Like this. Oh, dude. I cannot find it. Find me the
song. Okay. The whole point of it is that hey, if you make a
song about this and it's like a huge community meme for a long
time, the Destiny, did you really grab her chest song? I'll just
search for it on YouTube. It's got to be here, right?
It's like, okay, it's literally not going to pop up. I guess
it got taken down. Oh, somebody's got it for me. Thank you. It's
called Gropes toy. Oh,
like this is a song memorializing this and I feel like it was
a huge community meme and it's like, well, I don't know. Is that
Is that good that we turned that into a huge community meme?
I say we, I wasn't a part of the community when it became a meme,
but it
rubbing biting. That's
the
now you're known as gropin
Did you really take his wife
from his life?
I hope you're happy now. Destiny. Yeah, the song is kind of funny.
So, I will say the song did become a meme, but it's like it's
a meme that's starts with a Mia Rose. So, you know, it's it's
kind of weird. It's kind of weird normalizing some stuff that
probably shouldn't be normalized necessarily. You know, if you
go back and watch the clip, immediately after assaulting her,
he says, "Listen, I'm gonna apologize to you so much tomorrow."
Listen, I'm gonna apologize so much.
Why would you need to apologize to her tomorrow, Destiny? Is
it maybe because you understood that what you were doing was
wrong? To me, this shows that even in his incredibly drunk state,
he knew that what he was doing is wrong. And obviously, being
drunk does not absolve you of your actions. Otherwise, we wouldn't
criminalize drunk driving. You've come here to this stream to
defend drunk drivers to me. This is a common tactic with Destiny
where he'll half take accountability. Oh, I just realized with
Destiny's whole thing today. I so badly should have paused with
this whole crash and just gone, "Hey, Destiny, I think um I think
this will all go away if you just start ignoring it." Same thing
he told me about the juiceer thing, right? Hey, Destiny, I think
you just need to not play into it too much. Don't don't like
show that you're upset by it and eventually people will stop
saying it. He said that about her nude leak, too. Yeah, it seems
to be safe. Let's just common pattern. Very common. That Destiny
shared with other people that then got leaked. Yes. The video
that he leaked of one of his closest friends. Yes. Mhm. That's
the one. That's the one. For something, but half tried to downplay
it by saying, "Oh, I was so drunk at the time. Oh, I didn't understand
how bad it was at the time." But I'm calling. You understood
that what you were doing was bad even back when you did it because
you were an adult, not a baby. According to this woman, Destiny
has never directly apologized to her even though she would like
him to. She acknowledges that he has indirectly apologized on
his stream. But my question is, did he apologize on his stream
to save his reputation or did he apologize because he was genuinely
remorseful? I will allow you to answer that question for yourself
as we go through more of Destiny. Show me an instance of genuine
remorse if you want me to believe the second one. His pattern
of behavior from over the years. In 2012, Destiny shared private
nudes of a woman he had been named Blue Tea with his friends.
Destiny will often claim that the reason for his actions are
because he was provoked into doing them and he had no other choice.
I'm kind of being pushed into playing my entire hand. But here,
there was no provocation. He just thought it would be funny to
share this woman's private nudes with his friends. Wait, this
has happened before? Uh, yeah. Did you not know about this? You
don't know the blue tea? It's in the By the way, I would just
say if you don't know about the blue tea thing, that might be
indicative of cultlike thinking, okay? Because it's described
in explicit detail very meticulously in the Destiny report, okay?
It is it is just there. So you guys don't like me referencing
Mr. Girl, but unfortunately in the Destiny report, this is there
and it's explained and joke about how hideous her face is compared
to her beautiful body. And he also insulted her because he thought
she looked like Shrek. So, he shared a woman's private nudes
without consent for the purpose of degrading her. In response,
Blue Tea hacked Destiny's Twitter and tweeted out pictures of
his dick. Obviously, I condemn this woman's actions. She posted
revenge of Destiny, which is never justified. But don't forget
that
was Destiny maliciously. How did she hack his Twitter? I think
she like they were just in some kind of relationship, right?
And she just probably had like access to it. Maybe. I think she
I think she reset his password because he had logged into his
email. I think it's one of those where like she was logged into
his email so she did a password reset, grabbed yked his Twitter,
posted a bunch of [__] Sharing her nudes without
her considering they were in a relationship and he's going around
calling her ugly. What? Jesus. Yes. Wait, they were in a relationship.
Maybe not, but like I said relationship I meant. Yeah. Okay.
But do you normally share those details like login with like
a No, he wouldn't have shared the login. Sorry. He would have
he wouldn't have shared the login, Kelly. He would have um he
probably would have been logged in on a computer or something.
I'm guessing like they probably were close to each other. So
I I would guess. I don't know. I don't know exactly cuz guess
what? I haven't read the whole Destiny report. All right. But
I think I think it was an email thing. I think it was a password
reset, but I'm not 100% sure. Blueout thread for those curious.
We can go over the blue tea stuff after. I can't imagine how
you can think that people will never ever ever talk about anything
personal or private amongst their friends. Maybe I'm just stupid,
but I can't see myself caring at all if you shared pictures between
your close friends, especially given the fact that I'd never
see any of them in real life. So, in this comment, Destiny is
ad Wow. So, it's almost like he did the exact same thing once
before and was like appropriately chastised for it. Maybe, maybe
not quite. I I just don't get like this is, by the way, when
everybody's like, "You got to give him one more chance." It's
like, "No, we'll go through a bunch of these the the actual chances."
admitting that he did send the news without consent and he's
attempting to down. How did Blue Tea find out? Was it like one
of the people in that group tell him? I'm guessing like I'm not
100%. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. One of them. Well, they kind of
have been very close friends of him if they one of the two or
three people in there were like, "Yo, he's doing this thing.
That's weird." They could have been. I feel I feel like that
conduct. You're just going to share someone's nudes that like
more people other people cuz I think Blue Tea also played Starcraft.
So if he was Starcraft, bro, you'd expect most people to know
who she was, right? And if he was doing this, I I feel like a
lot of people will just go, "Yeah, no, that's not cool." Like
obviously that's not cool. Yeah. What I mean by that is my bad.
They didn't do it before. So like most likely they hadn't shared
nudes in that group in that way prior. So he was making a huge
assumption that it would be fine. I feel like Yeah. Not just
only for like the girl thinking it would be fine when it obviously
isn't. Especially when you're sitting there calling her ugly,
but obviously his friends weren't fine with it either. So, exactly.
Like a lot of dudes would actually be like, "Okay, this is really
[__] up. Like, we know who that person is. You're
leaking this [__] and talking [__] It's
so weird." Friends, especially given the fact that I'd never
see any of them in real life. So, in this comment, Destiny is
admitting that he did send the nudes without consent and he's
attempting to downplay his actions. A couple years later, when
one of Destiny's friends named Bob 7, somebody said, "No, he
wasn't chastised. Diddy Jeers were posting their in solidarity
at the time. Yeah, I remember for Destiny. Well, I sorry. I remember
I I know that the hashtag. I just on the internet at the time.
I just don't remember that specific thing. And then somebody
replied and said was likely the genesis to his exploration. That
is false, but I won't elaborate further. Allegedly shared a woman's
nudes without her consent. Destiny said that this should be life
destroying. Bob 7 shared nude photographs of multiple women after
pressuring one to post one without their consent. But I do believe
that these are relatively life- destroying revelations. But when
Destiny does it, he justifies it by saying that he wouldn't care
if someone did it to him. This is known as the personal preference
fallacy, arguing that something isn't wrong simply because you
wouldn't care if it was personally done to you. Even if Destiny
wouldn't care if someone shared his nudes, which I doubt, that
doesn't make it okay for him. In fact, he's been complaining
a whole bunch about how he's the real victim here. Nobody cares
when men's nudes get leaked or their tapes get leaked, right?
When he said, "Oh, apparently back then, listen, why would somebody
care about this?" Also, I don't even think that comment about
Bob is true. I think it was like an allegation of apparently
one nude that Bose couldn't even describe was shared and then
a link to a public nude was given and that was it. It was like
a supposed screen share that no one could prove. So, I don't
know, to do it to someone else. And a couple years later, Destiny
demonstrates that he knows that sharing nudes is wrong by laughing
at this clip of someone explaining how it's wrong. The guy sent
the nudes to like his buddy and the buddy sent it to the other
buddy and it just went like the whole school had her nudes. Wow.
Right. That's cray. That in of itself is another example of like
violating consent. Even though you know for so long we were trained
to be like oh consent has to do with like you
did you guys know that if a breaks up with you and you send your
nudes to everybody even that's wrong guys him laughing like this
wait I I literally can't tell the tone I can't tell the tone
I thought he was just like oh it's not like breaking consent
but then he is sarcastic about like if you send somebody's nudes
after you break up I can't tell what the tone is here I'm too
autistic help
Kelly help thing is bad when it's inconvenient to B. No, he's
saying it. It's obviously bad. Like, why why do you even have
to point that out? That's the joke that he's making. It's like,
why? It's so obvious. Why do you have to point it out? Okay,
fair enough. Yeah, I can see that now. This is him sarcastic.
Sorry. He started like laughing and I'm like, wait, what is this
supposed to prove? It's him saying that obviously it's a horrible
thing to do. And that's why did you know that that even that's
wrong? Like, wow. Showing that he obviously understands it's
wrong. So, I think even back when Destiny Sorry, I I didn't see
that clip originally when it happened, so I wasn't totally sure
what that situation was. And I'm like I'm sitting here and I'm
like, "Wait, is he I can't tell cuz clearly he doesn't care."
Clearly, like the sarcastic opinion he presented there is his
real opinion, right? So, like I Sorry, I lost it. That's why
I lost it. When he did this, he understood that it was wrong.
He's just pretending like he didn't understand that it was wrong
to avoid taking accountability for his actions. Destiny has a
long history of really not liking when women post about their
negative sexual experiences online. Real talk, opening up about
quote unquote your and on Twitter is incredibly weird and should
never have been normalized. I have no idea why the people encourage
others to trauma dump on social media. It's insanely unhealthy.
This was in response to a woman sharing an allegation about how
she was stealththed. She was allegedly having sex with a man.
She had established the boundary beforehand that he needed to
wear a condom during sex, but in the middle of sex, he removed
the condom, which is a form of rape. I agree with Destiny that
sometimes trauma dumping on social media can be unhealthy, but
sharing allegations on social media obviously has the possible
benefit of holding people accountable for their actions. And
putting the words, "Your rape in quotation marks obviously implies
that he's casting some level of doubt onto her story." It's one
thing to wait to see evidence before you fully believe someone's
story that they post on social media. It's another thing to instantly
cast doubt on their story just because you're annoyed that they
decided to post about it on social media. This controversy started
because Destiny had retweeted someone who tweeted, "If you knew
he took off the condom and you couldn't even bring yourself to
say anything, you shouldn't be having casual sex." Bunch of people
My tweet My tweet's going to be relevant soon. Oh, is it? Oh
yes, the furry wasn't even good. It wasn't even good. Get yourself
to say anything.
A bunch of people got mad at Destiny for retweeting this. So
then he tweeted, "If you are noticing someone is taking a condom
off and you can't say anything, you probably don't have the emotional
maturity to engage in. You should probably just grab a caretaker
or something and stick to furry porn." Sorry. People got even
more mad at this tweet. So then he tweeted, "Sorry, I want to
apologize for my last tweet. You should treat every single woman
you come across like a retired child who's incapable of voicing
an opinion about literally anything. Ideally, you would bring
her dad along to every so he can guide her through the process."
First of all, she did clearly assert her boundaries before sex.
She just struggled to reassert her boundaries when this man started
ripping her because this made her so uncomfortable. I agree that
if you struggle to reassert your boundaries during sex, this
could make it more likely that you would end up being harmed
during sex. And we should obviously encourage people to assert
their boundaries during sex as much as they possibly can. But
rather than show empathy for women who struggle to tell men to
stop because they're so terrified while they're being raped,
Destiny decides to insult these women's emotional maturity and
call them children. According to a neuroscience article in the
journal Nature Human Behavior, victims frequently report immobility
during andal assault, often using the term free. Okay. Neuroscientific
evidence suggests fear and I just have to sit my white ass down
and listen to this guy. Okay, I can't I shouldn't comment on
anything. Can block cortical neural circuits for action control
leading to involuntary immobility. And this sort of immobility
can manifest as physical immobility or verbal immobility. A 2017
Scandinavian study reported that 70% of the 298 women who had
visited an emergency clinic within a month of experiencing sexual
violence had experienced significant tonic immobility or paralysis
when it happened. So when women struggle to reassert their boundaries
while they're being this isn't because they're children with
no emotional maturity. There are actual neurological reasons
for this behavior. When the streamer Hans of Harkir Oh Jesus,
thank God we got through that. Yeah, I was going to make a joke
about some previous content on stream, but you know, I'm trying
to leave that alone. Brings up the fact that these women Why
is he bringing this up? Why is he doing the stealth thing? Why
is he bringing up Hans? I think he's doing everything. That's
the point of a content nuke.
We're not even a quarter way into the That's what I said as well,
Queen. But it's just a content nuke. He's just like going after
all of Destiny's hypocrisies ever. So, he's going to go through
the whole thing. All right. Is this where Hans cries? Yes. I'm
enjoying it, you guys. [__] break crying. It's awful.
A freeze response when they experience stealthing. Destiny disregards
this and says that a victim couldn't possibly have a freeze response
just from seeing a man take his condom off. Freeze up is some
[__] where you're like in a traumatic situation and
somebody's doing some crazy [__] Not like you look
down and you see that some [__] is trying to slip
a condom up. Oh, I'm frozen up. I can't I don't get the condom.
I'm completely frozen. Bro, what the kind of 14-year-olds are
you man? that just isolated from anything else. That looks really
bad actually. That looks not so good isolated from everything
else actually. Are you serious? But according to a 2010 study
titled Facing Freeze: Social Threat Induced Bodily Freeze in
humans, even negative social interactions can trigger a psychological
freeze response in some people. The more fear someone is experiencing,
the more likely they are to have a freeze response. But even
a moderate amount of fear can still induce a psychological freeze
response. And seeing someone non-consensually removing their
condom during after you've established that they need to wear
a condom absolutely could cause enough fear to induce a freeze
response. I know we got some DJers who really don't care about
consent and want to argue against that vehemently. Could we just
leave that alone? I just love to leave that alone if we could.
Right. Let's let's alation on this one. The definition of stealthing
has to mean that you didn't notice when he'd slipped the condom
off anyway. Right. So they at least stuck it in without you noticing.
So, you've already been violated regardless of whether you reassert
your It is absolutely true though that if you see three times
you see guys take off the condom and you don't say anything about
it, you probably shouldn't. I I mean, that's a pattern that you
assume they're not the same three guys.
It doesn't matter if the same guy. Ryan's gone out of his way.
If you say that, though. No, it gone out of his way to basically
agree with that, right? You should someone couldn't be unlucky
more than once. If you're saying that if it happens to you, if
that happens to you three times and each time you find yourself
unable to speak up, then you need to stop engaging in casual.
Ryan already agreed with this. So, I we don't even need to remake
this point cuz you've been yapping this whole time and now I'm
talking. Thank you. I barely get to say anything. I'm talking
still talking. Thank you. Uh, so he's made that point already
that like, hey, there's probably a pattern here that needs to
be addressed. But the isolated comment of him like, oh well,
if you notice if you freeze up from the guy removing the condom,
we're not talking about the pattern there. It's the one instance
of like you see it and it you've frozen up. Yeah. Sure. Yeah.
So, I just I agree with you, but he already he also agreed that
that's a harmful pattern that needs to be examined. It's a pattern
that needs to be addressed, but that's not saying anything. Like
you need to like stop until you can fix that. We just said the
same thing. I've got you need me to throw some more adjectives
there for you. That's the same point pattern that needs to be
addressed is yeah, it's got to stop. Come on. No, because literally
for Ryan Beard, that could mean anything as much as well, you
should carry on doing it, but just go to therapy. You just talk
to your about it a little bit, but carry on doing the same behaviors.
Yeah, I agree with you. That harsh stop is required. Harsh stop.
No more until it's figured out or somewhat figured out. Yeah,
I'm casual. Statistic statistical likelihood of things just happening
like this. Okay. Why? I'm sorry. I'm Do I not get to just finish
the sentence? Hands are off the hands are off the soundboard.
Go ahead, Kelly. No, I just think it's weird to make that type
of a judgment when you don't know the details of things. It's
just silly. Also, like stealthing is defined by not noticing
that someone has taken the condom off. So, additionally, it's
not freezing up as you stare at a man removing the condom. It's
just a weird scenario that people have in their heads of what
this is. I don't Well, I mean, that was the scenario that was
described. Sorry. No, it's freezing up when you notice they've
already taken it off. Otherwise, you're not being stealth, are
you? It's in the name. I think the hypothetical here was you
see them taking the condom off, but Well, no, you could just
notice that the hypothetical doesn't make sense because that's
not definitionally what it happened to that woman either. It's
just stupid. Sure. Okay, cool. The way that Destiny chooses to
mock these women who claim that they do have a freeze response
while being stealth is just really gross. I don't know what else
to say. Oh, I'm throwing out. I can't [__] think.
I jumped into him. I'm [__] completely frozen. Oh,
this I think this is That's some route to your [__]
right there. Destiny walked so Morau could run. Okay, hold on.
Where is
Oh, it doesn't finish. Mal, find the uncensored version of that.
Okay. Message via key. I Well, I told him to message. I don't
have via key. So, I said, "Mal, please message via key and find
keys on my server. Just send him a message." Oh, fine. This is
from the person who is the child. They said, uh, I've actually
been saying no, just made him harder. I know it's what happened
after he pulled out. This is not incomprehensible that I would
just walk away from that situation. I couldn't listen. We'd all
It sounds like she needs to stop having casual. To be clear,
I don't think that Destiny is saying it's okay to stealth people,
but I do think he is choosing to mock women for something that
is outside of their control. Obviously, women do have some level
of control over reasserting their boundaries during sex, and
we should always encourage people to assert their boundaries
as much as possible. But if someone is struggling to reassert
their boundaries because of a freeze response when someone is
raping them, maybe we shouldn't call them children. After this
controversy, the absolutely brilliant trans activist known as
Keffles decided to make a false god damn, I'm having a hard time
with the sarcasm today. Was that that is sarcastic, right? I
think I feel like that's not sarcastic, but it has to be sarcastic.
What? He said brilliant. Has to be. Okay. I'm like concerned
that it's not sarcasm, but I'm It has to be. The absolutely brilliant
trans activist known as Keffles decided to make a false allegation
against Destiny. She claimed that Destiny himself had stealth
a woman. Oh yeah. Meanwhile, he stealths people, which is legitimately
a form of insane. As far as we know, this is totally untrue.
Destiny himself has not stealththed a woman. He was just a massive
[__] to a woman who was stealththed. To give Keell's
credit, she did acknowledge soon after this that she was wrong
and Destiny actually didn't stealth anyone. Wait, I don't know
if he include this. I have no idea. Wait, backing up. I don't
actually know if he did it against people. Destiny is correct
that spreading false allegations like this absolutely does undermine
the cause of the left. Making this false allegation against Destiny
allowed him to shift his focus onto your false allegation instead
of focusing on the fact that he was a massive to this woman who
was stealth. Unfortunately, many of the people who have tried
to take down Destiny over the years haven't been the sharpest
tools in the shed. Speaking of until now, knock on wood, tools
in the shed, let's talk about the time that Destiny tweeted that
he hopes a woman is to death with a shovel. In 2015, the star
Stoya tweeted allegations that the male star James Dean had raped
her. This tweet really upset Destiny because as we've established,
he really does not like it when women talk about their negative
experiences online. Jesus, why not find I wonder why he wouldn't
like that? Why Why wouldn't he like that when women talk about
their file a police report instead of tweeting? You're disgusting.
What a idiot at Stoya. Steven Benell, why don't you write us
a long list of everything you feel a survivor of should do? Then
I'll use it to wipe my ass. Survivor
rape. It's rape. Not murder, not beheading, not a fatal car crash.
Everyone survives rape. Get over yourself. Survivor of rape here.
Hello.
Oh god. That's up. That's up. Want to talk about how hard it
is to go on every day yourself so you don't have to live with
the pain. So rape survivors should just get over it because at
least they didn't die. And if they're dealing with a lot of pain
or trauma because of their they should just kill themselves because
if they kill themselves the pain will stop. Very cool. Stephen,
I have no idea why anyone has ever accused you of being a So
it's justating for them not to survive. I guess just yourself.
Uh it's funny but actual insane behavior. Yeah. I'm trying not
to gigghat it too much. It's like I think the thing is it would
be there's a way for this to be like really funny if he was saying
these things like uh with any level of self-awareness, but you
know he's just like in a total impulsive rage spamming his keyboard.
Yeah. I never really understood why he got so mad about this.
It was very random. I don't know. Yeah. Like if if it was Sam
Hyde saying it unironically like with his calm voice, his like
calm demeanor. Yeah. Maybe just don't survive. Maybe just don't
survive. Like that might be funny too. That could be funny. You
didn't have a choice in getting. You got a choice in surviving
it. I I It's good for survivors to file police reports to hold,
but police reports don't always lead to rapists being held accountable
for their actions, which is why sometimes it's good to post about
it on social media. At least Destiny will be happy that the woman
he allegedly recorded while they were having sex without her
knowledge did file a police report against Destiny. Good job,
Cherry. You have done things in the Destiny approved right after
this. Listen, that's in the way where you want to make sure this
person who hurt you gets what's coming to them, okay? It doesn't
have to be the Destiny approved way. It's literally just the
way to go, okay? This deserves consequence. And he got into an
argument with another woman about how James Dean didn't respect
Stoya's safe word. Ask Steven Bennell. Ignoring a safe word and
not stopping when someone asks is ignoring consent and is rape.
Go [__] yourself. yourself. You I hope you get raped
with a shovel until you bleed out J and die. Holy. This right
here is probably the most violent vitriolic language that I have
ever seen Destiny use in his entire career on the internet. And
it just so happens to be in response to women talking. I didn't
I don't know if I've just never seen what that was in response
to. Person's like actually you don't stop during a safe word.
It's like you realize why he got banned on Twitter so much.
Is it just the go yourself? I guess shovel until you bleed out
your badge and die. I've seen this. I just assumed it was like
to something unhinged like I don't know. I assumed it was like
the other one where it's like uh the lit you say. Wasn't that
to like wasn't that to make a point? I thought this was like
something like that. Holy. This right here is probably the most
violent vitriolic language that I have ever seen Destiny use
in his entire career on the internet. and it just so happens
to be in response to women talking about their negative sexual
experiences. My question after seeing all of this is why does
Destiny have such an intense hatred for women talking about their
negative experiences on the internet? Is it because he just cares
so much about these women and he doesn't want them to harm their
own mental health because trauma dumping on the internet can
be really damaging for them? Or is it maybe because a culture
where women feel comfortable coming forth with allegations on
the internet can lead to women like Pixie and Cherry and Molina
coming forth with allegations against people like Destiny exposing
them for being massive pieces of I will again allow you to answer
that question for yourself. We'll get back to Destiny treating
women like a little bit later on. But now let's pivot to Destiny
harming children. For some strange reason, a lot of people like
to label
the the logs from the naked ape video, possibly the Medicare
conversation, the 5-year-old or whatever on Twitch on Justin
TV early on and they're like, what was it? What was what was
their group called? I forget that one. Those three for sure.
What else we got? You guys got kid. Do kid. Do kid. Do kid. Yeah.
Yeah, those four. Bro Squad. So, bro squad, the naked ape logs
plus the metacar thing because I think they're referring to the
same thing. DOS kid, I think those ones. Okay. Oh, I hope not.
Here a file. So, in the next section, we'll get to the bottom
of whether or not Mr. Banell here really is a certified EDP 445.
Is Destiny really a or are these just false slanderous allegations
meant to try to dethrone the debate bro king? Let's find out.
In 2012, when Destiny was 23, he shared in a group chat with
a couple of his friends the messages. You want to see the sickest
in the world? So many fan girls. I had one that was 15. She wanted
to meet and hook up. Dude, she's 15. What the? But she sent me
pictures that made it so hard to say no. Then Destiny linked
a picture of this girl in a bikini in the chat and said, "Girl
on the left, so hard to say no. Going to get arrested. one of
these MLGs, man. So, in these logs, when Destiny 23, he said
that it was really Wait, what? Man, so in these logs, when Destiny
was 23, he said that it was really hard to turn down hooking
up with this 15-year-old because she looked so good in this picture
of her in a bikini. He then shared this lewd image of a child
with his friends and said that he's going to get arrested someday.
Well, like I said, a woman just filed a police report against
Destiny. So, we'll just have to wait and see if his prediction
comes true. A couple years later in 2015, when Destiny was 26,
he shared in his chat, "I would the out of that 15-year-old.
What the? There's no way that chick is 15." So, now we've seen
two Bro, I got to stop with the edgy humor, okay? Somebody who
hates you reading these logs off with your edgy with your edgy
[__] Holy,
this is this is not good. Getting a court transcript read is
not good. You say edgy, but have you ever said this? Have you
ever said I was an underage person? I don't. No, but like that
one, the DG logs were probably edgy. The one before that with
the friends in the friend group, that's not edgy. He literally
linked the picture of the 15-year-old, right? I mean, I'm not
talking about whether it's edgy or not. I'm just saying, have
you ever said those sequence of words at all? No, I haven't.
But I'm saying fine. I'm saying I'm sure I've said some crazy
[__] that like I feel like I don't want the court
transcript read from somebody like Ryan Beard in like 10 years.
Okay. I'm just sure I've said some [__] that's not
like that. But I don't know other separate occasions where don't
say that. So they're probably fine. I don't know. The reason
it hits different is cuz you view Dest Predator now. Yeah, sure.
Criminal. I'm trying to think like Predator is accurate, but
I'm trying to think of something that like somebody couldn't
come after me with, right? Like Predator they'd be like, "Well,
who did he predate on?" Like was there any like not it's like
okay I think predators applicable criminals good offenders like
debatable. This reminds me of the Bill Bourbet. I was doing the
Bill Bourbet. No, I got it. I was doing the Bill Bourbet. Yeah.
The guy the woman reading the court transcript. What it's like
she said no. No. You're so bad. You're such a bad boy. No. Please
stop it. No. No. No. It's like and then he does the voice. No.
Stop it. You're so bad. Right. So yeah. There. I did it for you
poorly. Destiny says that he's attracted to 15year-olds. Ironically,
this conversation where he's sharing a picture of a 15-year-old
in a bikini with his friends is the exact same conversation where
he also shared that other woman's nudes without her consent.
Sharing non-consensual nudes and sharing a picture of a child
in a bikini in one conversation. What a certified destiny moment.
This is what we in the absolutely catastrophic conversation.
What the her consent sharing non-consensual nudes and sharing
a picture of a child in a bikini in one conversation. What a
certified Destiny moment. This is what we in the business call
a diddyiny party. A common defense that Destiny fans will get.
Why wouldn't you go with Epstein Island or something? Bro, Epstein
is better than it's Diddy G in Epstein. Okay, Destiny. This doesn't
roll. Okay, Epstein. Diddy G. when he says that he wants to have
sex with children is that he's just joking. For example, these
tweets where he says, "You were hot at 10." Any pics? Check DMs.
Jesus. I've never wanted to bend someone over the hood of their
little Tikeke so bad. I do think these tweets are jokes. Very
strange jokes. But I don't think that him saying he wanted to
hook up with this 15-year-old was a joke. You know that classic
prank where you send your friends pictures of You don't you don't
make that joke and then go look at the 15-year-old and how hot
she is like as proof that you're not crazy, right? In a bikini.
That's like where it stops being a joke. Kids in bikinis and
say how hot you find them as a joke. And to help prove that this
wasn't a joke, here are some clips of Destiny doubling down on
his attraction to this 15-year-old in a debate with someone named
Mr. Metaker. purpose of this chat log. I was talking with a bunch
of other esports guys and we were basically talking about how
crazy the jailbait is in the gaming communities. It's ridiculous.
I think I said something along the lines of like there are 15-year-old
chicks that are like hot as that will like try to send you pictures
to like you at events and [__] and it's like you
have to be really careful when you navigate that. So, what is
the admitting to jerking off to 15year-olds then? What is that
in relation? I never admitted to jerking off. I think I just
said like um I think the log is something like this 15-year-old
Well, I never admitted it to jerking off. I think I just said
like this um I think the log is something like this 15-year-old
chick was trying to send me or was sending me pictures of herself
and she was hot as it's like really hard to like turn down some
of these people. I think Wait, how old was she? Um she said she
was 15. So you did get pictures from a 15-year-old. Not nudes
though. Sorry, I should specify. I think a couple pics of her
like at the beach or some but um in swimwear. Yeah. So you're
getting swimwear pics from 15year-old. Yeah. Hell yeah, dude.
So, in these clips, he says that some 15year-olds are hot as
and he admits to sharing a picture of this 15year-old in a bikini.
Oh, he actually sounds so terrible in that clip. It's so crazy.
It's It's just Yeah, it's like, dude. Yeah, it's rough. It's
rough to put those clips down. Godamn. So, is Destiny a Well,
he admitted that he finds some 15-year-olds hot as and he sent
his friends a picture of a 15-year-old in a bikini because he
found So, and it's like also it's like, okay, maybe the logs
you get lucky, but why would you double down so hard? Like, yeah,
yeah, bro. Yeah, bro. So attractive. A lot of arguments with
Destiny about
end up getting wrapped up in semantic debates about labels instead
of focusing on the facts of the matter. If you call Destiny a
pedo for being attracted to a 15-year-old, he'll launch into
a tirade about how um is the attraction to prepubescent children
and 15year-olds are postpubescent. So therefore, by calling me
a you have slandered me. So then you go, okay, I guess you're
not a you're an aphibile because aphibilia is the attraction
to teenagers.
So then he'll go, no, no, no. Keepia is the primary attraction
to mid to late adolescence. I'm mostly attracted to adults. I'm
just a little bit attracted to children. There are 15-year-old
chicks that are like hottest. So therefore, I am not an aphibile
and you have slandered me yet again. Also, there's nothing inherently
wrong with aphibophilia because 18-year-olds and 19-year-olds
fall under the category of aphibilia. And there's nothing wrong
with being attracted to adults. So your normative position condemning
a feeophilia in its entirety is already a flawed premise. And
even if I was a there's nothing wrong with my arguments, right?
This makes sense. It's only bad if you act on that attraction.
So therefore, you have slandered me in countless ways and my
community will now harass you for years. See how you've now had
an exhausting 20-minute debate about labels instead of focusing
on the fact that Destiny admitted to being attracted to some
children and admitted to acting on that attraction by sending
a picture of a child in a bikini to his friends. This is the
debate, bro. Crush your opponent through pedantic arguments about
semantics so you never have to actually take accountability for
your actions. As far as we know, I don't think destiny falls
under the clinical definition of people, but the colloquial definition
of is someone who is attracted to children, and Destiny is at
least somewhat attracted to children. There are some 15 16 year
old chicks that like look pretty hot. Like I can't I can't help
that. Like some people mature older. Destiny defended another
streamer who got exposed for having Oh, the Stefano. Oh, this
is a deep cut. The
the Stefano arc. The I think Stefano when he was like 19 [__]
a 14-year-old or something. O I think
the [__] is Stfano? Captured. We take Ryan beard.
We need to flash up images of 17year-olds in front of his face.
And if he gets an erection, we put him in a crystal. I won't
say it, but yeah, put him in a crystal. Put him in a crystal
with a 14year-old by saying even if he did bang a 14year-old,
no, that's not what file means. Go look it up. Seriously, if
you don't understand the difference between being attracted to
someone that happens to be young and being attracted to someone
because they are young, you have absolutely no business whatsoever
commenting on the issue. Period. It makes true. It's a weird
comment from Queen's like, "Don't tie this guy up and have a
17-year-old with triple D to grind on him." Okay. Yeah, that's
a weird
picture. I really want to see someone use this argument in court.
Your honor, I didn't have sex with that baby because I'm attracted
to babies. I had sex with that baby because it just so happened
to be a really hot baby. Most babies are not hot, but everyone
Oh my I feel like that could be a soundboard. Do we need that
as a soundboard? Most babies are not hot. Okay. All right. Thanks,
Ryan. That once in a while, one of those extra special babies
rolls their stroller on past my goon cave, and I just can't help
myself. But this does not make me a You look really uneducated
right now. You know what, Destiny? You can feel free to have
your pedantic definition of that only applies to being specifically
attracted to prepubescent children because of the fact that they
are prepubescent. And I can say that I think you are a freak
for saying as a 26-year-old that some 15year-olds are hot as
and for as a 23-year-old sharing around a picture of a 15-year-old
in a bikini. Deal. The next child related Destiny incident is
when him and his friends the bro squad watched an 8-year-old
boy shake his for them on a I missed the stfano one. God damn
it. I I would have been perfect on this, but I missed the one.
I shouldn't tell this because I'm going to get [__]
arrested or child protective services. I used to be part of this
horrible thing called the bro squad. Okay, me, if you remember
that cheeks [__] and a couple other people that have
never been on my stream before, we're part of the bro squad.
And what we would do is we would go around Justin TV screen.
Sorry, we've seen this clip, but uh what what who is Stfano?
Stfano is a pretty legendary Starcraft 2 pro who was like the
best Zerg. Zerg was like super underpowered and he just figured
out how to play a strat and like got really good with one specific
strategy and just started rolling people over and then he was
like maybe the best player in the game. I think he's the first
like non-Asian guy to be really really good at Starcraft for
like a like basically nobody who was not Asian was good for a
long time and then he was like the first non-Asian who was good
non Korean I should say not even non-Asian but um yeah he's the
first non Korean yeah the the roaches yeah the two roach timing
against every everything yeah but that guy that guy I think he
was like 19 to 14year-old or something and Destiny defended him
trolling the out of these people and we went around from channel
to channel like around legend of the white gamer. He is not white.
He is like Moroccan or something. He's like North African. Like
it was horrible. We went to this channel with this like this
kid was like 8 years old and he was broing out with everybody
in this chat for whatever [__] reason. What does
broing out mean?
Take his I don't know to bro out with an 18y old boy. What? I
I don't know. I don't understand what broing out with an 18-year-old
boy. They're the bro squad. They're the bro squad. What was the
bro squad? They were just broing out with an eight with an 8-year-old
boy. They're broing out. The bro squad was broing out. This clip
is only bad for a normie. Unfortunately, when you put these clips
together, four normies. Yeah, they're they're like catastrophic
back to back. You just can't You can like do this in isolated
incences, right? I can defend this in like an isolated incident
when I'm like around a lot of DGers and I can be like, "Well,
I mean technically they're just watching this kid on stream.
There's not necessarily anything bad going on there." But then
it's like you got the logs the 15-year-old. When you put it all
together, it's like, man, why you got to be like that? Why you
got to do that? TJ act.
Okay. Pants off those eight-year-old on stream. I can't even
believe it. Oh my god. It was like I didn't even know. Like we
were on Skype. We were like, "Holy shit." Like we had to do like
a double take cuz we didn't even know like what the was on. Like
we were looking at like an 8-year-old like on the screen. his
brother and his brother, we called him Captain Push-ups, would
like come in the room and this guy was like years old. He had
his shirt off and he was like this, like watching the stream
the entire time and oh my god. As far as what Destiny says in
this clip, they didn't ask the child to pull his pants down.
But I still think it's very bad that him and his bro.
Uh, oh, Shawn Maloney,
the big 10 gifted. Sean, I saw you on Twitter spreading the good
word, not putting up with Diddy G and it's nonsense. Okay, thank
you very much, Shawn Maloney, for the 10 gifted. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Squad didn't immediately
click off of this live stream the second that this child exposed
himself. If a child exposes themsel to you, I think you have
a moral responsibility. This do not look good on paper. No, it
don't. It don't look good basically anywhere, especially when
it's all all consolidated together. Toya, sorry, I had a TTS
there, guys. Bro Squad didn't immediately click off of this live
stream the second that this child exposed himself. If a child
exposes themsel to you, I think you have a moral responsibility
to immediately click away from that [__] But I guess
Destiny and his bro squad thought it was really funny to sit
and laugh while staring at an 8-year-old's pit. Next, a couple
years later, Destiny planned to a kid. Apparently, this kid was
DDoSing Destiny's website. DDoSing is when you overwhelm a website
with fake internet traffic, causing it to shut down. And because
Destiny's website was shut down, he was no longer able to make
money. Um, it's like a minor point of clarification. I believe
he'sing the connection, like Destiny's actual computer, right?
And the actual like internet connection that basically you could
grab Destiny's like IP that would go directly to his machine
and they were spamming that with packets. And that's what was
like uh that's what was like shutting his internet connection
down. So he couldn't do use his internet for anything. I'm pretty
sure. Right. It's it's not quite the same as getting rid of the
website. It's a little different from it. Oh, I did troll the
[__] out of the dust kid. That's a guy that's one
of the people like legitimately like I was so you have no like
it's actually kind of scary like how close I was to getting people
together to go down to his house with him and his family or it
would have been it would have just been him and his father. I
don't cuz I didn't know anything about dude that that was some
of the most up in my entire life. I was so close to doing it,
but I was making so much money on Twitch and I had and I'm I
don't know if Nathan was involved in yet, but for whatever reason,
I decided that the current life I had wasn't worth the risk of
Oh my god. Oh my god. I was so close to this dress. I had streets
mapped out in every You had no idea. That's when I first started
getting an interest in like owning a weapon. I got a permit to
own a gun and everything. Destiny obviously never went through
with this kid, but the fact that he legitimately planned to kill
him is unhinged. Were you really considering it? Yeah, of yeah,
of course. It's actually kind of scary like how close I was to
getting people together to go down to his house and kill him
and his family. How old was the kid in relation to you? I think
the kid was probably 16. I think I was 22. Destiny has defended
this to this day, saying that if someone is stopping you from
making money, this justifies
them, even if they're a child. If you came outside every single
day and some guy was slashing your tires and he wouldn't stop
and you called the police and nobody wanted to do anything despite
having proof for it, you're like, "Well, I'm going to have to
attack this dude." And maybe even Yeah, sure. Go for it. Obviously,
I agree that someone maliciously taking away your primary source
of income is incredibly bad. But I think there are a lot of other
possible avenues you could explore before jumping to the nuclear
option of shooting a child. As much as it obviously sucks to
lose your income, I think you know how he could have fixed that.
A child in cold. How Kelly?
By logging out of Skype, changing his IP and not logging back
into Skype. They literally dodoed him because they got his IP
from Skype. Uh, sure. That's all he had to do. He didn't have
to shoot a child. Some things have uh what do you call it? the
thing. But yeah, I guess he wouldn't have he didn't have to use
Skype was around back then. Like clearly he could have used something
else. Sure. There was other but also he could have just made
a new Skype account, made sure that the DOS kid didn't have access
to it and just done why he didn't do this basic. I don't
like a way there's like a way if you added somebody as a friend
and like they couldn't really stop you. It was like you basically
couldn't stop the you basically couldn't stop you would have
had to keep the other Skype secret. Yes. or just not use Skype.
Also an option [__] Well, but he didn't he didn't
end up so he just didn't want to. So he's I don't care. Whatever.
Twitch revenue. You're just going to need to put the fries in
the bag and get a new job. The next child related Destiny incident
is when he encouraged an infamous loi or drawn CP artist to draw
a picture of his six-year-old child. This art just don't use
the internet. I said just don't use skunk. What you clown? What
the am I hearing? How did we not hear about Shadman allegations?
It's Shadman. How did I How did I not know Destiny had Shadman
allegations? I've never heard of this before. Becket has been
sweeping for Destiny, it seems, because he this was not in the
Copen Shadman logs Twitter thread. This I've literally It's very
rare you catch me with like new lore. This is actually new lore
for me. I feel like I heard him say it and I'm like, wait, do
I remember this? But I like it's not in any like concrete form
in my mind that I can like crazy artist is a man named Shadman.
You might recognize Shadman from the recent controversy with
Ava Chris Tyson from Mr. Beast who was a really big fan of Shad.
Are you sure? Hello. Why is Royal saying stupid in your chat?
No, I haven't said I never like Destiny. engaging with in the
chat instead of just Are you calling Kyle? Ryle a [__]
of so truth.
Shut the up, Riyle. You stupid. Holy. I'm just I'm just watching
the video. All you got to do is you don't have to
As if you don't do the same thing. Shut up my stream. Yeah. Okay.
Mine too. Now
brewing work. Shadman has a long history of drawing images of
actual children, including Keemstar's daughter. And because Destiny
was aware of this, he encouraged Shadman to draw a image of his
six-year-old son. This controversy started because Destiny had
been insulting the YouTube animation community. In response,
Shadman made this drawing of Destiny to make fun of him. So Destiny
then responded to Shadman by tweeting, "Hey at Shadbase, if drawing
fan art of me is a tad uncomfortable, you could try drawing my
son. He's only six, so it should be easier for you to try to
be okay
and cheek." I mean, that's it wasn't. It's just basically calling
the other guy.
This tweet was obviously a joke and he didn't actually want Shadman
to draw a picture of his son. However, I still think that goating
a known CP artist into drawing CP of your own son is incredibly
irresponsible because imagine if Shadman took him up on his request
and did go ahead and make the drawing in the same way he had
drawn. Why? Why? Because he knows that Shadman has a propensity
for drawing real life kids. It's weird. It's definitely weird
to be like, why even Yeah. Why put the idea out there for him
to then potentially like call your bluff and do it? Like why
why even play like that? That's very stupid. It's very negligent
thing to do. Like very strange. Destiny's son would have had
to deal with the fact that there would be drawn CP of him floating
around the internet for the rest of his life. If there was a
known child murderer and you decided to tweet at that child murderer,
hey, how about you come murder my child, lol? I think we would
all agree that that would be incredibly irresponsible, even if
that was just a joke. In the same way, I think it's incredibly
irresponsible to encourage a known CP artist to draw CP of your
child, even if it's just a joke. Thankfully, Shadman did not
end up drawing Destiny's child like he had drawn Keemstar's child.
And Destiny got to have fun making his little joke. What a great
comeback. Even though this joke could have Oh, was that brought
it was brought up on anything else. I didn't know that. I didn't
watch the Dantes one. Apparently was just brought up on anything
else. Why? Okay, good roast. That's actually pretty funny. Okay.
Well, I maybe it's controversial tweet. Although, this might
have been during the Shadman the Chris Tyson stuff like when
Dantes was there. I think this is fairly early. This could have
been during like the Chris Tyson
and maybe they brought up like, "Oh, Dessi, you had your own
thing with Shadman." Okay. Yeah, it was. Okay, cool. What a great
comeback. Even though this joke could have come at the expense
of his six-year-old son's safety. Even though a lot of these
situations involving children happened quite a while ago, I still
think Destiny has been spreading harmful rhetoric around children.
Even quite recently, a couple years ago, Destiny said that a
30-year-old randomly a 14year-old would not be grooming. Let's
say there's a person that's like 30 years old and tries to like
randomly like 14y olds and 15year-olds. That wouldn't I don't
think that would be considered. So that Okay. No, no, he's probably
saying grooming is about a long-term relationship, right? Yeah.
Coming up with a minor like Yeah. It would it would be like a
grooming is a multiple instances of behavior. We can't groom
somebody by talking to them once. That would just be Yeah. Lud
and lascivious conduct with like a minor or something. Sounds
pretty bad, right? But we don't want to approach Destiny in bad
faith or take him out of context. So, let's try to understand
the actual argument that Destiny is making. I think Ryan Beard
is doing a good job of pointing out he's actually by making those
arguments though cuz he's going to do that, right? He's actually
doing a pretty good video. Like a way better video than the initial
like normally read and then he's saying but Destiny will say
and then and then give a counter. Yeah, that's and then he's
going to say well I mean his counter is normally it's just like
but again like he's just he's just said something [__]
weird, right? He's like basically defended somebody. He's basically
like giving you a reason that you're being like soy about someone
a 15-year-old which is odd. Like this is odd behavior to do apppropo
of nothing, right? So, he's he's constantly building the Destiny
is a weirdo narrative throughout all of this, which is, you know,
it's pretty based. That wouldn't be I don't think that would
be considered grooming. Now, let's say there's a person that's
30 years old and they're specifically seeking out like 14, 15
year olds to kind of just like talk to them about their school
life, figure out what their problems are, you know, be cool cuz
you're old, you have experience, and then you kind of weasel
in. Like that's like grooming, right? That that would be like
grooming. So Destiny's argument is that a 30-year-old randomly
a 14-year-old isn't grooming. But if a 30-year-old tries to weasle
their way into a 14-year-old's life and slowly manipulate them
into them, this would be grooming. But this argument goes against
the definition of grooming. The definition of grooming is the
action of attempting to form a relationship with a child or young
person with the intention of assaulting them or inducing them
to commit an illegal act. Guess what, Destiny? Nowhere in that
definition does it say that grooming has to be a slow process.
Groom it doesn't have to be a slow process.
There isn't like a time limit to it. If you're just It's not
about being a time, but like it's not about being a time limit.
It's it's just about the fact that there has to be a process
there. If you just send like let's say someone sends us. So if
the kid gives it up too quickly, it's not grooming. That's a
horrible thing to say.
Kelly is doing a good job of proving how easy it is to fight
against these arguments by just calling somebody weird. No, I'm
not saying that. You want to give the you want to give the explanation?
I'm saying that there like I'm just saying what he said by the
definition of it. That's all. Jesus. Okay. Well, it has to be
a Yeah, I think he sort of it literally said forming a relationship,
right? You don't form a relationship by sending somebody a picture
of your company. So, but it's whatever. It's really That wasn't
the argument, was it? It wasn't just a picture of a it was like
actual
I thought it was I thought Destiny said at the beginning of the
call but he said it's just if you just randomly
so the point that's being made is that one instance of interaction
is not grooming because it has to be a process. Now if if that
continued that would be grooming but it's still bad. It's still
miscon with a minor but it's not it just wouldn't be it's not
grooming. That's not the definition. It's like saying still go
to jail if someone if someone ripped a kid. It's not necessarily
grooming, is it? They might have just raped a child. I mean,
are you basing this on how you feel or legal definitions? Cuz
I I'm not talking about a legal definition. You're not a lawyer,
Kelly, so I wouldn't bother using a legal definition. Grooming
in this term is being used as the illegal crime. It's not being
used. Yes, it is. What do you mean? Of course it is. This is
a crime they describe. Cream is going to be broken in one hour
of casting with Kelly when I have to be here all the time. It's
amazing. You mean the legal definition doesn't matter. Anything
that's being discussed that's illegal. Of course it does. Okay.
See, right? That's just what you got to do. Thank you. Thank
you. That's how you do it quickly. You cut the head off instead
of making me listen to you yap to them for 45 minutes of call.
Yeah. If you think you were correct and that's why I said okay,
that's not uh you do. It doesn't matter how I won. I won. see
I'm going to child for the purpose of a lot of times grooming
is a slow process because they have to slowly break down the
child's boundaries in order to get them to have a relationship
with them. But sometimes grooming can happen very quickly. For
example, in situations where the child already has some established
level of trust with the person who is grooming them. In this
clip, Destiny is talking about influencers who their underageed
fans and saying that these influencers their fans wouldn't necessarily
be grooming because grooming is a slow process. The reason that
influencers are often able to groom their fans so quickly is
because their fans already have an established parasocial relationship
with the influencer. If a teacher wants to groom a student, this
usually not engaging. He's throwing in the slow process, but
there's nothing about being slow process. Yeah, but he might
get to now when Destiny made the point to be fair that that's
like the actual argument. When Destiny was making the point,
Destiny did go, well, you slowly talk to them and you maybe
So, the way Destiny talks about it, he does actually make it
sound like it has to be a slow process, which is not the case.
It doesn't have to be a slow process. It could happen in a single
conversation, but the fact is it has to be a process. You can't
just go like just simply a kid or something isn't grooming on
itself. It's a different thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like you could
just look at the other versions of grooming when it's not referring
to like a relationship or grooming somebody into a single relationship
or like like mentoring somebody. You would also call that grooming
like that there is a usage of grooming to talk about mentoring
somebody, right? That is like putting the knowledge and skills
in them to accomplish a job. It just happens that when we say
grooming online most of the time means putting the knowledge
and skills in them to suck your dick, which is gross. Happens
more slowly because the teacher doesn't have a pre-established
relationship with the student. But because influencers already
have a parasocial relationship with their fans, grooming can
occur much more quickly. Maybe Destiny's argument is that the
very first time you speak a 14-year-old, this wouldn't be grooming
yet because you haven't established a relationship with them
yet. But this is still a stupid argument because in this context,
randomly texting a 14-year-old for the first time would be the
first step in attempting to groom them. You're acting like everyone
else is so stupid for not understanding grooming while you don't
understand. I suppose if wait
if the example has baked in continued contact uh continued contact
then that would make sense. If there's no continued contact baked
in, like I say, if it's just an like if someone has if someone's
like some weird exhibitionist and they send a picture to a bunch
of random exhibition
sends to random like 13year-olds on the internet like he doesn't
groom each individual one of those if he just sends an answer
pick. But he does commit like some kind of like whatever it be
exposure to a minor with every single one of those. What provoked
him to bring this up as a talking point in the first place? It
was Destiny's harm to children. So, he's talking about Destiny's
arguments around grooming and how he feels like probably minimizes
grooming. I meant why the was Destiny saying in this one, maybe
it's Doc, but I don't know. Drake was the one last year. That
was in LA. I think it was in LA apartment, wasn't it? That was
in LA. So, it would have been 2021 or earlier. That he just cares
about definitional specificity. But the specific definitions
you're promoting aren't even accurate. I'm not saying that Destiny
is making this argument because he wants to groom children. But
when you combine him saying that some 15year-olds are hot as
[__] with him sharing around pictures of 15year-olds
in bikinis with him saying that
olds isn't necessarily grooming. It starts to paint a very strange
picture. Destiny also got really mad that people were is seething
right now. Quimman hates it when people pet a jacket somebody
by like pulling together a bunch of like a co of random things
that go together. This is a question. I don't like this argument
and I don't go with the wow. I'm enjoying this video. However,
however, I I feel like during the Drake stuff, Destiny said some
crazy [__] that made me think that he probably was
fine with ending at least 18 as being the age of consent that
he could like he could totally have a normal texting relationship
with like somebody that age and like Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
There's some things along those lines. Yeah. I was like, "Bro,
what are you trying to talk about? What are you saying? Why are
you texting? What what conversation you having with a 14-year-old?
I just don't get it. Yeah. 15-year-old, 16-year-old. I just don't
I don't understand. Labeling Drake. He even had a debate about
why it's totally fine for Millie Bobby Brown at 14 to be texting
Drake about when you say he's texting her and he wants to give
her dating advice. What if she's the one that brought it up first?
Should he say something like, "I'm sorry, but it's inappropriate
for me to talk to you about high school boys." Or what? Like,
wait, wait. So, you're telling me if a 14-year-old asks me for
dating advice, I should say, as a 30-year-old that's not related
to you, it's inappropriate for me to talk about dating advice
with you. Uh, yeah. That's pretty much exactly what literally
everybody's saying. First, like, I'm sorry, but it's inappropriate
for me to talk to you about high school. You could have talked
to like any one of us for like 5 minutes. No, the only thing
that caught me off guard here was the Shadman thing. I don't
I didn't know that. Everything else like I literally Yeah, he's
been in my channel last week. Sorry. I mean, Kelly was not okay.
Follow me on Twitter, too. These things. I didn't know half of
these things. Are you crazy? I don't know all of this lore. Well,
what are you doing, Kelly? You're online all the time. Stop being
in Discord. Stop watching. Start watching the content. Okay.
You got to follow these people everywhere. What if she's the
one that brought it up first? Should he say something like, "I'm
sorry, but it's inappropriate for me to talk to you about high
school boys." Or what? Like, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You do it
all the time. When some young person comes up to you and starts
them weird stuff, do you just sit there with this 13-year-old
and then you start having conversations extended about them about
dating? Yeah, I have before. What do you mean? No. Would I tell
a if a if a young person came up to me and they were asking me
questions about some like boy problems or some [__]
Yeah, I'd probably say, "Yeah, of course." What do you mean about
a 35-year-old man? Of course, I'm going to have better advice
for them than some random high school person. Yeah, of course.
If a if a 15-year-old girl came up to me, she's like, "There's
some weird going on with a boy in my high school." Say, "Oh,
no, no, don't talk to me, honey. Go ask another 15-year-old boy
or ask your mom and dad who are gonna tell you to never talk
to any boys ever know what the Hold up. Do you think you should
be talking to them about sex? Uh, it depends on the context.
I don't Yeah, I don't give a No. No. Z, bro,
I'm pretty sure this is a lot to do with why I think this has
a lot to do with why [__] is so comfortable with
burning the bridge to tell you the truth. I think it's conver
was he on after this conversation? No, I I didn't see him around
very much our first conversation. I feel like after this conversation
he's like, "You know what? I'm at a distance." What do you mean?
If a 15-year-old ask like, "I don't want to this guy at school."
Yeah. You can literally hear it in the conversation. He's like
slowly getting further away from his microphone as the conversation
proceeds. Tactic? Yeah. I'd probably say, "Bro, uh, you're 15.
Don't destroy your life. Make sure you guys use protection. What
[__] Why would Why would I not say this?" Okay. And
do you think that most parents finding out that you're talking
to their kids about and giving them advice? Do you think they
would take it up? I don't know. I don't give a They should be
talking to their own kids about it. So apparently Destiny has
given children relationship advice in the past. Destiny is famously
really great at relationships. So I'm sure these children really
appreciated his sage words of wisdom. But if there's one thing
that nobody would ever say about Destiny is that he makes good
personal life dating decisions. Destiny also says that he thinks
he would give better relationship advice than a child's parents
and that he would give a child advice even if this would upset
the child's parents. Who cares if parents don't want you to talk
to their kids about? Destiny understands your kids better than
you do. Destiny, you're a rule utilitarian, right? That's actually
a really It's like Yeah, Destiny thinks parents are okay. He
thinks he's got way better advice for your kids than you do.
I was literally I was just talking about this earlier. I can't
remember why something on the Wick panel made me remember this
where Connor is just like basically saying he thinks that we
should have sort of like Christian values and culture but he
also thinks that like you know if you could go a few babies to
make Trump lose the election you should do and that's totally
incompatible to me but even then like if you took say like Destiny
he wouldn't even argue [__] like that I think wouldn't
he have the rule utilitarian thing of don't break the rules full
of babies because you can't necessarily predict the outcome or
whatever. Like the level of harm that will happen, the level
of harm we prevented. The thing that's on my head is uh I am
a sea monster cuz Destiny called me a sea monster earlier. That's
that's what that is. He did call Kelly a sea monster. I can't
believe you haven't read all those logs screaming. It was It
was actually like an insane crash out day today. It was Kelly
Se of
Kelly. So he said lav and quotes and Kelly or sorry bracket and
Kelly Jean bracket of creating discord servers to share nudes
of him or something like that. Jesus, why did he randomly throw
me in there? He's made that accusation about lav multiple times
and not at one point has he ever mentioned me. I don't know why
he said you too. Well, I think we do know why. Apparently somebody
posted maybe the video when maybe the the meme that was like
the song without the picture. Somebody posted something in Kelly's
Discord. It was like deleted immediately and I think they banned
the guy who did it or at least timed him out and said like, "Hey,
what the are you doing?" Yeah, we deleted. We didn't allow links
directly to Kiwi Farms either cuz like I was getting doc threats
from Kiwa Farms for 2 months. Okay. The idea that I was like
colluding with those people. It doesn't make any sense. We were
being pretty careful. Jesus, there's just so much so many of
these things. Okay. You believe that we should establish moral
rules based on what generally leads to the Oh, sorry. All I was
going to say, was that like a baby Hitler argument or something,
Queenman? Cuz I feel like that's No, it was like literally it
was like literally they were being asked like how far would you
go like how many of your moral how many rules would you break
your principles to would you break to win in democracy? And they
were like, "Yeah, if we have to a bunch of babies, I mean, it
was the response." I see. I see. Jesus. It was about because
the whole debate was about destiny and whether he he should be
allowed, you know, to be part of politics or something. I don't
know, man. It was gay. But it was quite funny just some of the
they were twisting themselves into defending or normalizing bad
behavior to help your political movement or something like that.
Like how can you how much forgiving bad behavior for like the
paragonss of your political movement kind of deal. Yeah. Okay.
Crazy. I have like a little bit of Conor so we can do whatever.
Yeah. Basically, I have like a little bit of like that Connor
gene in me where sometimes I like I I need to figure out how
to not do that as much. I'll sometimes like gigachad stuff that's
just to gigachad and I'm like I I shouldn't do that sometimes.
I mean, just stop pretending you give a about democracy. That's
that's the real answer. Like if you're just saying no, yeah,
I'll just people to win. I mean, then you just don't believe
in democracy at all, do you? You just don't think that should
be a thing. Normally the case for most people online. Yeah, but
Connor spent the whole last year going about how, oh, we got
to save democracy. We need to not call V a because democracy,
so he doesn't get to do that. True, true. Juck has fascist tendencies,
though. I also just say like democracyy's clearly failed. Like
I think with with like you just have social media in your hand.
Like democracy doesn't actually work. You can't have an informed
public anymore. You have just I think the fine grained manipulation
is just it's like it's still the best thing you can do and we
should stick with it. But I'm just saying I think it's kind of
I think the mobile phone is kind of your pig. I hope I'm wrong.
Royal Kitten House donated a donation. TBF, we learned last year
all that would need to happen for Destiny and Dan to destroy
society is if someone shuts down a career opt.
And if people use th it too much, Twitch. Uh yeah, sure. Right.
You believe that we should establish moral rules based on what
generally leads to the least amount of harm. But you don't think
that it would be good to establish a general rule that it's not
safe for 31-year-olds like Drake to be texting 14-year-olds like
Millie Bobby Brown about their relationships. Of course, I think
we have a general rule like that. And then there could be exceptions,
right? There could be exceptions for like a trusted family, but
like you don't have those exceptions because realistically if
like there's no reason for an adult in most cases to be talking
to a kid that young. And if they are, you definitely want people
to be Oh, one second. You if you if they are talking to them,
you definitely want like the parents to be aware of that. You
don't want like a a parallel relationship with another authority
figure in their life that the parents aren't aware of. Probably
for anybody around that age, the parents should be aware of the
authority figures in that kid's life. So, I think there's already
a rule like this. I don't know why somebody would argue against
it. There can be hypothetical situations where this isn't harmful
and the adult actually does have good intentions, but in general,
I don't think it's safe for children to be having these sorts
of private conversations with adults. And I think it is totally
reasonable to side eye Drake for having these sorts of conversations
with Millie Bobby Brown, especially because he kissed a child
on stage. Not only
we don't hate your voice because of how it sounds, but because
of the things it says. some Kelly slander. The worst part about
this isn't that he kisses this woman, this girl. Okay. It's that
he like describes how her breasts feel against his chest. I'm
pretty sure I think that's like the way weirder part of this
clip.
Why do you look like that?
Now, is Drake a Well, like I said, he kissed a child on stage,
but Destiny would probably explain that this child was postpubescent,
not prepubescent. And kissing one child doesn't prove that he
has a primary attraction to children. So therefore, we don't
have enough evidence to label Drake app. Oh god, can you see
how exhausting this is? Some people actually enjoy to listen
to this day in and day out on Destiny's stream. I actually like
that kind of problem. Mad Ryan Beard Drake good faith because
Drake has dropped so many bangers over the years. Or maybe he's
defending Drake because he sees himself in Drake because of his
own personal relationships with young people. Enter Rose is coming.
Destiny's 19-year-old egirl discord kitten. A couple years ago,
Destiny was previously married to a woman while having an affair
on Molina with a white nationalist woman named Lauren Southern.
Why is that? I fear him. I'm kind of hoping it's the other way.
Oh, we'll see. Well, hopefully for him. Yeah, we'll see. 19-year-old
Rose is coming on the side. Destiny was in an open marriage with
Molina. Wait, not a real person. Uh, so it's possible that he
just got giga catfished cuz he's been giga catfished in the past
and there was like a go-between. I'm pretty sure the Twitter
account is real or it's like somebody who's just paying for like
uh news for someone else. I don't know. Ina with a white nationalist
woman named Lauren Southern and this 19-year-old egirl named
Rose is coming on the side. Destiny was in an open marriage with
Molina, but he still managed to have an affair with Molina because
he didn't tell her about his relationship with Lauren Southern.
And he also violated his wife's consent by sending her tapes
to this 19-year-old e girl without asking her. Nothing has happened
with consent. I guess having an open relationship just wasn't
enough for Destiny. Even though he was already free to sleep
with other people, he still had to figure out some way to over
his wife. Anyway, while Destiny was this 19-year-old, he asked
her if she wanted to do age play, which is where you roleplay
as being even younger. She was already 15 years younger than
him, but you know, why not add on another 5 or 10 years for good
measure. According to Destiny himself, he views 19year-olds as
the same as sexingy
olds. When you're 19, you're a little kid. Okay? Now, if you're
22, a 19-year-old's not a kid to you. Okay? Now, I'll point out
that this is really unfair because he didn't have, you know,
global access through Instagram to the hottest 19-year-olds at
the time, okay? When he made this argument, he was like, he I'm
29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15year-old to me. It's all
the same, dude. Don't give me this. Just because of some legal
age of consent, whatever [__] I have about as much
in common with like an 18year-old, 19year-old [__]
freshman in school as I would a sophomore in high school. any
type of inclination towards any of those people is really weird.
If you live with your mom and dad, your mom and dad still pay
all of your bills. You're still a virgin. You've never been in
a relationship.
You don't go to school. You've never even had a job before. You've
never lived on your own. You're a child. You're very much a child.
So, Destiny views 19year-olds as little kids. You're a little
kid. Wait, just real quick. You can make you can make that argument,
Toya, and it doesn't look bad like his [__] does.
I said something about 19-year-olds. Okay, sorry. That's allowed.
That's legal. I'm just saying that's legal. Okay, you can't come
at me on that one. Never lived on your own. You're a child. You're
very much a child. So, Destiny views 19year-olds as little kids.
You're a little kid. And says that being attracted to them is
really weird. Really weird. Yet here he is 5 years later at age
this 19year-old asking her if she wants to do age play with him
and sending No, no, no, no. He doesn't get it that in this scenario
specifically with the age play stuff. Okay, Destiny it wants
to be the little kid. It's different. It's different. It's different.
It's different. He doesn't understand. I'm not convinced about
this. Why? Why do people seem to think he has to be the little
kid? Uh cuz he described the little kid scenario, but realistically
I don't know where those came through in the DMs. Those might
be totally different DMs. Well, yeah, but I don't think it was
ever explicitly stated that he would be the child. Was it? Uh,
I believe so in the longer description with the baby. I already
want to watch this video, but I might end up dying before we
get to the end. Well, SGE power through Kellyensual
tapes of his friends and wife. And honestly, it doesn't even
matter what my opinion is of this. In Destiny's own words, he
thinks this is really weird. Really weird. So is Destiny I don't
really give a what you label him. I choose to label him a freak.
Only freak. Now let's go. He's got he's updated on the lingo.
Okay. Freak.
Freak. Engage in the type of degenerate behavior that Destiny
has engaged in. I don't give a about semantic debates about the
technical clinical definition of if you send pictures of a 15-year-old
in a bikini to your friends and talk about how hot they are,
you are a freak. Let's finish out the video by talking about
Destiny's treatment towards women in more recent years. Do you
think Do you think he'll get to the Kelly Gene exception here?
I feel like the Kelly Gene exception is actually it's actually
like a powerful thing watching if he edits it right when you
read those fourth thought logs. You have those forethought logs,
you read it right, that looks insane about it. Everyone always
forgets about me. So I I shouldn't scan. I shouldn't scan. I
started scanning for a while ago. Destiny admitted that he was
psychologically abusive towards his
Queenman didn't believe in the Kelly Gene exception until that
argument earlier tonight and then he was like, "You know what?
Maybe I maybe going to be Molina venting about her relationship
with me to Bob." Listen, okay, I've said it a million times.
I'm a very hard person to date. I work a ton and I'm very cold.
I have a really hard time dealing with people when they get emotional.
Okay? But if Molina starts crying or we're having an argument,
I'll say like, "Listen, I'm going to go play Minecraft. like
come talk to me when you're done crying because I can't sit here
and listen to you cry. I'm wasting the few minutes of free time
I have in the day. I'm not going to sit. Him and Max are like
the same person. This is like the same as the as the girl the
real doll review, right? When Shayen goes to the other room and
starts crying, he's like, "That's your room to go cry in and
it's like the same thing. It's the exact same thing." Max
does it. When Max does it as Okay, he's going to hate that comparison
you cry doing. So, anybody that survives a relationship with
me for more than like 6 months, okay, props to that person cuz
they're going through some severe psychological abuse. All right,
it's a hard thing to deal with. I'm not joking. Maybe Destiny's
fans would claim that he was being the eye contact, the gym face
into the camera. It's a hard thing to deal with. I'm not joking.
Maybe Destiny's fans would claim that he was being hyperbolic
here and he wasn't actually admitting to being abusive. But here's
his best friend Dan also saying that Destiny was really towards
his ex-wife. I'll say this also. I think Steven was a really
husband to Molina. Okay, I'm coming out here saying it right
now. Um I I don't think Steve would deny it either, but it's
not good the way that he was. Like I I think the the gaslighting
of Molina on the Lauren Southern thing where like he's literally
telling her that she's crazy over believing that there's something
to to like the Lauren Southern relationship thing, that's up.
Like that's that's the kind of up that I really don't like when
like somebody's basically got the exact thing what's that's going
on. They're saying this is my real fear. I'm being vulnerable.
This is my real fear is that this is what's happening. And and
it's like I I just need you to tell me the truth right now. And
he goes, "No, no, no, no, no." Like no, no, no, no. You don't
understand. No, that's like not that's happening at all. I promise.
You're like my the most important thing to me. And then Molina
has to read those DMs to that Rose person of like, "Yeah, I don't
know how I'm going to tell Molina that I'm like nexting her for
you or for you." Whatever. Whatever. What? I think he's talking
to Rose. Like, I'm going to not going to talk to her about it.
I'll just let her I'll let her know eventually. It's like, bro,
that that's like the kind of That's like significant long-term
psychological damage when you get gas lit by somebody you love
like that. That's up. Yeah. And I I just don't think anyone really
understood how bad it was until we all saw it, right? We're like,
"Oh, he cheated on Molina." And we were like, question mark.
Okay. And then we saw these logs and we were like, "What the
fuck?" I don't know, man. Yeah. Yeah. I would say it's the the
gaslighting thing of like just being like no no that that's not
happening and then it is happening. Exactly.
A lot of times therapist weird crying and miserable and everything
else and Steve would say what do you want me to say? I'm a selfish
that's why I'm in the relationship that the way that I do things
that I'm in. And Molina like really was hurt by it. And I think
like she was like you know what should I do? Should I leave?
And I'll tell you this, I never was like I was never like, "No,
you should stay and make things out." I told her multiple times
like, "Listen, if you feel like this is abusive relationship,
get the out of there immediately." Molina herself has also accused
Destiny of being psychologically abusive towards her. I'm irritated
by a couple things. Uh, one thing I'm irritated about is that
my ex-wife has reached out to a ton of people. At least I'll
say at least five mutual friends have alerted me. I have no idea
how many other are affected. Uh, basically saying that. Can I
be honest? The video has one quick one. One second. One second.
Ryan needs to pull it together and get this train back on the
rails. Uh, I actually disagree. I think he's just building up
the the freak narrative thing actually works. It might not be
the best thing in the world, but I mean, sorry, he might not
be the most tightly edited thing in the world. Like, but I can't
say how to make it better because I'm not an editor, but it it
seemed to Oh, old dono. Okay, I see old donut. I'm apparently
my donos are delayed. Sorry, Kelly. What were you saying? As
to be honest, I think what he's doing here is a bit of fishing.
I think he announced that he heard some people say like Molina
say some to them so that he could like fish for more cuz why
why other why otherwise announce it? It's weird, right? Like
[__] right? Wasn't this part of But it's also fishing.
I think he wants to know other people's because Molina never
really him to me. So, I'm like, who she apparently mean? Like,
I know she sent some messages before they broke up, but I don't
really know how much she would have spoken to and about who like
I don't know, not renounce it on stream. Yeah, I think you're
underestimating how often he will send these signals to his audience
to like attack somebody or be against. I think that's basically
90% of I think this is just I think this is one of them though.
Yeah. Like I don't know if he leaked in this stream precisely,
but I feel like this is building up in his audience like a dehumanization
of Molina. And that that can I guess be twofold as in he maybe
he's going to leak stuff about Molina after this, but then it's
also in parallel just getting them to be like, "Yeah, we're going
to [__] on Molina everywhere." And honestly, I don't
know. I'd have to watch, but I I feel like Molina thinks the
community thing is like just about as bad as some of the other
stuff, right? Like I think Molina I'm sure Molina gets like a
lot of replies and stuff and that just wears you down. Uh, like
cyber bullying isn't real, but like long-term perpetual like
I'm just gonna post a selfie and then like 10% of people call
me a that that would be I I feel like that's gonna with somebody
eventually over time if they're sensitive enough. Yeah, maybe
you just have to get like deal with it. But I don't know. Sometimes
sometimes here's the thing. The whole like, oh, you just the
the thing you told Pixie, the thing you told tells everybody
thing you told me where it's like you just need to kind of like
like chin up, buttercup, right? Like like just deal with it.
That's true. But it also helps to just know somebody's on your
side so they could like say something like, "Hey, that's not
true." Like, "Don't say that about them. That's not true." Like
it just helps to have the person who like you feel like could
be responsible for that be on your side, right? And I think I
think when it's the person you you used to care about sending
that harassment your way and then they they have no empathy for
you, I think that with people too, right? Like they were married
and it's just never it's never come out and been like, you know
what, Molina is not really that bad. I was upset or at least
I don't know if I heard actually. She's a satanic demon, which
a very normal adult way to think about previous relationships.
By the way, these years have assured me this is what everyone
does. Everyone calls their exes satanic demons because they've
been slightly wronged in some way. I am so sad she gave him a
free divorce. He did not deserve that, [__] I lied
about a ton of stuff and that I am abusive. So, Destiny has said
that he was psychologically abusive towards Molina. Molina has
said that Destiny was psychologically abusive towards Molina.
And Destiny's best friend, Dan, also seems to think that Destiny
was psychologically abusive towards Molina. I wonder if maybe
Destiny was psychologically abusive towards Molina. Destiny seems
to think that as long as he's like, "Yep, I'm an abuser." Yeah,
but that's no that's there's no reason if Okay, just a little
psychological abuse and you're going to tell like five people
about that. That's That's crazy. Okay. What is this? That's That's
insane escalation. Okay, that's insane escalation.
Deal with it. They're going through some
psychological abuse. It's a [__] hard thing to deal
with. I'm not Oh, Jesus Christ. I cut the edit off. They're going
through some severe psychological abuse. All right. It's a hard
thing to deal with. I'm not joking. That he can just move on
from this and sweep it under the rug. But I don't believe he
should be allowed to do this. And I don't understand why any
woman would ever want to associate with Destiny after seeing
[__] like this. Destiny not only has a history of
allegedly being abusive himself, he also has a history of surrounding
himself with other abusive men. Years ago, the streamer Vosch
was exposed by Destiny forly harassing a woman named Max Carson
slander incoming. Let's hear it. Wait, did you click the tweet,
right? You clicked the tweet. I haven't clicked any tweets. I
feel like you clicked the tweet. Max is not happy about the the
slander that is about to come. See, you've hopped on the cool
new trend of maligning my report uh on Destiny while also using
it as a source. I changed my mind. You have been cowardly. Well,
I mean, some of those things existed outside of the report, but
I would say they're they're they're in the report, right? They're
in the report. Poppy. Yeah. So, the problem is that um we've
gotten these complaints for like I think about a year where like
you've been like really aggressive from a variety of people.
Um Okay. Yeah. Well, no. The worst thing is that you engage in
a repeatable pattern of behavior where you try to be very aggressive
towards a lot of the women in chat in order to make them uncomfortable
enough to send you pictures and then if they don't you either
act very aggressive towards them like by telling that you can't
continue conversations anymore or you continue to harass them
until they either give in or block you or go crazy or whatever.
It hasn't I mean none of this has happened. That's an extrapolation
that you can make based on Poppy. But even after Destiny found
out that Vosch had completely harassed her, he still decided
to be friends with him and platform him and help him start his
career. And now years later, because of Destiny's actions, all
of us have had to endure learning about Vos's horse fetish and
his short stack goblin porn. If you don't know what I'm talking
about, don't look into it. This is an example of the kind of
structure that I'm referring to. Later on, after Destiny's relationship
with Vosch fell apart, Destiny decided to become friends with
a rapist named Mr. Girl. And Mr.
Okay,
every thing to throw out like why that way? It's just such a
point, too. Like, at least go with guy who abuses his girlfriend
or something. Like, there's more of an argument there. The is
so stupid, man. Is not allegedly a racist. He is a racist. He
posted a video openly admitting to a woman. A couple years ago,
I matched with a woman on Tinder. I say woman because she was
46. Anyway, we got frozen yogurt. She came over. We got naked.
I got naked. Then we both got naked. We started making out. Kind
of makes me anxious, so I don't like a ton of foreplay. To me,
it should be like tearing off a band-aid, right? I'm trying to
be patient. Finally, I get her on top of me. I put my dick in
place like right at at her vagina, and I'm like, "All right,
let's do this." She holds perfectly still and says, "I'm not
ready." Clear as day. No mistaking her meaning. She doesn't consent.
But she has this look in her eye. Like she's daring me to just
push it in like I'm some kind of if I don't I could have been
imagining that. But I grabbed her shoulders and pushed her down
onto my I [__] her. Did she like that I did that?
I think so. She probably had mixed feelings about it. Was it?
Yes. I guess I don't know. She told me not to and I did it anyway.
That Jesus the whole Did he have to use these clips?
I don't know what the point girl's head that he thought it was
a good idea to openly admit to raping someone on the internet,
but you just could tell Ryan B is just like he got filtered.
He got filtered. Yeah, he got filtered. It's fine. That's Mr.
Girl for you. Just just say you got filtered. It's fine. Mr.
girl is most wellknown for his review of the movie Cuties, where
he said that he found the 10-year-old girls in that movie Hot.
And it juxtaposes these these amazing scenes where it's like
you'll see the girls playing on a bed where they're stuffing
gummy bears in their mouths and they're just totally children.
And then you'll see um them shaking their booties
on this stairway as they make this viral video. And um they're
pretty 10 years old is 5 years too young for Destiny's taste,
but he decided to become friends with Mr. Girl. Anyway, Mr. Girl
also
The actresses weren't 10. Okay, Ryan, are you good? Are you good?
You're making a You're doing one of these. A weird one. Talk
agrees. Um I I think probably the Cuties review is one thing
that I just don't go near in general. I will I'll defend Max
on the thing every day, though. It's clearly a thought experiment.
It's just clearly a thought experiment. Like, it's so obviously
a thought experiment and it filters so many people. It's just
like an IQ test. It's just the easiest IQ test on the internet.
So, like emotionally abusing his girlfriend on camera. After
they had been friends for a while, Destiny and Mr. Girl got into
some drama because Destiny had banned Mr. Girl from Destiny's
subre. Wait, I wouldn't even argue that not understanding Max
makes you smoothrained or stupid. Uh, lots of people don't understand
Max. Lots of people don't get it. But the the video specifically
is explicitly like a story that there are multiple instances
of that it changes each time and he's like watching. So the video
the produced video is like a lesser version but there are worse
versions where he tells it where he's like less obvious about
the consent, right? And he obviously changes it depending on
how the other person is reacting. It's it is literally just a
thought experiment about how like what consent means. That is
the entire purpose of it. And if you don't understand that, that's
fine. You just don't understand. But don't don't call her say
you don't understand. I think it's based on a true story. Uh
I don't know if it happened. I think it's probably based it could
be based on a true story, but it's like it it fit. So it would
have been an older story. The tone depending on situation, but
Sure. Sure. Sure. He adds details or takes away details as well.
There's little details that are either there or not. Yeah. But
like he's literally So I know for a fact that he told Supreme
in private that it was a thought experiment. that it was I I'm
almost positive I remember having this conversation with Supreme
that like in
and also true
sure where Sure. but like there are elements to that story which
if left out like could like exonerate him essentially as a make
food whilst they yap about Mr. because Mr. Girl was criticizing
Destiny for the way that he had defended Nick Fuentes. And then
a few months after this Mr. Grow released a report called the
Destiny Report where he outlined all of the ways that he believes
Destiny is an abuser. Most people ignored this report because
they didn't really care to listen to a potential abusive
rapist give his opinions on why he thinks Destiny is abusive.
And now you're going to say, "And obviously that was a huge mistake,
right? Obviously we should have looked at the information." What
Oh, we looking for response. We respond to the video. I was responding
to the video. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's not like you're asking
questions. Sorry. Oh, no, no, no. But did you were you not looking
you weren't listening to this? I'll just No, no, he he gave an
argument you're not a fan of. He's basically like ignored this
report because they didn't really care to listen to a potential
abusive pedophile racist give his opinions on why he thinks Destiny
is abusive. The report was also over a 100,000 words long and
it was terribly formatted and honestly no one had time to read
all that [__] And while I personally think that Mr.
Girl is a disgusting weirdo, I do think he made a couple decent
points in his report, Mr. Girl's main perspective is that he
believes Destiny has a pattern of being abusive towards the women
in his orbit. And now that we've seen evidence that Destiny has
been sharing tapes of his orbiters and his ex-wife behind their
back without their consent, I think this adds some credence to
the idea that there might be a pattern of abuse happening here.
In my opinion, Destiny kind of reminds me of the character of
Dennis from It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia. If Dennis was
shorter and more
I didn't know I was being filmed. If you're in my room, you're
always being filmed. You are true. That's just kind of crazy.
In case you haven't seen the show, the character Dennis is known
for being a psychopath who's incredibly good at manipulating
women. Oh, look. I'm not narcissistic. That's good. I told you
guys I was humble. We're a bit makavelian. a bit psychop psych
not psychotic psychopath a bit psychopathic that's what I'm looking
for the most famous clip of Dennis is where he explains that
if you take a woman out on a boat with you she won't say no to
having with you because of the implication the whole purpose
of buying the boat in the first place was to get the ladies nice
and tipsy topside so we can take him to a nice comfortable
but the implication here is footpicks in Discord okay or you
get thrown out of will place below deck and you know they can't
refuse because of the implication. Oh, okay. You had me going
there for the first part. The second half kind of threw me. Well,
dude, dude, think about it. She's out in the middle of nowhere
with some dude she barely knows. You know, she looks around her.
What does she see? Nothing but open ocean. Ah, there's nowhere
for me to run. What am I going to do? Say no. Okay, that
seems really dark. No, no, it's not dark. You're misunderstanding
me, bro. I think I am. Yeah, you are. Because if the girl said
no, then the answer obviously is no. But the thing is is she's
not going to say no. She would never say no because of the implication.
Well, in 2020, Destiny explains that he doesn't think it would
be good for someone who has a large online platform to be the
women who he has as guests on his show because of the implication.
Bro, I just realized I I literally just realized that the whole
rant today is just actually a twomad rant. The whole rant in
DGG chat today is literally just Tum behavior like with his where
he like couldn't stop talking nowhere near it's oh sure Tumad
was actually just like it was everything in every direction it
was
in the court case you know this was it was she was a he
still loves her like it was everywhere wait you know that Tumad
the whole time though with everything he said that he was like
cackling laughing his yeah yeah and like Destiny's different
like raging the whole time. Too bad's cackling. It makes it makes
it a little better. Let's say that I run like a really I just
meant that it's like Well, yeah. No, it's it is worse. I It It
just reminds me of like two That was an actual let him situation.
He He should have been allowed to carry on. We We should never
have let him Yeah. get to that place. Yeah. He was too politically
important to be taken. He was too important. He was too comedically
important to the world. Okay. Y we let him go. Big podcast. I
get 30,000 viewers. Let's say that I have a podcast. I got 30,000
beers. Let's say that there's a girl that messages me. We talked
for a little bit. She really wants to be on and I'm like, "Yeah,
cool. Like, you really want to come on the podcast?" Blah, blah,
blah. I could probably start her and she'll probably give in
and send me nudes and because she doesn't want to lose that opportunity.
She might not actually want to. She might not be into it really
at all, but if I start propositioning her, if if she says no
to me, she might worry like like if I say no to this guy, like
I'm not going to make it on that podcast. Oh, yeah. Definitely.
And and then are you wrong for asking in in that case, even though
you saw it? I think I think it is wrong. Yeah, I think I don't
think you should. However, as we now know, Destiny has a long
history of doing this exact thing to the women who are guests
on his show. I don't like the idea that we're normalizing,
you know, someone bringing in a bunch of small content creators
that are women, them, right? And then when that fallout inevitably
happens, like just cast them away. Like, it's a really weird
dynamic. I work with women and I'm happy with the fact that it's
professional and that needs to be a standard that we set for
more people because I I hate the idea that I just show up on
screen with a woman and it's automatically
but can I really be mad at an audience for thinking that when
I hang out with Stephen who literally pretty much everybody he
works with? It is possible that like you are like a very like
mature person and even if they turn you down, you're still cool
with them being on your podcast. Like there are some people like
that but like not everybody no one knows. That's the problem.
Nobody can ever know that if you're if you're actually that kind
of person. And that's why it's like a very hazy area where you
can't really consent in that situation because you don't really
know. So on the one hand he is saying that you shouldn't with
women who are guests on your show because they can't fully consent.
And on the other hand he is with most of the women who are guests
on his show. No you don't understand Ryan. He says unless you
really want to you don't have to. And that actually clears up
all of the ethical quandry there. Just so you know you might
feel like you have to but you really don't. Okay. And then coincidentally
if you don't possibly nothing else I feel hold on wait I don't
think it exists. I may change the moderation rules around you
and make it so the harassment against you is actually just that
oh no I just I feel like something almost certainly exists but
I I don't remember a quote and usually when I don't remember
a quote it's not real. But I wonder if there's um I wonder if
there's a point where he uses Pixie to to reinforce this by saying
look I've never slept with Pixie and I bring her on all of these
things. I wonder if there's a quote like that somewhere because
I feel like I feel like that's his argument, right? Is like,
well, no, I would never make them. And then it's like, well,
coincidentally, like you kind of just go away. I feel like there
might be an example. I But I hold on. I'm telling you, I don't
remember it. And if I don't remember it, I feel like normally
I don't believe it happened. So, I'm I'm like thinking that's
got to be that that he used Pixie in that same way, which would
be crazy. Watch Fresh and Fit. Maybe. Maybe. I know he said something
similar about Lav too. Well, I think he just tried to like he
just tried to like uh finger wag at people who were like don't
don't say that I just sleep with all the women here. Don't say
that. That's [__] up. Maybe maybe I think he was
trying to give Lav he was trying to say like no obviously Lav
and I have never done anything. But I don't think it was like
an as like an example of no look I bring women on even who don't
sleep with me. I think it was like I didn't sleep with Lav. That's
not why she came on and stopped saying that. I think which are
slightly different things. Zena. Well, I mean, they've been doing
that with Zena now. Like, Zena is mentally ill and Destiny didn't
try to her. Look, it's proof that it doesn't happen and sharing
around their tapes without their consent. A woman named Lav came
forward and said that she felt pressured to send Destiny feet
pics in exchange for being a guest on his stream. At least in
my case, I was so desperate to get out of work and I okay. out
of all the times they could have grabbed a lav clip. Told him
that and he said, "Why don't they grab it off of some random
noamers streaming
that and he said you stream with me avenue where like you don't
have to do what you hate to do and I'm a political streamer.
You can get into politics like like fully extending himself to
me in a way that was like very friendly and then it turned into
something like oh right after that conversation he was like oh
by the way I don't see any feet on your profile. He he he like
immediately after apparently after she sent him feet pics he
said welcome to the orbiters club implying that sending her feet
pics is what will give her the chance to be one of his orbiters.
Now Destiny claims that this was a completely ironic joke and
it wasn't meant to be taken seriously whatsoever. But if Destiny
himself has said that he shouldn't be his orbiters because of
the implication and then he his orbiters and then says, "Welcome
to the orbiter club." I am struggling to see how this is a joke.
And even if it was intended as a joke, like Destiny explained
in this previous clip, you shouldn't be making jokes like this
because the person on the receiving end might not understand
that you're joking. It seems strange to me that Destiny Wow.
I wonder if anyone else has ever made that point. had this incredibly
nuance and he
kind of made that view of a couple years ago abusing people.
All of these rules that he set for himself went out the window.
Now again, there are exceptions. Maybe you're friends with this
person for 10 years or some [__] and you guys have
like some like it could be like very niche. I don't want to say
like every single time, but like as a as a blanket rule, if you
even have to stop and think about this, you should just not do
it. It's just a bad it's a bad idea. Later on, Lav accused Destiny
of being the Harvey Weinstein of YouTube because she felt like
Destiny had a pattern of manipulating the women in his orbit
into doing favors for him. And because she felt like it was emotionally
abusive, that every woman who came on Destiny's stream would
inevitably be flooded with hate comments on his subreddit, which
Destiny would refuse to take down. If you come on to Destiny's
stream as a woman, you can be pretty safe to assume that you
are going to get a bunch of hate comments on Destiny's subreddit.
But according to Destiny's community, it's not because they hate
women. It's just because these particular women all happen to
be too stupid to debate their daddy, Destiny. One time, Destiny's
head moderator of his subreddit named Let's Go. Oh, I feel so
bad about being here now when she's not she's like getting food.
No, no, keep watching. I refuse to go back. If she wants to go
back, just keep going. Keep going. I can't I can't do that to
her. I can't. I'm sorry, Queenman. I realize that I'll hold the
line. Okay, just keep going. Yeah, I realize that you want to
do this, but listen. I She would be Well, I'll watch. I'll go
back, though. We can just watch. We'll debate their daddy. Destiny.
I'll go back. One time's head moderator. Actually, I just cooked
food. Wait, Kelly, did you do you understand what we're talking
about? Why don't you put your headphones on? Did you see what
this is about? We literally just clicked onto a new topic. Hello.
Oh, great. there. Hello. Hello,
Kelly Jean. Hello. What? Okay. Hi. Okay. Can you hear us now?
Yes. Yes. I just had my headset off. Okay. All right.
We're on to a new topic, Kelly. Yeah, I just saw Wow, I didn't
get forgotten about. That's nice. Thank you, Mr. Beard, for not
forgetting about me. Wow. Wow. Happened to be too stupid to debate
their daddy, Destiny. One time, Destiny's head moderator of his
subreddit named Forethought sent one of his female orbiters the
message, "Kelly Jean, stop pretending like you're hurt by your
greatest aspiration was being an esports victim. Holy [__]
no wonder you wish you got. You've got literally nothing going
on to be doing this at 40." After seeing these messages, Destiny
refused to remove forethought as a moderator of his subreddit.
But the whole idea is that if there's no wrong way to those are
I Pixie making the argument. He you just got to be happy that
they didn't get to like the dog arguments. There were a couple
logs that didn't make it to the stream that were probably potentially
worse than these treat Kelly Jean or whatever if that's your
mentality when it comes to her. Who's to say that doesn't expand
to other people? Like can we just Why is it okay to do whatever
you want to? You have to ask Destiny that. I mean it's Kelly
Jean. That's not
Brilliant. argument. You are by the Kelly Jean exception. Wait,
what we mean? I said Kelly is kind of owned. Owned. I mean, who's
owned? Okay, it was like Kelly's got to go and now someone else
is going. Actually, no. True. No truth. I think abuse wise, I'm
suffering on the lower end comparative to everyone else. So,
I avoided his ugly
Kelly Jean. Oh, yeah. You have to ask Destiny that. I mean, it's
Kelly Jean. That's not If you have that mentality, Destiny, then
yeah, he's going to copy it, isn't he? I wonder why women don't
always feel comfortable on Destiny's subreddit. At the time,
Destiny and his community absolutely tore Lav to shreds because
they didn't think that she had enough evidence to substantiate
the claim that Destiny was the Harvey Weinstein of YouTube. One
time when Lav was in the hospital, Destiny sent to his public
chat like, "I wish this person would just themselves already
or off from my forever." Destiny even one time shared with his
public chat that there was a Kiwi Farms thread being made about
Lav in case. Oh wow. I wonder if he if he's ever done that before
like with Anna or with today where he explicitly pointed out
that some people were were technically like docks somewhere.
Like I wonder I wonder if he dude it's actually the same patterns
over and over and over again. Time's literally a flat circle
in this space. In case you don't know, Kiwi Farms is a message
board. Well, he just straight up docked Sunday himself. It wasn't
that he pointed at KF that is famous for doxing and harassing
people they don't like. So by sending Destiny's community to
her Kiwi Farms page, Destiny was essentially doxing her. To be
clear, I'm not trying to 100% defend Lav here. I think that some
of the negative comments about her debating were accurate. I
don't think she's a particularly good debater. I also don't think
that she necessarily had enough evidence to back up the claim
that Destiny is the Harvey Weinstein of YouTube. Although these
days, I do think there is a lot more evidence pointing to that
being the case. She also one time claimed that Hassan had slept
with a 17-year-old, which she didn't have any evidence to back
up, and then Hassan ended up tearing her to shreds for that.
And since then, she has become a turf who says a bunch of racist
and transphobic [__]
Brian Beard's covering his bases here. It sounded like he was
going to probably He still links her Twitter. Here's the thing,
Kelly. Here's the thing. I don't know. Giga chat. Um, there are
a lot of long-term DJers who like this whole thing with Pixie,
Cherry, Molina. I don't know what to say. Stasia. Okay, I don't
know if to say the name or what. It's all these people. Okay.
It's I think it's put a really like sour taste in a lot of people's
mouths. Okay. And they I think a lot of people who are like longterm
in this community used to write effort posts and stuff. They're
like and they will go and like like if you've ever watched DJs
when they archive some [__] and then they're going
to go post about like like when I'm trying to think of maybe
on me or on Kelly like when they do that they will like they'll
source it incredibly well. Some people might have just sent Ryan
a whole bunch of for free in the moment. He might have just been
like, "Hey, can somebody tell me about this?" And it's like they
happen to know, you know, one random lore master. And it's like,
"Okay, boom. Here's all the info you need." I think one guy could
have helped him write this. I'm not joking. I think one guy could
have just sat down and been like, "Here, here's like how you
structure this and I'll I'll just go grab all the links." I I
would say like a lot of this a lot of this stuff would just be
on Destiny's wiki.
I'm sure you could source a ton of information for uh TV and
film. It's like a DGG consultant.
Uh, that's so funny. Also in the community who follows all the
memes maybe. Twitter. However, I do still think that the treatment
she endured from Destiny's community was insane. Being a bad
person does not disqualify you from being abused. And if a woman
feels like she's being abused by you and your community, I don't
think a good way to prove that you're actually not abusive is
by telling her to kill herself and doxing her. Destiny's community
wrote off Lav as mentally unstable and insane. And because both
her and Mr. girl were widely hated by most people on the internet.
Most people ignored their allegations that Destiny was abusive.
Destiny has a long history of bringing mentally ill women onto
his stream to the point where it's a meme in his community that
all of the women on Destiny's stream have BPD. Destiny himself
has said that he's most attracted to women who he considers mentally
unstable. This dude really has a penchant for going after mentally
ill women, okay? women with like severe depression and a lot
of them got like self-dagnosed BPD or some like he just likes
that. I don't know. To me, the fact that there's a pattern with
a lot of these girls is a bit weird. But the question is, does
Destiny just happen to attract a bunch of mentally unstable women
to his stream or does he purposefully attract mentally unstable
women because he knows they are more easy to I think he's not
I think eventually, and I'm not making this as a claim, but I
feel like it will be that there's basically like vulnerable women
and you can basically take vulnerable women who are like using
this as an outlet of some kind. Like let's say they they're isolated,
they're lonely or something or that maybe they just get something
from the attention. And I think you can get them to keep coming
on stream and once they're like being, you know, having certain
things rolled at them for enough time, I think you can actually
crazy make a lot of fairly normal people. I think that's I feel
like that's eventually where it's going to go. That like when
a lot of people leave this space, they'd end up going back to
fairly normal. I also think you'd have to be mentally ill to
like him in the first place. Rude. But also, you liked him. Not
in that way, but you liked him. So as a person, not to want to
him. Gross. You can say gross. I wouldn't say gross because it
kind of denigrates the victims who did have sex with them and
that's what this whole thing is about. So, no, it I'm not calling
them gross. They just um you literally you literally just said
you'd have to be mentally ill to him and then said gross thinking
about Yes, but that just means that they're superficial than
me. That doesn't mean I think they're gross, you [__]
It just means What about the mentally ill? What about the mentally
ill comment? You just called Molina mentally ill. That's that's
an insult at him, not at them. Okay. I'm just saying that like
you should be a little sensitive. probably describe like say
exactly. Oh, shut up. Shut up, JTO. Oh, shut up. to abuse. Another
mentally ill woman that Destiny had a long conflict with was
a woman named Anna. Just like with Lav, Destiny also encouraged
his community to go to Anna's Kiwi Farms thread and he encouraged
them. I can't wait to watch. Okay, I need somebody. How many
subs do I have to give Darius to make him watch this video on
his stream that's getting embedded in DGG? How many subs is Darius
live? How many subs? Cuz I I can't wait to review them going
through this video and then watching them argue these points.
This is going to be so funny to post in her thread. Oh, okay.
Also, heads up. This is my only non-media blackout time. Okay,
this is my only non- media blackout time. I med this. Okay, somebody
on Kiwi Farms has made a thread of Anna. So, if you are obsessed
with Anna and you want to talk about her all the time, you chatter.
You can actually go to Kiwi Farms and Oh, I wish I wish Ryan
would share his document with me with his sources cuz I need
to know when this time stamp is. It's 2022 sometime 2020 maybe
between it's between 2022 and 2023. We get the black thing on
the wall here. That's so before at or before summer 2023 and
after like midway through 2022. I think this guy got some good
clips. He did a good job clip. You could message him and ask.
I could message him and ask, but this one I want to know the
time stamp cuz I want to know how far this away is away from
like them still
cuz it's just like it's so crazy that like you would go on stream
and say this. I hope at least at this point they were like dark
and not texting each other cuz this is crazy. This guy knows
Well, it's not hard. If you watch like a lot of the streams,
it's not hard. How often does a streamer's backdrop change if
you just if you just Yeah, it's not that hard. This is the same.
Yeah, I know, Coer. I know. And you can go and post all you want,
read all you want that go there, post about it, talk about it.
People put a a lot of effort into categorizing and archiving
everything. There you go. Okay. And in the thread about Anna
that actually it probably is between September and January of
2022.
January and September of 2022. Found a clip where he denies Pixie
claim using transcript search. Yeah, I've got that one as well.
I've got that in my DMs. Um,
yeah. Destiny encouraged his fans to go message they doxed Anna
and it was later revealed that at this time Destiny was secretly
in an ongoing relationship with Anna. So you acknowledge that
you've been texting with her for a year. I think yeah we've had
on and off sure in response to this Anna texted Destiny. You
literally ruined my life. You just doxed me on your stream. You
you put me in danger. Oh please tell me. Oh my god. You're doing
it. You're doing it to yourself. What the [__]
This guy is such a lunatic. It's always the uh It's always the
crazy making. And I noticed the more subtle crazy making a while
back. I was looking through my logs for something and I remember
we were like having a private conversation once. I want to say
it was like in one of these private VCs and he literally like
types in the chat like, "Cherry, you're out to sea right now.
Nobody understands what you're saying." It's like why would you
I don't understand why you would do this kind of thing to people
you know might have like something where they're where they could
have like an adverse reaction. I don't know why you do this like
subtle thing where you're like trying to convince them that they're
not perceiving reality correctly. It's like that to me is so
sinister. I don't know. Yeah. Doubting someone's reality is like
one of the meanest things you can do. I like and but but saying
it Yeah. It's just uh actually ogre boy. I literally Yeah, I
just had that clip from somebody else. But thank you with Anna
and you want to talk. Sorry. I'll say Riyle sent this first and
then Ogre Boy sent this one as well. So we'll check this out.
Talk about her all the time. Is that Ogre boy? Otherwise Jude
from Hassan's community with the Hassan tattoo. Jude. Yes, that
is him. Wow. He goes on live and learn now. I think I think I've
seen him on there twice maybe. But now listen, he's I remember
it from chat on Twitch. He's on the TDD train. So listen, we're
all sharing a purpose, okay? We have a commitment to test-driven
design. We will make sure. Okay. Red green refactor. Red green
refactor, guys. All right. So, if you are obsessed with Anna
and you want to talk about her Oh, this is just the you chatter,
you can actually go to Kiwi Farm and you can go and Oh, was this
all it was? I wanted the pixie thing, but thank you guys for
sending me the clip. I guess you sent it before you saw it in
the video. Save that for the stage. Is Is this Sorry. Is this
going to the pixie thing? You sent me the pixie thing. Wait,
where? I don't Oh, this one. Sure, sure, sure. When I actually
said that I diverge from Miss Oh, wait. Did you not give me Oh,
30 minutes. Okay, 30 minutes. You imply over and over again that
we had an active relationship while you were blowing up on my
stream. You've said it this stream. I'm abused and coerced. And
that is the implication. Very good for someone to tell you that
something is not your fault. Hello. Lav is like sad in general
chat. Like I'm out of the fold. You're going to forgive her and
give her her perms back. Uh yeah, we're on a live clip. Lav can
come in for a laugh clip. Lav, are you still there? Well, this
was like half an hour ago. I must. Okay. Well, I can still go
find her and give her notable here. I will dink dark in her direction.
Leia, I think witch ethel rolls.
Yeah, I'm sure it does. Especially when it all is your fault,
Lab. I'm sure it feels really good when you imply over and over
again that we had an active relationship while you were blowing
up on my stream. You've said it this stream. I'm glad at least
you admit that that's not true. That that is horribly misrepresented.
And then when you're out here talking [__] about
all these other streamers, about Kelly, about Pixie, about Madam
Genevie, when you're trying to like leak all these other things
that you think you may or may not know about me to the detriment
of them, cuz none of this hurts me, right? And then you're sitting
here acting like you're the indignant one after you've leaked
personal hookup details about me to uh big tech that's leaking
it publicly when you've talked about it multiple times on stream.
How do you think you have the high road here? Like you've done
nothing but betray my trust and the trust of every other person
for nothing. And if I wasn't abusive or coercive, it's even worse
for you because you're leaking it all for attention. You're not
even leaking it for a good reason. But this is what I was um
saying earlier. Sorry. Did I I thought I heard some crazy making
there in the middle. Let me let me You're talking about all these
other streamers, about Kelly, about Pixie, about Madam Genevie,
when you're trying to like leak all these other things that you
think you may or may not know about me to the You think you may
cuz none of this hurts me, right? And then you're sitting here
acting like you're the indignant one after you've leaked personal
hookup details about me to big tech. that's leaking it publicly
when you've talked about it multiple times on stream. How do
you think you have the high road here? Like you've done nothing
but betray my trust and the trust of every other person for nothing.
And if I wasn't abusive or coercive, it's even worse for you
because you're leaking it all for attention. You're not even
leaking it for a good reason. But this is what I was um saying
earlier. Low key, I had no idea how gaslighty this was because
I didn't know how much of the stuff he was saying was just like,
no, I thought I thought this was genuine like she deserved this.
I was like, you know what, hindsight, Jesus. Oh, man. Somebody
makes a good point. And Wendy makes a really good point here
that he's like oscillating between like excoriating her over
a leak and then saying what you think you may or may not know.
So like getting her to like saying like not try trying to admit
it's not true, but also like why would you leak this? But also
why would you just lie? It's like, okay, it's too bad that she
didn't, you know, it's difficult when this guy's like in the
VC with you when he's like, you know, motor mouthing it a little
bit and to to know to go just like, wait, am I lying or am I
leaking? Which is it? Like that that question alone would have
just cut through this, right? Am I lying or am I leaking? Oh,
look, it's Chris Lettuce and Lisa is a blogger. Oh, boy. In Stardust
chat based that it's almost like it's understandable why Steven
feels this way because it's okay. Well, we're not I don't think
we're going to keep watching this right now. Let's finish the
content nuke and then we can uh and then we can move forward,
guys. All right, let's finish it up. She would have to fully
blow up Pixie to show he lied there. She She would, but I'm saying
that like she could have just said, "You have to pick one. Am
I lying or am I leaking? Which am I doing?" Because we can have
this discussion either way. And then it puts the onus back on
him now to say that she's leaking, right? to say that she's leaking.
He has to now blow Pixie up and then it can just go to a conversation,
a different conversation. Play the next 10 seconds. It's like
he didn't do one thing. He he didn't uh do some one thing that
he doesn't do for anybody, right? And you took that and discounted
every part of his friendship. And I don't I don't I'm having
a conversation with Steven. You do not need to run defense. I
don't want this to be a conversation with a peanut gallery. If
it's going to be me and Steven, it's going to be me and Steven.
You understand that it's like also like extra annoying that I
two messages I literally explicitly told you that our relationship
was totally independent from anything happening on our stream
which you seem to understand and joke about and two I explicitly
No, let me finish. You've cut me off on every single thing. Okay.
No, no, no, no. Because Stephen, you're talking too fast. You're
talking too fast and ramble on some irrelevant [__]
Go for it. And we're not having we're not having like a healthy
discussion when you when you when I I don't have notes. You're
talking really fast. If you could please talk slightly slower.
Okay, two things. One, I explicitly told you that nothing we
do or did or will ever do has anything with you coming on stream.
You joked back at me about that, but I even reaffirmed it to
make sure and you said that you appreciated and you understood
that. Number one. And number two, you keep saying I wasn't taking
care of you or checking in on you. I explicitly DM'd you to check
in on you to see if you were okay. And you told me you were fine.
And all of this was happening when we did not have a relationship.
How is it my fault for you minding yourself on my stream? Stephen,
I've already I've already conceded publicly and and said, "But
that was my bad that I that I should have managed my own emotions
better. I've already
if I'm checking in on you and giving you like clear boundaries
on like, hey, this does it's actually it like makes me uncomfortable
to watch some of this stuff like the um and it just makes me
like actually uncomfortable to watch this stuff and watch like
all the she's lying. I think I might have done like a reversal
thing. I might have had a comment here that implied Lav was lying
to be honest with you. Somebody said they saw I was annoyed because
she made a comment about me, but with me she did immediately
take it back and then clarified it. So, I really shouldn't have
been that. But I think it's because I got dragged into the situation
in general. It's just um but yeah, I don't know. I I Oh, I forgot
is Kelly made cry. I forgot Kelly made cry. Jesus. To be fair,
she insulted me first. Okay. Wow. Wow. I still Lucy if we do
something like that it'll be as a part of like we'll see I'm
like kind of kind of thinking about some stuff like that kind
of kind of kind of kind of doesn't have to be I'm going to go
back to the nuke but that was good to watch a little more of
and Destiny responded to this by saying you're doing it to yourself
and you're going to keep doing it to yourself. This is one of
the most insane things I have ever seen in my entire life. Choosing
to dox a woman you are actively with just because she you off.
I guess if you want to live life by destiny's rules. If your
wife or girlfriend or friends with benefits ever pissed you off,
why not just dox her to hundreds of thousands of people? I also
want to be clear that I'm not defending Anna. Anna also has a
long history of harassing Steven, which is obviously not good.
But Destiny also treated Anna like garbage. He not only doxed
her, but he also threatened to leak her nudes when she threatened
to leak messages between the two of them to prove that Destiny
had been lying about her. So, do you and like it's all but this
is the clip I told you guys about yesterday with Tom Foolery
where he justifies like, "Hey, you're going to talk about my
like Yeah, I'm I'm going straight to leaking your nudes." Do
you think that leaking
and leaking nudes is proportional or do you think it's a proportional
response in the way that you're reacting to that? I think it's
about proportional. Yeah. Thanks. You don't think that she has
more to lose in that scenario? Like you think that people you
have more to lose, but I just don't see the huge difference between
like and nudes. Like you're leaking like personal like
sent you and like trusted you with like I in my opinion that's
just under the law. This is like one of the biggest forms of
like weird like backstabbing [__] that you can do.
It's like one of the worst things a person can do is like leaking
like private. I love you. So Anna had What was that? That must
be from
It's like a It was a donation. I think it might have been on
Tom's thing. Yeah, it's it's a donation thing. Yeah, it's a No,
it's a donut sound or whatever. It's like a You see the pop that
that t-shirt?
Love you, Tom. No, it's a subscription alert. So, you should
be getting a lot of those. Um, so Anna had stalked and harassed
Destiny. Is that really had lied about Anna and threatened to
leak her nudes and sent his fans to a website that doxed her?
This is a situation where they were both clearly in the wrong.
But I think this situation sent a message to Destiny's previous
partners that if you get onto Destiny's bad side, he will not
be afraid to threaten to leak your nudes and send his fans to
a website that doxes you. Looking back at Destiny's streams from
over the years, I found at least 20 different women who had allegedly
had some sort of relationship with Destiny at some point. And
I found at least Oh, I see. I That's why he's got to talk about
Mr. Girl because he's just rewriting the Destiny report himself.
Based Let's go. Bunch of these women are about to come out and
say, "Why is this Ryan Beard guy messaging me?"
previous female orbiters who now all hate Destiny's guts and
Destiny now labels them as crazy. The fact that Destiny has had
sex with a bunch of his orbiters and now a bunch of them hate
him doesn't necessarily prove abuse. But what I do know is that
Destiny is not living by the standard he expects other people
to live by. Again, he said himself that you should not people
who are guests on your platform because they might not be able
to fully consent because of the implication. I think I think
it is wrong. Yeah, I think I don't think you should. And at the
very least, he has totally and utterly failed at living up to
this standard of conduct that he expects other people to live
by. I think we would need more evidence to concretely prove that
Destiny's stream really is this system of abuse. But all I know
is that there are at least four alleged victims and a whole host
of other women who absolutely hate Destiny's guts. So I would
recommend that women should stay as far away from Destiny's community
as possible. If you know that the people you're going to be involved
with are only short-term partners. And you constantly see the
after effect of most of your hookups and your interactions leaving
a trail of broken hearts and disappointed. This is the thing
to me where it's like, okay, at some point, how is a pattern
not identified of like, okay, this is what I need to avoid? It
it seemed like the Yeah, there was just like it just wasn't a
concern, right? There's probably a pattern here that it continues
to reoccur that I'm not avoiding in any way. And that that seems
spooky to me. Like guys intelligent enough to recognize the patterns
in my opinion. People that's a moral failing and yet I say that
I say that while sharing a stream with Kelly Jean once again.
So you know XD. All right, let's recap all of Destiny's treatment
towards women. Destiny assaulted a woman. Destiny has a long
history of sharing women's nudes and sex tapes without their
consent. Destiny allegedly recorded a woman having sex with him
without her consent. And in his messages to his Discord kitten,
Rose is coming, he sent her audio recordings of men that he had
slept with from Grinder and said, "I went out and sucked the
guy off a few nights ago and recorded the audio. It's really
scuffed in my pocket, lol. Did I ever send it to you?" If he
was recording the audio from his pocket, it sure doesn't sound
like that audio was recorded consensually, does it? Maybe he
did ask if he could record him, but then he put the phone back
in his pocket where the audio would sound terrible for some reason.
But I highly, highly, highly doubt that. And if he was recording
men from Grinder without their knowledge, it's also very easy
to believe. I can just tell you if if Destiny watches this at
some point, his response to that is going to be something like,
"Look at this guy. This guy doesn't even know what is. This guy's
just a fat virgin. Like this fat virgin loser. How he doesn't
know exactly. Well, he is a fat virgin loser. Let's be serious.
Yeah, but it's not an argument. However, he's making a perfectly
fine point. Yeah, it's not an argument. Yeah, I'm sorry. I'm
describing it accurately, but that's not an argument against
what he's saying. There's no reason when you go the audio is
scuffed because it was in my pocket. It's like, you know, that
that's not good, right? Literally implies that he's recorded
stuff in his pocket before and he knows exactly what is causing
that scuffness, right? It's a straw man voice. Yeah, I like I
like the straw man voice. Probably always going to use that.
It's just fun to make other people sound soy and myself look
good. Believe that he was recording Cherry without her knowledge.
He has a history of calling 15year-olds attractive and sharing
pictures of them in bikinis. He has a long history of getting
very mad at women when they post about their assaults on social
media. He has allegedly abused at least one of his female orbiters
and was psychologically abusive towards his ex-wife. And he also
admitted to choking out another one of his exes multiple times.
However, he claims that this was done in self-defense. Cuz you
better believe I had to choke her out a few times. Finally, Destiny
has a history of doxing and threatening to leak the nudes of
women that get on his bad side. I find this incredibly ironic
because in his Keell's manifesto, he says that progressives believe
there's no such thing as bad tactics, only bad targets. And what
comes of the belief that there are no bad tactics, only bad targets?
Well, if you ask me, doxing women and threatening to leak their
nudes is the definition of bad tactics that you should not be
doing, even if you think that woman is a valid target. If you
add up all of these allegations, I think it's time to consider
that maybe Destiny is just not a good person. Maybe he's your
typical male feminist and all of the liberal that he spews on
his platform is just him trying to get into women's pants. Before
it had been publicly exposed that Destiny had shared Pixie's
tapes without her consent in private, he acknowledged that he
had severely at the very least psychologically damaged her. But
once Pixie came out with her allegations publicly and announced
that she was planning to sue Destiny, he went back to his old
defensive ways and took accountability for nothing. He posted
to his subreddit, "Legal arc beginning in mysterious ways. Such
wow." Which is the most millennial cringe way possible to respond
to allegations of crimes. In this post, he never takes direct
accountability for sharing Pixie tapes with Rose's coming without
her consent. And instead, he focuses on how he's
never had any an intention for any of these images to be published.
Um, well, I mean, they were published under a lot of legal definitions.
You published them into other people's places. You crystallized
them in a digital medium, right, for other people. I mean, you
did. You just didn't want them published broadly. You didn't
want them exposed to the public internet in a way where they
could be consumed by millions of people. Maybe, but then again,
depending on what the numbers get to, I might not even believe
that excuse anymore. I doubt a lot of other people will. Coming
without her consent, and instead he focuses on how he's a victim,
too, because his nudes were also leaked by the hacker that apparently
hacked Rose is coming. Obviously, Destiny is also a victim in
this situation, but I struggle to find empathy for him because
he refuses to take accountability for sharing the tapes non-consensually
in the first place, which led to this entire mess. He also talks
about how Pixie was asking him for a large amount of money because
she was trying to teach him a lesson. And I don't necessarily
see anything wrong with he went with the President Sunday gambit
while also trying to call out President Sunday and draw attention
to him. That's a risky play. Okay. Okay. To go to use President
Sunday's tactic. Exactly. To leave out that charity picture and
paint her as like an extortionist who's I guess in your case
getting by Lauren de Laguna. But then but then to uh to point
people at Sunday and say, "Look at all the criticism he's getting
or why isn't he getting enough?" And then people look at the
criticism. They're like, "Wait, he called her like an extortionist
without that charity screenshot there. Wait, didn't Destiny also
Oh. Oh jeez." With her wanting to teach That's That's Sorry,
that's just a ballsy play. Okay. to use a guy's tactics and then
go look look at the criticisms that that he's not getting. Look,
there's so many criticisms there to teach him a lesson. And I
don't necessarily see anything wrong with her wanting to teach
Destiny a lesson. Maybe he needs to be taught a lesson. Pixie
made the point that unless there are some real consequences to
Destiny for doing this, he'll probably just do it again in the
future, which I agree with. Destiny later said to his public
chat, "Pixie and the people behind her just want money." Yet,
this is a blatant lie because she made it abundantly clear to
Steven that she would be willing to donate the money he gave
her to charity. So, just like usual, Destiny is attempting to
smear his victim in order to silence her. Even though, in my
opinion, Pixie has done absolutely nothing wrong. And I think
this shows incredible moral character on Pixie's part that she's
even willing to donate this money to charity because I don't
think she has any obligation to do this. But even with Pixie
being basically the quote unquote perfect victim, Destiny still
decides to smear her. My favorite sentence from this post is
when Destiny says, "I have been trying to move on from covering
drama content as it has had an increasingly negative impact on
those in my life." You loved covering drama content when it was
other people's heads on the chopping block, but now you want
to stop covering drama once your head is on the chopping block
after this. To be fair, he also loved covering drama when his
head was on the chopping block. He just knew that the axe was
blunted before and now he's like, "Oh [__] that axe
is too sharp. I can't get I've lost my like keys for the handcuffs."
Blunt axe. Oh, sorry. This is going to hurt. I was trying to
figure Yes, I was trying to figure out a metaphor, Kelly. Now
you pointed out that my metaphor didn't work. So, thank you.
He didn't have the key for the handcuffs anymore. Okay, there.
That was what I should have said. Me. Yeah. So, he Now, now he's
like, "Now I can't get No, no, no. Whoa, guys. Whoa. I think
I I felt the consequences. Okay. Destiny sent some messages to
his chat that were even more defensive. I have never done anything
maliciously as any of the insane allegations say. That's
my only crime was being too much of a gooner in 2023 and earlier.
100% sure. Though again, I can't say anything specifically because
everyone wants to come at me in court now. I guess when he says
that he didn't do anything maliciously, I think he means that
he didn't intend for Pixie's nudes to ever get leaked to the
public. But I would argue that non-consensually sending her tapes
in the first place was malicious in and of itself. And again,
I think Destiny would agree with me that sharing the nudes in
and of itself is malicious because he said that when Bob 7 allegedly
did the same thing, this should be life destroying. But I do
believe that these are relatively life destroying revelations.
And you are not stupid, Destiny. You know that if you're sending
around tapes to random 19-year-old eirls, eventually something
is going to get leaked. You know, actually, one of the craziest
parts about this whole story is the fact that Destiny trusted
a 19-year-old Discord lady, okay, named Rose is coming with tapes
of other people in his life.
He paste, but also uh I love that he did like a visual like check
notes, right? Like if he was writing a post right there, he would
have put like star checks notes star, but he he just did it like
literally like actually 2-year-old Discord lady, okay, named
Rose is coming with tapes of other people in his life. [__]
if that's not compromised judgment, I don't know what the is.
Okay. Also, your only crime is being too much of a gooner. Destiny
is just a little bit of a goofy gooner. It's not like he's too
much of a goon. Ryan Beard is kind of a s. Can't go ahead and
clear up the the lies about me. Okay. Got to clear up all of
the lies about every single woman in this sphere, but he can't
take two seconds to help me out. This guy. Okay. Destiny is just
a little bit of a goofy gooner. It's not like he committed any
crime. He's just a little goofy. Call him Mr. as well. Gooner
goblin. Yeah, but he thinks Mr. Girl is a Yes. So, we didn't
clear anything up, did he? You want him to
You're a stalker as well. Will that help? Okay. Over there in
the corner gooning. As usual, every single thing that Destiny
says is an attempt to downplay, downplay, downplay, and refuse
to take any accountability. Then Destiny sent this to his chat.
Bro, if I need to go on the defender list, I'm taking like 20
other streamers with me. Okay, lol. W again trying to deflect
from taking responsibility by saying that a bunch of other streamers
have done the same. If other streamers have done the same [__]
then yeah, maybe they should be on the offender registry. Recently,
another clip of Destiny resurfaced where he talked about how
he knew that a bunch of different streamers had committed crimes
against children, but he just didn't care to expose any of them.
Like everybody's gotten picks and more from underage chicks depending
on what you've heard in different communities. No, no, no, no.
Let me finish. Let me finish. In the esports community, okay,
everybody has been involved in that [__] Okay. Um,
and there have been people that have gone farther than that.
Do you know people in the esports community have Yeah, but I'm
not going I'm not going down that road. There's tons of Wait,
no, no, wait, wait a minute. If you're saying you have knowledge
of a crime and you're not willing to bring it forward, well,
people talk about it, but like I don't have the means to go and
acquire the evidence to like find to like name names and name
victims. Dorito gate right now. Destiny, come on.
This is not my job. Listen. Okay, I'm going to be frank. I'm
not going to my career to go on some vendetta against a bunch
of video game guys. Okay, this is not my life. But now that his
head is on the chopping block, I guess maybe he'll finally expose
these abusers that he's been covering for for years. And the
last thing that Destiny has posted at the time of this recording
was an absolutely hilarious meme on Twitter where he said, "Korean
barbecue is a little overrated, but I've always loved the short
rib at this the place." And it's a picture of a Korean restaurant
called Goon Barbecue. Again, implying that he's just too much
of a Goonar because Goonar sounds a lot better than criminal.
He is choosing to be his same old self, making jokes instead
of taking accountability. This mother has the absolute gall to
release an entire manifesto about how Keles needs to take accountability
for her actions, but then once he's in [__] he takes
absolutely no
accountability for his actions. Like, is this dude an actual
baby? Are you a child? In what world is this the right way to
respond to the fact that you violated one of your friends and
in your own words severely psychologically damaged her? Never
in a million years could I imagine being a soulless, heartless
piece of [__] like this who treats my best friends
like actual human garbage. And for you to get up on your high
horse and act like you're the moral police of the universe who
has any place to judge other people while acting like this is
insane. You know, with this whole situation, I don't think Steven
shared this because he thought it was okay to share. I personally
believe, this is my theory, that he shared this because he just
didn't care and he didn't think that the other person would ever
find out. And that to me is almost worse because it shows that
you don't care about the people you slept with and who shared
that intimate moment with you and recorded it. And it shows to
me that if you are going to be able to avoid the consequences
of it, you'll say and do things behind closed door that are just
unbecoming.
And if I'm your friend and I see you do that to your other people
that you slept with and you call friends, then I can only imagine
that even for me, I might not be safe and I can't trust you.
And what I see is another moral failing where it's like when
no one's watching, you're not doing the right thing. You you
can this is I mean this is just blatantly obvious in this whole
cheating position, right?
Look who it is. Hello. I saw your message kind of late otherwise.
Yeah, we we went over. Have you watched this video yet? Yeah,
I already watched it. I thought that it was uh pretty stupid.
Some of the stuff he was saying was ridiculous, but
when he Well, yeah, I saw that. But also the I was mostly talking
about like the, you know, uh the the na asking that guy to draw
Nathan or whatever. I was like, "Okay, obvious like come on,
give me a break." I think this guy's been working on this video
and just keeping all of this information for like the last few
years ready for now. So, I guess maybe he just didn't cut out
some of this stuff.
Yes, that was just Yeah, I think he just wanted to do everything.
I kind of It's entertaining. Just after his rant, I want to get
the I want to get this other clip in. I'll wait. I'll wait. Massage
it however you want. It's a thing to share tape, but it's not
the worst thing. I'm sorry. That's garbage behavior. Okay, it
just is. Call it a spade of spade. It's garbage behavior. Don't
mush it over because you like your favorite streamer. Don't mush
it over because you think he's important politically. It's garbage
behavior. Right before uploading this video, another woman named
Stasia just came out with allegations that Destiny shared explicit
material of her without her consent. And a woman named Denims
just came out with an allegation that Destiny had recorded her
without her knowledge. This recording was,
but apparently it's illegal to record people without their knowledge
in that state. Destiny chose to ignore Staceia's allegations
for some reason. But in response to Denim's allegations, he sent
messages to his public chat threatening to leak the recordings
of her in an attempt to silence her, showing that he is still
engaging in the exact same behavior as always. So now we have
four different women who who Destiny allegedly shared nudes of
without their consent.
That that one was clear. Which one? Uh the one the one where
she was going to leak that recording of denims that was taken
a state that was two party consent. Oh, I can find it. Just give
me a sec. Oh, wait. Sorry, you did throw it here. Yeah, still
have this recording. L W I could publish it. Yeah, that'd be
a good idea, wouldn't it? Allegedly, case is going on. That might
hurt. shared nudes of without their consent. One woman that Destiny
assaulted. One woman who felt pressured into sending Destiny
feet pics. One woman who Destiny allegedly recorded. That's sexually
without her knowledge to Sorry, that's a that was a lowb blow.
My bad. Men on Grinder who Destiny allegedly recorded. Nothing.
Nothing. Just ignore him. He's fat. Not true, actually. But people
think so. It's actually without their I feel like you are fat
and that's why Sorry, I can't hear you. You're too fat. Hey,
I can't hear you. Well, I can't hear Lav because she's too quiet.
We turn her up. Am I actually? Can you fix your quiet? Is that
better? A little better. Little better. Okay, I'll sit up. I'll
sit up now. You can hear me really well, I bet. Uh, yes. Much
better. Thank you. What were you saying? Of course. Anything
for you? Thank you. I don't remember. Okay, we'll continue. knowledge
and one woman who was recorded not without her knowledge for
a grand total of 10 different victims that we know of so far.
And this is of course not including the 15-year-old girl that
Destiny shared bikini pictures of or the 8-year-old boy who's
Destiny stared at? When will Destiny's community stared at the
way to describe that? Yeah, this is a little bad faith. Little
bad faith's okay. I think you could call it bad faith, but what
I think it is is he's just doing like a normie approach. He's
like, "This is literally because that I mean that is literally
what happened. That is a literal interpretation of what happened.
Wake the up and realize that Destiny is just not a good person."
I know that I said that I wouldn't focus on my personal beef
with Destiny in this video, but I wanted to just point out one
thing. I found it really funny that in his Vosch manifesto, he
cries about how people online have attacked him for identifying
as non-binary in the past. Many have attacked me in the past
for identifying as a non-binary. I no longer identify this way.
Even though I have considered different gender identities and
discussed it at Wait, this is just his part, right? Did he say
that already? This is going to be his part. He had a non-binary
phase in his early 30s. Can we wrap our heads around this? various
points in my stream. Destiny and his community have been harassing
me for years about identifying as non-binary. He said that he
doesn't think my identity is real. And he tweeted that I'm faking
being trans for clout. And I've had a bunch of his fans come
and make fun of me anytime that I post about being non-binary,
which made me feel like I had to go back into the closet at one
point. But when people attack Destiny for being non-binary, many
have attacked me in the past for identifying as a non-binary.
It really hurts his feelings. This is just another example of
Destiny being a hypocritical little
cries when I cut him off again to pull off at one point
for being non-binary. Many have attacked me in the past for identifying
as a non-binary. It really hurts his feelings. This is just another
example of Destiny being a hypocritical little who cries when
people are mean to him and then turns around and does that exact
same [__] to other people. if you want. Okay, true.
But also, that's true. Wait, I paused. Why did I pause now? I
had a point to make or you guys had a point to make. I I was
gonna pause after Kelly, you were talking. That's what I am a
sea monster. Real literally so real. When people are mean to
him and then turns around and does that exact same [__]
to other people. If you want to be an [__] to non-binary
people, be an [__] to non-binary people. But then
don't be a weasly little who turns around and cries when people
are an assh to you about being non-binary. Destiny is the perfect
example of rules for thee, but not for me. He says Bob 7 should
have his life destroyed for sharing nudes without consent. I'm
not running around screen sharing people's nudes. Then he shares
nudes without consent. He criticizes Keles for being a bully
while he's the biggest bully on the internet. He cries about
how people on the internet have doxed him. And then he turns
around and doxes a woman who he is secretly in an active relationship
with. He says it's not good to women who are on large streams.
I think I think it is wrong. Yeah. I think I don't think you
should. And then he turns around and every single woman on his
large stream. He says it's super weird toys
because they're basically children. You're a little kid. And
then he a 19-year-old. He says we need to hold Keles responsible
for her actions. And then he takes absolutely no responsibility
for his actions. My worst crime was being too much of a gooner.
If you go back and rewatch this entire video, do you agree with
Destiny that his worst crime is just being too much of a gooner?
Destiny, you are not too much of a gooner. You are a criminal.
To this day, Destiny is still refusing to fully take accountability
for his actions as he has done through every single step of his
career. According to Destiny, he really hates weasels. He even
has a weasel emote that people spam in his chat whenever someone
is
trying to weasle their way out of an argument. This is such a
random or is refusing to take accountability for their actions.
Well, Destiny, I think you should get this emote tattooed on
your forehead. You are a weak, pathetic little weasel, and I
hope that everyone has finally opened their eyes to how much
of a wriggling little weasel you always have been. I hope that
after this you take a long look in the mirror and you realize
that you actually have a lot more in common with Keffles than
you would ever care to admit to yourself. You have both lied
to and scammed your audience. You are both massive bullies. You
both aren't afraid to use harmful tactics to get what you want.
And most of all, you both have a pathological need to avoid ever
taking accountability.
So from now on, I shall be referring to you as Keelston.
How's that for a nuke, buddy? That sucks.
This guy's honestly I won. I was like, this guy totally won and
then he dropped that. What the He's so gay. I like couldn't handle
that.
Why? Why would you do that? You could have just said epity and
it's like not even creative, but it's just fine. It's a totally
like so much of that video is like good. Like he lays out the
points fine. Why is he just such a que? Yeah, he's just cringe.
I it's hard to get through even like the understanding of calling
someone a bad person. I wouldn't even call Stephen like a bad
person. I would call him like an abuser and a predator. But I
think that person is like very elementary. No, that's accurate.
I think that that's very elementary. I think that that's a very
like it is. We don't need complicated analysis. Young understanding.
He's more bad than he is. We don't need We don't need a complicated
understanding. That's true. I don't know. I I think that calling
someone a bad person writes off like what exactly went wrong
and how you can avoid something like this. It's a bit simplistic.
Anything else? Okay.
How's that for a new buddy? Anything else? Play the song. Really
quick before the video ends, I've linked the fun. I think he's
Yeah, just going to like
dude. He needs to not being He was never going to hard end this.
He was always going to do a little thing to be like here's how
you can support the victim. Anything else ending was hard as
that could have been so
it was down below if you would consider donating to that. I would
appreciate it so much. If this lawsuit is successful, maybe this
is finally an opportunity for Destiny to be held accountable
for his actions. I've also linked accounts for Pixie, Cherry,
Lav, and Molina down below and recommend you give them a follow.
I think in situations like these, victims can end up being used
as ammo for different people to fling
and these victims can I mean, he just showed your tweets on screen.
You can't be that upset. Okay. No, he showed my tweet without
any context. I think Nick Fuentes is like a loser. Like, but
he he like posted it in it like I was like a Nick Fuentes fan.
It's like deranged.
Okay. Okay. If he if you if you typed big tech there and he'd
made the same assertion, it would have actually been like valid.
But with big tech also, I think I think big tech is less of a
loser. Okay. But I don't agree with it. I don't know why I've
got so much random misinformation. What about ABBA? What are
Yeah, I like don't get it. Also, why bring up why bring up Hassan
and then Hassan dunked on me? Like Hassan is going to be dunking
on me until someone wants to substantiate that and then he's
going to himself.
Okay. in a video game in a video game. Damage. So, it would be
super nice if you could go show them some love after all of the
[__] that they've had to endure from Destiny and
his community. I also wanted to let you know that I got Pixie
and Cherry and Lab's blessing to make this video. And I really
hope that I approach things in a way that they will approve of.
I know that I did some flinging in this video because I really
don't like
him. hope that I approach things with nuance, understanding,
and empathy for the victims. Also, in a little over a month,
I have a massive 3-hour long project that I've been working on
for the last 6 months or so coming out. I think this is going
to be the last traditional commentary video that I make on this
channel. If you want to see more like short form commentary videos,
go check out my other channel, which is also linked in the description.
Also, don't forget to subscribe to this channel if you want to
see that massive project that I've been working on. All right,
I'll see you then. Wow, you just leave 10 seconds. You just left
like a bunch of dead air in at the end. Cool. Cool. Lots of dead
air in. Okay, nice. Wow, what a video. That was cool. I wonder
if anyone still remembers when Destiny and Tiger Lily, his girlfriend
at the time, catfished the fat SC2 streamer into sending them
nudes and basically chased him off the scene. Are you talking
about Desro? Do that to Desro? That's [__] up. Oh
no, I didn't know that. 7.5 out of 10. Yeah, I get it. And give
it a seven out of 10. That is good editing. I I like Don't It's
We're 10 and a half hours into stream. I'm probably just ending.
Okay, I get that live just got here, but I am big time sleepy.
Okay, it was a long stream. It was a big stream. It was a massive
stream. Grow up. Grow up. 7 a.m. for me. I got to stay up another
hour. I'm going to maybe shoot you guys over to Danny. Looks
like Danny's watching South Park. I guess we got We got Tom Foolery.
Oh, Tom. Hold on. Tom Fuller without one or the other [__]
Brilliant. I mean, or there's Ice Poseidon. Or there's Sam Pepper.
Or me. I could just stream, guys. Oh, based. Are you actually
going to go live if I wait five minutes? No, I hate streaming.
I'll probably just throw Danny away. I'm just danking and rivals
right now. Nobody wants to see that. Based. Okay, I'm going to
rate Danny and we will be back tomorrow, guys, again for more
content, more laughs, more fun. I think we got through all of
the pirate software we wanted stuff we wanted to do today. I
guess we're just we're kind of idling looking for like what what's
coming next. I don't know what's coming next. Do drama, do politics.
I haven't really thought about it. Yeah, we'll see. We'll see
where we go. Not totally sure. All right, we'll be back tomorrow,
guys. Bro, no Reddit post. Also, uh we went 10 and a half hours,
so I don't know if we're doing what was it called today? I I
realize I teased that. I am kind of burned. All right, we lied.
All right, guys. I love you. We'll be back tomorrow. Bye. Enjoy.
See you. Bye. scammed. I I kind of scammed a little bit. I kind
of scammed. Love you guys.